you are in the right place to learn to
become a data analyst in this massive
boot camp Alex the analyst will cover
all the core topics that data analysts
need to know and along the way you'll
build plenty of projects to gain
hands-on experience hello everybody my
name is Alex freeberg better known as
Alex the analyst on YouTube and in this
video you're going to be taking my
entire data analyst boot camp this boot
camp is comprised of videos that I've
made over the past 3 years and they
cover a lot of different topics like SQL
Excel powerbi tableau and python
throughout the boot camp there are a lot
of Hands-On guided projects that will
really help you learn these skills well
and speaking of projects there's an
entire Part near the end where you can
build a free portfolio website where you
can put all of your projects on so that
hiring managers and recruiters can go
and look at all these projects that
you've built if you wanted to go even
more in depth into the skills that we
learn in this boot camp I have a data
analytics learning platform called
analyst Builder analy Builder was
designed specifically for data analyst
so all of the courses and all the
content are just for you and it has a
coding section where you can learn and
practice for technical interviews and
lastly before we jump into the boot camp
I want to give a huge shout out to free
code camp for putting this all together
personally learned a ton from free code
camp and so I'm really honored that my
boot camp is going to be here for you
guys to learn and I really hope you
enjoy it what's going on everybody it is
2023 and in this video I'm going to help
you become a data
[Music]
analyst we're going to start at the very
beginning assuming you haven't started
this process at all of becoming a data
analyst if you already have you can kind
of find IDE identify where you are in
this process and then go from there now
before we dive into everything I want to
warn you I will be mentioning my own
channel a lot in this video I have
videos and playlists on just about every
single topic that we're going to be
talking about today I'll have all the
links to those videos in the description
so you can dive into those topics more
in depth so I hope that's okay and it's
all completely free I've been building
this out for the past 3 years and
honestly you can probably get 90% of the
way to learning everything you need for
data analytics just on my channel so now
that I've warned you let's J been of
number one and that is learn the data
analyst skills now there are literally a
hundred different things that you can
learn for data analytics you can learn
things like alter X or a cloud platform
or different programming languages but
there are some core skills that I
recommend you start out with before kind
of branching into some of those other
skills the number one skill that I
always recommend people start with is
SQL SQL is just one of those fundamental
skills I think everybody should learn
even if you don't use SQL you'll use
some variation of SQL if your company
has a large enough data set SQL is used
to actually query and retrieve data from
a database so if your company collects
data which every company does they're
going to put it somewhere to store it's
usually stored in a database and sqls
how you get that data from the database
I think SQL is also fairly easy to learn
which makes it really good when you're
just starting out I have several
playlists dedicated to SQL starting from
beginner all the way to Advanced and you
can learn all of that for free one other
reason why I think you should learn SQL
first is that a lot of companies
interview or have a technical interview
during the interview process on SQL
that's something that really caught me
off guard when I was first starting out
out because I thought it was going to be
more behavioral I didn't even know what
a technical interview was so knowing SQL
actually became a really important part
of interviewing and getting a job as a
data analyst the second skill that I
would learn is a business intelligence
tool like Tableau or powerbi now there
are a ton of different bi tools I can
literally name 10 off the top of my head
that I've used throughout my career but
what I will say is that learning
something like Tableau or powerbi is
pretty transferable to almost all those
other bi tools they're all fairly
similar and how they do things and how
they show display the data you most
likely won't have a technical interview
asking you about Tableau or powerbi like
to build something for them that usually
does not happen but the combination of
SQL where you can query your data and
then taking that data to build something
that is a really really great
combination to learn right away I have
entire series on both Tableau and
powerbi with projects on my channel the
third skill that I would learn is Excel
now most people have used Excel they
know what Excel is and how it's used but
it can be used a little bit differently
for a data analyst for example example
in Excel a lot of people haven't cleaned
data in Excel or built charts and graphs
using Excel and those are things that
data analysts would probably do excel is
also just a fundamental skill that every
company is going to expect you to know
so I have an entire playlist dedicated
to excel to actually walk you through
how to use it for data analysis the
fourth skill that I recommend you learn
is python now a lot of people will have
python higher up on their list they only
use Python they don't use SQL or a bi
tool they just do everything in Python
now python is a fantastic tool you can
use it to manipulate your data to create
data visualizations and a ton more like
web scraping and regular expression and
a hundred different other things but it
can be kind of hard to learn it took me
a long time to really learn the basics
very well that's really the only reason
why it is farther back I feel like SQL
and a bi tool are really easy to learn
and really pack a big punch whereas
python can be quite tough to learn in my
experience and you may not use it as
often as you would something like SQL or
a bi tool if you're interested in
learning py python I have an entire
series dedicated to python as well as
projects that you can build again I
warned you there's going to be a lot of
self-promotion in this video I have
videos on just about every single one of
these topics the fifth and the last
skill that I recommend you learning and
this is the only one that I don't have a
series on yet I will make those is
learning a cloud platform like AWS
Google Cloud platform or Azure there's
no denying that these platforms have
played a huge impact in how we use data
as a whole in the data analyst industry
they can be kind of tough to learn
though if you aren't using it Hands-On
in an actual job I think that learning a
cloud platform is already something that
most people should start working towards
because in the future it's only going to
become more prevalent now where can you
go and actually learn all of these
skills that you need to become a data
analyst well the number one place I'd
recommend of course is my channel I have
free tutorials on all these skills and a
lot of other topics and I think it's
just a really great place to start the
next place that I recommend you looking
at is udemy I recommend udemy especially
if you're just starting out because it's
pretty pretty cheap you can buy an
entire course entire SQL course for $10
or $15 and they have courses on every
single one of these skills and I just
recently made a video called DIY data
analysts curriculum using udemy for
under $75 so you can create an entire
curriculum to learn all of these skills
for under $75 which is just amazing the
next place I'm going to recommend you
look is corsera now udemy is fantastic
they have really good instructors and
good courses but as a whole I find that
sometimes corsera just has more
professional or better content corsera
is a bit more expensive though you're
looking at $59 per month for all of
their courses or you can pay upfront an
annual fee of $399 so again it's just a
lot more expensive I moved to corsera
once I started having a data analyst job
and had a bit more money but when I was
first starting out I just couldn't
afford it so I went to udemy and it was
a really great place to start there's
also places like data camp and data
Quest that kind of gamify learning and
they're more text based so all these
other platforms udem me corsera and me
they're all video based but if you like
reading data camp and data Quest are a
lot more of text where you can learn it
by reading it and doing it after you
learn all of these skills the next thing
that I recommend you do is actually
build projects with those skills now
what is building a project actually mean
it means taking a skill and then
building something out of it that you
can then show a potential employer for
example if you went through and learn
Tableau you go and take a data set and
you could build a visualization and a
dashboard in tableau and that would be a
project with these projects you can
build something called a portfolio and I
usually call it a portfolio website a
portfolio website is a website that you
create where you store all of your
projects and then you can share that
with recruiters and hiring managers so
that they can see all of your work now
do you absolutely need a portfolio to
show employers no you don't but it does
help in two different ways the first
thing that it may do is actually help
you land the interview if you have a
link on your resume and they click on it
they may see your skills and see your
projects and be like man this person
really knows what they're doing this is
exactly what we need the second reason
that I recommend building projects is
because most likely during your
interview you're going to get asked
questions like how have you used SQL how
have you used Tableau and if you don't
have any experience in that you're just
going to say well you know I've taken
courses to learn it but with a project
you can be a lot more specific you'll be
able to say well I actually just built
out this project in Tableau I took the
data and cleaned it in Excel and then I
put it in Tableau and built out this
Dash board and here are the insights
that I found from this data set it's
just a much better answer and as a
hiring manager myself I can tell you
that it is definitely beneficial to
build out these projects The Next Step
that I recommend you take in becoming a
data analyst is building a data analyst
resume the resume to say the least is
extremely important it's what's going to
actually allow you to land an interview
to potentially get a job now if you were
like me when I was first starting out I
had a resume it just had nothing to do
with data analytics so how do you make a
data analyst resume if you don't have
any experience as a data analyst well
you are asking the perfect questions
because the very first things that we
talked about are what are going to go on
your resume those skills and those
projects if you have no experience or
degree like myself who has a
recreational therapy degree if you have
no background in this it can be really
daunting to kind of display that you
know what you're doing and that a
company should hire you so what I
usually recommend is right beneath your
contact at the top you put your skills
and your projects that you built out on
your resume things like work experience
and education should go on your resume
as well but just a little bit lower you
want them to see those things before
they see that your last work experience
was at Domino's and you have a degree in
Marine Biology it's just not relevant to
data analysis and if you put those
things at the top they're probably going
to rule you out right away the fourth
step to become a data analyst is
actually applying you have the skills
you have the projects you have the
resume now you're ready to start
applying for those data analyst jobs now
there's there's a lot of different
opinions on how you need to go about
applying for data analyst jobs but I'll
give you my take on it and this has been
the most successful for me in my career
the first thing I want to mention is
actually what I would not do which is
just blindly apply on glass door monster
zip recruiter and all these other
platforms to just any data analyst job
that you can find now I'm not against
this I think you should do that but I
don't think that's the only thing that
you should do because the chances of you
getting a call back or actually hearing
something back are extremely low to
really increase your chance of becoming
a data analyst I highly highly highly
recommend working with a recruiter a
recruiter is literally someone who is
there to help you find a job now when I
first started out I didn't understand
what a technical recruiter was at all I
was kind of nervous or scared to work
with him but it's actually pretty simple
a company has a position that they want
to fill and they don't want to spend
hours and hours and hours to find
someone to fill that position so they
hire a recruiter a recruiter is going to
go out and try to find someone to fill
that position AKA you and so if you go
into talk to that recruiter and they
have a position that opens up they will
help you get that interview and then if
you get a job let's say for
$50,000 the company is going to pay that
recruiter let's say 10% of your salary
so they'll give them $5,000 so you don't
actually lose or have anything to lose
using a recruiter you can reach out to
Recruiters in several ways and I've done
every variation but I'll tell you my
most successful way which was using
LinkedIn there are tens of thousands of
Recruiters on LinkedIn I made an entire
video of how you can reach out to
recruiters and what to St Recruiters on
LinkedIn to help you land a job so be
sure to check out that video when you
actually get to that point but you can
also just cold email and cold call these
recruiting companies but to me it's just
not as effective as reaching out
directly on LinkedIn and this is just a
bonus one the last thing that you need
to do is accept a job offer so on step
number four after you apply to those
jobs you do actually have to go in
interview and then get a job offer which
you will accept I just thought I'd
mentioned that just in case that was not
super clear now that was a lot of stuff
let's talk about time frames to actually
complete all of these things now doing
all of these things from scratch is
going to take a while but let's break it
down by each step and see how long I
generally think it's going to take let's
start with step number one which is
actually learning the skills now just to
be up front this one probably is going
to take the longest for most people for
most people to learn all of these skills
it's going to take around 3 to four
months now if you don't learn a cloud
platform and python which are the last
ones that I recommend and you just focus
on SQL a to in Excel I think you can do
that in under 3 months that is very
dependent though on how much time you
have to study that time frame is more
for someone who has several hours per
day maybe 3 hours in the end of a night
after you go to work that is someone who
has quite a bit of time to dedicate to
learning during their week of course
that time frame is going to take longer
if you don't have as much time to
dedicate to learning now let's look at
number two which was creating projects
and a portfolio of projects from my
experience when you're first starting
out it takes a lot longer to actually
create these projects it can take one
one or two weeks per project I usually
recommend people doing three to five
projects in their portfolio before they
start applying and since they can take
anywhere from 1 to two weeks you're
looking at anywhere from 3 to 6 weeks
The Next Step was to create a data
analyst resume now in my opinion this
one should take the shortest out of
every single step here because you're
really just kind of reformatting a
resume or creating a resume you're just
adding skills you're adding your
projects and then kind of reformatting
it to make it look nice this should
hopefully take under a week but if you
use something like a professional
service so they help you build a resume
it could take one to two weeks the two
last steps which kind of go hand inand
are step four and five which is actually
applying for jobs and then Landing a job
now this process can take as little as a
month or it can take as long as 6 months
or a year it really depends on how
you're applying where you're applying
and just the kind of luck that you're
having with actually Landing interviews
I've seen people who have never had any
experience land a job within a month of
starting to apply and it's incredible
it's amazing but it doesn't happen too
often you're usually looking at around 2
to 4 months on average to land your
first data analyst job if you put all of
those together and kind of average
everything out you're looking at around
6 months total for the entire process
now I don't want that to discourage you
okay 2023 is a long year you have a lot
of time and it doesn't have to take 6
months you could do it faster you could
do it in three months and just prove me
wrong but if you are really focused and
you are really driven to become a data
analyst this year I know that you can do
it now to maybe boost your spirits and
make you feel a little bit better I
didn't know any of these things when I
first started out I didn't have anyone
telling me kind of a plan on what to do
I had to go out and figure all these
things out by myself and it took me
almost a year to land my first real data
analyst job so with all that being said
I hope that this video is helpful I hope
you now have a path on how to become a
data analyst this year and that my
channel can be a big part of that so
thank you guys so much for watching I
really appreciate it if you like this
video be sure to like And subscribe
below and I'll see you in the next
video
[Music]
what's going on everybody my name is
Alex freeberg and in today's video we're
going to be starting our basics of SQL
series now in this series we're going to
be going over everything you need just
to get started and then in future videos
we're going to be going over some
intermediate Concepts and some more
advanced concepts and then in the final
series we're going to be going over some
portfolio projects in this video in
particular we're going to be downloading
SQL Server Studio we're going to be
creating our tables inserting data into
our tables and in future videos we're
going to actually learn how to query
those tables if you already have SQL
Server management Studio downloaded you
can skip ahead to where we actually
create the tables and insert the data
into the tables if you don't care about
that at all and you're just looking at a
query I would skip to the next video
where we actually start quering the data
that we inserted into those tables so to
download SQL Server management Studio we
actually have to download two things and
I have both links right here I'm going
to leave those in the descriptions that
you guys have those but this one is to
actually download SQL Server management
studio so let's go down here I actually
deleted it off my computer so I can walk
through this with you guys so we're
going to download that let's also go
over here this is actually a server so
we have to download a SQL server and if
you go down right here there's a free
version now I don't need the developer
version I'm just going to download the
express version it's actually smaller so
let's download that as
well now once this is done running we're
going to open it up and I'll show you
what to do next so it just finished
running let's click on
it all right so we need to install it
we're going to click yes and this is
going to take a little while so this
popped up I clicked install and it's
been running for the past couple minutes
apparently I was not recording so I
apologize for that but that's all I did
so now it's been installed I'm actually
going to pull it up right
here and let's open it
up now when it pulls up it's going to
ask you to connect to a server and
that's why we downloaded the SQL Express
server so let's connect to
that and there you go it's as easy as
that so now we have SQL Server
management Studio set up and we are good
to go so the first thing that we need to
do is actually create a database so
let's go over here to databases and
let's click new
database and let's just do
SQL
tutorial keep it simple and if we click
that it's going to create our database
for us now when you open up the database
there's going to be a lot of stuff you
really do not need to know all this
really what we're going to be sticking
to is this tables right here uh as of
right now we do not have any tables so
we need to create tables now there's two
ways that you can do that you can click
right here and you can go to new and
create table we're not actually going to
do that we're going to create it using a
script or a t-sql so we're going to go
over here and do new query and we will
get started on actually creating uh the
two tables that we're going to be using
for all the stuff going forward all
right so let's get rid of me CU you
really don't need to be seeing me
anymore let's get started by doing our
very first table which is going to be
our employee demographics table so let's
start off by saying create table and we
have to name it so let's do
employee demographics and enter down we
want to do an open parenthesis now we
need to specify what our column names
are going to be and what the data type
is for each column so let's start off
with employee ID and we want that to be
an integer so that'll be like 1 2 3 4 uh
anything
numeric now we want to
do first name and let's make that varar
50 if you don't know what these data
types are that's okay uh that will
probably be covered in a different video
that's not really necessary for this
video uh let's do last name we'll also
make that varar 50 let's do age make
that an integer and very last let's do
gender and we will make that varar 50 as
well so now we have our very first
table let's run that and we'll see if it
works we'll go over here we'll refresh
our
tables and there you go so we have our
very first table let's go up here let's
get rid of this one and now let's create
our second table so we're going to do
basically the exact same thing but we're
going to have a little bit different
information in it this is going to be
our employee salary table so let's do
create table and again we need to name
it and enter and open parenthesis so now
we're going to do the same thing we're
going to do employee ID let's make that
an integer now we want the job title
because we want to know what they
do and this one is going to be varar 50
because we keep it pretty simple
whoops and then for our very last one
we're going to do salary and that will
be integer as
well and I'll just do PR here so let's
create this
table let's see if it is there and there
we go so let's open up one of these
tables really
quick see what's in there see what it
looks like as you can see we do not have
any information in there uh when you
create a new table sometimes when you
open it up you're going to see this if
you want to get rid of that you just
need to do a I think it's called A Hard
refresh or something like that but you
can do control shift R let's see if it
works for me I just did it all right it
goes away so now it recognizes it as a
table so we're good there let's go back
here and let's get rid of all this we've
already created our tables now we want
to insert the data into our tables so
let's see what that looks like let's do
insert into and now we need to specify
what table we're inserting our data into
so let's start off with employee
demographics let's do
values so now we have to select what
values we're going to put into um into
this table
so now we're going to have to do the
employee ID so let's do
101 then we're do first name so let's do
Jim last name
Halpert and then his age let's say he's
30 and he is a
male now just for fun let's execute that
let's go back to this table right here
and execute
and as you can see all of our
information actually went in there so
now we have his employee ID his first
name his last name age and gender now we
need a lot more information uh for this
table in order to actually learn a lot
of the concepts of quering the table so
I'm actually going to go through and add
a ton more information I'm not going to
bore you through that but I will show
you the final product before I actually
hit execute so stick with me I'm
actually just going to cut to the end
where I insert all my stuff down on here
and then if you want that I'll probably
leave it in the description or maybe put
in my GitHub or something so you can
easily just go copy and paste that if
that's what you want to do so I'll see
you in a few
seconds all right so I have all my
values right here I actually going to
take this one out cu I already did that
one but this is our additional
information let's insert that into our
table real quick and go back here and
take a look at it and there you go this
is going to be our core information that
we are querying off of
uh in future videos so that table is
completely finished let's go back here
we're going to get rid of this because
now we want to insert our information to
our other table so let's do insert into
and let's do
employee and now we're going to do
salary so let's do values to specify
that we're inserting values into
there and in this one we have employee
ID so again let's do in th1 that's
gym his job title is
salesman and let's say his salary is
$45,000 and let's execute that and you
can't see it but down here it says it's
done let's go to that
table and as you can see that is
inserted I'm going to do the exact same
thing as I did before I am going to fill
out all these and in a second it will be
done uh on your side and then again I
will leave it in the description or I'm
going to put it on my GitHub and you
guys can just copy and paste that if
that's what you want to do or you can
write it out whatever you want to do all
right just like before I'm going to get
rid of this first one that is Jim he is
already done now let's insert this
information Ed is finished let's go back
here and there we go now we have both of
our tables and we are good to go for
future videos so thank you so much for
sticking all the way through this one in
the next video we're going to actually
begin uh quering the table and learning
the select the from the where the group
by and the order by statement everything
is in these upcoming videos so stick
around and we will learn all of that
together thank you so much for joining
me if you like this type of content be
sure to subscribe below and I'll see you
in the next video what is going on
everybody my name is Alex freeberg and
in today's video we're going to be going
over the select and the from statement
so if you joined us for our last video
we went over creating our tables and
inserting data into those tables and so
we have this employee demographics table
and we also have this employee salary
table and today we're going to be
walking through the select statement in
the fir statement on these tables so
here are some of the concepts that we're
going to be going over today let's just
get it started by doing select
everything and let's do this from the
employee demographics table so let's
execute this if we wanted to only show
the first names we can just do first
name and run that
and if we want first name and last name
we can just separate that by using a
comma and it will return those well if
we want to return all columns and all
rows then all we have to do is use this
star so that's what the star does now we
have nine rows of data here and if we
only wanted to return let's say the top
five we can easily do that and we can
just say top five of everything now the
reason this could be useful is say you
have a table that has millions of rows
in it and you only want a small sample
you can say select top 1,000 and when
you do that it will only select the top
five rows now let's get everything back
in here really quick because we're going
to move on to this distinct feature so
when we use distinct we're actually
saying that we want the unique values in
a specific column so if we say distinct
and then let's do employee ID
D everything should be returned so all
nine rows should be returned and that's
because every single one of these are
unique now let's try gender so there's
only going to be two results the male
and the female and that's because
there's only two distinct values in that
column now let's look at all of our data
again so now we want to look at count
now count is very simple all is going to
do is going to show us all the non null
values in a column so let's look at last
name for example if we do count of last
name all that's going to give us is a
count of nine because we have nine last
names if for whatever reason somebody's
last name was left out and that was null
then it would have returned maybe eight
or seven depending on how many were
actually in there so if an entire column
was null we it would be a Return To
Zero and if you notice we are not given
a column name that's because this is
derived information based off the last
name so if we want to actually give this
a name so that that column does not say
no column name we can use this as right
here so once you put as you can actually
name it so since this is the count of
the last name we'll write last name
count keep it simple and if we execute
that as you can see we have last name
count right there so that's how you use
that as let's look at all of our data
again we want to look at some Max mins
and averages right now and the only
column here where it would be useful to
do it on is age but let's actually go
over and let's look at our salary table
and at our salary table we have some
really interesting salaries that I think
would be a little bit more useful for
this information so let's go over
to employee
salary all all right and let's look at
this table really quick so we have our
salary now we want to look at the
maximum
salary that is
in uh that column and that is going to
be
$65,000 now let's say we wanted to know
what the minimum salary was let's
execute this and the person who makes
the least money is making
$36,000 now what's the average what is
the average salary for all employees
that's going to be $
48,5 so so super easy to use all of
these things they're extremely useful I
use them every single day so I know that
each of these are very very useful and
are definitely among the basics that you
have to know let's look real quick at
everything really quick so we just
learned the select statement but
learning this from statement really
quick is also important up here this
actually shows us that we're already
Hitting off the SQL tutorial database
but let's say we change it to master
when we try to run this it's going to
give us an error and that's because now
we're hitting off this database and this
database does not have this table in it
so in order to do this in order to still
hit off that table while up here we're
actually hitting off a different table
we can change this information so the
from statement you have to specify three
separate things the first thing that you
need to specify is the database so let's
say we want to hit off the SQL tutorial
database
now we want to select what table we're
going to do this is actually a dbo so
let's put dbo there's there's a lot that
can go into that um it's not worth
getting into now but dbo do and let's do
employee
salary when we execute this our
information comes up even though up here
we're still hitting off the master
database when we specify it right here
then we actually are choosing what
database and what table a hit off of and
so it does not matter what it is up here
so that's how you use the from statement
in the next video we're going to be
going over the wear statement and then
after that the group by and order by
statement and that will be the complete
basics of SQL tutorial and then we'll
start getting into a little bit more fun
stuff some more advanced concepts which
I think it be really really exciting for
everybody to learn thank you guys so
much for joining me I really appreciate
I hope this has been helpful if you like
this type of content subscribe below and
I'll see you in the next video thanks
and goodbye
what's going on everybody my name is
Alex freeberg and in this video we're
going to be going over the we statement
and SQL in the very first video we
created our table inserted data into our
table in the second video we went over
the select and the from statement and
now we are on to the wear statements now
what does the wear statement do it helps
limit the amount of data and specify
what data you want returned we have
quite a few Concepts that we're going to
be covering today let's just start out
with something really easy let's
do where first name
equals gym really simple so we're
selecting everything where our first
name equals gym and this is our output
so really really simple now let's try
where it does not equal this right here
says does not equal gym and let's
execute that and as you can see we have
everybody except Jim Halbert in there so
now let's look at the greater than or
less than so in this table I think the
one that we're going to look at is age
so let's look at age and let's do where
it's greater than
30 and when we execute that we're going
to get everyone who is over the age of
30 now as you can see we're not
including people who are 30 years old if
we want to include people who actually
are 30 years old we're going to add the
equal sign right there so we should be
seeing people who are now 30 so before
Pam and Jim were not in there and now
they are if we do the exact same thing
let's do less than 32
here's everyone that's going to be
included but if we want to include the
people who are 32y old then we are just
going to add that equal sign and now the
people who are 32 years old like Toby
and Meredith are now
included if we want to go even further
we want people who are less than or
equal than
32 and who are male we can say where
gender
equals
male so now we have two two things that
we are specifying that we need we need
somebody whose age is less than 32 and
we need their gender to be male so let's
execute that and we have four people who
meet that criteria so that's what the
and statement does if we write or then
only one of these criteria has to be
correct in order for it to be met so if
we hit execute now we're saying anybody
who's under the age or equal to 32 or
their gender equals male so if we look
down here Michael Scott is actually 35
years old so he's over 32 but since he
is male he is now included let's get rid
of everything really quick I want to
look at this like really quick so let's
execute just that and if you do that you
highlight just that hit execute then it
uh will only run what you have
highlighted so now let's look at this
whole table now when you're using like
you typically are doing this for
sometimes numerical but most of the time
you're using it for text
information so if we're looking at this
right here if I'm looking at last names
and let's say I want everybody whose
last name starts with s you can't really
do that with anything else so I'm going
to say where it's like and then I'm
going to say s and after that I'm going
to put a percent sign that's actually
called a wild card and if I close that
off what this is saying is is I want
every last name where it starts with
where it's like
where it only starts with an S so let's
run this really quick now we have two
people whose last names start with s now
if I put a wild card at the beginning we
are now saying where there's an S
anywhere in anybody's name so let's
execute this and see what we get so now
even if the S is like flenderson towards
the end it's still counts so you can
specify multiple things in here as well
so let's say I want it to start with s
that would return shre and Scott but now
I want something that also has an o in
it so so it has an S at the beginning
and then somewhere in there there's an O
now let's execute that and there's only
one person that meets that criteria so
you can do that for multiple things you
can even say OT
TT and let's execute that and he's still
going to be returned and if we put C at
the back it's not going to be returned
because it follows it in order so isn't
s o TT C the C would actually need to
go over here so now we have s c o t t
and although there's a bunch of wild
cards in here it is going to return
Scott so that is a little bit a little
hint at how you can use like there is a
little bit more that goes into it you
can use it for numerics um there's a lot
of things that you can use this for but
this is just the basics how you can use
it today how you get started on using
the like a nutshell that is how you use
like and as I said before you can use
like with numerical data as well but for
demonstration purposes I wanted to use
text Data let's get rid of this really
quick um let's look at our entire
table and I wanted to show you how to
use null and not null I can't really
show you how to use null because I do
not have any null Fields I could easily
update this table and make n but that's
in a future video where it's a little
bit more advanced where you can start
altering your data but just for purposes
of showing you what null and not null is
let's do where first
name is
null and if we see that is not going to
return anything but if we say is not
null it's going to return everything
because nothing in here is null nothing
in this first name column is null so
that's how you use it um there are a lot
of use cases where you actually will use
null and not null that will be in future
videos probably in the project section
or the portfolio section we weren't able
to show really how to use this super
well but just as a demonstration that's
really all it does it looks at the whole
column and whether it is null or not
null that's really all it's used for
this is actually super useful and you
can use it in a ton of situations but
again for demonstration purposes that's
really all it does so let's get rid of
this let's look at in really quick so in
is kind of like the equal statement but
it's multiple equal statements so let's
say we want to say we first name equals
gy and then we were like wait we also
want to include Michael
Scott so then we would have to write and
where first name equals and then we
would do Michael and then etc etc for
anybody that we wanted to include but if
we said in we could do an open
parentheses and then we can say
gy we can say
Michael and we can say as many people as
we want going down the road just
separating it by commas and if we had
execute everything would be returned so
it really is just a condensed way to say
equal for multiple
things so that is the we statement I
think the wear statement can get
extremely complex but this really is
highlighting the basics so if you can
learn all of these Concepts you will
absolutely have the basics down and will
be set to go over some more intermediate
and more advanced things with the we
statement later on in the next video
we're going to be going over the group
buy and the order buy and then we are
done with the SQL Basics and then you
can practice and work your way up into
my intermediate level videos which are
going to be coming out very shortly
after these videos thank you guys so
much for joining me if you like this
tutorial Series be sure to subscribe
below and I'll see you in the next
video going on everybody my name is Alex
freeberg and in today's video we're
going to be going over the group by and
the order by statements in previous
videos we created tables we went over to
select the from and the where and now we
are at the very end of our SQL basic
series if you stayed with us for the
whole time hopefully you have learned a
lot and learned the basics of SQL in
future videos we're going to be going
over intermediate and even more advanced
concepts and even going through
portfolio projects that you can use to
put on your resume if you like this type
of content be sure to subscribe below
but let's get into it for today the
group by statement is similar to
distinct in the select statement in that
it's going to show the unique values in
a column the difference is is if we say
distinct
gender what's going to be returned is
the very first unique value of female
and the very first unique value of
male but if we say
gender and we say Group by
gender it's only going to return two
values but in these two values we
actually have all the males rolled up
into this one row and all the females
rolled up into this one row now let me
further show you what that means if I
say count of
gender now you can see that this whole
time there were six males in this one
row and there were three females in this
one row so with a distinct it really is
only showing us what value is in there
that's unique but with the group by it's
showing us what the unique value is but
it's also rolling them all up into one
column that we can use it for other
things now real quick I want to be able
to see both of these at the same time so
let's just put this up here and let's
run this so we can actually see both now
let's add age to this statement down
here or this
query and let's only run this one and I
want to show you what happens and why it
happens we're now looking at gender age
and then the count of gender so if we
look down here we only have one male who
is 29 we have one male who is female
that's age 30 and so on and so forth so
none of these people are both the same
gender and the same age if for example
we had two or three people who were male
and who were 30 years old then we would
have a two or a three over here so this
count is actually being counted at each
row that's being returned so for our
data that we have today this isn't a
fantastic example CU it really split it
out there any that were the same but as
you can see you can put multiple columns
as long as you put multiple down here
now why did we not have to put this
count gender down here in this group by
that's because this count gender is
actually a derived field or derived
column it's derived based off the gender
column so it's technically not a real
column that's in the table it's one that
we're creating that's fictional uh per
se so the age and the gender are actual
fields or actual columns that are in our
table they have to be down here and like
I said before it's the comparison to
that distinct in the select statement
because we're looking at the distinct of
gender and age so we're saying distinct
across multiple columns both gender and
age now as we had it before we were only
looking at gender it's going to roll all
of those up into just male and female
but if we want to add more we can easily
add more in this group by statement we
can still do things like where age is
greater than
31 we can still do those things so let's
execute this and our numbers are going
to change now we're doing it based off
gender and we're looking at the count of
people whose age is greater than 31
which is smaller than before now let's
look at order bu I'll do it down here
really quick for demonstration but I am
eventually going to come up here and use
it because I think it'll be a little bit
better to completely round out this
query down here let me give this a name
let's do count of gender and then let's
come down here and let's order
by uh let's order by count
gender and when we run that it's going
to do 1 three and that's because as a
default SQL has an ascending feature
which is going to be smallest to largest
going down if we want to change that we
can change it to descending that's going
to be largest to smallest so now we have
31 and if we want to do it based off
gender and we do it descending now we
have Z to
A and so that's going to be male female
and if we get rid of that it's going to
do the the default
ascending and let's see what that brings
female male now for what we're trying to
do let's look at this large table so I
think it's going to be a little bit more
descriptive or a little bit better
visually let's do order by and let's do
age let's run this and it's going to
order smallest to
largest if we do
descending it's going to do largest to
smallest now you don't only have to do
just one thing you can do multiple
columns so if I wanted to do age and
then gender I can do that as well so
let's do
gender and let's run that so now we have
the age but under the age we also have
it ordered by female and that's an
ascending order so AB BC d f so females
first so it's going to be female first
and then it's going to be male and again
female and male now we don't have to
just let it be ascending for each one if
I wanted to do it reverse in this column
I can do descending now let's run that
and when we have 30 now male is first
and female second and if I wanted to do
that over here I can do descending and
now we have them both descending so it's
going to go top to bottom and we have 32
it's going to be male 32 female so you
can specify lots of different things in
here and we don't actually have to use
column names we could just use numbers
so if I wanted to do 1 2 3 4 5 I could
but let's try to replicate the exact
same thing before this would be column 1
2 three four so let's do where four
descending and then let's do
five descending and if we execute that
it's going to give us the exact same
result as if we' actually put in the
column name and I I do use this a lot
oftentimes I don't use the column name I
just if it's a small table I'll just use
the number so in my actual queries I do
this a lot where I just use the number
instead of the column name so that is
the group buy and the order by statement
and if you have walked through my
previous videos you should be completely
done with the basics of SQL so
congratulations the next thing to do is
really just practice the basics because
the basics are what you're going to be
using day in day out and so what I would
recommend is create a few more tables
query those tables try to think of use
cases and what you would actually want
to know from that information after that
I would move on to my intermediate
videos if those are already out and then
I would move on to my Advanced videos
those are going to go over some more
challenging topics but things that would
be very useful for anybody to know in my
next video I'm going to be going over
intermediate SQL topics things like
joins and subqueries and a ton more so
if I already have posted those be sure
to go check those out on my page and if
I haven't I hope to have those up soon
thank you thank you guys so much for
watching I really appreciate it if you
learned anything in this basics of
sequel Series be sure to subscribe below
and I'll see you in the next video
what's going on everybody my name is
Alex freeberg and today we're going to
be starting our intermediate SQL series
if you joined us for our last series we
walked through the basics of SQL which
is everything you needed just to get
started and in this series we're going
to be walking through some intermediate
Concepts to really take your skills up
to the next level now today we're going
to be walking through joins but let me
show you what you can expect from the
entire series for this intermediate
course
so we're going walking through joins
today and then in future videos we're
walking through unions case statements
updating and deleting data Partition by
data types aliasing creating views
having versus the group by statement the
get date function primary care of your
foreign key and then we're going to have
an advanced course and this is not set
in stone yet but these are some of the
things that I think I will be going
through or walking through we're going
through CTE CIS tables or system tables
subqueries temp tables string functions
regular expression store procedures and
then importing and exporting data so
with all that being said let's get into
it all right now let's get rid of me
because we do not need to be seeing me
for the rest of the series at the very
top here are some of the things that
we're going to be going through today
which are inner joins and then outer
joins and in the outer joins we have a
few different styles or a few different
types of outer joins now a join is a way
to combine multiple tables
into a single
output for now we're going to be using
the employee demographics and the
employee salary table so let's get a
look at both of these tables and see
what's in them in our employee
demographics table we have employee ID
first name last name age and gender and
then down here in our employee salary
table we have employee ID job title and
salary if you notice they have a similar
column and that's going to be the
employee ID now when you're doing a join
you have to do this based off a similar
column and typically you want it to be a
unique field so we're going to be using
the employee ID from both tables to join
these tables together to create one
output so let's get rid of this real
quick and let's start building our query
to join these two tables
together so the first thing we're going
to do is an inner join so let's do
select
everything and let's do it from SQL
tutorial.
db. employee
demographics and let's do join we can
also say inner join but join by default
is going to say
iner and we're going to do SQL tutorial.
db. employee
salary now we have to join them together
which is what we talked about earlier
and we're going to be doing that based
off the employee ID so for that we have
to say on and then we're going to
say employee
demographics dot employee ID is equal to
employee
salary dot employee ID so let's run this
real quick and take a look at the
output and let me pull this up real
quick
so what we are looking at is actually
both tables combined we have the
employee ID first name last name age
gender and then here's the salary
employee ID job title salary now an in
join is really only going to show
everything that is the same so in both
tables there are employee IDs of
10001 all the way down to
10009 but if you notice there is data
that is missing real quick let's go down
to this graphic and let's look at this
inner join an inner join is going to
show everything that is common or
overlapping between table a and table B
so what we are looking at here is
exactly that we're only looking at the
things that are similar based off this
employee ID in both tables now let's
change this join to a full outer
join and let's run this and see what we
get now if you notice the output is very
different so let's take a look at it and
see why it's so different if you notice
everything down till here is the exact
same so employees 101 down to 1009 are
exactly the same but once we get down to
row 10 it starts to get very different
now we are joining these tables based
off the employee ID so for example right
here Ryan Howard has an employee ID of
101 but as you can see in this table for
salaries there is no 101 employee ID so
it has nothing to link it to so because
of that it fills in everything as null
because it has nothing to match on this
table and vice versa in the employee
salary table there's a person in here
that's a Salesman and there's no
employee ID at all which means all this
information is going to be null and we
can see that in this diagram right here
so this is the full outer join right
here and what it is saying is we are
going to show everything from table a
and table B regardless of if it has a
match based on what we were joining them
on so even if table a has an employee ID
but there's no employee ID in table B
we're still going to show it and vice
versa so now let's look at a left outer
join a left outer join is going to take
the left table and say we want
everything from the left table and
everything that's overlook lapping but
if it's only in the right table we do
not want it now what is the left and the
right table the left table is going to
be our first table that we use our right
table is going to be the second table
that we use so we're going to look at
everything in the employee demographics
table regardless of whether or not it
has a match on the employee ID in the
employee salary table so this is what
that looks like so as you can see this
is our entire table for employee
demographics and down here we have three
that have information in the employee
demographics table but have absolutely
no information in any of the employee
salary table because there's nothing to
match it on so this 101 is not in this
table this 13 is not in this table and
this one does not even have an employee
ID so we're not going to have a match at
all and if we change that to the
right you'll see the exact opposite it's
going to show us everything in the
employee salary table so now we have all
of our information right here from the
employee salary table and if it doesn't
match in this table it's just going to
give nulls so down here we have 1,0 and
obviously there's not going to be
anything associated with that because
there's no 10,0 in the employee
demographics table and for this one we
have a Salesman with no employee ID and
since there's no employee ID to tie it
to this demographics table we're going
to have nothing and we can see that in
the diagram right here so for the left
outer join we're looking at everything
in table a which is our demographics
table and in our right outer join
looking at everything at table B which
is our salary table now let's pull this
down a little bit so so far we've only
been using the select star so we've been
selecting everything and I only did that
just for demonstration purposes but you
most likely would not be doing this when
you actually use these joins what you're
probably going to want to do is Select
exactly what columns you want in your
output so for example let's do employee
ID let's do first
name last
name and let's do job
title and let's do
salary and let's try to run that really
quick and as you can see it is not going
to work now why is that not working it's
not working because we have two Fields
one in each of these tables and we have
to specify what employee ID we want
because that is going to drastically
change what our output is so we have an
employee ID in this table and in this
table which one do we want to use so for
this demonstration let's use employeed
demographics. employee ID and let's
actually just do an inner join because
it's easier for the
output now let's run this and see what
we get so as you can see we now have the
employee ID first name last name job
title and salary now we're doing this
with an injoin based off the employee ID
from the employee demographics table but
if we use the employee salary table it
should give us the exact same output and
that's cuz we're using an in join and an
in joint is only going to show us
everything that overlaps between both
tables but now let's try a write outer
join and let's run this now we're using
this employee ID from our employee
salary table and since we're doing a
write outer join we're going to get all
the information from our employee salary
table and it does not have to be in our
left table which is our employee
demographics table so if you look at the
information down here this 110 is in the
employee salary table but it's in this
position because that's what we're
looking at in our select statement and
then over here we have our salary and
since we have information right here
which is in our employee salary table
but there is no employee employe ID our
employee ID is null now let's change
this to look at the employee
demographics employee ID and execute it
as you can see that 110 is gone now we
just have this information right down
here and we didn't have the employee ID
for either of these so it's going to
show it regardless and that's again
because we have a right outer join and
that's why we have no employee ID down
here now let's do a left
join and it's basically going to do the
opposite of what we just looked at now
we're looking at everything from our
left table regardless of if it's in our
right table and so our left table is our
employee demographics table and we are
looking at our employee demographics ID
so with the employee demographics ID
it's going to show us the first name and
the last name which is everything in our
left table our employee demographics
table and since for these IDs or lack of
IDs it's just going to give us NES in
all of these places if I change it right
up here to the employee salary employee
ID and I execute it because we're
showing everything from our left table
which is our employee demographics table
we are still going to see our names but
since we're using the employee ID from
our right table now we're just going to
have blanks in this information and this
information now let's look at a use case
for these joins let's say Robert
California is pressuring Michael Scott
to meet his quarterly quota and Michael
Scott is almost there he needs like a
thousand more dollars and he comes up
with the genius idea to deduct pay from
the highest paid employee at his Branch
besides himself so how does he go about
doing this and identifying the person
that makes the most money well of course
he's going to come to SQL first so we
actually want to look at a
full outer join real quick
and let's just look at
everything so here's what we have we
have the employee ID first name last
name age gender employee ID job title
and salary now what information do we
need to know to get the information that
Michael Scott needs well we need the
employee ID we want the first name and
last name so let's write all that real
quick so employee ID we need first name
name we
need last name and then we're also going
to need the
salary cuz we need to know who is the
highest paid
employee so now let's do an injin
because we really only want to look at
the employee IDs where we know what
their name is and their salary is and
let's do this based off the employee
demographics table really doesn't matter
for an in join but let's do that real
quick so let's look at this so we have
our employee ID we have our first name
our last name and our salary and we want
to do it where it's not Michael Scott
and that's because Michael doesn't want
to take away his own money he wants to
take away his employees money so let's
do
where first name does not equal Michael
and he knows that he's the only one that
is not named Michael so now we have our
list and let's do order
bu and let's do
salary and let's execute
this and let's do descending so that we
can get at the very
top and this is tough tough news for
Dwight shut because it looks like he is
the highest paid employee besides
Michael and so it looks like he is going
to get a cut in his pay this quarter so
that Michael can meet his quota so
that's just one use case let's look at
one more use case let's start out by
getting rid of this and looking at
everything
again so for our next use case Kevin
Malone who is an accountant thinks that
he may have made a mistake when looking
at the average salary for our salesman
now Angela Martin is very good at SQL
and so what she is going to do is she
wants to go in and calculate the average
salary for our salesman so let's try to
get that information so all we're going
to need is the job title and the salary
so let's come up here and let's get job
title and let's get
salary and let's look at
this and now we only want to look at
where the job title is equal to
salesman now the very last thing we want
to do is we want to say we want the
average of salary now since we're going
to need to do a group buy we're going to
have to get rid of this
salary and just take job title write
down here and do group by job title so
we're going to have job title and then
the average
salary and there you go we have the
salesman and the average salary is
52,000 so Angela now knows to go back
and fix what Kevin made a mistake on so
that's how you use joins I will includ
include this image in the description so
you can go and look that up yourself if
you are curious and want to look at that
that really helped me out when I was
first getting started to kind of
conceptualize and understand what kind
of data I was pulling based on what join
I was using so I hope that was useful to
you as well in the very next video we're
going to be looking at the union so if
that is posted be sure to check that out
next thank you guys so much for joining
me I really appreciate it if you like
this type of content or got anything out
of it today be sure to smash the like
button smash the Subscribe button and
I'll see see in the next video what's
going on everybody my name is Alex free
in today's video we're going to be
looking at unions now in the very last
video we walked through joins and I
thought it was appropriate to look at
unions next because unions and joins are
somewhat similar or closely related and
that's because in both instances they're
combining two tables to create one
output now what's the difference the
difference is that a join combines both
tables based off a common column and in
last video that was the employee ID so
in both tables we had an employee ID and
when you're selecting your data you have
to choose either to only select one
employee ID or you can choose both
employee IDs but they're in separate
columns and with a union you're actually
able to select all the data from both
tables and put it into one output where
all the data is in each column and not
separate it out and you don't have to
choose which table you're choosing it
from now that may not have made1 100%
sense but let's look at it real quick in
stages so let's go down here and let's
actually join this table
together and see what we get now the two
tables that we're looking at is employee
demographics and warehouse employee
demographics so over here we have our
employee demographics information and
then over here or actually down here we
have our warehouse employee demographics
now right now I'm doing a full outer
join so we're looking at all the data
and if we were to pull this in to an
Excel spreadsheet we could just copy
this and paste it over here and we would
be good to go and that's because we have
all the same columns first name last
name age gender first name last name age
gender but if we tried to combine this
in a query where we have this
information right here it wouldn't work
we cannot get it in the same column and
that's where a union comes into play so
let's go back up here and let's actually
run both of
these now as you can see they have the
exact same columns and that makes it
super easy for what we're about to do
all we're going to do is between these
two queries which are completely
separate right now all we're going to do
is write
Union so let's run just
this now because of the Union you can
look down here and the information that
used to be in the other table which were
in separate columns are now added Down
Below in the exact same order now Daryl
filin was actually in both tables and
the reason he isn't showing up multiple
times is because this Union is actually
taking out and removing the duplicates
kind of like a distinct statement now
there's actually another thing called
Union all and if we do Union all it is
going to show us all of the information
regardless if it is a duplicate or not
so let's run that real quick and they
they are both there but let's order
by and let's do employee
ID so now let's run it and as you can
see right here these are exact
duplicates and so the union got rid of
it because they were the exact same but
the union all kept it in because it is
showing just the data as is now let's
get rid of this Union all because the
only reason why it works so well is
because those two tables were exact same
they were employee ID first name last
name age gender so they're basically the
same tables just with different
information so it made it really easy
but we have another table
employee uh
salary and let's look at these two
tables so these two tables are obviously
very different they hold different
information now we would still be able
to combine them so let's do employee
ID first name and let's do
age now down here on the employee salary
table we will do employee ID job title
and
salary now let's use a union really
quick and run this
one and it is still going to work now
why does this work well first off the
the reason it's working is because these
data types are the exact same or at
least similar so text and text age which
is an integer salary which is an integer
it has the same amount of columns so
three and three so we have employee ID
first name and age and it's taking that
from the first select statement and it's
still using a union to take the data
from the second select statement so it's
still inserting this information now
this is not what you want to do because
right here we have first name and it's
salesman salesman and then our age we
have 30 45,000 and 45,000 is obviously
not an age so you want to be careful
when you're using a union to combine two
separate tables and make sure that the
data you're selecting is the same in the
very next video we're going to be
walking through case statements thank
you guys so much for joining me I really
appreciate it if you like this type of
content be sure to subscribe below and
I'll see you in the next video what is
going on everybody my name is Alex
freeberg and today we're going to be
walking through cas statements in SQL a
case statement allows you to specify a
condition and then it also allows you to
specify what you want returned when that
condition is met so we're going to be
using this employee demographics table
that we're looking at right here we're
going to walk through the syntax of how
to create a case statement and then
we're going to actually go into some use
cases at the end so let's start off by
specifying what columns we want let's
say we want the first name we want the
last name and we want want the age now
let's just get that
information now for our case statement
we're going to be using this age column
so we actually want the age to be in
there so let's
specify where age is not
null and run that so now we have a
pretty good look at it and let's just
order
by H just to clean it up a little bit so
now let's start building our case
statement so we're going to say case and
then we want to say when now we need to
specify what condition we want to look
for so let's do when age is greater than
30 then then what do we want to be
returned so we want to return that they
are old else so that means anything that
is not over the age of 30 we want to
return
young and then you need to specify that
you done with the case statement and so
you will write end at the very bottom so
this is our first case statement let's
run it and see what we get so as you can
see a new column was created and if the
person is over the age of 30 so 31 and
up they are given old and if they're not
over the age of 30 they are given
young now we can do as many when and
then statements as we want so if we want
to we can also do when the age is
between 27 and 30
then we want to return
young and anyone else we're going to
call a
baby so now we have Ryan Howard as the
baby anyone between 27 and 30 they're
considered young and anyone over the age
of 30 is old now something to note is
that the very first condition that is
met is going to be returned so if there
are multiple conditions that meet the
criteria only the very first one is
going to be return returned and let's
demonstrate that real quick so if the
age equals
38 then return Stanley because that is
Stanley uh and let's execute this real
quick so right here I'm specifying that
if it's 38 it should return Stanley but
he is right here and it still says old
and that's because this condition was
already met now if we were to put this
right
here it should work correctly and let's
try it out so now because this condition
is met first it is going to return
Stanley down here so now let's get into
our first use case let's start off by
copying this and then commenting it out
I only did that because I don't want to
rewrite it because I'm
lazy uh let's get rid of that and let's
look at this real quick we are going to
join on another table that we have
really fast um that's going to be SQL
tutorial if you watched my other videos
then you know this table and we're going
to do that on employee
demographics. employee ID is equal to
employee
salary. employee ID okay so let's just
look at everything in these tables
really quick now we are going to be
focusing on the job title in the salary
column but we want their first name and
last name as well so let's start
building that out
let's do first
name last
name job title and salary and let's look
at this really quick so now we have our
employees and here is the situation we
had a fantastic year this year selling
paper and corporate has allowed Michael
Scott to give out a yearly raise to
every single employee but not every
employee is going to get the same raise
because our salesmen are genuinely the
people who made us our money and they're
going to get the biggest raises well
other people really aren't going to get
that big of a raise so now let's go
through and create a case statement to
calculate what their salary will be
after they get their
raise so let's start off by saying
case and
when and we want it to say when job
title is equal to
salesman so when they are a Salesman
what do we want to happen so this is
where the calculation occurs so we're
going to take their
salary and then we're going to add their
salary times how much their raise is
going to be so the salesman did really
really well and we want to give them a
10% raise this year now when their job
title is equal
to
accountant then and we'll take their
salary we will give
them let's give them a 5% raise still
very
generous there we we go and when the job
title is equal to
HR then it's going to be the salary
plus the
salary times and then we're going to do
01 all right and else we are just going
to
do
salary plus salary oops let's do
parentheses times and let's just give
everyone else a 3% rays and then we'll
write end now let's take a look at our
results so here's what we have so far we
have our first name our last name our
job title and our salary that is our
current salary and then we're going to
have our salary after we get our raise
so I'm going to actually write that up
here so let's do as
salary a after
raise and let's execute
that so let's look at these raises
really quick so we have 45,000 and since
he is a Salesman he gets a 10% raise
which is a raise of
$4,500 so 45,000 plus
$4,500 is $49,500 and as you can see
down here we have HR who is making
$50,000 and now he is making
$5,000 5 so everybody got a raise so
that is our case statement I hope that
was helpful I find myself using the case
statement a lot when I'm wanting to
categorize things or label things and
that's kind of what we did in the first
example and you can even do calculations
like we did in this use case so I hope
that was helpful thank you guys so much
for watching I really appreciate it if
you learned anything from this video be
sure to like And subscribe below and
I'll see you in the next video what is
going on everybody my name is Alex fre
and today we're going to be looking at
the having Clause now the having Clause
I feels a little bit unappreciated in
the SQL Community I feel like it doesn't
get a lot of love and so today I want to
describe how to use it and what it's
used for so before we use the having
Clause I want to set up our query here
uh we want to use an aggregate function
in the group by statement and then I
will show you how to use this having
Clause so let's look at the job title
and let's look at the count of job
titles and then down here we need to do
group by job title
and let's execute
this and here is our job titles and
here's the count of how many people have
those job titles so now let's say we
want to look at all the jobs that have
more than one person in that specific
job so let's do where uh the
count of job title is greater oops is
greater than one and let's run
that and as you can see we're going to
get this this message right here now
let's read it an aggregate may not
appear in the wear Clause unless it is
in a subquery contained in a having
clause or a select list and the column
being aggregated is an outer
reference what that is basically saying
is is we cannot use this aggregate
function in the wear statement we need
to use a having Clause so let's get rid
of this and let's say
having the count of job
title greater than one I did the same
thing again and let's execute this and
we're still going to get an error now
why are we getting that error the reason
is is because this having statement is
completely dependent on the group by
statement because we are performing this
after it has been aggregated so this
having statement actually needs to go
after the group by statement because we
can't look at the aggregated information
before it's actually aggregated in that
group by statement so now let's run this
and and it worked
perfectly so now we only have the jobs
that have more than one employee for
that job
title so now let's look at one more
example let's do the average let's say
salary and let's get rid of this having
Clause real quick and just to look at
this
information uh let's do order by and
we'll do average
salary so let's look at this and we have
36,000 to 65,000 so in the middle we got
44,500 so let's use this having
statement and let's
say the
average of
salary where it is greater than
45,000 and we actually need to put this
right here right after the group buy and
before the order buy so let's run this
and see what we get and it worked
perfectly so now we're looking at the
job titles that have an average salary
of over
$45,000 so there you go that is the
having Clause definitely one that is
good to know and is very useful in
specific situations thank you guys so
much for watching I really appreciate it
if you like this video or learned
anything today be sure to subscribe
below and I'll see you in the next
video what is going on everybody my name
is Alex freeberg and today we're going
to be looking at updating and deleting
data in a table now what's the
difference between inserting data into a
table and updating data insert into is
going to create a new row in your table
while updating is going to alter a
pre-existing row while deleting is going
to specify what rows you want to remove
from your table so let's get going with
the updating so down here Holly flax
does not have an employee ID age or
gender now we want to update this table
to give her that information so let's do
update now we need to specify what table
we are going to be hitting off of so
let's do SQL tutorial. db. employee
demographics so now we're going to use
something called set and set is going to
specify what column and what value you
actually want to insert into that cell
so let's set
her employee ID equal to and it's going
to be
1,2 and we have to specify which one to
do this to because if we ran just this
is going to set every single employee ID
to 112 because we haven't specified that
we only want Holly flax's row to be
updated so now we have to specify
where first
name is equal to
Holly
and last name is equal to flex so now
let's run this and see what we
get so one row has been affected
let's see what we got and there we go as
you can see the employee ID was updated
exactly how we specified it right here
so we also want to update age and gender
and let's do that in the same
query so let's set the age equal to 31
and instead of using and we actually
need to use a comma so let's say age
equal to 31 comma gender is going to be
equal to female and let's write
this and see what we get there you go
now let's look at our
table and as you can see it was updated
to 31 and
female so very easy very easy to specify
what you want often times uh tables like
this will have a unique key like
employee ID is our unique key in this
table so I could easily just say uh
where the employee ID is equal to and
then you know
102 so it's an easy way way to specify
what employee you're trying to update so
now let's look at the delete statement
the delete statement is going to remove
an entire row from our table so let's do
delete and we actually need to say from
and we have to specify what table we
want to be removing this information
from so let's do SQL tutorial. db.
employee
demographics and now we need to specify
what row we want to remove so let's do
where employee ID is equal to and let's
choose a completely random employee ID
105 so let's run this and see what
happens so one row is
affected let's look at our table and as
you can see 105 is now gone now you have
to be very careful when you use the
delete statement because once you run it
you cannot get that data back there's no
way to reverse a delete statement so if
I had gotten rid of this wear statement
and I ran this it would delete
everything from the entire table and you
could not get that data back so a little
trick that I use before I actually run a
delete statement is I make it a select
statement because you're going to select
everything where the employee ID is
equal to let's just do
1,4 and now when you run this you are
going to see exactly what you will be
deleting and now we know that Angela
Martin that entire row is going to be
gone if I hadn't done that and I just
went like this and I wrote delete and I
only had this running I would not know
that this information is going to be the
only one that's gone maybe I made a
mistake down here maybe I accidentally
put something in there that wasn't
supposed to be in there and now I'm
deleting much more than I thought I was
actually going to
delete so using the select statement can
be a very good Safeguard against
accidentally deleting data that you do
not want to delete so that is update and
delete thank you guys so much for
watching I really appreciate it if you
like this video be sure to subscribe
below and I'll see you in the next video
What's going going on everybody my name
is Alex free and today we're going to be
talking about aliasing now all aliasing
really is is temporarily changing the
column name or the table name in your
script and it's not really going to
impact your output at all aliasing is
really used for the readability of your
script so that if you hand this off to
somebody or somebody comes behind you
and starts working on this they can more
easily understand it and it may not
sound super useful especially for small
scripts like what we have on the screen
but when you start getting to larger
scripts where you have six seven or
eight joins and you're selecting 10
different column names it actually is
very useful and very important so let's
get into how that actually works and
then I'll have an example later of how
we can use aling with a little bit of a
larger query so in this table let's
select first
name and
execute what we want to do is just write
as and let's do FN name and all that's
going to do is it's going to rename this
column from first name which it was
originally named to FN name now you can
can use as but you can also just get rid
of that and do it exactly how I have it
and it's still going to work perfectly
you can either use the as or you can not
use it I typically don't I just put a
space in between the actual column and
the Alias now let's look at an example
of how this might actually be useful so
we have a first name and a last name in
this column so what we're going to do is
actually combine those so let's do plus
and let's add a space in there and let's
do a plus and let's do last name so this
is going to take the first name add a
space and then do the last name and
we're going to do that as and let's do
full
name and let's execute
this so now we have a column called full
name which is our Alias so we've
combined the first name and the last
name column into one single column and
we've renamed it full name if we had not
used this Alias at all it would have
just said this which is no column name
at all we don't typically want that when
we have an output we want to give this
column a name so that somebody who's
actually looking at the script or who's
looking at the output of the script
actually understand what is contained
within this column so for that we're
just going to keep it as full name now
another time that you're often going to
use aliasing in the select statement is
when you're using aggregate functions so
in this table we have age so let's pull
that up really
quick so we have age right here and
let's actually just do the average
age and when we execute this we're going
to get no column name and 31 so we want
to do
is give it average
age and when we do that we now have a
column name and again you want to have a
column name in case someone comes up
behind you and is reading the script so
that they understand what this column is
being used for now that we've looked at
aliasing column names let's look at
aliasing table names it basically is the
exact same thing uh we're just going to
write as and let's do demo for
demographics and let's do demo Dot and
it's going to give us all of our options
and we'll do employee
ID so when you alias in a table name
when you are selecting in the select
statement you actually need to preface
your column name with a table name or
the table Alias Dot and then employee ID
and this is extremely important to do
especially when you have a lot of joins
that you're doing or you're selecting a
lot of columns when you have several
joins because it can get very very messy
quick so let's actually join this to
employees
salary and let's do that
on
demo. employee ID is equal
to
s. employee ID so now let's do demo.
employee ID comma s do and let's do
salary so looking at the script now is
very clean it is very easy to understand
and that is what's so important with
aliasing if for for example we took this
off every time we wanted to reference
this table we would have to put the
entire table name and putting the entire
table name is correct it just is very
cumbersome and does not look clean at
all and so using something like demo as
an alias makes it a lot more easily
readable and a lot more manageable when
you're looking at it when you have a
very long script let's look at this
queer where we're joining together three
Separate Tables and after each table we
have an alias for employee demographics
we have a employee salary we have B and
warehouse employee demographics we have
C now unfortunately I have seen a lot of
scripts that look exactly like this and
this is what you do not want to do you
do not want to use your aliasing to just
write an a a b or a c that is very
frowned upon when writing queries
because it really doesn't give any
context to what the table that you're
referencing is and it gets really
confusing as this query continues to
grow and as you add more columns to your
select statement it makes it more
difficult to understand where those
columns are coming from and so when I'm
reading that I say select a. employee ID
okay what's a a is employee demographics
so you really do not want to do that now
let's look at an example of what it
should look like so for employee
demographics instead of having an alias
of a a I used demo for demographics for
employee salary I used s and for
warehouse employee demographics I used
where now this is not perfect by any
means but in the select statement if
you're just glancing at it you can
easily understand which columns are
coming from which tables so when I look
at employee ID I know that's coming from
employee demographics CU I have demo as
the Alias so it's a lot easier to
understand and when you hand this query
off to somebody it is going to be a lot
easier for them to read through it and
understand where those columns and those
table names are coming from and so they
will appreciate that in the long run so
that is all I got that is aling again
not a super tough subject but a really
important one to understand especially
as you start working in teams and as you
start creating more and more complex
queries you want to have it more
organized and more easily readable and
so it may not come into play with those
really simple queries but again as as
you build out those more complex queries
this becomes very useful I really hope
you enjoyed this video if you did be
sure to comment and subscribe below
thank you so much for watching and I'll
see you in the next video what's going
on everybody welcome back to another
intermediate SQL tutorial today we're
going to be covering Partition by now
Partition by is often compared to the
group by statement the group by
statement is a little bit different the
group by statement is going to reduce
the number of rows in our output by
actually rolling them up and then
calculating the sums or averages for
each group whereas Partition by actually
divides the result set into partitions
and changes how the window function is
calculated and so the Partition by
doesn't actually reduce the number of
rows returned in our output let's get
started to look at the actual syntax of
how to use Partition by and then we'll
compare it to the group ey statement
later just to see the differences
between the two we're going to be using
these two tables on our left over here
so I'm going to pull those up really
quick so let's run this and let's look
at the two these two tables Side by well
one underneath the other really quick so
what we're going to be using to
demonstrate these partitioned by is this
gender column as well as this salary
column and so we just need to join these
two tables together on the employee ID
and then we'll go from there now I'm not
going to bore you with that I'm going to
skip ahead and we'll actually look at
how to use this partition bu so I've
joined these two tables together and
this is our output but we don't want
every single column I'm going to start
selecting some of these columns and then
we'll start using this partition Buy and
see what the output looks like after
that all right so let's go right up here
let's choose the first name let's do the
last name we'll do
gender and let's do salary and now we
want to identify how many male and
female employees we actually have and so
we're going to say count of
gender and this going to be
over and now we're going to do our
Partition
by and we're also going to partition
that by the
gender as total gender now I'm going to
come back to why we did each part but I
want to see the output first and then we
come back to why we wrote it this way so
let's just do this really
quick so it's going to be a little bit
different than what you typically would
expect in a group by statement the group
by is going to roll everything up and
you typically wouldn't have like a first
name last name in a group by statement
because it would be very hard to roll
all those things up into those
individual columns and to reduce the
number of columns that are in your
output and so in our output we can see
Pam Beasley she's a female she makes
$36,000 as a salary and there are three
total women that work alongside her in
this employee demographics table and so
in our total gender column over here
this is where we use the partition bu
and if we used a group bu statement to
get this kind of information all we
would be able to do to get this
information in a group by statement is
say select gender count of gender and
then Group by the gender down below
underneath the join so because we're
using the partition bu we're able to
isolate just one column that we want to
perform our aggregate function on and so
we're able to add things like the first
name and last name columns even though
we aren't trying to include that in any
partition or group by statement yet
we're still able to add the aggregate
function to each individual row while
still maintaining those other columns
let's take this entire query and let's
basically just transform it into a group
by statement and we'll see kind of what
that looks like and what the difference
is so all I'm going to do is get rid of
all this I'm going
to copy all of
this and I'm going to say
Group
by and I'm going to do that because we
have to use all these columns in our
group by statement so let's execute this
and as you can tell we are not able to
see the output for the aggregate
function that we were hoping for if we
wanted to get the same output that we
had before where we're showing three for
females and six for males what we'd have
to do is get rid of this first and last
name and the
salary and do the same thing in the
group by
statement and so let me get rid of these
really
quick and run this and so what the
Partition by is doing is basically
taking this query right here and
sticking it on one line in the select
statement and so I hope now you can see
how valuable the partition bu can be if
used correctly thank you guys so much
for watching I really appreciate it if
you like this video be sure to like And
subscribe below and I'll see you in the
next video what's going on everybody
welcome back to another squl tutorial
today we're going to be talking about
CTE
a CTE is a common table expression and
it's a named temporary result set which
is used to manipulate the complex
subqueries data now this only exists
within the scope of the statement that
we were about to write once we cancel
out of this query it's like it never
existed a CTE is also only created in
memory rather than a tempdb file like a
temp table would be but in general a CTE
acts very much like a subquery and so if
you know how to do subqueries you should
be able to pick up on CTE fairly easily
so let's get started writing our very
first C CTE and we're going to come down
here and we're going to say with and
we're going to write
CTE
employee and we're going to say as and
this is where everything's going to
start now CTE are sometimes called with
queries I've never personally used that
but I've seen it called that online but
that's because it uses this with
statement right at the very beginning so
now we have with CTE employee as then we
have an open parenthesis and now we have
to construct our select statement and
this is kind of where we build out our
quote unquote subquery and so I'm going
to take in a select statement that I
actually used in a previous video where
we using the partition bu and so I'm
going to put that in there and I'm kind
of walk us through what that does and
how we're going to use this so I'm going
to paste this down right here and I'm
actually going to go like this just to
make it look a little nicer and then I'm
going to close the parentheses at the
end so now we have our CTE in place and
as you can see it is basically just a
select statement within the with CTE
employee as and what this is going to do
is going to take the first name last
last name gender and salary and then
it's going to take this aggregate
function with the partition buy
aggregate function with the partition
buy and it's going to place it to where
we can now query off of this data so
it's putting it basically in a temporary
place where we can then go and grab that
data so all we're going to do at the
very bottom is we're going to say select
everything and we can do that from CTE
employee so let's run this entire thing
and see what we
get so as you can see this select
everything from CTE employee we are
selecting everything from this select
statement and so this feels a lot like a
temp table we're actually quering off of
a temp table but it actually acts a lot
more like a subquery now we don't have
to the select everything we can just do
first name and let's do average
salary and when we run this we'll just
get those two columns and we don't have
to go through and actually write this
out each time it's just in this CTE for
us so it does all the heavy lift within
the CTE and then we can just query off
of what we want now something to note is
that the CTE is not stored anywhere and
so it's not stored in some temp database
somewhere if I try to run just this by
itself it is not going to work so let's
try that out really quick and we should
get an error and that's because each
time we run this query is actually
creating the CTE again and so it's not
being saved anywhere and so each time we
run it we have to run it with the entire
CTE another thing to note is you
actually have to put the select
statement right after the CTE if I try
to go down here and say select
everything from uh let's do
CTE employees it doesn't actually work
it's not going to come up at all and
that's because it only is going to work
with the select statement directly after
the actual CTE that you've created I
hope this was helpful and I hope that
you understand how to use a CTE a little
bit better again you don't have to go
super complicated with the select
statement within your CTE it can be very
very simple I just wanted to demonstrate
that you can use aggregate functions
within your CTE and then just query off
of those without having to do the the
aggregate function again which I find is
very very useful again thank you for
watching if you like this video be sure
to like And subscribe below and I'll see
you in the next video what's going on
everybody welcome back to another squl
tutorial today we are looking at temp
tables and if you can guess it based off
of the name they're kind of like
temporary tables and we create them very
much the same way we're going to do
create table um it's just a little bit
different and you can hit off of this
temp table multiple times which you
cannot do with something like a CTE or a
subquery where you can only use it one
time or with a subquery you need to
write it multiple times within a query
and so these temp tables are extremely
useful I'm going to kind of talk about
how you can use them as we're going uh
throughout this video but let's get
started right away with actually
creating one looking at it inserting
some data and and and kind of showing
you how temp tables work and what we can
do with them so uh we're going to start
off with create table
much like uh a regular table is created
the only difference is we're going to do
this pound signed and then we're going
to do
tempcore
employee uh so literally the only
difference between a regular table and a
temp table is this right here at the
very beginning this this pound sign so
uh let's just start by doing employee ID
we make that an integer we'll do job
title
and we'll make that a varar
100 and then we'll do
salary and let's make that an
integer and so now we have our temp
table uh let's go ahead and create
it so now we have our temp table created
and so we can look at it really
quick so let's select
everything from and we'll do temp
employee so let's take a look it's
completely empty um and we can insert
data very much the same way we'd insert
data into a regular table so let's start
doing that let's do insert
into and we'll do temp
employee and we'll do
values and let's just do something
really quick because I'm going to get to
a little bit more interesting stuff in a
second
oops so we'll make this person
HR that's their job title then for
salary we'll give them
45,000 and close it off so let's run
this and let's select everything again
and see what's in there perfect so we
were able to insert data into this temp
table and again we we don't have to
create this every single time we um um
or we don't have to run this every
single time we need to hit off of it
like we did a CTE if you watch my
previous video and this one we can just
run it and it sits there and so U again
it feels very much like a real table and
I'm going to get to a little bit of the
nuances of of the and the differences
between a regular table and a temp table
in a second but let's really quickly um
we want more data in there you don't
have to just um do it value by value we
can also just do
um uh where we select all of the data
from a specific table and insert that
into a temp table and that is really
quickly you know how I do it most of the
time most of the time I'm not inserting
values um I am you know taking a large
table and taking a subset of that and
then sticking it into a temp table so
let's look at this really
quick and
and run that so now we took all of the
data from employee salary and then we
just stuck it into this table and really
quickly this is one of the big uses of a
temp table we had let let's say for
example that this employee salary table
had a billion rows or or or just an
extremely large number and we were
trying to uh you know hit a somewhat
complex query off of it where we're
using joint coins and we're using U
maybe some window functions or different
things you know it would take a very
long time to hit off of this but what we
can do is we could insert that data into
this temp table and then we can hit off
the temp table and it already has that
sub uh that subsection of data that
we're wanting to use for all of our
later queries so really quickly that's
kind of um kind of a use case for that
so let's go down here we're going to
kind of create another one and this
one's going to be a little bit more
advanced a little bit of how I would
actually use a temp table above was just
kind of showing the basic syntax how you
kind of put data into it you know kind
of how it's used now I'm going to show
you kind of how I would actually use it
so let's do create table uh let's do
temp
oops create
table uh let's do
temp uh employee
2 and then let's do open parentheses and
we'll do job title and we'll make that a
varar
50 and then we can do
employees per job we'll make that an
integer now we need average age make
that an integer and the very last one
will be average salary I'll make that an
integer as well and let's run this oops
so we have our second table now we want
to insert data into this one so we're
just going to do insert
into and we'll do temp employee 2 and
for this one I'm going to take a query
that we used in a previous video and so
I'm just going to copy and paste that to
save time uh and then we'll keep on
moving from there all right so I'm just
going to paste that in we will run this
and really all it's doing is from this
these tables it's taking the job title
we're getting a count on the job title
average age average salary and that is
it um so let's see if that worked which
it looks like it did but you know let's
actually take a look at the
[Music]
data and so now we have this subsection
of data from this join
above and what this is going to do is is
whenever we want to run this we don't
have to run it on these two tables and
create the join and then do the
calculations which takes time what it's
going to do is it's going to take this
these exact values and place this into
this temporary table and if we want to
run further calculations on these values
we can easily do that in a fraction of
the time instead of having to run this
every single time which will take up so
much uh uh processing power and it will
reduce your runtime dramatically when
you're placing this data in this temp
table and hitting off of that instead of
all these joints and everything above uh
a lot of times these temp tables are
used in store procedures now if you
haven't learned about store procedures
or used stor procedures at all you know
that's okay I still want to show you
something that might be useful um
although this is used a ton in store
procedures so for example let's say we
have a store procedure set up we run the
store procedure and we get an output and
you know we for whatever reason want to
run it again and when we run it again uh
we get this error and you know this temp
table lives somewhere it it doesn't live
in an actual in the actual database uh
but it lives somewhere and so when we
run it again we get an error because
there's already a temp table created one
trick or one little tip that I would
give is doing something like this saying
drop table oops I don't know why I did
so many spaces drop table if
exists and we'll do temp employee
2 just like that now what this is going
to do is when you're running that store
procedure over and over and over again
you're getting error or whatever for
whatever reason you need to run it
multiple times every time that you run
it it's going to encounter this and so
if that already exists it is going to
delete that table and then allow you to
create it again and this is just a
really good thing to do so now if you
see down below I can run this time and
time and time again and it is going to
work every single time because it is
checking to see if that exists and if it
does it deletes it and then I can create
again and so that is just a helpful tip
if you're going to try to use this I
highly recommend adding that to your
query just to make sure things run
smoothly I know there is a lot more that
can go into temp tables a lot more of
the technical aspects or the DBA stuff
um obviously I just want to teach you
how to use it and what you might use it
for and how to actually write it out but
you know there are a lot more things
that you can do research on about
processing speed and storage but unless
you are something like a DBA you
probably don't need to worry about those
things and so if you are a DBA I do
recommend looking into those things
making sure you understand how that
works how this data is stored uh so that
when people use them or you are using
them you know what's going on in the
background but for getting up and
running with temp tables I hope that
this was helpful thank you guys so much
for watching I really appreciate it if
you like this video be sure to like And
subscribe below and I'll see you in the
next
[Music]
video what's going on everybody welcome
back to another SQL tutorial today we're
going to be looking at string functions
some of the things that we're going to
be looking at are things like trim
replace substring and upper and lower uh
we're going to create a new table insert
a little bit of bad data into it and
then we're going to be using that to
work on our string functions today so I
already have this set up right here um
I'm going to put this in the GitHub that
you can just download this you don't
have to you know type this out manually
so go look in the description if you
know you just want to get that off the
GitHub and download that and copy and
paste it save you a little bit of time
but let's go ahead and run this really
quick and as you can see in this table
we have uh our data right here give me
one second so in this employeee errors
table basically what we have actually
let me pull this back up basically what
we have is in this first one we have
here we go we have some uh basically
blank spaces on the right side the
second one some blank spaces on the left
side U we also have Jimbo which is an
error because his name is Jim um and
Halbert because his name is actually
Halbert um and then for Toby for
whatever reason that o is capitalized
and then uh Michael got in here and
added this extra part so we're going to
have to figure out a way to take that
out when we're doing our query and
that'll come in a little bit later I
think in the substring section so let's
get into it right away
let's start using uh our left trim and
right trim we're going to kind of go
through each one um pretty quickly
hopefully I'm not not trying to make
this a super long video because we got a
lot of things to get through in this one
video uh so I'm going to go through the
trim right trim and left trim let's look
at uh the employee ID because that's the
one where we have some blank spaces on
the right and the left side the left
side you'll be able to obviously you're
going to see that one much easier but uh
let's start walking through this so
let's do
select employee ID and before we get any
further let me just get the employee
errors on here so we can
um so that we can see everything as it
comes up so we're just going to do trim
and then type in the column that we want
to uh take these blank spaces out of
that's where the trim does the trim gets
rid of Blank spaces on either the front
or the back or or the left on the right
side so on both sides that's what trim
does and we'll say as ID trim so let's
run this one really quick and as you can
see this is our regular employee ID and
so you know you can't visually see it as
easily on this first one but there are
blank spaces after this 101 and we got
rid of those and then there were blank
spaces before the 102 and we got rid of
those now I'm just going to copy this uh
two times because it's basically the
exact same thing but uh I'm going to
show you them all at the same time so
it's the exact same thing except lrim
and right trim uh and let's take a look
at all these at the same
time and let me pull it up so in the me
see if I can get these all in here okay
in the trim it got rid of both the left
and the right side so all of these were
fixed in the employee ID for the left
trim we're only getting going to be
getting rid of this one this one still
has um blank spaces on it and when we do
the right trim we're only going to get
rid of the stuff on the right side so
this one doesn't change because this is
on the left hand side where the blank
spaces are so this one was fixed again
not super visual so you can't really see
it but that one is fixed uh let's move
on to the next part uh which is using
replace so for this one we're going to
be looking at the last name so let's go
back up really quick to the employee
errors uh as you can tell the last name
um the biggest one where we kind of want
to take something out of because we
don't want that um that Dash fired still
in there we're going to replace that and
so let's look at how to do that um let
me
just copy this real quick and get rid of
this top part um so we're going to do
the last name so let's just start off
with our last name um and then just as a
baseline so we can see what it looks
like before and then we'll do replace
and all we're going to specify is the
column that we want uh to do the
replacing in we're going to specify the
value that we want to replace so in this
it's going to be Dash fire oops got a
little aggressive on that one dash
fired and we're going to indicate what
we want to replace it with now I'm just
going to replace it with blank
um and we can say as last name
fixed so let's see what this looks like
really
quick and it looks like it worked so in
this last name it originally had
flenderson DF fired and when we replaced
it and we took that Dash fired and
replaced it with basically nothing uh it
then fixed it and so now it looks
correct all right let's move on to the
next one I think this one might be um
the the longest one to write but that is
the
substring um and let me take this real
quick trying to save us some time so
substring is
very is very very unique you can
specify um in a either a number or a
string you can specify the place that
you want to start and then you can also
specify how many characters you want to
go out um and and and it pulls that in
so just as a really quick example um and
then I'm going to show you kind of a use
case for this one that I think is pretty
cool that um you know
maybe let me
see so that maybe that you'd find useful
so I'm going to do first name and then
I'm just going to do one comma three so
it's going to take the first name it's
going to start at the very first um very
first letter or number and it's going to
go forward three spaces or three spots
spots so let's just take a look at what
that looks like so for our table it's
going to take Jim Pam and to or or Tobe
for Toby um and so it's only going to
take the the first three because you're
starting at number one now what if we
started at three so we do three comma 3
it's going to go to the
third um digit or or third letter and
then it's going to go forward three so
you kind of get a sense of how this
works now I'm going to show you
something that I think is very
interesting that I think you guys will
also find interesting uh let me fix that
CU I just messed it up so if you've ever
heard of something called fuzzy matching
now if you don't know what fuzzy
matching is I'll give you an example
let's say in one table my name is Alex
and in another table my name is
Alexander if we tried to join those two
together based off of my name they will
not join because one is Alex and one is
Alexander there's not they're not an
exact match but for if I take the
substring and start position one and
move forward four characters it's going
to take Alex from both and then it will
match them together uh and say that they
are the same so that you know it may not
be perfect that's why it's called a
fuzzy match because it can work for a
large majority of the time but it's not
going to work every single time and so I
want to show you how we can use this
here um really quick I need to join this
to um the demographics table so I'm
going to do that really
quick bear with me for just one
second let's try to make this at least
look somewhat good so what I'm going to
do is I'm going to start off by saying
um let's tie it to the first name uh
let's do whoops let's do air. first name
is equal to the demographics table first
name okay so I want to see and I'm just
going to do first name for
ER and let's do them. first name so
let's see what comes up when we do it
like this so the only one that is going
to work is Toby and that's because even
though it has a capital O it's still
going to take it um so you know we want
to get all of them to match and we can
do that but it's going to be um a little
bit of a different way than maybe is
perfect but that's why they call it
fuzzy matching so we're going to use
substring on this so I'm going to say
substring oops let me that right so I'm
going to say substring and we're going
to go one three so starting at the first
position and going forward with three
and we're going to do the exact same
thing on the oops subst string it be
great if I could spell that correctly
we're going to do the exact same thing
so one and
three so we are actually going
to take this give me a second missed
that we're going to take this up here
and we're just going to go like that and
I why did I copy it with the error okay
so let's run this really
quickly and as you can see it is now
going to match all of them and you can
do this on a lot of different things
typically when I'm doing a fuzzy match
like this I'm not just going to do it on
a first name right because if every
there can be a ton of people named JY
you know we want to do it on uh and and
real quick let me actually show you
um what the originals looked like just
to make sure I hit the the point
across um and that is going to be first
name and come all right so real quick
let's actually look at this so it
originally was Jimbo Pamela and Toby uh
in this one was Jim Pam and Toby And so
when we just took the first three
because it was Jimbo it then becomes Jim
it was Pamela it becomes Pam now it
matches and so that's what that's kind
of the example that we're going
for like I was saying I typically will
not just filter on a first name because
there's going to be a ton of people
named Alex or Jim or or or you know
Henry or whatever you're going to do
this on many different things so would
be doing it on things like uh if I'm
trying to do a fuzzy match on a person I
do it on their gender to make sure that
their gender is the same um and I
wouldn't probably need to use a
substring for that but just to kind
of give you a little bit more
information I need to do it on the last
name um so I need to use that substring
again and I would probably do it on the
age
oops the what am I doing come on the age
and the date of birth okay so all of
those things if you if you fuzzy match
on the first name and the last name and
then the gender the age and the date of
birth are all the same then you can
typically get a very high accuracy in
matching people across
tables whether or not you have you know
this is an example if you don't have
like an employee ID which is what we do
have but take for example we were not
given that uh this is a way to match
them using substrings let's move on to
Upper and lower all upper and lower is
going to do is basically take all the
characters in The the text and make them
either upper or make them lower so it's
very
self-explanatory uh let me copy this up
here and we will get going on this
one uh let's just look at the first name
um specifically we're going to be
looking at Toby right here so let's do
first name
let's do uh lower and all we have to do
is put in the column that we want to
do so this is our original first name
and it then takes every single uh string
that is in here or every single I guess
character and and it makes it lowercase
that's all it does uh and it is the
exact opposite when we do upper so we
can now take take a look at this one and
now everything's going to be capitalized
so there is a lot that you can do with
these string functions and this is not
all the string functions that there are
there are a lot more but I would say
that these are the more popular more
useful ones that I typically use on a
regular basis and so I hope that this
has been helpful I hope that you learned
something from this if you did be sure
to like And subscribe below I have a lot
more videos coming out with tutorials on
everything from SQL python Tableau and
Excel
thank you so much for joining me I
appreciate it and I will see you in the
next
[Music]
video what's going on everybody welcome
back to another SQL tutorial today we
are talking about stored procedures now
what is a store procedure a store
procedure is a group of SQL statements
that has been created and then stored in
that database a store procedure can
accept input parameters and we will be
looking at that today but that means
that a single store procedure can be
used over the network by several
different users uh and we can all be
using different input data a store
procedure will also reduce Network
traffic and increase the performance and
lastly if we modify that store procedure
everyone who uses that store procedure
in the future will also get that update
let's start writing out the store
procedure so we can look at the syntax
we'll start off very simple and then in
the next one we'll get a little bit more
complicated so the very first thing that
you need to write is create and then
procedure and after that you're going to
name it so let's just call this one
test and all you're going to say is as
and then you're going to write your
query and so let's just do select
everything from employee
demographics and that is it we have
created our very first store procedure
of course this is super super simple but
let's execute this really quick and take
a look at
it so it says that the commands
completed successfully let's go over to
our SQL tutorial we're going to go over
to
programmability store procedures and it
is not showing up there what we need to
do is we need to refresh our store
procedures we're just going to go right
here we're going to click refresh and
then there is our store procedure now
how do you actually use the store
procedure that we just created so let's
go right down here and let's say x which
means execute and then all we're going
to say is test test and we're going to
run
this and there we go so all we put in
this store procedure was a select
statement and so when we actually
Rebrand the store procedure it returned
our select statement now let's go down
here and we're going to make it a little
bit more complicated we're going to do
the exact same thing in create store
procedure make sure I spelled that right
and let's call this
tempore employee so if you remember from
a previous video we worked on temp
tables and we created our temp tables
then inserted data into that we are
going to add that to this St procedure
so we can see the difference between a
simple query versus a little bit more
complicated query so I'm going to say as
and then I'm going to insert that in
here now what this is doing is I'm
creating a table and then right down
here I inserting that table now if I
create this store procedure and then
execute it nothing is actually going to
be returned it will insert the data into
that temp table but since I don't have a
select statement in this proced
procedure nothing will be returned so
let's write
select everything and we'll just do
from and this is temp
employee and right here and so now let's
create our store
procedure so that created successfully
let's refresh over
here and let's execute this so let's
just go down right
here and say execute and it's going to
be temp
employee and now we will execute
this and there is our output now really
quick let's go into temp employee and we
actually want to change this store
procedure so we're going to go over to
modify so when we modify it a few things
are going to show up on your screen the
first thing that you're going to see is
it says use SQL tutorial so it's just
specifying the database the next two
things you may not be as familiar with
it's set anzy nules and then set quoted
identifier if you don't know what these
are it's not super important the first
one just talks about how it to deal with
nulles when you're using the wear
statement and then the quoted identifier
just talks about how it uses quotes in
the actual query itself again not super
important but they have those
automatically turned on let's go down a
little bit further and we're going to
look at the alter procedure so we
created our store procedure but now we
want to alter it so this is the alter
procedure and we are going to add a
parameter to this so what the parameter
is going to allow us to do is when we're
actually executing the store procedure
we can specify an input into that store
procedure so that we get a specific
result back and I'm going to show you
what I mean by that in just a second but
let's actually add our input and we're
going to say at we're going to say job
title and we need to specify the data
type that that is going to be so let's
just say
nvar 100 I know below it says varar 100
but that's um not extremely important so
this is going to be our input so we need
to go down here and say
where job title is equal to at job title
so when we actually are executing this
and we say the job title is equal to
let's say accountant this is going to
become accountant and it's going to give
us our results based off of it being an
accountant so let's go over here and we
are going to click this execute temp
employee which we just modified and when
we run it we're going to get an error
because it is now expecting us to
include our parameter of job title so
what we need to do is we need to say at
job title and let's say it's equal to a
Salesman now let's try running this one
and see what we get and so there is our
output if we go back here I just wanted
to show you really quick we do not have
to put this job title right here you can
put this anywhere in the query and use
it however you want that's how
parameters work and that's why
parameters are so useful and you can use
multiple parameters for one store
procedure so you don't have to just
limit yourself to one or none you can
put as many as you really like so I hope
that this video is helpful and that you
understand store procedures just a
little bit better thank you guys so much
for watching I really appreciate it if
you like this video be sure to like And
subscribe below and I'll see you in the
next
[Music]
video
what's going on everybody welcome back
to another SQL tutorial today we are
going to be talking about subqueries now
subqueries are often called inner
queries or an nestic queries and they're
basically a query within a query a
subquery is used to return data that
will be used in the main query or the
outer query as a condition to specify
the data that we want retrieved you can
use subqueries almost anywhere you can
use it in the select part of a query the
from the where you can also use it in
insert update and delete statements but
in today's tutorial we're only going to
be looking at the select the from in the
Weare statements and you should get a
pretty good idea of how to use it in
those other statements all right now I'm
going to paste on screen basically what
we're going to be walking through today
but really quick let's just take a look
at the table that we're actually be
working in and that is going to be from
the employee salary table and I just
want to show you the data that we're
going to be working with before we
actually get into it so we have an
employee ID we have a job title and then
we have a salary so really quick I'm
going to show you what it looks like to
have a subquery in the select statement
so let's go down here really
quick and what we're going to try to do
is kind of do something like a Windows
function but without actually having to
do the windows function um and so we're
going to do this with a subquery so I'm
going to select and really quick
actually let me copy this so we're going
to do employee
ID there we go we're going to do salary
and now we can start building our
subquery so we need to do an open
parenthesis and I'm just going to copy
this really quick because we're going to
be doing it off of that table so we're
going to say select and then I'll paste
that and close it as well but what we
want to do is we want to say average and
salary now what this is going to do is
it is literally going to run this and
let's run this really quick it is going
to run this and is going to show that
the average salary for all the employees
is 40 $
7,99 so we are looking at the average
salary for every employee so when we run
this it is going to give us the employee
ID the salary and then in the very last
one is going to show the average salary
for every employee now it doesn't have a
column header so or or a column name so
let's give it um let's say as all
average salary and we'll run that one
more time just to make it look a little
prettier um you can also do this in
Partition bu I'm going to Super quickly
just really quickly write this out um it
should take no time at all and then I'm
going to show you why we can't do this
without the subquery why you aren't able
to do this with a group buy so really
quickly let me copy this I'm going to
put it right down here and we're going
to say average salary whoops and we can
get rid of all this and we can say over
and we're not going to partition it by
anything
but let's run both these at the same
time and you'll see that they're the
exact same outputs and so it's just a
different way of doing it in this
example but it really is just to show a
comparison of how you might be able to
use a subquery in the select statement
now you might be wondering why group I
does not work for this uh really quickly
I'm going to write this out and let's
get rid of that and we'll say Group by
whoops let me at least try to write it
correctly Group by and we'll do employee
ID and we also have to do salary and
then we'll say order
by one two so let's run
this and as you can see since we have to
use the group by it groups by both the
ordered ID and the salary and so we're
not going to be able to get that all
average salary that we're looking for
that we can get in the partition buy and
also the subquery in the select
statement now I'm going to show you the
subquery in the from statement so let's
just get rid of that really quick and
let's say select everything let's say
from and we're going to do an open
parentheses here and here is where we're
going to write our subquery so if you
have watched previous videos where I've
done uh tutorials on the CTE or tutorial
on the temp tables this is one that is
very much like those except I think a
little bit less efficient when I'm doing
something where I'm creating a table and
then quering off off of it which is what
we're about to do I much prefer a CTE or
a temp table subqueries tend to be a
little bit slow compared to a temp table
or a CTE I tend to use temp tables a lot
more because you can reuse them over and
over whereas a subquery you cannot you
have to write it out each time so really
quickly I'm going to show you how it's
done although I don't really recommend
using this method really quickly let's
go up here and let's steal this
partition bu really quick this will be
our
subquery uh and let's paste this in here
I'm going make this look a little nicer
just so you can visualize it a little
bit
easier um so really quick what this is
going to do is it is first going to run
this and create this table again much
like a temp table or a CTE so let's
execute this really quick it's going to
create this table and then it's going to
allow us to query off of it so I can
actually say um and let me give kind of
kind of an alias to this a. employee ID
and then let's say all average salary so
now I can take um columns from this
inner query if I want to and just select
those or I can select everything and
return that entire table again I much
prefer a temp table or a CTE for this
type of situation but as an example I
just wanted to show you how it works now
let's go down to the subquery in thewar
statement but really quick I just steal
this query so I don't have to rewrite
everything and let's get rid of this
really quick and add back the job
title all right so let's look at this
really quick so we have our table that
we've been using our employee ID job
title salary so for this example we only
want to return employees if they're over
the age of 30 and as you can see in this
table there is no age column that is in
the employee demographics table now if
we wanted we could join to that table
and get that information or we could use
a subquery and so for this example we
are going to be using a subquery so
let's go right down here and say where
employee ID is in and we'll do an open
parentheses and now this is where we are
going to build out the subquery so just
for visual purposes I'm going to go
right here I'm going to say select
everything and we'll do from employee
demographics and close the parenthesis
so we're going to try to select
something in this subquery that will
then identify the employee IDs that are
over the age of 30 so really quickly
let's take a look at this table so right
now we have the entire table selected so
we have the employee ID first name last
name age and gender so in this subquery
the only thing that should be returned
is the employee ID and in fact in your
subquery you can only have one column
selected so I can't select everything I
have to specify one column and that's a
little bit different than how we did it
in in this from statement where we were
basically able to select the entire
table and then in the select statement
specify what columns we wanted in the
where statement we can't do that so we
want to return the employee ID and we
also want to say where the age is
greater than 30 so let's run this really
quick and see if it works as you can see
in the results these are the employees
who are over the age of 30 now if you
wanted to display the age as a column in
this output you would have to join to
that table and then put that column or
that field in the select statement but
in a lot of situations you won't
actually want or need to do that and so
a subquery can be a really good option
in these scenarios with that being said
this is the last video in the advanced
sequel tutorials I hope that this Series
has been helpful and that you learned
something along the way thank you so
much for joining me I really appreciate
it if you like this video be sure to
like And subscribe below and I'll see
you in the next
video
[Music]
what is going on everybody welcome back
to another video today we are starting
our data analyst portfolio project
[Music]
series now before we jump into our first
project I wanted to talk with you for
just a second so that we're all on the
same page first thing is that there are
going to be four projects the first one
is going to be SQL and we doing a lot of
data exploration and we'll be setting up
a lot of our data to visualize it in
Tableau Tableau is going to be our
second project in our third project
again we're going back to SQL but we're
going to be doing a lot more of the ETL
process so a lot more of the data
cleaning I did that one as the third
project because I think it's going to be
a little bit more advanced than this
first project I tried to make it as
beginner friendly as possible so even if
you are a complete beginner as long as
you've walked through uh you know the
tutorial that I have made on my channel
you should be pretty good and then the
fourth and the final project will be
with python we'll be using a lot of
pandas doing a little bit of data
cleaning and then doing visualizations
as well as I said just a second ago I'm
trying to make this as beginner friendly
as I possibly can the whole point of the
series is that if you are trying to
apply for a data analyst job by the end
of the series you should have an entire
portfolio or at least a a really good
start at a portfolio to show a potential
employer I give you full permission to
copy every script every query line for
line if that is what you want to do and
create your own portfolio I am totally
fine with that but I will encourage you
and I'm sure I'll say this throughout
the video I encourage you to try to
think of your own queries try to think
of your own insights and your own things
that you can do to make this portfolio
project unique with that being said I'm
super excited to get started on this
with you guys so let's jump over to my
screen and get started on our very first
project all right so now that we are on
my screen we are going to get started on
this project we're going to download the
data set we are going to format it just
a little bit in Excel
and then we're going to get into sequel
where we will start querying it I will
say that I think this is going to be a
very long video I'm hoping to keep it
under an hour and a half I may separate
this into two videos depending on how
long it runs um but you know I I will do
my best to keep it short but we have a
lot to get through I'm going to
basically do no Cuts I'm I'm that's my
goal is to do no cuts um in this because
I want to walk you through each step of
the process so that you understand
everything that's going on and I I you
don't get lost at some point um but I
think this is probably the best way to
do it we'll see uh the very first thing
we're going to do is download our data
set so you know as we're looking at this
there's an option right here to download
the data set I don't recommend that one
um you can it just won't give you all
the information that I personally want
which is go back to like the very
beginning um if you go down right here
to the very first graph um you can
actually push this back and then
download it and what this will do is it
will go back to I think January 1st of
2020 so let's open this one
up um and when we get in here we're
going to reformat it just a little bit
it's nothing too complicated I hope um
I'm just going to double click here
actually let me let me go up here and
filter just in case we want to filter
anything so um what we have here is a
ton of information on Co I mean just a
ton and it goes back to early 2020 I
believe it does go back to the first of
2020 so really quick a really brief
introduction of what kind of data is in
here we have total cases new
cases um total deaths new deaths we use
those quite a bit in the the queries
that are coming
up um if we go way over here we have
total vaccin vaccinations people
vaccinated um and then over here a
little bit farther we have population
that's the main stuff we're going to be
working with today as you can see
there's so many other things in here I
mean you can use this if you want to go
back and do more stuff on this I highly
recommend it there's such you know
there's so such unique data in here
about smokers and diabetes and like all
this random stuff that I did not do a
deep dive in I mean I could I could
spend you know a month just like looking
at this data set and and getting really
interesting stuff from it um but I'm not
going to do that I wanted to do this
faster than uh two months to to
complete what we're going to do um is
we're going to go back over here we're
going to take this
population and we're going to click on
this as and we're going to click contrl
X and that's going to cut it we're going
to go back to the very beginning and
we're going to place it right here and
we're going to right click and say
insert cut cells now why are we doing
this because I've already done this
entire project um and if you don't do
this you're going to do a join with
every single query you do which if you
want to do that keep it there and then
just you know change your query for for
that I did it like this because I wanted
to show joins later on I wanted to keep
it kind of simple at the beginning um
and then work my way to a little bit
more advanced things which you will see
um it gets you know semi Advanced but
not too much I promise um just stick
with me let's go back over here we're
going to go to uh actually double A and
then we're going to click control shift
right key that's going to select
everything over here and we're going to
literally delete it okay this is going
to be our first table over here so
everything you see over here is our
first table um and we're going to save
that so let's save as I'm just going to
keep it in my downloads as and let's do
covid deaths so that has our death
information the next one is going to
include our um vaccination information
which is what we're going to join on and
then um we're going to do that later so
let's let's hit contrl Z that's going to
bring it back now let's select on Z and
go all the way to e and we're going to
do the same thing we're going to delete
this looks like there's no data but I
promise there is later on the
vaccinations um like total vaccinations
if we go down um you can see that that
starts on in February the end very end
of February in 2021 that's because
vaccinations are you know didn't come
out till recently now let's save this
file and we're going to save as instead
of covid deaths we'll do Co
vaccinations all right now let's save
that so now we have our two excels that
we want we need to get them into SQL
we're going to go over to SQL and we're
going to create a portfolio project
database I've already done this all you
have to do though is rightclick click
new database type in
portfolio project and then click okay
and it will create your database for you
um if you open up the tables it should
be empty and that's where we're going to
put these two Excel files now uh I had a
ton of trouble actually importing these
excels um I mean I tried everything and
I eventually just went down a rabbit
hole of how to get these in I don't know
if it's me or or what but I could not
figure out how to do it if you go to
portfolio project you hit tasks and you
hit import data that may do it for you
and it may work um it did not work for
me uh it just it kept giving me errors
so what I would recommend you do right
off the bat just to make sure that we're
doing the same thing um and you can do
it that way if you want I went over here
to start um again I'm on a Windows and I
went down to Microsoft SQL Server 2019
and clicked Import and
Export looks the same but for whatever
reason it it all the research I did it
has to do with the 32-bit versus the
64bit when you do it this way it goes to
the 64-bit and it is able to import the
data if you do it the other way it was
doing it the 32-bit version and gives
you an error I don't understand it don't
ask me that's that's the re that's I
mean I went down a huge rabbit hole but
this one works so let's go over here and
this is going to be our data source
where is the data coming from it's an
Excel file
so let's do that let's browse and let's
go over to my
downloads I thought I saved it in
downloads uh maybe because it's an Excel
workbook what was I saving
before Oh that's a
CSV okay something important to note is
we're doing an Excel and not a
CSV you're going to get the same error
I'm just doing it live and I'm making
myself look stupid so um we're going to
save it but instead of a CSV we're going
to save it as an Excel workbook so let's
save that um now we have to go back to
how it was right
here um the same way and we're going to
file save as and let's do this is now
covid
deaths and save it as a workbook now we
have them now let's go back um now we
have our covid deaths and our covid
vaccinations let's do our deaths first
um let me get back right here so it
looks kind of more
normal um so we have our Excel file we
have our covid deaths let's go next and
now we have to say where we're going to
place it where's our destination so
we're going to click over here and go
down to SQL Server native client
11.0 I want to say this is something
that I messed up and it took me like 45
minutes to figure out it was the
stupidest mistake um it's gonna autop
populate a server name
and I never checked to confirm that this
was my server name and so I couldn't
figure out why I wasn't able to insert
this into my portfolio project uh
database that's because mine is 01 I
created two different servers um
intentionally and for whatever reason I
forgot that and so all I have to do is
add 01 over here so just make sure yours
is is the same thing click portfolio
project click next yes we're want to
copy the data should autop populate if
it doesn't if it gives you like multiple
you can always uh check mark on the one
that you think is the right one it
should be the first one we'll click next
we'll just click finish I'm sure it says
run immediately we'll click finish and
finish now while this is running um
there should be around
89,000 that's how it was like a week ago
when I started it maybe a little more
now because there's extra
days um with that being said you know
there's going to be
a good siiz amount of data um we're
about to do a lot of different things
we're going to start at the very basics
of just like queer quering the table
like super simple um and then we're
going to go into things like joins ctes
temp tables creating views um I the
whole purpose of what we're about to do
is not
to it's not to keep it too simple um I
want to showcase to a potential employer
right that you can do more advanced
Advanced things so I'm going to probably
do I mean I'm I'm looking at because I
have already done this entire project
individually I mean we've probably got
like 15 to 20 queries here you don't
have to do all of them um I'm going to
walk through all of them and you can
choose which ones you want but you don't
have to do all them it is quite a few so
just know that so there's 85,000 right
here that's
fantastic uh it won't show up
immediately you need to refresh it uh
and there we go so that's our covid
vaccinations U let's get rid of this so
we just have Co vaccinations um I
thought that was our covid deaths one
but maybe I'm wrong um but let's do the
exact same thing down
here and we will import and say
next we're going to go down to
Excel and browse and now we want to do
the covid deaths apparently last time we
did the vaccinations which
um I actually actually you know what I
bet what it did was it took yeah it took
this right here as Co vaccinations but
that was the deaths one as it saved so
uh forget that let's go right
here let's do the co vaccinations it
just has the same sheet
name uh so sorry for the confusion
destination is going to be the exact
same place it's going to be SQL Server
native client let's add that
01 and let's click refresh portfolio
project next next um like I said before
if it does this just click the first one
it's going to be Co vaccinations it did
that for the covid deaths that's because
I made the mistake earlier I hope you I
hope when you're watching this you
aren't super confused um the whole point
make two tables or make two excels one
should be covid deaths one should be Co
vaccinations upload them and then rename
them in a nutshell U so we have the same
amount uh let's refresh
this this one is actually the co
vaccinations this one is covid
deaths I'm telling you this stuff is
it's confuses me sometimes to be honest
um but we're going to query this really
quick to make sure we act are actually
doing um what we're supposed to be doing
so let's do select
everything from um and let's do
portfolio project and you can do
dbo or you can do dot dot I tend to just
do that because it's easier um let's
look at this one make sure it's the
right table so we have total cases new
cases
perfect um and let's order on let's do
three comma 4 just to make
sure or order by of course just to make
sure that we have all everything that
we're looking for so this looks right
this looks like our
Excel let's copy this let's go down here
we're going to do covid
vaccinations and let's run this one make
sure the second one came in correctly as
well so perfect so we have our two
tables this is fantastic news um and now
we can get going um we can keep this one
I'm GNA comment it out in case you know
we want to come back to it um I'm going
to really quick again right here I have
another laptop I have already done this
whole project so I'm just using it as a
guideline to know kind of what I'm doing
next so that I don't waste everyone's
time um so really quickly let's just
let's select the data that we are going
to be using you don't have to use these
comments I will say that I'm going to
specify I'm going to say hey this
comment is something I would keep in
your portfolio project I'm going to add
a bunch of extra stuff that is not
needed um just for your purpose but when
you are creating your portfolio project
you shouldn't be adding some of the
things that I'm going to be commenting
um on so we're going to do um or
actually let's do really quick let's
copy this so that it kind of knows what
we're doing so let's select the
location uh the date the to total
cases the new
cases the
[Music]
total deaths and then
population uh now where we're at I'm
going to turn off my camera because it's
going to get it's going to start getting
in the way to be honest I don't want it
to interfere with your ability to see
what we're doing on screen so it's been
great seeing you guys I'm going to turn
this off and we will continue from here
all right that should be turned off so
let's keep running so this is what we're
doing let's actually let's keep this
going because I I don't like things not
being
organized um so we have our location oh
no we want to do one two we want to do
it based off the location and the date
makes things everything easier I promise
you so we're going to be the first one's
obviously Afghanistan here's our date we
have our total cases are new cases total
deaths and population so really quick
I'm just going to scroll down just a
second um they started having you know
the the total deaths it's um it started
about a
month after they got their first case it
looks like so and then it just like
ramps up a lot um and we're going to be
diving into all these numbers what they
mean how to you can do some really
simple calculations on them um but
really quickly we're just going to do
again a super simple calculation um and
one that we do multiple times for
different things um so let's go right
down here and let's say uh we're going
to be looking at the total
cases
versus total deaths so how many cases
are there in this country and then how
many deaths do they have per um uh you
know how many deaths they have for their
entire cases so let's say they have a
thousand people who H who've been
diagnosed they had 10 people who died
what's the percentage of people who died
who had um who had it
so uh let's go right down here and we're
gonna I'm just going to copy this really
quick this just going to make our life
easier I think you should do the same as
well um so we have location date total
cases um and we're going to get rid of
our new cases we don't need that one in
this query right here uh nor do you need
this population so let's work on our
calculation really quick it should be
super super easy let me make sure I'm
still recording perfect oh man we're 25
almost 25 minutes in um or more because
I have the
intro so now we're going to do uh we
want to know the percentage of people
who are dying who actually get infected
or or or or who um report being infected
so we're going to do um total underscore
deaths we'll go right down here and
we're going to divide that by the total
cases total cases and if we do this
really
quick um what it's going to have and
well let's go down to where there's
actually
numbers so we have 34 we have one um
it's it's showing
0.029% if you ever try to get a
percentage of something you have to
multiply times 8 100 um so let's do that
really quick all we have to add is the
what's that the asteris sign um times
100 um and while we're here let's just
add the um what's it called Alias Let's
do let's call this death percentage I
don't know that that works for me and
let's take a look at this it'll be a
little bit more accurate
accurate so when there were 34 there was
one and that gives gives us a
2.94% death rate and we can go down even
further um and this is still all
Afghanistan let's go down to the very
bottom let's go down to the very very
bottom so as of as of today yesterday
there were
59745 total cases in Afghanistan and
there were 20 2,625 deaths which is 4%
so you have a 4% chance basically right
now of dying I mean if if you want to
look at it like that 4% chance of dying
if you get it and you live in
Afghanistan um let's I mean we you don't
have to but really quick just to look at
it further let's look at where the
location um I think
it's let's say like real quick because
I'm not 100% if it's
States
um it should I think it's United
States but yeah so I mean I live in the
United States if you don't you can look
at your country but um you know
we we this is like this is genuine real
reported data so it's really interesting
um right at the beginning I mean the I
don't know if it was the way we were
reporting or what but we had really high
percentage rates um as we go down we're
looking at a 5% 6% I mean this was the
peak of it this got really bad in the US
um maybe get I hope it gets better um
how many are we at this is I'm going to
go to the end of this year we sitting at
around 2 to
3% um um yeah it goes down to under 2%
so at the end of at the end of the year
we were looking at over 2 million people
that's 2
million no wait 20 million
9363 wait wait wait 20 million people
who have been
infected um that's a lot that's a lot of
20 million people who have had it 35,000
or 352,000 deaths by the end of the year
that's a lot um let's keep
going um and at the very end we had over
m346fa um there's a lot of deaths
576,000 and I verified this number um I
Googled it Google knows all I googled
this number and it's pretty accurate um
and it's really sad that's a lot of lot
of lives um and that's
1.78% so as of right now if you're were
to get it today a estimate is around one
uh and three fourest to 2% chance that
you're that you could die from it um so
really interesting numbers this is the
kind of exploratory stuff that that you
know we're going to be doing we're going
to get a lot more advanced as we go on
but this shows you know the likelihood
um and we can I'm going to write that
shows the likely I hope I'm spelling
this right I'm not spelling this right
likelihood I hope that's right if this
not I apologize likelihood
of dying if you
contract uh covid in your
country um again rough estimates but you
know just glancing at the data that's
kind of what we're looking at um now
we're going to look at and let's go down
here let's look
at looking at the total cases versus the
population again we're going to do a lot
of this like percentage stuff um it it's
pretty simple um that will only last for
so long I promise you but it'll be
really I'm going to keep it on the
states just because um I'm going to be
looking at that one the most because
obviously it's pretty relevant to me um
so if you're in another country filter
by your country you'll be really
interested in the stats I I know I was
really really really um shocked by a lot
of the things that we're going to find
today so we're going to keep the
location we're going
to we're going to keep the date keep the
total cases um but let's change this to
population and then instead of um the
total cases being here we're going to
put the total cases there and then
change this to population so what is
this going to do for us this is going to
show us what percentage of the
population has gotten covid so shows
what
percentage of population
oops got covid um some of these things
again they're they're good to know um
the one that I upload to
GitHub will have the notes that I
recommend keeping um again not
everything in here is um not everything
in here is
what you know you need to have in there
this is mostly just you know what I
think you guys need to see while we're
actually typing this out all right so
let's take a look at this um actually I
want to change this I want to put this
right here just as easier for me
visually um just for because the total
cases right here so our our population
in the US is around
million um
so at the beginning when we had one case
I mean it's like nothing let's keep
scrolling um and see where we get to 1%
so
1% that's
3,311
32 uh people and that happened in what
is that August August of last year so 1%
of the population let's keep going all
the way down again we're just kind of
glancing at this we're about 10% um
again we're at the that 32 million so
10% of the population has has gotten it
gotten a test and it's been confirmed so
really
interesting um you know we'll come back
to that one I'm sure in the future I you
know we might make we might use this one
as
like um a visualization again uh I'm
only looking at the states or United
States right now but you know think
about it in terms of how we're going to
visualize this in the future cuz a lot
of what we're doing
we're going to visualize in the future
um in Tableau I have Tableau even open
right here you can see I have a map um
this is just a super I threw this
together in like two seconds um we have
the uh we have the location and so you
know this is like our future this is
what you need to be envisioning when
you're looking at this data so we have
you know Afghanistan and let's just
scroll through bellaro and Bolivia and
Bulgaria and cambod all the every single
country um that that is reporting so
we're just looking at the states but
remember all of these are going to be
used so just something to remember um I
want to know and I'm really curious as
to what countries have the highest um
infection rates compared to the
population so we're just looking at our
population um up here um how are we
going to do this we'll do actually let
me say well let me write it out really
quick so let's look looking at
countries with highest infection rate
compared to population so that's what
this script is going to do or this query
is going to do I'm going to copy
this um so we're going to keep the
location we are not going to keep the
date this is not going to be date
specific this just going to be
overall and then we're going to look at
the max of the total cases so we only
want to look at the highest so when when
we were looking at the us we had 32
million we don't want to look at every
single Pop um uh of the total cases we
only look at the very highest one so
we'll look at the Max total
cases um and let's right here we'll just
say give it an alias at least something
to recognize it so highest U I guess we
can say infection count so we'll say
highest infection count that's the
highest infection count per country um
so per location
um and then we want to also take because
it's going to it's not going since we
don't have Max total cases here if we
just kept total cases here it'll give us
the same one that we were looking at in
this above query what we need to do is
we need to look at the max of this um so
we're going to look at
Max and just add a parentheses there um
and we'll look at this isn't the death
percentage anymore I forgot to change it
in this last one this is
is what is this it's percent of
population
infected so let's change that for both
of these because I don't want to get
confused when you're looking at the
column headers later um so we'll look at
the percent of population infected let's
run this and see what we
get uh list is not contained in either
the aggregate oh I need to add a group
ey of course um so let's add Group
by um and we need to group by both the
population and the location so let's try
that really quick let's see if this
works
awesome um well we ordered on location
and population but I really want to look
at the
highest um so let's so let's just see
really quick look at some of these
numbers got like 1% 4% um 10% okay so
yeah yeah what we want to do is order on
um this percent population infected so
let's go ahead and do that uh and let's
do that
descending so the descending gets the
highest number
first um my goodness 177% so what
percentage of your population has gotten
covid it's been reported and and and um
we can see that now so the very first
one small population so it doesn't
surprise me but if you look right down
here here so that's that 32 million that
we were talking about that's that Max of
total
cases um which is the the highest number
of our infection count so we have 33 so
we're at I mean we're we're right up
there on the list let's look for other
large countries I mean it's us you know
there's Israel there's
Belgium Portugal France so you know
we're up almost to about 10% in a lot of
these countries
so some some of us including the United
States we are we are in there as well
some of us has have really high
percentage rates we just did not keep it
under control um and you know a large
amount of the population has gotten it
that's what this one shows um now let's
look uh kind of at the sad side of
things we were just looking at how many
people were infected let's look at how
many people actually died um so let's
do let's comment and we'll say this is
going to this is
showing the
countries with the let's do
highest high am I spelling that right
yeah highest death count per
population um now how are we going to do
this let's copy this off the bat but I
don't know if we're going to do it the
exact same way because we just need
location um and not much else honestly
so let's get rid of all this stuff but
we do need we're looking at the highest
death count so like we did up here with
the Max total cases we're going to do
Max and then we'll do total
deaths I hope it's like this total
deaths um and then we'll do as total
oops total death
count um and we'll order that by the
total death count see I don't need
this I think yeah I need to group by
because there's an aggregate function
and let's try this really
quick okay so if you're getting this
there's a there's a simple slash
confusing explanation to
this total deaths right now let's go
into our covid deaths
columns okay let's show the total deaths
which is right
here it's an nvar chart 255 it's an
issue with the data type um oh wait
total deaths no total deaths right here
it's an issue with the data type um it
just has to do with how the data type is
read when you use this aggregate
function we need to convert it um or
cast it is what we're actually do we
need to cast this as an integer so
that's red as a numeric um why I cannot
100% give you a perfect explanation for
it but this happens all the time you
just need to look at the data and
realize oh it's probably because of this
data type let's try something else um
and then it'll work so let's cast this
and we're in casting it I find is just
easier but just as int boom there you go
so now we're taking this nvar chart 255
over here and then we are converting it
to an
integer now let's run this um and let's
get rid of this just for visual visual
purposes now we are much more
accurate but we have a slight issue or
we're we're now seeing a slight issue
with our
data in our data in the location section
we have a few ones that really shouldn't
be there ones like world or
Africa um or South America these are
grouping entire
continents so let's go back up to our um
let's go back up here and let's do
actually let's pull it up really quick
because this is just part of exploring
the data and figuring it out so if we
scroll down um we're going to f we're
going to see one like right where is it
right here this this location is all of
Asia whereas in other ones the continent
is Asia if I can pull one up real quick
so like right here the continent is Asia
whereas before the location is Asia but
if you also notice um the continent is
null here so what we need to do is say
um uh where
continent is not null because when it is
null that means that this location is
actually an entire continent and we
don't want that um that may be helpful
for us um later on but it is not helpful
now so now this right here will get rid
of that um and just knowing that
figuring that out now we can add that to
every every
script um and we can do you know you
don't have to do this I'm just doing
this for you know visual purposes I'm
not going to do that for everyone um so
let's say where continent is not null
and now let's look at this and now you
can see that the United States is number
one and
so number one is not the best thing to
be number one in but we have a death
count of 576,000 and again I I googled
this earlier these numbers are pretty
accurate there some of them are like a
day or two behind give me a second I'm
going to take a
water they're like a couple days behind
um this number is actually higher um and
as you know as we continue to have more
people die unfortunately that number
just continues to go up um so the data
that that you download may be a a lot
higher um as of right now we've been
breaking everything out by location
right really quickly let's just do this
by something we kind of saw earlier um
and I'm just going to do this for
breaking it up purposes but I'm going to
say I'm going do caps lock let's break
things down by continent how SP
continent
Contin jeez is that even how you spell
it I don't even know let's keep going um
but now we can do consonant right
here and we'll just copy and paste that
let's get that back up here um and now
we can see where continent is not
null let's see if that makes that yeah
okay so now it's breaking it out by
continents um with North America South
America Asia Europe Africa
Oceana is this
perfect no no it's not perfect um North
America looks like it's only including
the numbers from the United States and
not Canada um so we have some small
issues in here um but for the purposes
of what we're trying to do which I don't
think anyone's going going to come in
here and fact check us or check the data
they may and then you're I don't know
you might be screwed but for the
purposes of
hierarchy um and you know drill that
drill down effect in Tableau which is
something we are going to do we want
want to start including this continent
in our in our queries so that we can
drill down um further into these things
um we can also do where just wait I'm
going to do where
isnull um actually let me see so before
we were doing work continent is not null
but let's do location I'm just I I'm
doing this on the Fly I haven't done
this before I just kind of
am doing
this um this actually is the correct
numbers
and I don't know why I didn't do this
before when I was actually creating this
project but now this is a wonderful
beautiful thing I believe this is the
correct numbers um I could verify but I
don't want to do that live because I I
might look stupid but I think this is
accurate um remember before we were
looking at the location and the location
um and it was actually the countries
itself and then there were ones where we
did where is notnull to get rid of all
the ones that were like world and all
those other things well now I'm just
filtering on those instead of deleting
them before we were looking at
everything but these now we're only
looking at these and these numbers look
a lot more accurate so with that being
said um I'm going to use this going
forward in my script so I'm going to
kind of change things up to where from
what I originally had um let me see
though because if that is the case it
may screw up our drill down effect um
which is highly unfortunate I may I I
honestly might just revert back to it
for the pure fact that we want the
visualizations to look correct um just
know that this is the right way and if
you want to go back and do that I highly
encourage that I didn't figure that out
my first time around um but I'm willing
to admit when I'm wrong let me see what
let me do a time check all we're run
like 50 minutes or so I think we're
gonna we're just going to keep going all
the way through I I I don't think we're
going to stop um I don't think we're
going to stop in this project so we want
to do some of the the above queries were
kind of what we were going for nothing
crazy difficult right nothing crazy hard
um and now we want to we want to start
breaking this out by um continent as
well I'm I'm going to go back
and is this correct let me look no so is
not
no
um so we want to start doing some of the
above queries but adding that content in
there you can even go back and add that
as well um if you want to that's totally
fine I'm going to do some more queries
down
here um or at least one more one or two
more and then we're going to start
getting I think into some a little bit
more advanced things we're going to
start getting into some temp tables uh
stuff like that because we're going to
eventually set these up in um views so
that we have these views to um use for
Tableau
later um and again it shows you know how
to create a view so that's important so
we we've we've done this first one this
next one is going to let me go down one
more this is
showing the continents with the highest
death count so almost the exact same as
we did before but now we're looking at
the continents um we can even go up and
look at uh just wait we literally just
did that
um so that's what this one is
actually looking at my notes wrong
idiot okay perfect um now we you know we
want to start looking at this from a
Viewpoint of I'm going to visualize this
so how do we do that what we want to
look at let's look at some Global
numbers um you can do as many many of
these as you want anything up here just
add continent to it um anything what
like groupy just replace it with
continent and you and you got it um so I
don't want to go through and do every
single one of those but that is kind of
the gist of what you might want to do
especially if you want that drill down
effect and if you don't know what that
is um you know it's like clicking on
North America and then when you bring up
North America then it shows all the
countries in North America so Canada uh
and the United States and so it's a
drill down so you like on Africa and
then there's all the African countries
that's what drilling down does and
that's what you can do when you have um
those layers so you have the continent
then you have the location um so you
know I'm not going to we we'll look at
that when we actually get to Tableau but
I don't want to actually spend all the
time writing that
out um but what we now want to do is we
want to calculate everything for the
across the entire
world so
let's do this let's
say um breaking let's do Global let's
just say global global numbers easier
easier than
nothing
um all
right uh I let me really quick find the
I think it's probably the first one the
death percentage let me let me see if
this is the one that we want
[Music]
okay let me
see all right so let's take this one I'm
sorry that took me a while to find again
I'm not cutting any of this stuff out
you just got to stick with me you if
you're sticking with me this long I know
you care I know you're not you're not
cutting away because I'm trying to
figure things out on my side so um let
me get rid of this so this is the exact
same SC what well let's say where just
so we can get the right
numbers um so we are now going to look
at the global numbers uh so we're not
going
to we're not going to uh include any
location any continent or anything like
that but we do want to make sure that
we're only looking at all of the um
countries and we're not looking at the
world numbers plus all the countries
because then the numbers would get
astronomical so instead of now now we
can't do so let's try running this
really
quick so now
we really can't do this um because now
it's breaking everything out by
um by you know that uh which is the date
it's breaking everything out by the date
because um these total case the numbers
are different right so really quick
let's Group by date
and now let's see what it looks
like uh it's going to give us an error
obviously that's because we're looking
at
um that's because when we're looking at
this we're looking at multiple things
and we can't Group by just the dates
obviously if we wanted to group by
something which we need to
do we then need to um start using
aggregate functions on everything
else um so really
quickly let's do some aggregate
functions I'm looking at my notes for
just a second um to see what I
did basically what we want to do and I
think what'll make things
easier is I mean I could try to do the
sum of Max total cases I don't think
that's possible um let me comment this
out really
quick yeah um it's because there's an
aggregate function within an aggregate
fun function and we can't really do that
um if we go back to the data and you we
kind of looked at this earlier there's
one called new
cases um let's use this because instead
of doing Max we can just sum it or or or
do a sum on it and that's going to give
us the sum of all the new cases which
adds up to the total cases so if we do
this let's see this will give us on each
day the total across the world because
we're not filtering by any continent or
or we're filtering out um like the world
and in the actual continents we're not
filtering by location or continent or
anything it's just by date so we're
looking at the sum of the new
cases so now let's
do uh let's do the
[Music]
sum
of uh new underscore
deaths and we can run that
one um operating data type and our chart
is invalid for the some operator so
going back um and this is something I
encountered a lot when I was doing this
is these new cases is a float which is
why it's working in the sum but the new
deaths is an narar so what we need to do
again is cast that as an integer it's
just the easiest thing to
do um and now that one should
work so um let's get rid of the well
let's get rid of down to here so we're
we're about to do another one and that's
going to be our death percentage
globally across um across the I guess
the
world so we need to do the sum of I
think it's we need to do new
deaths all right divided
by the sum
of new
[Music]
cases all right times
100 let's see what this takes
us um okay of course we're getting the
same thing let me
um let me put this right
here and see if this
works um
invalid data oh that's because this was
new cases
the new deaths one is right
here and let's run
this and now we
are looking good um and as you can see
the death percentage is right here we
have
91 um and let me give these I don't we
can't let me go back real quick and just
say as total
cases as as
total
deaths um and let's run that
again okay and so across the world these
are our numbers so we have total cases
on that very first day that cases were
starting to be
reported there were 98 total cases there
was one total deaths that gives us a
death percentage of 1% across the
country
or across the world and as we scroll
down it gets lower and lower and that's
cuz we have a lot of people who have
gotten infected are the total cases um
and again that's per day right so if we
remove this all together that date Al
together which we can do right
now this
will uh this will give us the total
cases which is oh gosh let me read this
through one two 150
million um versus
3,180 26 so overall across the world we
are looking at a um a death percentage
of a little over
2% so interesting numbers you can keep
both of those queries separate if you'd
like um you know they might come in
handy
later but let's do
this
so we
have
um give me one second check on my notes
again because I just want to make sure
I'm not doing something
stupid all
right all right so again we have a whole
another table that we haven't used yet
uh it's this covid
vaccinations um and just to you know
refresh your memory let's do um let's
look at the table from portfolio
project. Co vaccinations let's jog our
memory on what we got
here so we have
um we have these tests we have um
vaccinations over here which was what
we're actually going to be
using
um excuse me
me uh that's what we are going to be
using so let's join these two tables
together uh and let's let's actually
just
do from actually let's just do this
whole
thing from let's do covid deaths and
here's how we're going to join it so
we're going to say join and we're going
to say oops wait that is wrong join and
we're going to say on so what are we
going to join them on um we're going to
join them on two things we're going to
join them on location because that's
much more specific than the continent
we're going to join them on location and
we're going to join them on date let's
call this one DEA let's call this one
vaccination so a little Alias for these
so that we don't have to type out this
entire table name each time so let's do
dea. location
is equal to
vac.
location and da do and we'll say date is
equal to
vac. date and let's just see what we get
really quick so we'll have all of these
things and let's look at Granada
0717 let's go all the way over
here and it should
have Gren
0717 so just making sure that they were
joined
correctly um for this query what we're
going to do is look at the total
population and let's do that right here
so looking at total population versus
vaccination so how many PE what is the
total amount of people in the world that
have been vaccinated that is that is
what we're going to do in this query
right here so
let's do
dea.
continent
location uh da. date again these are
going to be the same in either one but
we have to specify um let me just for
example if we do population population
oh actually that's a terrible example um
because population's only in one let me
go back real quick let me say I only
write date that's going to give me an
error because there's date in both of
them in fact we joined it on them so we
know there's date in both of them so
it's going to give us an error we just
have to specify what table we want to
pull it from so we going to do
DEA um and da. population just to keep
it consistent um and now we're going to
add the next one da do and let's do new
vaccinations um and really quick let's
just look at
this um and let me get my
orders cu I want it to be organized I I
actually one let's do one two three I
don't like it when it's not organized it
bothers
me so we're looking at oh no I also need
to add or consonant is not
[Music]
null there we
go uh
da perfect now let's run this this
should look much better there we go all
right we are in fact if we want to look
at Afghanistan like we have normally
been doing um in previous ones we do two
slash3 so there's our population here's
our new
vaccinations
now let's
see we're going to go back go down and
let's see they have vaccinations
starting on
218 um if we go even further down let's
just go
to who's this Canada oh yeah Canada
would be a good one to look at they
started doing vaccinations
on right here so 12:15 I mean they
started very
early and their numbers only increased
and now they're you know doing this is
per day right so this is 288,000 in one
day um so that's you know really high
numbers but this is the number of new
vaccinations um there is a column called
total vaccinations in this table but
we're going to do something pretty just
to display again this whole portfolio
project is to show potential employers
that you know how to do certain things
so I want to set up opportunities to do
that we're not going to use the total
vaccinations we're going to use this new
vaccinations which is new vaccinations
per
day um so we want to we want to know or
do kind of like a rolling count um out
here so as this number let me go back to
the beginning as this number increases
718 2300 4179 we want it to add up over
here it's a pretty cool thing I mean you
know it's once you see it you'll be like
oh that's pretty easy but you know we're
going to be using partition bu we're
going to be using
um uh this a Windows function so it's
really good to to Showcase I think so
we're going to do
um and let's
do um we need to do the sum because
we're going to be adding these together
so we need to do the sum of new
vaccinations
oops do the sum of new
vaccinations let's do
over and we're going to say partition oh
gosh Partition by and
we need to Partition by the location
first and foremost because we're
breaking it up by if we do it by
continent the numbers are going to be
completely off we need to do it by
location location and and also partly
the date but you'll see that in just a
second but we need to partition it by
breaking it up by um
location and why is that because every
time it gets to a new location we want
the count to start over we we don't want
this aggregate function to just keep
running and running running it'll ruin
all of our numbers we only want the this
part a partition on the the location so
that it runs only through Canada and
then when it gets to the next country it
doesn't keep going um and if we only did
that by the way let's look at what this
looks like uh okay real quick I need to
cast
this um as an integer like we've been
doing in the past you can also do um
real quick I want to show you another
one convert and I think
it's comma
[Music]
integer um or is it integer comma let me
try integer comma I think it's that way
actually um and you can do it this way
as well that is up to you um you know
either one is totally fine if you want
to use both that's even better because
then it kind of shows you can do both um
but they basically do the exact same
thing so let's go
down and let's see what what's happening
here so it goes down to Albania and
since we're partitioning on Albania
Albania their total amount of
vaccinations is 347,000 I know that
going into it because it has it on every
single stinking row but down here they
started to add they started to add up
right but we didn't do that we only
partitioned on location so it added it
did the sum of all the new vaccinations
by that location so what we need to do
is go over here and say order by and we
need to order it by both the location
oops da.
location and the date that is very
important uh the date is what's going to
separate it out um and you'll see in
just a second what I mean so now let's
run this and let's go back down to
Albania I think it was so here's Albania
let's go to our first one so here's what
we have we have 60 and it gives us 60
then we add 78 so we add 60 + 78 = 138
then 78 + 1 78 sorry 60 + 78 + 42 = 180
then 60 + 78+ 142 + 61 241 so you get
the point it adds up every single uh
consecutive one and when there's nulls
or there's zeros it's going to uh not
anything it's just going to keep it uh
going and then you can see as it's it's
a rolling count so we're going to name
this let's do
as
um let's do as um rolling people
vaccinated let's call
that um I think that's
good now what we want to do is actually
look at the total population versus the
vaccinations um and really what we want
to do is use this rolling people
vaccinated we want to use the max number
because at the very bottom is our Max
number this is how many people in
Albania um we want to use that number
and divide it by the population to know
how many people in that country are
vaccinated so what we want to do is
we'll do this we'll do rolling people
vaccinated divided by
population times 100 and as you can see
we're getting an error you can't use a
column that you just created to then use
the next one so what we need to do is we
need to create either a CTE or a temp
table um this is at this is the time of
of the show of this tutorial whatever
you want to call it where I'm going to
give you some options you can do one you
can do
both you know there's no preference to
me
um but we're going to take this and
we're going to at least for this first
one we're going to use a
CT so we're going to say excuse me we're
going to say with and let's call
it um pop vers vac I don't
know population versus
vaccination and then all we need to do
is specify the um basically the columns
that we're going to input um so let's
put as and let's insert that down here
because what we need to do is we want to
say
um we do
continent oh gosh I'm so bad at spelling
continent uh
location date
population um and then we'll have this
rolling people vaccinated that should be
it um and let's see if there's we just
need to close this parentheses so this
is our CTE it should be
working um actually that's not true I
need an open parenthesis here that's why
it's giving me that
error um let's see it's I'm still
getting an error so let me see if I'm
doing something
wrong do
I have this in
parentheses there and there I say
with pop back there continent location
date
population
ah I believe that is the
issue so then we need we just need to
add that last
column new
vaccinations um if the number of columns
in the CTE is different than the number
of columns here it's going to give you
an error so you got to make sure um and
then let's just say for real for right
now select everything from and we'll do
and we can even say pop versus vag it'll
come up right away so really quickly
let's run this and see what
happens uh the order by Clause can't be
in there I knew that but
whoops let's comment that out
let's get that all the way up here let's
run this so now that query that we were
looking at before is now in here but now
we can actually use it to perform
further calculations um so we'll just do
everything
comma and then we'll do rolling people
vaccinated uh divided
by and that needs to be
population time 100 I'm pretty sure this
is incorrect give me me a
second um invalid object oh it's because
I have to run it with the
CTE my bad
um so let's look at this percentage
really quick
um it's not wrong and it's actually
going to give us a rolling number and
this may actually be what we
want
um so basically what it's doing is it's
taking this column
and doing it versus this column and so
this number should only increase because
as this number increases this number
will increase because the population
stays stagnant um again I'm kind of
looking at this as we go so right now
12% of the population in um
Albania is vaccinated so that you know
that is that's all we know I don't think
we need to go any further than that I
think um if you want to
you can look at the max
one um but you'll have to get rid of
date and just keep the location um
population Etc because the date is going
to throw everything
off so if that's something you want to
do absolutely do
that um you can use a temp table here uh
we can look at how to do
that really quickly I think um so that
you guys know how to do that again I
recommend throwing in one or two of
these um like even up
here you can do different um different
counts and then do one for each um so
let's do temp
table all right so it's going to be a
lot of the same stuff we're going to
keep
this
and this is going to be what we insert
so let's say insert into and we need to
write where we're inserting it into but
let's say uh again I'm only doing this
for it's going to be basically the same
it's going to have the same effect but
um with a temp table so uh we're going
to do temp table and let's look
at um let's say let's call percent
population
vaccinated and we need to specify our
columns so let's go down here excuse me
let's go down here and let's do the
basically the exact same thing so
continent
I think I spelled that
right no I didn't spell that right I
almost did I got really confident we'll
do we and and just so you know for these
we have to specify the data type as well
um because we're basically creating like
a genuine table is just a temporary one
so let's do invar Char 255 we'll do um
location we'll do the same thing and
barar
oops
255 we need to do date and we'll do that
as date time we'll do
population and we can do I mean there's
lots of different ones we can do but
we'll do numeric for this
example there's new uncore
vaccinations and let's do that one as
numeric again you can use different
things um and then we'll do rolling
people
vaccinated Um this can can be numeric as
well
um and then we need to insert that into
here okay so we're inserting the data
and then down here we can actually
select it and let's let's take
this and do right here except we're
going to be doing this
by this right here but it hasn't been
created yet but it will be created in
just a
second okay so you let me see if
yeah so these were the rows that were
affected um and and then we got our
actual output from this right here now
let's say you wanted to change something
in here you're like oh you know I I
don't want to do it we this let me
comment that out and then let me do this
and um create that table again oh no we
got an error um how can we get around
this very simple I've done this in a I
should do this in a different one you
can do drop table if exist
and then do this right
here um and when we run this it
should give us our output I highly
recommend just adding this especially if
you plan on making any alterations so
that when you um run it multiple times
you don't have to you know go and then
delete the view or or delete the temp
table or drop temp table or you know
it's just built in it's at the top it's
easy to maintain and it looks good it's
it's something that that a lot of people
do and so if you have that at the top of
your query and somebody you know
somebody who wants to hire you looks at
this like oh okay that makes sense I'm
glad they included that they know what
they're doing this guy's smart I should
hire them um now what we're going to do
is uh I feel like I've showed you as
much as I can show you um with the
limited data that we've looked at again
I could have done this for six hours
straight if I had used all the data at
least I mean there's just so much data
but let's create a view you know I'm
only going to show you how to create one
view but I want you to go back and
create multiple views you know if this
is one that you want to look at these
Global numbers um let's look at this one
really quick if you want to look at this
number right here toss it in a view I
mean that one doesn't make sense to toss
in a view but this
one toss these numbers in a view um and
we're we're going to um look at it in
Tableau later but for right now let's
just create our
view um so like let's just
say
creating view to store data for
later
visualizations all right so let's say
create view um and I want I'm just going
to keep the same thing um like that um
and for views it's so easy I mean I'm
literally just going to and I can even
take um the order by I believe we'll see
if I'm
correct um actually let's get rid of
both of these
things so it says create view percent
uh percent populate oops percent
population
vaccinated um and let's see am I doing
anything wrong
[Music]
here let me
see the order by clause
I was completely wrong I was wondering
why I was getting that now let's try
running it okay so it ran successfully
um let's look at our views it's not
going to be in there let's refresh it
hey look we got our very first view we
can open that up like a table if we want
to um isn't it's I mean it's gorgeous um
if you want to get rid of that select or
sorry control shift R that's a
refresh um and now it it basically
recognized is it but let's go back here
for a
second um and you know we can now query
off of that it's a view now so you know
it's it's something that you can it's
permanent you know you have to go in and
actually delete it's not like a temp
table this is now permanent and this
could be something that we now use for a
visualization later so do some of these
look at some of the queries that we've
looked at and create a few of these
views um and we will use them later
um normally in like a normal setting uh
if I was actually working I would put
some of these in actual like I would
call them like a work view or a work
table or something set aside so that I
can use them consistently um but I would
also set them aside so that I could
connect Tableau to that view now we're
going to be using something called
Tableau public that'll be in the very
next tutorial unfortunately um
let me see if I can show you I can't
show you Tableau public does not connect
to SQL databases um and that's because
it's free and I totally get it you have
to pay for the upgraded version but I am
not a a billionaire okay I cannot afford
uh the real version of Tableau I'm also
not like a student or or like something
where I can get it cheap so I'm not
paying for that so we're going to use
Tableau public and and I recommend this
anyways because anybody can access it
it's it's free for anybody so we're
going to be using Tableau in the next
one to actually visualize a lot of these
things I want to get at least five
visualizations we're going to create a
dashboard it's going to be a beautiful
beautiful thing all right so the very
last thing that we are going to do is we
are going to actually save this and then
put it into GitHub and I just want to
show you how to do that that's where
we're going to be storing our code at
least for now um so let's go up here
let's click file let's click save as
I've already have multiple versions of
this let's just put
B2 we're going to save that so we have
this saved now I'm going to go over here
I'm going to go to my GitHub now if you
don't have an account I highly recommend
getting an account so you can start
putting your portfolio projects in here
of course we're not going to put our
Tableau one in here but our SQL ones and
our python ones you can put in here
again I'll talk a lot more about how we
actually want to display this in GitHub
or other places but what we're going to
do for this is we're going to create a
new
repository let's call this one
portfolio
projects make it public we'll create the
repository we'll do all that extra stuff
later so what we now want to do is
upload an existing file we'll click
right there go to choose files and we'll
click this latest one that we saved uh
and we'll open it and we can always
change the name of it later on and you
can add notes if you'd like but we'll
commit that change so we'll actually
upload this uh this
file um but let's look at it really
quick and I'm going to go back and I'm
going to use the real one where has the
formatting and and the notes that I have
that I wanted to add in there but as you
can see you know you can see all of the
queries that we wrote and this is
fantastic so if somebody comes in here
you know we'll have more notes and kind
of better comments on what they do um
and what the takeaway is this from for a
hiring manager to you know when they
actually look at this so this is a
really really good place to start again
uh this may not be your optimal place to
put this I'll give you a few different
options in a later video about how we
can actually uh potentially improve upon
this I'm really looking forward to
getting more portfolio projects done so
we can actually start building a compl
complete
portfolio uh if you've stuck around all
this way I just want to say
congratulations I mean I know this was a
long video I know that it took a long
time but you stuck with me uh you you
put in the hard work and that is
fantastic and I really hope that it pays
off and I hope that this has been
helpful thank you for watching we'll
have a lot more uh videos in the future
on these portfolio projects and I'm I'm
just really really looking forward to
doing them to be honest so thank you for
sticking with with me uh thank you for
watching I really appreciate it if you
like this video be sure to like And
subscribe below and I will see you in
the next
[Music]
video what's going on everybody welcome
back to another video today we will be
heading back in a sequel for our third
portfolio
project
now I am extremely excited for this
project in particular for a few reasons
one we're getting back into SQL and I
really like SQL and two we are finally
focusing on data cleaning and I have
talked so much about why data cleaning
is important and that you really need to
learn how to clean data and that that's
a big part of what a data analyst does
but I haven't actually showed you how to
do it yet and so that is what this whole
project is going to be and then at the
end you'll get to add it to your
portfolio so it's really a win-win now
before we start I just want to say that
I think it's going to be a little bit
more advanced than our very first video
in Sequel where we walk through data
exploration if you see something that
you have never seen before I will do my
best to explain it while we're walking
through it but if you get confused or it
seems a little complicated please pause
it Google it do a little bit of research
and then come back and I think that will
be very helpful with that being said
let's jump over to my screen and we'll
get started on the project so we're
going to start over here on GitHub and
this is where I've actually put the data
set that we are going to be using so I
will put this link in the description uh
we're going to go right over here to the
Nashville housing data for data cleaning
all you have to do is Click download and
it's going to download it and you can
open it up if you want to we're not
going to do anything to this data at all
but really quick I'm just going to show
you what it does look like um and we'll
of course look at this in SQL in just a
little bit but we have a unique ID
parcel ID uh we have this
address a sales date uh the price of the
home so this is housing data if you
didn't pick up on that already uh who
actually owns the home the owner address
and then some information about land
value um bedrooms bathrooms things like
that again not super important um
because we're going to be doing all of
this in uh SQL so let's actually get
this data into SQL we're going to import
it the exact same way that we did uh in
the very first video so we're going to
come right over here going to go all the
way down to Microsoft SQL Server 2019
Import and Export we'll click next our
data source is like last time a
Microsoft Excel and let's take a
look and we'll take that first one this
is the most recent one I've downloaded
but I just wanted to make sure so I
downloaded a few times um for the
destination we're going to click SQL
Server native client
11.0 and this is my client or my server
right here
and I'm going to go down here and I want
to put it in this portfolio project so
you know just configure this to what
your server is um again if you haven't
done this before you've never set up SQL
server or a server um to go on SQL
Server I will leave a link hopefully
right here also in the description uh
like I did for the first project so um
you know be sure to go through that
video so that you know how to download
this and have everything we're going to
copy the data we're going to take sheet
one um we could renamed sheet one to
something else but uh we didn't and then
we're going to finish this and finish
and it should run successfully
hopefully it's looking good perfect so
we have
56477 so let's head over to
SQL all right let's go to our
database portfolio project uh and here
is our sheet one now I'm going to rename
this um let's rename name it what is it
Nashville let's just do Nashville
housing that's what I'm going to rename
it as um at least so when I post these
queries um to the GitHub and you see
them this is what they will be so if you
want to have them the exact same or be
able to copy and paste them um you know
you should you should do that as well so
let's take a look really quick let's
select the top
1,000 but there's about 56,000 rows
there's a lot of data in here um and a
lot of things so
uh I'm about to open up a a save thing
and we'll walk through the exact things
that we're going to be working on in
just a little bit but um yeah this is
what the data looks like in here there's
lots of columns uh lots of data so
really excited about this um let me pull
this open really fast it's going to be
this project walkth through here are the
things and I'm going to show you this
really quickly here are the things that
we're going to be walking through so
we're going to standardize the date
format we're going to populate the
property address data um that's
referring to this right here if you
notice there's the address and there's
also the city that it's in so we want to
be able to separate that out um and that
is actually right over here we're going
to be doing the same same thing to the
owner address except that has an address
a city and the state um which makes it a
little bit more complicated and so um
that one should be really really cool to
to show you um oh whoops I I messed up
that's what this one is breaking out
into individual columns that's where
going to do for that this popular in the
property address um you know if you
notice and we'll go into this a little
bit there's actually some values in the
property address that are blank but I'm
going to show you how you can actually
populate that um which you know is a
it's just a cool trick that I've used a
few times and it it it does work I think
you'll find that one interesting um in
the sold as vacant field we're going to
be doing some um some case statements if
then um then we're going to be removing
duplicates and then delet deleting
unused columns so we have a lot to get
through this could be potentially the
longest video and I'm okay with that um
because I'm I love SQL down here and and
I will say that when I when I in the
very first video I said it was going to
be an ETL video um and I fully intended
on doing that but I ran into not issues
on my side but issues in the fact that
the ma vast majority of people who are
going to be watching this are not going
to be able to do what I did to configure
my server um but I left it in here
anyways when I think ETL is an automated
process in order to uh extract the data
from somewhere we're going to transform
it and then put it somewhere this was
going to be the extraction method um and
I was going to put it in a store
procedure so that you could um you know
run the run the store procedure run the
job import the data it was going to be
really cool but I know that if I was
having trouble with it me trying to
explain it to you and you being able to
figure it out on your side was going to
be very tough I left the this anyways
because I was able to get to work on my
computer um but it is tough and it took
a lot of research um and I did this for
a previous server like a year or two ago
and I remember it being crazy hard but I
was able to figure it out on my computer
so if you want to try it out um try it
out and and look into the stuff so I'm
going to leave this here this is just
for if you want to try it it's a little
more advanced um and so you don't have
to just important and this will be a
data cleaning project
instead of an ETL project but data
cleaning is what 90% it was going to be
anyways um anyways let's go back up to
the very top really quickly I have a
whole another laptop right here as I did
in the first video I didn't show it to
you last time but um I have all of my
queries written out over here I'm going
to try to do this as quickly as possible
we have a lot to get through now before
we start writing our queries I am going
to turn off my camera so I do not get in
the way all right you should still be
hearing my voice let's let get started
let's just start with select everything
and we'll do from uh and it is portfolio
project.
db. Nashville housing so let's just get
this pulled up on
screen awesome so this is exactly what
we were looking at
before and the very first thing that
we're going to be looking at is this
sale date now uh I wrote standardized
sale date but I'm really just going to
change the sale date um so let's copy
this really
quick and let's look at just s
date and it has this time on the end and
it serves absolutely no purpose and I it
just annoys me I want to take that off
and so right now it's a say it's a date
time format but we're going to convert
and we're going to do date and we're
going to take sale
date sale date and we're going to go
like that and let's run this really
quick and this is what we want it to
look like all right so let's say update
and we have portfolio project specified
up here so we can just say Nashville
housing and we are going to set sale
date equal to and we're just going to
copy this now I will say before we do
this um I had some issues in my when I
was initially doing it whether or not it
made the update and I was I'm not sure
why why not it was doing it um so yeah
it's not doing it right now I you try it
out on yours it may or may not be
working I'm not exactly sure why that is
because I would say like 80% of the time
it's doing it 10 20% it's not I don't
know why um no logical explanation of
that but uh when I most the time when I
did it they would then be the same
column something we can do I just
thought of we can do alter alter can't
even say that word alter
table and we can say um I think it's new
or it's add add um give me one
second yeah so add and we'll just do
sale date
converted um and let's make that a date
format and bum just like this and then
we can
say like this and say
sale date
converted um let's try this and see what
happens so I'm going to add this
column and then I'm going to update this
and it says it's affected let's see what
happened uh so let's write sale
date convert
sale date
converted let's see what happened let's
see if it actually
worked and it worked okay so we we now
have a column um and maybe at the end
we'll remove that sale date column U so
that we just have that sale date
converted but we know what that is you
don't have to name it that you can name
it sale date to or something like that
um cool well let's go down to the
property address and let's get a just a
really quick look at it uh let's copy
this up here I hate rewriting this stuff
so I'm always copying and pasting um but
we're going to be working with the prop
address there we go so let's take a look
at this really
quick
um so let's look at sorry I was looking
at my notes we need to look at where the
property address is null so what you'll
see really quick when we run this is
that there are null values um why there
are null values yeah I really don't know
um I I really am not sure but let's look
at
everything where this
is um where it's n so we have this
property address we have a sale date a
price legal reference um there's this
parcel ID and there's this unique ID um
so we have a lot of information and when
you have something like this something
like a u an address an address is you
know the address isn't going to change
the address is the address the owner the
owner's address might change but the
property itself the address 99.9% of the
time is not going to change so you can
say with almost certainty that you know
this property address could be populated
if we had a reference point um to base
that off of so really quickly um let's
look at just
everything and let's look at and we'll
just order by
let's
do property not property address uh
let's do parcel ID and let's take a look
at this so we have to do a little bit of
some research on this um but I'm going
to show you something really quick let's
see if I can find
example um in not too
long okay so here's an example here's
the same ID so 015 bum and that's the
exact same address and we'll find this a
lot of times and I look through the data
and it's it is pretty much accurate um
when it does have it it it is the exact
same address so this parcel ID is going
to be the same as the property address
um so something that we can do is
basically say if this parcel ID has an
address and this parcel ID does not have
an address let's populate it with this
address that's already populated because
we know these are going to be the same
that is basically what we are about to
do um and it's not super complicated um
but let's get started writing
it let's copy that down there um one
thing we are going to have to do with
this is do a self-join so we have to
join the table to itself to look
at if this is equal to this then this
needs to be equal to this that kind of
thing um so real quick let's just write
that join part out and we'll go from
there I don't know why I sounded
Canadian right there we'll go from
there uh so we'll join on this and we'll
say
on a do oh wait let's let's label them
I'm gonna do this in a really lazy way
I'm just going to do a and b a. parcel
ID is equal to b. parcel ID
and um let's see really
quick so we need to find a way to
distinguish these the sale date could be
the same um one thing this unique ID is
is unique so we need these to be
different so let's use this and let's
say um let's say and a. unique ID is not
equal to b. unique ID so all we have
done here is we've joined these the same
exact table to it self and we said where
the partiel ID is the same but it's not
the same row right because this is a
unique ID unique will never that means
these will never repeat themselves so
we'll never get the same one so if
this is equal to this but these are
different we want to then populate um
populate the other one so let's do a.
parcel ID and we'll say a do property
address B do parcel ID comma bproperty
address um and let's take a look at this
really
quick and let's
do let me see if this works where
aproperty address is null and let's see
if see what comes up
here okay so this is perfect this is
exactly what I wanted to see so we have
this parcel ID we have this parcel ID
and here is our address and it's blank
in all 35 of these so we have an address
for all of these but we're not
populating it so what we want to do is
we want to say use this thing called
isnull so isnull is basically saying
it's the first thing is what do we want
to check to see if it's null so we want
to check aproperty address this whole
thing now if it is null what do we want
to populate um we want to put in there
this B do bproperty um address because
we want to take that property address
and stick it in there so um let's run
this really quick so this row is what is
eventually going to be stuck into this
row so this is perfect um it's literally
saying when it's null take take this and
put it there and so that's what this um
this part of is doing so let's go in
here and write our update
uh so we want to update and let's take
this whole thing from here
up and we this will be the set
oops um so we're going to set
um
property okay we need to specify um and
just so you know when you're doing joins
in an update statement you're not going
to say Nashville housing okay that's
going to give you an error you need to
use it by by its Alias so let's put a so
now we're going to say property address
is going to be equal to and now we're
just going to copy this is
null and put it right
here and we only want to update let's
see if it it does take this so I think
this should be correct let's let's test
it out really quick and we're going to
run this above query and see if it made
that
update all right so there you go um as
you can see there are now none that have
null in there otherwise it'd be giving
us an output right now so that one is
fixed we can go back and check it if you
want to please go back and and double
check that um but that is what we did
and it worked perfectly so that's what
that is null does it checks to see if
this is null if it is null it it it can
populate with a value you can also do
like a string and what we I mean you can
write you know no address if you wanted
to do something like that we don't want
to do that we're going to keep it how it
is let's keep moving on we do not have
unlimited time here trying to keep this
I'm going to try to keep this on one
under two hours stretching the rules
because for my love of SQL and that is
the only reason um and this I think is
going to take a little longer so let's
take a look and let's copy this real
quick and let's take a look at uh what
are we doing the property address the
property address um and we can get rid
of this as
well so if you notice we have two things
here we have both the address and then
there's this comma after all of them and
there is the
city now you know you don't know that or
you maybe you haven't looked into this
but I have and there are no other commas
anywhere except for in between these
things as a separator as a delimiter
um a delimiter is lit if you don't know
what if you've never heard that term
delimiter a delimiter um is something
that separates different columns or
different values so for us the delimer
is a comma and for this first one
because we're going to be separating
this one out and then we're going to be
doing the owner
address um for this one we're going to
be using something called a substring
and we're also going to be using
something called a character index or a
charart index so let's start writing
that out and let's do
select and let's say substring now the
substring that we want to take we of
course want to be looking at oops let me
um put this down here so it helps us out
a little
bit and I'll get do like that so
substring and of course we're looking at
property
address and we want to look at position
one so we're going to start at position
one one now this next part
is something that you may have never
seen before um and if that if you
haven't that's totally okay um we're
going to be the character index is going
to be searching
for the um it's going to basically be
searching for a specific value okay
that's all it's doing and you and you
can look into this a little bit more if
you want um so it's going to be Char
index that's how it's spelled and then
like an open parentheses and we want to
specify what we're looking for so it can
be anything you can even do you know if
you wanted to things like um Tom or you
can do Val well you do it um like this
you can look for Tom or if you're
looking for a specific word like John
you can search that that's what this is
for um but we're going to do a comma
where are we looking that's what this
next one is so we're looking in property
address uh and then we're going to close
the
parenthesis and and we'd also close it
again to complete off that substring and
we'll say as
address um and let's just take a look
really quick at
this so right now it's taking the it is
basically going it's looking at property
address it's going to the very first
value or starting at the first value and
then it's going until the comma Now the
unfortunate thing is is we actually
getting this comma in this output and we
don't want that uh you don't want a
comma at the end of every address we can
change that um so we can say because
this is specifying a position if we just
look at this chart index which we can do
really
quick it is going to give us a a number
it is saying at position 19 that is
where the comma is right so it's not
like it's taking it's not a value or
it's not a um it's not a string it's a
it's a number so we can say minus one
one and if we do
that and now we run
it now that comma is gone because we're
looking back we're going to the comma
and then going back one from uh one
behind the comma so that's how you get
rid of that comma right there um the
next one's a little bit more tricky
because we're not starting well it's not
super tricky but we're not starting at
that first position anymore so let's put
a comma then we have our substring now
where we want to start is at this as at
where the comma is so instead of
position one we want it to be where that
character
index um I don't want it to look like
this this whole time is it like this
what am I doing it doesn't
matter let's just get rid of this and
see if that fixes
it what am I doing here oh it's just
because this is wrong um and we'll just
do comma parentheses that might fix it
ah doesn't matter okay I'm wasting time
I'm going to keep going we want to start
in this in this position okay um but we
actually don't want to start at minus
one we need to start at plus one because
we want to go to the actual comma itself
then once we get to the comma we want to
add one so if we didn't if we just left
it the same again it would include the
comma at the beginning um then we need
to specify where it needs to go to where
does it need to finish now every single
thing is going to be different every
single address has a different length
but we can use that to our advantage in
this one and we can literally say the
length
of property address you guessed it right
and then we can close this off let's see
if that
works okay what's messing up so we have
property
substring property
address comma character
index and then we have specifying it in
the
comma um we have the property address
plus one okay we can't have that right
there I don't know why I had that F
finally figured it out at the end um so
let's see what we're doing here let's
see if it worked it works perfect um and
again this was one that I'm guessing a
lot of people haven't used before so I
was trying to explain it a little bit
more than other ones um but if we take
that out we take out that plus one
you're going to see the comma at the
beginning right here so that's what that
is um so Plus one and that's what we're
going to keep now we can't separate two
values into from one column without
creating two other columns so just like
we added this um table up here we're
just going to I mean we're we're I'm
just going to copy this down here really
quick we're going to create two new
columns and add that value in so we're
gonna we're gonna add that we're going
to call this um let's call it because
it's property address let's do
property property split um and this is
the
address and then we'll say this one this
next one is going to be property and
this is City split
city city and this isn't going to be a
date of course uh this going to be let's
do narar and let's make it 255 just in
case it's a large um just in case it is
a large string a large text so then we
can say um update that update
that um and now we need to in insert um
what we did for it so this first one is
the address so we're going to say that
equals the address and we're going to
take this whole thing this whole
substring oops and copy that and that's
going to equal this um and then at the
end we'll we'll look at it really quick
so first let's add this table I'm going
to do this one at a time really quick so
you can see it so it adds the
table now it adds the results and again
adds the table of city and sets that
City to that
substring and now let's take um let's
take this and just do
select everything from this and you
should see at the very end because when
you add it it goes to the end we should
have two new values and here we are so
property split address and property
split city um it's much more usable than
this I mean this would be a nightmare
not a nightmare it just be annoying to
use this column I mean now that it's
separated on the address and the city
it's so much more usable of data it
really really is the next thing we're
going to be looking at is this owner
address
now it was hard enough or it was tough
enough to do this um but I want to show
you maybe even a simpler way to do it
even though this is more complicated so
let's go down
here and let's get rid of
this so let's say um let's get this and
let's just say property oops no we're
doing owner owner address here we go
let's just take a look at this let's see
what we got so again we're using or what
we have in here is the address the city
and the state so what we need to do is
split all of those out um and again I
don't want to use substrings again that
was a pain I want to use um something a
little different something again that
you may have never seen it's called
parse name um and parse name is super
useful um especially for like delimited
stuff stuff that's delimited by a
specific value um so let me just show
you what it is and then we'll go from
there so we can say
parse parse name um and we're going to
be doing this on the owner
address okay let's let me see let me see
yeah I mean it's because I don't have
this of course I do that all the time so
annoying so on the owner address um and
then let's do
one and let's just see what happens
uh nothing changed of course because
parse name only is useful with periods
or that's what it looks for that's what
par name looks for and these are commas
so something we can just do is we can
replace those commas with uh a a instead
of a comma we replace it with a period
so super easy we're just going to do
owner address
comma um and we'll look for the comma in
there then we need to specify what we
need to change it to we'll change it to
a period and let's close
that and now let's run
it and it's taking Tennessee so
something odd about at least to me odd
about parse name is that it kind of does
things backwards than what you would
expect it to do uh let's really quick
let's add the other things um you'll
you'll get a kick out well you won't get
a kick out of this as much as I do
here's one two
three let's execute this and it
separates everything for us but it's
backwards so it's 1 2 3 you would
imagine it' be one two 3 but no it's one
two three so all we need to do is go
three 2
one and run
this and there we go so now we have it
broken out this is now our address this
is our city and this is our state so
super what I would consider super easy a
lot easier than the substring but I
didn't want to show you the easy one
first and then give you the hard one um
so now we just need to add those columns
and then we need to add the values so
let's do
this uh let's make some room and I need
to get rid of one of these I think o did
I do that right what did I
do I have my alter table update alter
table update what is this doing here
what is this I don't even know what this
is we'll just go like that so now we
have three perfect um so from National
Housing we're going to say we're going
to say this is the
owner oops owner split
address um actually let me just copy the
owner make it easier so we have owner
split address owner split
City
and let's do owner owner split and then
State oops and copy there owner split
City there we go owner split address
owner split address so I'm putting all
the sets equal to what we're about to
add to so now this first one this three
is the address we'll paste it there the
second one is the city so we'll put that
oh I see what happened here that's what
happened got to get rid of
that um I set the owner split City equal
to that middle one and then of course
the third one is the
state so let's go do
that and that should be done so let's do
it two at a
time oops owner split address what's
wrong with that oh I probably just got
to run this first let's try that
tried to get good too quick um you can
do this a much more efficient way I'm
just doing this for visual purposes I
would update all the tables first or add
all the um columns first I mean and then
do all the updating at the end that's
normally how I do it but um again for
visual purposes that this is what we're
doing so let's go get this actually
let's get this bring this down
here um don't keep this in in your final
queries it's a lot of extra selecting
everything you don't need to do that um
so here we go so owner split address
owner split City owner split State again
so much more usable than when it's all
in one column I mean it is 10 100 times
more useful data now um you know that
one to me you that gets used a lot let's
keep it going I feel like we're making
fantastic time I don't even know I'm not
even keeping track of time time is not
even relative anymore be three hours and
I wouldn't care let's keep going um
let's take a look at this column right
here sold as vacant um right now has no
but let's look at let's do select
distinct oh gosh I hate when I do this I
do this all the time am I the only one I
don't think I'm the only one and we'll
do sp uh what is it sold as okay sold as
vacant let's do a distinct count on are
distinct on
these so right now we have yes no n y
I'm guessing which is no and yes and
then no so let's look just for just
because I'm curious um let's look at a
count
of I don't want to do the let me just do
sold as vacant let me do a count of this
and we'll Group
by uh sold is vacant okay let's run this
and see what we get oh gosh let me order
by okay here we go now we're now we're
moving that's not what I wanted at all
order by two here's what I wanted okay
so at no we have 51,000 yes 4,000 almost
5,000 no and then just a few so let's
change them to to yes and no because
these are obviously the vastly more
populated ones um and we're just going
to do this through a case statement so
we're going to say oh yeah let me get
this ready before we start oh yeah I'm
ahead of the game now let's do select
and we'll do sold as vacant and then
we'll start our case
statement um yeah let's do right here so
we'll do case when sold as vacant is
equal to yes all we want to do is say
then we want to make it
no oh
won't make a yes what am I doing geez
I'm losing it when and I'm just oops
oops oops oops ignore that pretend that
didn't
happen
when sold as vacant is equal to
n
then
no and then else we want to say if it's
already if it's not one of those values
it means it's already a yes or no so
we're just going to say just keep it as
sold as vacant and then we'll end it so
let's take a
look okay so let's scroll through here
and see if we get any that we can see oh
I just went byy some didn't
I oh I just went buy some I know I
did um let's see okay here we go so
here's an N it's now a no so this this
sold as vacant as this column the newly
uh the case statement right here is
changing it so the N is no so this
should work all and this will be a
unique update statement um and I hope it
works unlike the first update statement
that we we did that was a that was a
travesty um let's do update Nashville
housing um and we'll
say
set sorry I'm talking faster than I'm
going set sold as vacant equal to and we
can just literally put in this case
statement um it's not but let's try
it okay now let's go look at this again
and see if it made the update there we
go the update statement worked oh
fantastic it's a beautiful
thing okay great I'm glad that one
worked I was worried for a second that
uh my update had broken in um in SQL
Server now now we're going to do
something um these next two things is
we're going to remove the duplicates and
then we're going to get rid of unused
columns um this removing duplicate I got
to be honest I don't do it a ton in SQL
but I have done it um especially for
like
queries you know when I'm looking at
full tables I I will write some sort of
temp table and like put the remove
duplicates in there I normally don't
delete actual data we are we're going to
do that um but it's not a standard
practice to delete data that's in um
that's in your database so just for
future purposes don't blame me if you
delete all the all the duplicates back
accident in your uh table at work so you
can do this a few different ways but the
way I'm going to show you is we're going
to write a
CTE and we're going to do some windows
functions to find where there are
duplicate values okay so excuse me so
let's start writing out our CTE and or
you know even we can write out the query
first then put it into a CTE that might
be a little bit better so let's do
select everything and oh my gosh I was
about to do it somebody's out there just
like waiting for me to make that mistake
again so we want to partition our
data um when you're doing removing
duplicates we're going to have duplicate
rows and we need to be able to have a
way to identify those rows right so you
can use things like rank order rank
um row number there are a few different
options we're going to be using row
number um and you know if you want to
look into how Rank and rank uh like
dense Rank and all those ones work
please do that so you know why we're
doing it um but we're using row number
because it's the I think the simplest um
and it's going to do what we need
exactly so I'm going to get this over
here we'll say select everything because
we're selecting everything then we're
going to add this row number on here so
row number and we're going to do these
parenthesis right here we're going to
say over and an open parentheses now we
need to write our partition because
we're going to partition this data so
we're going to say um
Partition by cool um now really quickly
while we're here we need to actually
know what we're partitioning on that's
helpful so let me write this so while
we're writing it we can see what we're
doing we need to partition it on things
that should be unique
um
two basically to each row um if in I
guess for the sake of what we're doing
we're we're going to pretend this unique
ID isn't here um although you know you
could say I'm cheating it doesn't matter
but I'm going to say you know if things
like the parcel ID are the same if the
sale date is the same um the property
address is the same the sales price is
the same This legal reference which I'm
guessing is some type of legal document
saying it's like somebody's uh property
if all of those are the exact same then
to me that is the same data it's it's
unusable just for example I mean this
may I don't I mean this data is just
some random data set I found online
right so that's what we're going to be
going with that's what we're going to be
running with and pretend that lie that I
just told you is completely true so what
we want to Partition by let's start with
the
parcel um can I is this not right here
why is it saying this why is it not
giving
me okay doesn't even matter I'm just
going to say parcel
ID um we can
say
property we'll do a property address
stick with me we're getting somewhere
we'll do sale
price um what do we say sale date I mean
there shouldn't be two of this they
didn't sell twice on the same day come
on and then legal
reference
and oh I know why it's not working or my
autocomplete isn't working which I love
um it's because we're creating our own
partition so it's its own column of
course I don't know why I'm it's late as
you can see down here it's 11:15 it's
getting late for me but hey I I this is
an adrenaline rush for me um now we need
to order it now we want to order it on
something that should
be um not necessar I guess unique so
we're going to order it on this unique
ID we'll see if that actually does what
we want it to do um oops what am I doing
order bu come on and we'll say uh
unique oops unique ID perfect and we
should be able to close that off and
we're going to call this R num I mean
that's just that just makes sense so now
we have this and let's run this really
quick and see what happens so um and
maybe we should order this as well but
we'll maybe we'll do that
later yeah let's order this on parcel
ID um order by parcel ID let's just see
what happens because this I think that
should be pretty
accurate um let's scroll down and see if
we get
any this is all
ones maybe should be doing it on unique
ID I don't know let's see if we get any
hits okay there's a two in
there let's let's look at this really
quick because I want to see
it maybe I did something wrong I don't
know it is absolutely
possible somebody play some Jeopardy
music for me real
quick yeah I don't know I don't know why
it's um okay so let's see let's let's
look at these
two um and let's see if I
did something wrong
oops don't need to pull that
up I was doing some research when I when
that convert by wasn't working um okay
so this one and this one it's giving
different row
numbers so let's look at the actual data
ignore the unique ID but the data itself
so the the sale date is the same the
sale price is the same the legal
reference is the same the owner is the
same this is the
same I mean literally every single thing
in here is the same so this is a good
example so we're going to in this query
that we're about to write that that will
be that second one will be deleted
because we don't need it now there
there's only one so it looks like this
is working as intended um I can also
do um
let's do where rowcor num is greater
than one let's see if that I don't think
it will work
actually yeah that's because uh it is
that is in a Windows function of course
we can't do that what am I thinking
that's why we need to put it into a
CTE oh of course it all comes back so
let's call this all comes back to the CT
those things are amazing um let's call
this um row num
num
CTE and we'll say as and then open
parentheses and I don't think we can
have an order by in here let's do it
like this and let's just do select
everything from row number
CTE so again if you haven't watched my
like CTE CTE video or you've never used
a CTE before um this is now basically
almost like a temp table so we're going
to be able to this query down here is
querying off of this table that we quote
unquote
created so um it looks like it's working
so all we're going to do is select um
everything from that and we want to say
where row num because that's now a row
is greater than one and let's order that
by I don't know property address let's
see if that
works and let's see what happens
okay so all of these are duplicates we
have 104 of them it looks like so
there's not many but it there's twos any
threes no no threes so there's multiple
of these rows or columns that are
basically duplicates um and we want to
delete them so all we're going to say is
we're going to select instead of saying
select everything from row we're just
going to say delete
and uh yeah I got to get rid of that
order bu that doesn't work and let's do
this there's 104 let's see if it worked
um so now let's do let's go back and
we'll say select everything and let's
see if there's any more duplicates in
there there are none that is fantastic
every I'm like biting my nails now to
see if each one of these Works um
because I that first one didn't work um
so yeah so it worked we got rid of the
duplicates that is fantastic um and now
it's smooth sailing from here because
we're just going to delete some um
unused columns that we don't care about
this doesn't happen often um this I
would say actually happens more in like
views when I'm creating views I have a
view and I'm like oh I didn't mean to
add that column let me just remove it
because it's a I don't need it you don't
do this to um like the raw data that you
import usually this is I mean again best
practices please don't do this to your
raw data that comes into your database
um talk to somebody before you do this
that's just my my legal advice for the
day I'm not legally bound or legally
held responsible for any mistakes you
make so let's keep going um we're
literally just going to delete some
columns it could be any columns that we
want um but for example we got have
these property split address and owner
split address um in city and state and
city and these are perfect and much more
useful than these owner um these owner
address because this is really unusable
to be honest so we're going to delete
those um and maybe we'll also get rid of
like I don't know maybe the land that
land use might be useful this tax tax
District who cares about that um so it's
going to be super easy we're just going
to write alter table alter table did I
say that right
geez um and we're going to say alter
this
table and we're going to
drop a column and you can do as many as
many as we want so we're going to say
owner um
address we're going to do tax
district and let's also do the property
address all right and let's try this and
let's see if it
works I'm
nervous all right so as you can see that
the property address is gone the owner
address is gone the tax what was it tax
district is gone and now we are left
with this um now remember the whole
point of everything we were doing was to
clean up the data right we wanted to
clean the data and actually now well now
that we're here we have this sale date
as well U and we have the sale date
converted over here let's get rid I
forgot let's get rid of this oh that was
my dog Max excuse them let's get rid of
oops let's get rid of that sale price
that that or the um sale date that made
me look like an idiot this is Sweet
Revenge sale
date Sweet Sweet
Revenge all right and it is gone so it's
as easy as that now remember like I was
saying before the whole point of this
project is to clean the data and make it
more usable um and it may not have felt
like that as we were going through cuz I
wasn't you know really looking at the
clean cleaning data uh uh we were
cleaning it but you know what was the
purpose of it I may not have highlighted
that too much all these other columns
that we created um are just it's much
more usable much more friendly um this
is standardized now and you know we we
did that through quite a few various
methods um so let's go back up the top
we're going to recap what we did really
quick so using this convert we tried to
standardize the date format or change
the date format may or may not have
worked for you didn't work for me we
populated this property address um which
we did that
before we broke this out because if we
reversed it if we broke these addresses
out into individual columns and then we
populated the this thing um we would
have because then we went and
deleted uh we went and deleted this
column oops sorry we went and deleted uh
this property address so we wouldn't
have actually gotten any of that data so
there was a reason it was in that order
uh don't mess that up that's happened um
so we broke it out we did that to to
using um substring chart index as well
as parse name and
replace then we went through and we
changed yes to no or Y and n's to yeses
and NOS using case
statements um then we use we removed
duplicates using a row number a c te and
windows function of Partition by and
then at the end we deleted a few useless
columns that we no longer want to see
because um they are horrible and
terrible and um you know we don't want
to see them anymore that is the entire
project that was everything and you did
it and I'm honestly super proud of you
for sticking around this long it this
this was not necessarily an easy project
we used quite a few new things that I
may have not talked about or showed you
before this to me is just the beginning
right this is just a a glimpse into all
the things that you need to do you need
to look for um in order to clean data so
you know I really do think this is a
good portfolio project because it will
show that you understand and know how to
clean the data although this is not an
end to-end project right that could that
would take a long time and a lot more
exploratory analysis looking into the
data to to figure out what we need to
change but for all intents and purposes
I mean this is a a pretty good project
for cleaning data and I hope that you
learned something I also hope that you
worked on this hard um if you want to
make any improvements please do that
this is not perfect by any means there's
other things that you could change um
you could you know I don't even know I'm
not even going to try to guess you could
do other things to this data though um
and and create your own queries create
your own um data cleaning uh part of
this and so um you do that if you were
able to get this um the ETL part of it
done do that I think it'd be really
really cool um again I was able to get
it to work but I don't think 90% of
people out there would be able to get it
to work um it's just every computer is
different every server is configured
differently um and so it would just be a
huge pain so I decided to cut that out
and I'm sorry um but hopefully this will
suffice um with that being said this is
it you made it all the way to the end
again I'm super proud you guys are doing
fantastic you guys are the ones putting
in the hard work to build the portfolio
for your future job I mean it's not easy
but you're putting in the work and so
and so kudos to you um in our next video
we're going to be going into python for
the very first time really excited about
that one because um I think the only
python video that I have up right now is
on one where I was scraping data from
Twitter so um you know this will be a
nice change a pace or a little bit
different content than I normally put
out and so I'm really excited about it
and I hope you are as well with that
being said I am done with the video I'm
going to be stopping it soon thank you
for joining me if you like this video be
sure to subscribe be sure to like this
video leave a comment below um telling
me how it changed your life uh and I
will see you in the next video
[Music]
goodbye
what's going on everybody today we are
starting our Excel tutorial
[Music]
series now there are so many things that
you can do in Excel so I don't know how
long this series is going to be it could
be 15 or even 20 videos but what I do
know is that I'm going to be covering
just about every single thing that I've
used since I became a data analyst and I
want to show you how to do it uh so
won't just be the more concrete things
um you know like pivot tables charts V
lookups things like that it'll also be
some of the more nuanced things like how
to deal with missing data or how to deal
with dirty data and how to clean that up
within Excel and so those are things
that you may not be able to do you know
if somebody wasn't showing you how to do
it and so that's what I'm going to try
to help you because I know that that is
something that you will need to do or
learn how to do in Excel now before we
get into it I want to give a huge shout
out to the sponsor of this Excel series
and that is udem me I took so many Excel
courses on you to me when I was first
starting out as a data analyst and there
was this one course that I kept going
back to over and over again because as I
got into it in my job I realized that
there were so many things that were in
that course that I really needed to know
but I didn't realize I needed to know it
and so I'm going to put the links to
those courses in the description in case
you want to take those again huge shout
out to you to me without further Ado
let's jump on my screen and get started
with our very first Excel tutorial all
right so I'm going to go ahead and get
rid of myself we are going to be looking
at something absolutely pivotal in your
data analytics career and that is Pivot
tables uh and I think that's really
appropriate it is probably one of the
most commonly used things I think that
data analysts use to convey information
in Excel it's super easy to group things
together to display information in a
very easily understandable way
especially for people who are not data
analysts right I use this a lot for
other managers or for higher-ups um who
don't want to get into SQL or or you
know aren't super text savy in like
python or Tableau they just want it in
an except sell and so I use it all the
time for that reason and so we're going
to be using this data set right here
bike store sales in Europe I will
include this link in the description um
we're not going to look at the columns
just yet we're going to download it um
I've already downloaded it a few times
but we are going to go
to um our downloads we're going to open
it up and we're going to open up this
sales right
here and give it a
second all right perfect and so here's
what it looks like uh at least on my
screen I'm going to uh spread it out
just a little
bit um and really quickly let's take a
very quick glance at this so we have a
date a day a month a year so some um
some date
information um then we have some
customer age information so how old was
the customer again this is bike sales so
what did um you know what did they buy
and they have some demographic
information so this is their age group
we have uh the gender country State the
product category the subcategory the
actual product that was purchased and
then we have things like um you know how
much these things cost the quantity that
was that was ordered so we have order
Quant quantity unit cost unit price then
we have the profit cost and revenue all
things that we almost everything in here
we can in some way put into a pivot
table now I'm not going to go through
every single variation of that but we
are going to be um looking at a lot of
this um Revenue over here because I
think it's it's pretty easy to show the
value of a pivot table with especially
with um you know currency or money so
what we're going to do to get started is
we're going to go up to insert and we're
going to click on insert and then we are
going to click on pivot table now really
quick there is a recommended pivot
tables and if you click on that what
will come up is some recommendations
that Excel gives based on the data that
you have um and it can kind of give you
some ideas of of what you can do with
pivot tables it's going to generate it
for you we're not going to do that we're
going to build our
own uh but let's click on pivot table
and it's going to Auto Select basically
everything and that's fantastic um but
what if it doesn't come like that I I
just erase that if it doesn't come like
that you can click right here you can
cck excuse me you can click control
shift and then the right arrow and then
the down arrow and is going to select
all of our data um and you have right
here a new worksheet or an existing
worksheet we're going to create a new
worksheet just tends to get too clogged
up if we put it on the same worksheet
that already has a lot of data in it so
right over here are pivot table fields
and these are all of our columns that we
just looked at and we're going to be
able to select those and kind of drag
and drop now if you just took the
Tableau um tutorial series that I just
finished doing last week then this is
going to be pretty pretty familiar um
you're going to start seeing a little
bit of um hopefully some patterns about
how the data is kind of displayed and so
we have our filters down here we have
columns rows
values all these things uh we will be
using I'll show you how to use today as
well as some additional things um one
thing that we want to start with uh for
this demonstration is we're going to be
looking at kind of the um these bottom
ones right here profit cost and Revenue
and we're going to be doing that per
country uh per country and state and
we'll kind of do some drill Downs um and
I'll show you how those work so for just
to start out we're going to take the
country right here and you'll see it
populate right over here in fact um let
me zoom in maybe once uh yeah that
should be fine I don't know if I want I
might zoom in it again in just a little
bit um so we have our country and and
it's just like this very very simple
oops um now I'm going to include the
state now I'm going to drag this um all
the way and I'm going to put it under
you can put it above or you can put it
below I'm going to put it
below uh it definitely makes the most
sense there now when you do that it it
um kind of populates it in an expanded
way but you can collapse this very
easily we're going to go right here
we're going to right click we're going
to go go down to expand and collapse and
we're going to collapse the entire field
and so now here are all of our um all of
our countries as they were before now
each of them has this plus sign to the
left and if you click on it now we can
go and we see this state that we that we
added to these rows and what this is
going to do is it kind of is like a
rollup or it's like a grouping um and so
if you you know have taken the SQL um
tutorial series and you've done things
with Group by this is very similar to
that um and if you've done the Tableau
tutorial series it's kind of like a
drill down it's very very similar so you
can drill into the information so we um
can put some values in here uh and what
we're what that's going to do is that's
going to kind of create some some
context to what this what we're grouping
by so just for um visual purposes let's
add this Revenue so this is the revenue
that is bike uh bike sales revenue right
that's what we're looking at so this is
the sum of the revenue for these bike
sales per country now if we drop down
right here we can see that in Australia
uh New South Wales had uh 92 was that
9,234 N5 Queensland had 5 million you
know etc etc so now we can break it down
we can't it's we don't just have to look
at Australia we can now drill down even
further to the actual state is what
they're calling it um the actual state
within Australia and so it's super super
useful and you can do that for every
single one and so we can look at Canada
we can look at France and we can really
drill down into uh the revenue for each
of these countries as well as the states
within them now over here this is not
the most uh pretty um it just says sum
of Revenue and then it has some numbers
not not the most pretty thing I've ever
seen um really quick we can go like we
can um kind of highlight over these and
we can go back to home you can do it in
a couple different ways we can go to
home and will type currency now it has
these two. Z at the end you can get rid
of those really easily by going like
that um already this looks quite a bit
better just visually um especially if
you're looking at it in uh you know
dollars you can change the currency um
to different currencies if you want to
do that now we don't just have to do uh
the sum of Revenue we can do a lot of
different things so let's go to the
value field settings so we can customize
this name so we can do um Revenue oops
good if I get spell Revenue per
country that's fine that you know it's
just a placeholder trying to show you
but we don't have to just do that um you
know we could do the count the average
the max the Min we can do just about
anything we want um but let's keep it
the sum right now um and if we want to
we can show this value as different
things so we percentage the percentage
of column total percentage of row total
let's do really quick just for
demonstration purposes the percentage of
grand total so when we do that we can
see that the United States the per
Revenue per country United States has
32% just between these um you know these
countries and Australia has the next one
so you know it might be kind of hard to
glance at this really quickly to know
who has the highest um but what we can
do is we can go right here and we can go
to sort and we can do largest to
smallest and there we have the United
States on top now when you do it right
here it's not sorted largest uh to
smallest you'd have to go in again click
sort and do largest to smallest and so
now we can see that California has the
has the um you know biggest percentage
they're pulling in 20% of that 32% of
Revenue so I'm just going to click C
control z a few times and get us back to
where we just were um and what I want to
do is I want to show you a few different
things uh pretty quickly so we want to
pull in this profit and this cost uh and
so I'm going to pull in this cost next
and then I'm going to pull in this
profit again uh I'm going to
change the currency on
this and I'm not going to change the
names um right now but you know you
absolutely can do that now the revenue
is the how much is actually being sold
so you know for the United States it was
27 million now the cost is how much did
it cost to manufacture or or store um or
distribute all of these products so that
was 60 million and the profit is
actually how much money is being made at
the end of the day after um you know all
their costs after all their employee
costs after everything they're still
making the United States is still making
$1
million now you might look at this and
you might say well you know I can kind
of glance at it and say know that this
profit is correct based off these two
numbers um but we can do a calculated
field um if you remember what calculated
fields are that's something from Tableau
very uh basically the exact same thing
and so we can create an additional
column right here that is a calculated
field that can add and subtract these
things to make sure that our numbers are
adding up correctly
so let's do that really quickly U let's
go to pivot table analyze we're going to
go over to Fields items and sets and go
to calculated field now we can name this
anything um and I'm just going to for
demo purposes I'm going to say um oops
calculated field demo uh I'm sure yours
will be different now um if you want to
you can go in here and this is the
formula it's almost like um you know we
haven't looked at formulas up this is
our first tutorial but you know when we
look at formulas it's basically the same
thing as writing it if inside of a cell
but here it gives us kind of this um
open text to do how we uh do what we
want with it now what we're going to do
is we're going to do Revenue I'm going
to insert that I'm going to get rid of
this I'm going to do revenue and so
that's the the the very large number and
then we're going to
subtract and we're going to sub subract
our cost we going to insert that and
let's do this and click okay so this is
our calculated field demo column that we
just created and as you can see it
matches our uh sum of profit column
exactly and that's exactly what we want
to see we want to kind of check to make
sure that this revenue and cost uh
fields are generating the correct profit
and sometimes those are off and so it's
really good to kind of check those and
have that additional column um You
probably wouldn't have this if you were
um you know going to submit this to
somebody uh just so you know now that
this is an actual column you can't go
here and do something like cut or and
paste it over here you know that's not
it won't let you do that what it is is
is now an actual um column and so we can
go and remove that and we can add it
back at any moment so if we want to go
back and add that um oops add that down
here we can do that because we've
created that column it's now permanently
there unless we go and delete all of
that data uh and so we can just click
this check mark and it will get rid of
it for us all right now the last thing
that we have not used down here is the
filters now the filters is exactly what
it sounds like it's going to allow you
to filter on certain things um but
probably not things that you already
have included in your pivot table so if
you add something like the country down
here um it's going to kind of expand
everything and then if you then go and
filter on it it kind of breaks it down
that's really not what the filter is
kind of used for or meant for um for
example right up here we have uh
customer gender okay so let's take the
customer gender and we'll put it in this
filters now we can see all of the
revenue all of the cost all the profit
and we can do that based off of the
gender so we can filter by a gender not
really having to change anything about
our pivot table and so at a super Quick
Glance we can see that uh the males are
the profit from the males is
16.48% so at a super uh basic level at a
really quick glance we can see that the
men or the males are you know spending a
little bit more than the females by
about about
$700,000 now let's go ahead and create
one more pivot table uh we are going to
create a pivot table right over here
let's go back to the
sales right here again control shift
right down it's going to select all of
our data and we're click okay so one
thing that we're going to look at is
we're going to use some of this date
information right here so let's select
our country just like we did before um
and what we want to do is see you know
what year were we performing our best
when were we doing our absolute best uh
with oops
let me go
back uh with our sales so I'm going to
select the year and put that in our
columns and so now we have 2011 through
2016 and we want to look at our Revenue
let's put our Revenue right down here
and now we have all of our Revenue now
let's again make this into a
currency just like that and super
quickly now we can get a really quick
glance at at how Australia was doing
each year and we can see that there was
a huge uptick in 2013 and a huge uptick
in 2015 it didn't happen for every
single country uh it did go up uh for
most countries very slightly for some
but we can see on a large scale from um
year to year what that's like and So
within just a few minutes we're able to
create some really useful pivot tables
that anybody could look at and
understand and that's really the biggest
use of these PIV pivot tables is that
you can kind of group these things
together show some uh information and
data at at kind of a broad larger scale
and make it to where anybody who's
looking at it can understand it that is
why pivot tables are so useful and so I
hope that this video was helpful I hope
that I was able to walk through it and
help you better understand how pivot
tables work and how you can use them
when you are working within Excel thank
you guys so much for watching I really
appreciate it if you like this video be
sure to like And subscribe below and
I'll see you in the next video
[Music]
what's going on everybody today we're
going to be looking at formulas in
[Music]
Excel now I know what you're thinking
there's absolutely no way that you're
going to be able to show us every single
formula in Excel and you're absolutely
right but I am going to show you some of
my favorites and the ones that I found
the most useful and then you can go
ahead and practice those and try those
out and if there are ones that you
really want me to do and you think that
I missed put it in the comments below
and I will see those and I'll try to
make a list of those and make another
video on formulas and include all of
those as well and now before we jump
into the actual tutorial I want to give
a huge shout out to the sponsor of the
series and that is udemy you guys
already know if you have watched any of
my videos that I absolutely love udem me
I mean honestly they were the ones who
got me started and were able ble to give
me affordable courses for me to get
started as a data analyst I learned SQL
and Excel and python all through udimi
courses and so if you are looking for a
platform to take a course I absolutely
recommend you look at udemy they have
fantastic sales going on right now
especially during the holiday season in
this new year and so if you're looking
to take a full-fledged Excel course I
have some of my favorites in the
description below and now without
further Ado let's jump onto my screen
and get started with the tutorial all
right now before we start I want to say
that this is not like every other
tutorial that I have created created
this one is very streamlined okay so I
already know exactly what I'm going to
do there's not going to be much messing
around I left little notes here and
there um and I'm going to try to get
through it because there's a lot of them
to get through um so all these ones at
the bottom now these are ones that I use
a lot that I think are useful again if
you know other ones that you use a lot
that think that I should be using which
I know there are ones that I left out of
here you know put it in the comments um
I'll see the ones that people are liking
and I will I will create more videos on
the because I know there are so many I
also will save this um excel in on the
GitHub so you can go and download it it
will be exactly what you're looking at
right now I highly recommend trying
these formulas out for yourself so you
can get a feel for how they work and how
they're actually used and you can mess
around with it yourself so um as you can
see at the bottom we're going to start
with Max Min and then we're going to go
on to some more I think a little bit
more uh difficult things um and all
these things are super useful I'll try
to talk about how you can actually use
it as we go through it some are super
self-explanatory but some may not be so
this one I think is super
self-explanatory but again one that
you're going to use all the time um and
so what we can do is we can say equal
and that's how you kind of start off
saying this is going to be a formula in
this cell equal means uh I am now
creating a formula and we're going to
say
MX and I'll hit Tab and so it'll kind of
populate it and right here if you've
never seen a formula before it'll to
give you what the inputs need to be so
it's going to say Max of number one
number two etc etc what we're going to
do is we're going to give a range so
we're going to go from here down to here
you don't have to close the parenthesis
but you can I'm going to and then you
hit enter and so for this date it's
going to give us the max date now these
are um the start dates for these people
right here and so if we just kind of
glance through here we can see that 2013
was the last year and this one is
actually the latest in that year and so
it gave us the correct one the Min is
going to do the exact opposite it's
going to give us uh the smallest and so
we'll give it the same range we'll close
the parenthesis and it's going to say
December 7th of 1995 and we can see that
that is correct so Michael Scott started
in 1995 the earliest of all the
employees um and you can do the exact
same thing for really any of these
columns we can see who the who's making
the most money or at least what the
higher salary is U so we'll do Max and
then we'll do the salary range and so
this is this one again uh whoops what
did I do oh I did the wrong range didn't
I no I didn't do the wrong range it's
just there it goes uh this column was a
date range or a date column for whatever
reason let me get rid of that uh and
then we can do equals Min and we'll do
again we'll do the salary and at a quick
glance we can see that Pam Beasley is
making the least and 65,000 is Michael
Scott who's making uh that so super
simple it shows the max it shows the Min
you can select a range there you go
let's move on to if and ifs now if is um
I think pretty straightforward so all
you're going to do is you're going to
say if this then that um ifs is a little
bit different so ifs is you can you can
put multiple conditions and as we're
writing it I'll show you kind of what it
the conditions that need to be met all
right so we're going to click right here
we're going to say equal we're going to
do if hit Tab and we need a logical test
uh and so we're going to give it a range
or or or something we're going to say if
it's equal greater to um something like
that then we're going to say if the
value is true what's the what is going
to be the output or if the value is
false what's going to be the output so
let's do this right
here we'll do this age range and so if
they are greater than let's say let's do
30 if they're greater than 30 we're
going to do a comma and so if the value
is true what what should be the output
uh if they're greater than 30 we're
going to call them old and then if it is
false so if they're younger than 30 what
should it say and we're going to say
young and we'll close the
parenthesis and there you go so if
they're over 30 then they are going to
have young or if they're younger than 30
they're going to have young now this is
something where you need to specify if
you want 30 and over or over 30 we chose
over 30 so 30 is not included in that um
so they're going to be
young now uh let's get we don't actually
need two of these that's pretty
self-explanatory the ifs is a little bit
different right you can have multiple
conditions so let's open that up real
quick so ifs and now we have a logical
test value if uh that's true then you
can do logical test two value if that's
true um so you can have multiple
multiple multiple things now this one is
a little bit different in this one oops
let me get out of this in this one you
had a value of true a value of false ifs
does not have that ifs is going to give
you um different ranges in different
specific conditions
and you can't say if this one's false
you're just going to have multiple
conditions so let's do equals and ifs
Tab and we'll do our first logical test
so let's
do
um if the
salesman or if that equals to
salesman we're going to say we're going
to respond with
sales so that's if the value is true
that's what we want the output to be now
we're going to go on to our logical test
two so you're going to see this pattern
right if this is our conditional or
logical test so if this is true this is
what's going to be returned so you'll
notice that's just a a pretty simple
pattern we can just do random things so
if it's equal to sales um and we'll just
do the same one if that is equal
to say HR we can say fire
immediately and now we're going to
say if it's equal
to
regional
manager and we
say give
Christmas bonus and we'll close the
parenthesis and let's see what we get so
as you can see there's no default value
for true or false like like this one
there was a logical test and if it was
true there was a value and if it was
false there was a value so for every
single one you'll get a value for this
one that's not exactly going to happen
as you can see there are these
Nas now when that happens it just means
nothing met that condition so we never
said anything about supplier relations
we never said anything about accountants
but if it was part of that ifs statement
then it got something um and so that is
how the ifs works now let's move on to
length uh this is exactly what we're
going to do but you know some of the
uses for this U for the length I've used
it for a lot of different things um one
thing that I've used it for in the past
and you know Max and ifs you know you
can use it for almost anything length is
there's a lot of different use cases one
I used to work with a lot of um customer
data or patient data they had like
Social Security numbers and if you know
there was bad Social Security numbers we
didn't want to include that and so we do
like the length of that and if a social
security number was let's say 10 numbers
or 11 numbers where it should only be
nine or or you know however many they
are I think it's nine then we know that
that social security number is incorrect
and then we can get rid of that or
discard it from our results that's just
an example right um so for this oops
what I do that I did control Z to undo
that if you didn't know how to do that
um so we're going to do equals Len which
is length um and again if you didn't see
that it Returns the number of characters
in a text string so let's go right here
and let's go to uh let's go to their
last name and we'll give it a range so
it's going to tell us how many
characters are in that string so for
halber it's seven characters for
flenderson it's 10 characters and we're
able to see a length and so again there
are a lot of different use cases for
this uh the social security number was
one another one is phone numbers right
if you look at the length of the phone
numbers and there's ones that are like
12 numbers long you know those might not
be ones that are accurate and you need
to go look at them and see if you want
to include them in your results or your
output so that is how length is done
let's move right over to the left and
right um I I might be going a little
fast but uh you know I'm keeping it I'm
keeping it live I'm keeping this on our
feet uh so let's keep going left and
right um are kind of like substrings if
you've taken the the sequel um tutorial
series that I've done uh substrings are
where you can choose a certain part of
the text string and you can extract data
from that um and usually have to
reference a certain number so a certain
amount of characters that's the exact
same thing except uh unfortunately
there's no substring there's substitute
but there's no substring left and right
is really the closest thing that we have
so let's kind of take a look real quick
and see what we can do so we're going to
do left and it's going to say Returns
the specified number of characters from
the start of a text string so we're
starting from the very far left and we
need to choose our text and then choose
the number of characters that we're
going to be looking over so let's go
over here and let's just choose you know
start symol uh we'll get a little bit
more advanced so we have um this is our
text range so these are the the the ones
that we want to look at and then how
many characters do we want to look
forward and we'll just choose three as
an example and so you can see that it
takes the first three characters from
every single thing now you can also do
this with numbers it doesn't just have
to be um you know name with with actual
words or letters you can do the exact
same thing so you can say
write um and we're going to choose our
our string uh and let's do this one so
you know all of them start with 100 um
and we'll just say we want to take the
last one so this one is going to start
from the very far right and go over one
character
so right here you can see this is our
range and I just chose one so starting
from the very far right we go over one
character and that's what we take and so
that can definitely be useful another
one that you can do and this one is one
that I have used so many times I mean
honestly countless times in in actually
using this in my job uh so we're going
to go from the right and we're going to
look at a date so you know sometimes you
have these date structures month month
day day year year year or year um you
know day month year all these different
and sometimes you just want to extract
either the month or the year or or
something like that the day and so we
want to come in here we're just going to
extract the oops I wanted to make that
arrange we want to extract the year of
the start dates so we're going to do
that and then we're going to go over
four so we want to take the first four
characters from the right to give us the
entire year let's do that and now we can
see exactly the year and this can be
just super super useful this is again
one that I've used used a lot and so
that is one that you might want to
remember in case you're ever doing
analysis on you know start and end dates
or or anything with um date data uh
again one that I highly recommend
remembering let's go over to date to
text I actually probably should have
included that um before because I
actually used it in this one um if you
notice right here this is a text so in
in this one we just did that was a text
you can't do this right on um start and
end dates when it's a date uh format and
let me show you so this is a date now if
I do equals and you know we just did
this uh let's do on the end date and
I'll do the whole range give me a second
and we'll do
four it's giving us completely random
numbers why is that because underneath
the date range there are um numbers
right so if I go right here and I make
this a general it's going to have the
numbers and look these are the first
four characters from the right and so
it's doing what it's supposed to do but
uh it's not doing what we actually want
and that's the issue so how can we
convert this now there are a ton of
different ways um but the quickest
probably the easiest besides actually
writing writing it out like this like
11-2
d201 which then converts it to a date
format um but what you can do you know
just so you know you can create a as a
text you can do 11-2
d201 and now it will stay a text string
and as you can tell these are a little
bit different because this one is uh
formatted or situated on the right and
this one's on the left that's how you
can tell the difference now if you don't
want to do it by hand uh completely
manually and waste hours of your time
you can do it in a very simple way so
we're going to do uh text so this is the
exact um form for that we're going to
use so let's get rid of that one there
we go so we're going to do equals we're
going to do uh oops text it says
converts a value to text in a specific
number format so for a date format we
can choose a date format and then it'll
convert it to a text for us which saves
so much time I promise you uh let's do
all of these just like we did and then
we need to tell it what the format is if
we don't if we tell it something
incorrect it's going to give us a
completely terrible output or just give
us an error alog together so this is a
DayDay month Monon year year year year
format and that is what we're going to
do so we're going to do
ddmm y y YY and close that up and there
you go and now we well because it's in a
formula what we need to do
is copy
this and past paste it right over here
and now you can see that is a general
this is something that we can use as a
string and let's just check it just to
make sure we're going to do right we're
going to do this one let's do all of
them and we'll do
four and there you go so now it works
that is what we are looking for um and
you can do that imagine doing that with
millions of rows or you know let's say
10,000 rows it's going to be a breeze
right it's going to take you two minutes
or a minute
to do everything that you want to do
instead of having to just do a bunch of
mess to convert it to a string which I
promise you I've done it it just takes
forever it's it's terrible so that is uh
date to text super helpful formula let's
go over to trim now I I purposefully
messed up this column now why do I did I
mess it up like this because when you're
working with real data you're going to
get data like this it it's messy it's
dirty it just has random spaces at the
end for no reason um because sometimes
you're going to be working with um data
that is inputed by a user it's not like
a drop- down option so imagine
somebody's typing this in they
accidentally put a space so they
actually put an enter or something and
then they submit it and this is how it's
going to look in the database um and if
you're a data engineer or you know
you're working with the raw data if they
don't clean that up then you're going to
be working with that that dirty data and
I I guarantee you if you're working as a
data analyst you're going to see stuff
like this not with maybe a last name but
all sorts of data so we're going to go
right here we're going to say equals
trim do open parenthesis actually this
says removes all spaces from a text
string except for a single space between
words so like you know if it said
Halpert space uh or gy space Halpert it
won't take the space in between there
because it it kind of understands that
the in normal language space is supposed
to be there so it won't do that um but
we'll take that we'll give it this
Range close that up and there you go now
it is nice and clean much more usable
now let's look at concatenate one that I
have used just way way way too many
times um and something that I've used
concatenate for and you'll see this one
in a lot of demonstrations for a good
reason is because a lot of people use it
for this um so what you can do is you
can say equals um and well let me tell
you what concatenate does real
quick so what concatenate does oops I'm
totally messing up here um but it joins
two or more text strings into one string
it basically joins things together and
adds them together so let's do
concatenate and we're going to add this
first and last name again one that gets
used all the time but that's because um
it really is useful so you can do this
and you can say now now I want to
include this so concatenating this and
this and let's take a look so it says
Jim Halpert U but it's all connected and
that's typically not how people write
their names so what we can do is we can
go back in here and we can do what my
demonstration up here already tells us
to do which is we're just going to add
another thing in here and if we add two
parentheses we can include anything in
here we can include a dash we can
include an exclamation point or we can
just include a space so let's just
include a space really quick and just
like that it works perfectly and so now
we have the full name now something that
you could use it for is something like
generating uh an email this is something
that you absolutely could do um and it's
you know pretty simple so I'm going to
do it like this I'm G to say oops what
did I do I'm G to say um Dot and then at
the end I'm going to say at
oops comma
quotation
gmail.com and now I've created emails
for all of these people so just
something that you can do with this um
and something that it it absolutely is
used for and you'll see that
demonstration almost everywhere because
honestly it gets used a lot um by data
analysts and so uh you know just a good
one to know understanding how that that
concatenation works um let's go over to
the next one
so we are going to do substitute now
substitute's really interesting um there
are different ways you can do it I'm
going to show it to you on these dates
real quick uh that's what we're going to
look at so changing a date format
changing how what it's supposed to look
like is absolutely something that
happens all the time and um you know
sometimes you'll even get it like
this where it'll look like it'll be
messy it'll be different a different um
I guess format so this one has all the
other ones have slashes where these ones
have
dashes and you know what you can do is
if you want to well let me actually go
with the no instances real quick because
this one is uh actually makes the most
sense um so we'll do equals and we're
going to say
substitute and oops and let me say
substitute replaces existing text with
new text in a text string so if we do an
open parenthesis it says we take the
text have the old text we have the new
text and then we have how what instance
or how many times uh or or or what
instance are we looking at it and I'll
explain that in a little
bit so the text that we're going to be
looking at is this one right here so
let's take this
range and the old is we're going to take
this Dash and so let's take the
dash and then what do we want to replace
replace it with we want to replace it
with this slash right here I think it's
a forward slash isn't that what it's
called it's called a forward slash am I
crazy um and we're not going to put an
instance notice that that's in a bracket
that means it's optional we're going to
do none of that um and what it's going
to do is it's going to fix this so this
one is now in the correct format that we
want uh and that's fantastic that's you
know that's what we tried to accomplish
given what we had now let's fix that if
we want to do the exact same thing uh we
can say
uh what are we doing substitute we can
do substitute we can do open parentheses
we'll give the range and now let's say
we want to change all of them to a
different format so instead of the um
forward slash I'm going to keep calling
it that if that's correct we want to
give it a dash and so then we close that
and now all of them are in this new
format so it it's able to substitute a
specific value for a new value and if
you don't include an instance
then it'll do it to every single one in
there so let's go over here and we're
going to actually use the the um the the
instance num and I'll show you what that
does uh and so really quick we'll do the
exact same thing that we just did we'll
do the forward slash and we want to
replace it with this one again this Dash
but we only want to do it on the first
instance of that forward slash and so as
you can see all the ones that um all the
ones that were replaced are the very
first instance whereas the second
instance which is the second time it
appears in this string does not get
touched so if we take
this and we put it right over here and
we move it to
two it's kind of the opposite so the
first one wasn't touched the second one
was so we're choosing which instance or
which time it shows up in that string
and then it replaces it if you do not
choose an instance it chooses all of
them so this can be super useful if you
want to do like a bulk replace um but
you only want to do it on a specific
column um and you just want to use a
formula really quick right um and so you
can use this in a lot of different ways
so that's how you're able to actually do
it with the first instance the second
instance and if you don't include an
instance at all let's go over to the sum
uh this is one I think everyone knows
how to use but I want to show you two
other ones um as well so let's go to the
sum and we're just going to do equals
the sum and I hope you know what this is
well not hope I if you don't know what
this is it just adds up all the numbers
in range so we're going to add sum means
add so we're going to take this and it's
going to give us the uh what all these
salaries are together so super super
simple Su is one of probably the most
basic formulas that you can do um some
if is a little bit different you can add
an if statement which we learned right
back here you can add an if statement
and then add it if it meets a certain
criteria all right so we're going to do
equals some if and then you're going to
need to give a range in criteria and you
can include a some range if you would
like so we're going to do the salary
again we going to do a comma and now
here's our criteria let's do if they
have greater than 50,000 for their
salary and close our parenthesis so now
it's only going to add up if their
salary is greater than 50,000 now his is
50,000 exactly so that won't count but
we have 63 and 65,000 which does equal
128,000 so it it just gives a specific
criteria or an if statement then it does
the addition uh so super useful on that
one so that is how you do a su if and Su
ifs is kind of the same thing as we did
back here there's the if and the ifs so
the ifs is going to be if it has it
meets multiple conditions so let's take
a look at that one so let's do um equals
some ifs now uh oops now the Syntax for
this one is going to be a little bit
different you'll see that in just a
second this adds the cells specified by
a given set of conditions or criteria so
let's do an open open parentheses we
give the sum range so let's do um the
same one as before then we have our
criteria range so what are we looking at
What's um this is the area that's going
to be added after all these if
statements are done right so we have to
initially set that now we're going to
say okay what criteria are we basing
this off of so let's put a comma and
we're going to base it off of let's do
this one we'll say um if the uh gender
so we'll do comma if that's female oops
if that's female and then we'll give
another one we can say if they're female
and let's say they are greater than oops
greater than 30 and we'll close that up
and it's going to give us 88,000 so
female female there's one two right here
so it's going to be this one and this
one that equals 88,000 so that's how
that works you're able to incorporate
several different
conditions into uh the sum formula so
again I know this one's super simple but
you you can use it in a much more
complex way if you use the sum if and
the sum ifs um almost the exact same
thing for this count I'm not going to go
super in depth into this one um I'll
just kind of show you because count is
um count and sum are kind of on the same
level of difficulty they're both pretty
beginner this is just going to give you
a count of how many cells um are there
so let's give this range um and so it's
not going to add it it's just going to
give us a count so if we do right here
and scroll over them like highlight them
this countdown here oops this countdown
here is nine and so it's going to give
us that count but we can do a count with
conditions exactly how we did it in the
sum so if we do count if Oops I did not
spell that right if we do count if we're
going to give a range and a criteria
exact same as we did before so let's do
this I me you can do this on basically
any of these it doesn't really for this
demonstration it doesn't really matter
um but we'll say if their salary is
greater than 45,000 so how many people
this is going to give us how many people
have a salary over 45,000 and that's
five so before in the sum if if we did
that um we did 50,000 it adds everything
together the count is just going to
count the amount of cells that meet that
criteria and again count
ifs uh we're going to have a criteria
range and then we will specify what if
statements we want to be uh to occur in
order to count those cells so let's do
we want you know we want to count it can
be any range or it can be any of these
we'll do the ID this time and now we can
say you know want it to be is our
criteria one we can say we want it to be
greater than want their ID to be greater
than
1005 and let's say we want them to
be
male so they have an ID over a certain
um a certain range and then they are a
male so there's only three people that
meet that criteria and so it'll be
Michael Stanley and Kevin those are our
three people and so it gives us a count
very useful to give quick numbers like
this something I I genuinely use a lot
and I know I've said that a lot during
this tutorial but that's because
everything I'm showing you are things
that I've used a lot so I don't feel
like um you know I'm speaking out of
turn here let's look at this one this
one is very um has some specific use
cases um notice that this is a text
right now um if you do it when it is uh
in a date format it actually will not
work I mean I can you can test it out
yourself you just got to trust me it's
not going to work so what this does is
it's going to give you the range from
this day to this day that's what it's
going to do so let's do uh oops days
it's GNA we want to choose our end date
so this is our end date it's kind of
backward from what you think end date to
start date you think start date to end
date so you have to start with this one
and then we're going to choose the start
date and now it's going to tell us how
many um how many uh days was it from
here to here and this one it's
5,56 so Network days is extremely
similar except it takes out holidays and
it takes out weekends and you can see
how many working days has this person um
how many working days or network days
has this person worked not including you
know weekends and holidays have they
actually worked since their start date
and their end date so let's do Network
days and we need our start date our end
date and you can specify extra holidays
if you'd like but there are a already
standard set holidays in there that it
takes out um so you know if you want to
do that you can so we're going to do the
start date again this one's different
this one says start date end date and
then we're going to give the end
date and if you
notice they are going to be different
numbers is dramatically lower because
it's taking out weekends and holidays so
this is how many days uh calendar days
they've worked and this is how many days
they've actually been in the office and
worked and that is it um again there are
so many formulas I mean literally
hundreds of formulas that you can
utilize and use and are out there for
you to try out yourself if there are
specific ones that I did not cover in
this video please please put it in the
comments below so that I can you know
show you how to do these things I I I
will say I've probably used a majority
of the ones that you're going to put in
the comments already and if I haven't
used it I'll take a look at it and see
if it's really useful and I'll show you
that so thank you guys so much for
watching I hope that this has been
helpful I I feel like a lot of these
things are not things that I learned
before I started almost all these are
ones that I learned while I was on the
job and so I'm hoping that you can get
ahead of the curve and you can learn
learn these things before you actually
start so that when you get in there
you're just like killing it with the
formulas and people are like whoa this
guy is like this guy knows what he's
doing in Excel give him all the Excel
work and then you become like you know
just the Excel guy um and everyone you
know loves you for it so with that being
said thank you so much for watching I
really do hope this helped if you like
this video be sure to like And subscribe
below I'll see you in the next
[Music]
video
what's going on everybody welcome back
to another video in this Excel tutorial
we'll be looking at
[Music]
xlup now if you don't already know what
xlookup is it is a new feature in Excel
to kind of replace vlookup or to be a
much better option at least in my mind
is a much better option than V lookup
and so if you're someone who's either
used V lookup a a lot and you're trying
to you know learn this new Option or if
you've never used it before this video
will be super helpful because I'll walk
you through kind of the options and what
x lookup can do as well as the
difference between X lookup and V lookup
but before we get into the tutorial I
want to give a huge shout out to today's
sponsor and that is udemy udemy is the
go-to place if you want a full-fledged
course in Excel I have three options of
courses that I have taken on em me so
I'd highly recommend checking those out
they are having a huge sale on all their
courses during this time and so if you
are in the market for a course I highly
recommend checking out UD to me and
getting one there now without further
Ado let's jum on my screen and start the
tutorial all right so let's get me off
the screen because we all know why we're
here so I didn't include this in the
formulas video last week because I knew
this was going to be a large one and a
lot of people are going to want to know
how to do this what the difference
stream V lookup and X lookup is so it
has its own dedicated video to it so
let's get started it is a Formula so
we're going to come in here in this cell
we're going to hit equal and then we're
going to start typing X lookup now I'm
GNA hit tab in just a second but let's
read what this says it says searches a
range or an array for a match and
Returns the corresponding item from a
second range or array by default an
exact match is used so really useful to
know um we'll talk a little bit more
about that in just a second let's hit
Tab and it's going to complete it and
it's going to start giving us or it's
going to tell us what our input values
need to be we're going to have our
lookup value we're going to have our
lookup array our return array and then
some options things like if not found so
if your option isn't found you know what
will be um you know the the uh output
that it gives us a match mode and a
search mode and I'm going to show you um
kind of how to use every single one of
these things as you can see at the very
bottom I've kind of already set up all
of the instructional um instructional
content for this video and so we'll kind
of get through all these different
scenarios so let's just start really
quickly with um how to use it very
simply with the lookup lookup array and
return array so we're going to come in
here and we're going to give it our
lookup value Now Toby Fenderson right
over here in A3 is going to be our
lookup value so that's who we're going
to be searching for now we're going to
hit comma and now we're going to be
needing to look up uh or to input our
lookup array now an array is just uh you
know a range basically so we're going to
do this is where it's going to be
searching for um that value this is
where it's searches for A3 so here's
Toby Fenderson here's Toby flenderson so
it will find it in this array right here
then we're going to hit comma and now we
need to give it the return array what
it's going to return on that row when it
finds it so we're going to return his
email keep it really simple so what it
should do and let's close parentheses
what it should do is it should take Toby
Fenderson it's going to search in this
column or in this array and then it's
going to return the email when it finds
Toby Fenderson so it's on Toby Fenderson
is on row six so it's going to find Toby
flenderson it's going to come over here
and it's going to return Toby flenderson
dundermifflin corporate.com that's what
it should do let's see what it actually
does said enter and it returns it now if
we drag it down like this it'll apply it
to all of these names right here and it
works exactly how it's supposed to um
again if you have never used vlookup you
don't know how good you have it okay
vlookup um was extremely useful but just
uh a bit complicated and I'll talk about
that near the end of the video when we
compare V lookup to xlookup but just
know that if you're using X lookup for
the first time and you're just getting
into using Excel you guys have it good
okay so just know that um now let's go
over here to X lookup multiple rows
because you can return more than one
output with um with X lookup so let's go
right in here and we're going to
basically write the exact same thing as
we did before so let's write X lookup
we're going to do Toby flenderson as our
value we're going to search here and
we're going to do something a little bit
different this time we want to include
our end date and the email so what we're
going to do is we're going to start here
we're going to go down all the way to
the bottom of end date and then we're
also going to include the email and when
we do that it will uh in the output give
us a row or a column for end dat and a
column for email so an output for both
so let's hit enter and now we can see
that we have the end date here and the
email here now one of the downsides or
or something that I'm not a huge huge
fan of is well first off I love that you
can do this that's fantastic um but it
have to be right next to each other so
you're only going to get that output
exactly how it is in the columns so if I
went and did this range um I would
include all of that um so H you know
let's just for example let's pull that
down here so let's take
this and put it right here if I did
instead of zero or or O2 to P10 if I
included age to email this whole range
and I hit enter it's all going to be
included so you know that's one of the
small downsides of of that functionality
of when you can use multiple rows is
that it's going to use the rows exactly
as they are you can't really customize
it within the formula you can move
around um these columns to how you want
it um so that is something to note and
again you can pull this down and it'll
be applied to all of those names let's
go over to X lookup exact match so let's
open this up we're going to do equals
xlup as we've been doing and we're
actually going to be looking at the if
not found and the match mode U both you
know on this tab right here so let's do
what we've been doing before we take our
value that we're looking up we take the
array that we're looking and we're going
to do the email and you know as you can
see this says Toby flender and not Toby
flenderson so what we are going to do is
we're going to hit comma and if it's not
found you can return um a value or a
string that you want to return now for
simple purposes or for simple
instructional purposes we're going to do
not
found and then we're going to close that
off so let's do this and Toby Fenderson
was not found and so it was returned not
found if Toby Fender was actually in
this full name then it would have
returned the email and then if along the
way you know one of these was not part
of it then you know we would have uh we
would have had the KN found all right so
let's go right up here we're actually
just going to copy this uh because I
want to reuse it um and then we're going
to go right here and we hit a comma now
this is our match mode option and so we
have four different options that we can
choose from a zero is an exact match and
that is by default that is what we have
or what we use then there's a minus one
that's an exact match or next smaller
item then there's a one which is an
exact match or next larger item and then
there's a two which is a wild card
character match now we're going to do
that and we are going to um you know try
this out and it's not going to work and
not just because I forgot to put A4 um
it's doing it because it's searching for
Beasley but if there's not a wild card
option already put in here um it doesn't
recognize it so we need to indicate
where that wild card needs to be so
we're going to do a double apostrophe or
quotation marks we're going to put put
an asterisk right here and then do
another one and we're going to hit an
Amper sand so we're going to have an
Amper sand right here and when that's
going to say is anything that comes
before A4 anything that comes before
Beasley is okay doesn't matter what it
is as long as it has Beasley at the end
that is going to be okay so we're going
to have Pam that comes before Beasley
and that's going to tell it and it's
going to say okay I know that anything
that comes before Beasley is all right
and so when we hit enter is now going to
return the output that we are looking
for and we can include that on these as
well now this one is Meredith um and so
Meredith is at the beginning so we have
Meredith Palmer so we can actually take
this and we're going to put this at the
end put the Amber sand right here and
now it'll work and the exact same thing
for Kevin Malo right here Kevin Malone
so it just didn't include uh the ne at
the end and so it's still going to work
if we include that asterisk at the end
now I know I said we were looking at
search order but I'm actually going to
kind of give you an exact match uh first
and then search order but it just kind
of easier to show it over here so I'm
going to do X look up I'm going to look
up this value do a comma here's the
range this is our start date that's it's
going to be looking for and I want to
return the full name now no value in
here has one one 2000 but what we can do
is we can do comma and then a comma for
the match mode and do an exact match or
next
larger and I know this is in the exact
match part but it you know kind of
refers to search ORD a little bit um
where it searches for the next largest
value that's that's what that number one
represents the next larger value so we
have 112000 and if we look right here
the next value above 112000 is
152000 and so it should should return
Angela Martin let's see if that works
and there it is now let's look up the
actual search order um so let's do
equals x
lookup this is the value that we want to
be searching for and we're going to be
looking in this start date and comma and
we want to return the name now let's get
over to search mode now the search mode
performs a search starting at the first
item so at the very top going down so by
default it searches from first to last
but you can reverse that and do search
from last to first or you can do a
binary search which is where it sorts in
ascending order or sorts in descending
order um and that's with the actual
value and so we won't be able to show
this binary search or on ascending or
descending because our values are the
same but if we had different values and
we were looking up um using this um next
largest we we would be able to show that
but I'm going to show you the search
from first to last and last to first so
let's put in by default and this is what
it would be search From First to Last
what the default would be so it starts
at the very top it goes down and finds
the first 56 2001 and returns Toby
flenderson now if we go in here and we
hit minus one that is going to search
from last to first so it's going to
start at the bottom and go to the top
and the first one that it finds is
Michael Scott so that's that first one
starting from the bottom and then the
Michael Scott right there so these two
the exact match and the search order can
kind of be combined into um this one
right here we're using this
one um which is you know exact match or
next larger and you can include that in
this binary search in this one as well
all right now let's head over to the X
lookup horizontal I think we're we only
have a few left yep X look up horizontal
then we'll do X lookup with sum and then
I'm going to show you the V lookup at
the end so let's go right here let's say
equals X lookup the value that we want
to be searching for is February that's
what we're looking for hit comma and
where do we want to search to find
February we want to search in uh these
calendar months and then we hit another
comma and now we're going to be
searching for paper so let's do paper
and we'll hit enter and it found
February and it return paper right here
and we can do that for paper printer and
manila folders and so it's going to give
us the 310 the 40 and the 118 from
February now let's go right over here to
XL up with some um I actually it's
basically a carbon copy of this uh let's
take this over here real
quick and place it right there because
it's the exact same thing except at the
end we're going to use I'm going to show
you how to use sum with the X lookup at
the same time now um we're going to be
using the formula sum and
so we're going to do sum and then within
the sum our first number is going to be
an X lookup and then our next value is
also going to be an X lookup so let's do
X lookup and now we're going to search
for our very first value oops our very
first lookup value so we're going to go
to
i1 and then we're going to search this
again and we want whatever value oop
goes into that so let's close that
parenthesis and now we're going to do a
colon and another X
lookup and now let's do March so now
we're going to search for March we're
going to do our search range where we're
searching for that March and we want the
paper as
well and let's close that and then we
also need to close that parentheses so
now we are basically adding this
February and and this March so it's
going to be 310 plus 150 it's adding
those um two values and it should be uh
what 460 so let's see if that is our
output and it is so you can do this with
a lot of things not just some but you're
able to use x lookup within different
formulas if you're searching for a
specific value and a specific value um
in in another um cell you can add those
together using X lookup which is
honestly it's pretty great so let's go
over to V up so I wanted to show you
this because I wanted to show you where
it came from and what we used to do um
unless you are continuing to use V
lookup and what we can do now so X
lookup I just showed you kind of
everything um but super quickly I'm
going to show you how vlookup used to
work um in a super short way so that you
can understand how it used to be used
and how it is used uh how X lookup is
used now so let's go in here and we're
going to say equals and we're going to
do a vlookup and so we have a lookup
value Val and so we're going to click
this we're going to hit Comma just like
we did before and now we're going to do
a table array and the table array is a
little different in that you're
searching an entire area so let's do uh
H2 all the way through o oops o10 so
that's what that's what our table array
is going to be then we're going to do a
comma and now we have to do a column
index number which number um are we
going to be um searching for which um
value are we going to be searching for
in here and so we want to search for
eight because this is 1 2 3 4 five 6 7
eight we want to return that email and
we're searching for the name right here
in this very first column so we have
that comma and we're going to do eight
and then in the range lookup you can do
true which is an approximate match or
false which is an exact match and we'll
do
false I don't know why it's not Auto
auto doing it but there we go and now we
will do it and it's going to return it
just as we had it um a lot of people uh
I guess not everybody but some people
didn't like and the reason why they
created X lookup you had to do those
ranges and if you ever went in here and
then we let's say we um added another
column which happens to data now it
gives completely different um different
data so let's say for whatever reason we
added uh address so now we have these
people address well now it's going to
give us a different um value it's going
to have this end dates because if we go
in here now it doesn't um now the eighth
is this end date and the ninth is this
email so if you have a vlookup that you
use for um you know a calculation or a
table that you've created or different
things in Excel you then have to go
through here and manually change this
and so a lot of people didn't like that
CU if you you know needed to change data
or you needed to change something or add
an additional column you'd have to go
back and fix all of your vlookups they
wouldn't just automatically U Move with
it which is what happens with xlookup
and just to prove this uh let's go back
to the very first one which is the X
lookup and right now the email is
looking at O2 and through o10 um we're
just going to insert right here and that
would be our new colum we'll do address
oops address and notice that it hasn't
changed and why is that because it auto
changed for us from P2 to P10
understanding that it wanted to stick
with when something was inserted here it
wanted to stick with the original data
the original array that was selected and
so xlup does that work for you and it
makes it a little bit easier to automate
things and create these processes in
Excel without having to go fix it later
which you had to do with lookup so that
is it for today I hope that you know how
to use x lookup a little bit better now
that you have watched this uh if you
enjoyed this video be sure to like And
subscribe below and I will see you in
the next
[Music]
video what's going on everybody welcome
back to another Excel tutorial today
we'll be looking at conditional
formatting
[Music]
now if you've never heard of conditional
form mounting before that's okay I had
never heard of it before I became a data
analyst and so now that I've been using
Excel a lot of course I use it quite a
bit and so I want to show you how to use
it conditional formatting is basically
just a way to see patterns and Trends
and data and that's a super simple way
of putting it um but it's very easy to
use and so hopefully I can show you how
to use it uh really easily in a lot of
the things that I use the most and some
of the things that I use it for so that
you can also know how to use conditional
formatting now before we jump into the
tutorial I want to give a huge shout out
to the sponsor of this Excel series and
that is udemy you guys know by now that
I absolutely love udemy I've been using
them for years and I've taken literally
hundreds of courses on udemy and I've
learned so so much especially when I was
first starting out as a data analyst uh
I learned a lot through their Excel
courses on udemy and so I have actually
put the ones that I really like and I
have taken and enjoyed and think you
would as well in the description so if
you want to take those sure to check
those out again huge shout out to UD me
for sponsoring the series now without
further Ado let's jump onto my screen
and get started with the tutorial all
right so let's jump right into it on
this Home tab right here if we go all
the way over to the right there is
conditional formatting and the
description that it gives us is easily
spot Trends and patterns in your data
using bars colors and icons to visually
highlight important values and that is
exactly how I would have defined it a
really good job Microsoft exactly how I
would have done it so what you'll see
right away is there's nothing too
complex so we have some highlight cell
rules um we have some top bottom rules
data bars color scales icon sets and
then at the bottom we can create a rule
we can clear the rule and we can manage
our rule so if you create a rule then
you can manage it so we're going to
start with these icon sets and I'm going
to show you how to use those and we'll
work our way to the top and then I'll
show you how to create some rules
yourself and how that all works so let's
start off with the icon sets I'm going
to go over here to sales um and for this
data we kind of have this um you know
Trend or or pattern that you can kind of
see over time so over the months um so
if we go right here and let's use that
conditional forming let's use that icon
sets and right here we can use these
directional so you know we have this
kind of Time series each month that
shows us how much paper they're selling
and if we do this right here it's going
to show us if it's kind of average or if
it's below average or if it's above
average or if it's going up so at a
really quick glance you can kind of see
the pattern of this data set it's kind
of going mostly yellow and red there's
only two months where it's going up
significantly now we don't have to only
do that for one row or one column you
can apply to all of them but as you can
see all of these are red now why are
they all red it's because they're using
numbers for everything so they're
comparing these 24s these 50s and 65s
against these 450s and 750s and so
they're all going to be red but if we do
it individually if we do it each row if
we take it just like this and then we go
to Icon sets and do it it's going to be
much more representative of the actual
printers not of all the numbers as a
whole and you can do other things uh the
arrows are ones that you'll probably see
the most often that's the one I've used
if I ever do use them um but you can you
know do ones like this where they have
you know kind of a trend upward or a
trend downward um and so there's just
several more arrows this one only gives
you three as you can see this one gives
you five um and you can do you know
colors or shapes or or different
indicators and all these different
things um and honestly it's kind of
whatever you want to use whatever makes
sense for your data but you know I've
really only ever seen like these colors
being used I've never really seen these
flags or anything like that but again it
just depends on what industry you work
in you might you might see that let's go
right over here to the demographics um
and let's look at our color scales now
color scales are going to be the
probably the most obvious thing that in
datab bars are going to be the most
obvious things in here um if you go
right here and and you look at this
color scale if it's high if it's among
the top ones it's green the lowest it's
red and you can change that um to really
any colors you want any colors that they
offer you um and it it does exactly what
it does it's a color scale a gradient of
the colors from high to low or low to
high and so any color that you do you'll
be able to kind of see um you know
what's good and what's not good that
really is um color scales in a nutshell
data bars are again super super
straightforward it's going to be either
a gradient fill or a solid fill so let's
look at the gradient fill if we do a
blue gradient fill I'll actually let's
get rid of our um let's go over here
let's go to clear rules from selected
cells we haven't looked at that yet but
that's how you clear it let's go to data
bars and we'll use this blue gradient so
with this blue gradient you know this
one is or sorry this one is the highest
one so it's going to be completely
filled and this one is 36,000 almost
half of this I'm pretty close and so
it's almost half um this one again you
know it's not used very often
I you don't see these a lot to be honest
you just don't um but if you do see it
that's how you use it that's how it can
be done again pretty easy uh as I just
showed a second ago if you want to clear
the rules you can clear from the
selected cells that's what we're doing
so I have column G selected and I'm
going to I'm going to clear that if you
want to clear the rules for the entire
sheet you can do that as well so it
would affect every single column and row
we'll just do this for now so now let's
go look at the top bottom rules so so
this is the top 10 items top 10% bottom
10 items bottom 10% above average and
below average and they're going to do
exactly what you think they are going to
do if you select above average it is
going to select or highlight the cells
that are above the average in column G
so let's look at the salaries that are
above average all right and so uh the
ones that are at the very top are
Michael Scotts Toby flenderson and
Dwight shro uh no shock there um I
believe the average is somewhere around
like
48,500 or something so I think this one
just is just below it and so all these
other ones are below average and that's
just because you know Michael Scott and
Dwight Sho are and Toby are kind of
bringing up that average quite a bit so
everyone else is going to fall beneath
that so at a super quick glance you're
able to just highlight the cells and
you're able to see who is above average
and you know you can do this in a lot of
different ways in Excel but this is just
a really simple fast way to do that um
let's get rid of that real quick and
let's go back up here and now we can
oops let's go to top bottom rules and
now we can see the below average and
it's going to highlight all the other
ones and so it works exactly how you
think it is going to work and this is
the default way that it highlights these
cells so it highlights them this kind of
um seeth through red and then it
highlights the actual text or or the um
characters in there red as well now I'm
not going to go through and show you
every single one of these top bottom
rules I think they're pretty
self-explanatory I just kind of wanted
to show you what happens when you do use
one of them it's going to highlight that
cell so let's go up here to the
Highlight cells rules and honestly these
are the ones that I use by far the most
uh all these other ones combined I do
not use more than this highlight cells
rules um and the one in here that I use
more than any other conditional
formatting rule is this duplicate values
so I'll start with that really quick and
I'll kind of show you a few few of these
other ones but this duplicate values to
me is one of the most useful ones um and
so let's kind of show you how that works
if we go to the start date you can see
that we have a duplicate value right
here and if we go over here to
conditional formatting highlight cells
rules and duplicate values it is going
to highlight um the uh duplicate and
that says duplicate right here now we
can go through here and click on unique
um and then it would highlight all the
ones that are not duplicates um so you
can use it you know kind of in a similar
inverse way uh it's just different
different but I use the duplicate almost
always um another thing that you can do
is go over here and you can change the
color um or you can even do a custom um
which I never do that it's not um
something I spend a lot of time doing I
typically just stick with this one so
you can do that and it's going to
highlight um you know something that has
a duplicate value in there now why do I
use this so much well I work with a lot
of different types of data sets but one
thing that you'll find in almost all of
them is they have some type of ID and
they're going to have some type of um
personal information whether that's a
social security number or an address or
um you
know or a cell phone number or something
like that there is going to be data that
is going to to identify that person now
I work a lot with pharmaceutical data a
lot with Pharmacy data um as well as
Healthcare data so like names Social
Security numbers addresses phone numbers
all those things all that customer or or
client information and oftentimes when I
get a new data set and I have it in
Excel or I convert it to excel I will
start using these duplicates to try to
find issues with the data and I find
them all the time either there's an
employee ID or some type of customer ID
or client ID that has a duplicate in
there that should not be in there or
there's multiple Social Security numbers
or there's an issue in some other way
and I'm able to find those things and
spot those patterns using this
duplicates and I promise you I use this
one almost every single time I open a
new data set or I work with a new
clients working with their data um and
so I wanted to show you this one I
wanted to really press upon you that
this one is a really really really good
one to know and learn how to use it's
not complicated it's not hard it just
shows you you know you know
if there's a duplicate value but I
wanted you to know how I use it and how
often I use it so that you can you know
pick that up and put that in your tool
kit in your back pocket so that you can
use that later on if you have uh if you
have a similar need or if you're trying
to do something similar to what I was
just talking about so that is how
duplicates work again super great it's
obviously not super useful when you're
only using um 10 rows but when you have
you know 50,000 100,000 and there should
be zero duplicates in there and you
highlight it and then uh you come right
here use the
filter and we're going to filter and
we're going to sort by the color and it
allows you to sort by the color and you
have duplicates in there then that's a
problem and you identified a problem
super quickly uh and you know some of
those things they slip by because nobody
checks it and so that's something that I
I often check and if you go here and you
sort by color and there isn't an option
to do um this this pink red color and
that means there aren't any duplicates
and that a really good thing most of the
time that's a really good thing so let's
go ahead and we're going to clear that
as well
as get rid of our conditional formatting
rules now another one that I use a lot
is this one right here which is the text
that contains honestly this one comes a
lot in handy especially when you're
looking for like a specific keyword in
my uh case a lot of times I was using
this when I was going through drug names
I am not a doctor I do not pretend to be
a doctor and so when I was looking for
laraza Pam or something like that um I
would just search for like lorz or
something and and not Lorax but loras
you know I I would just search for it
and then all the ones that contain that
would pop up I can bring them to the top
and I can see them and to me that's
super super useful and I would do that
all the time and so in this case we're
looking at emails and let's say we all
only wanted to pull all the ones that
are Gmail and so now we can go through
and we can you know click okay and
that's going to pop up or we want all
the ones that have Dunder oops Dunder
Mifflin and if we click on that all the
ones that are Dunder Mifflin come up or
have done their Mylin in it and again we
can um sort by or we can um and so we
can sort by right here and we can bring
all those to the top and so super super
useful um and another use for it that
you may not think of is something like
if it's you know there's some incorrect
data in there this happens often with
phone numbers addresses um start dates
or or or dates in general date formats
where you can go in here and you can say
text that contains and if you know you
put in a oops a dash and it has it in
there then you know that that is that is
wrong now that is really all I wanted to
show you in the Highlight cells rules uh
the duplicate values and the text
contains are by far the ones that I use
the most all the other ones I have used
um these ones not so much but in these
highlight cells rules I use you know
these two all the time um sometimes I
use this between I don't really use
these other ones as much although I have
used them and so you got nothing else
from this video I just wanted you to
know that these two are super useful and
if you haven't used them before to maybe
try them out and see if you can apply
them to your own data sets now we've
looked at all of these preset ones in
conditional formatting but you can also
do a new rule and so if we click on new
rule right here and we go down to use a
formula to determine which cells to
format we can add our own formula in
here that will then highlight exactly
what we want and so if there isn't a
preset rule that you like and it doesn't
have the option that you want you can do
almost any formula that you want in our
formulas video that we did a few weeks
ago and you can put it in here and then
you can format uh what you want the cell
to look like if it meets that criteria
so let's take this right over here um
and before we start this formula I just
want you to note that you know I have
h11 highlighted that's going to come
into play in just a little bit but I
want you to be aware that h11 is the
cell that we're highlighted so what
we're going to do is we are going to
create our formula now if you've never
created a formula I highly recommend uh
watching my formulas tutorial because
that is going to show you how to do this
um but we're all we're going to do is
we're going to do equals that's how you
start the uh how you actually create a
formula and we're going to give it this
range right here and so it's going to
take everything from G2 to G10 now these
dollar signs are super important if you
don't know how to use them or you don't
know what they do um you're going to
mess up this formula a lot uh and so
what this dollar sign basically does is
it's basically hardcoding it in there it
is only going to look at G2 and is only
going to look at G10 or through G10
because that colon and this can come
into play because if you have something
selected like the h11 it's going to mess
it up because now if you have h11
selected like we do you'll see this in a
second it's not going to be applied to
this um and again I'll show you that in
just a minute but we don't want this
hardcoded in there okay but we do have
to select the proper range in a second
um so we're going to get rid of this
we're going to get rid of the dollar
signs because we want to pretty fluid
and be able to applied to be applied
basically anywhere we want let's go into
this
formula um if it meets our criteria
let's give it um let's give it a border
and we'll give it um we'll give it some
color we're going to say if this is
greater than
50,000 so let's hit okay and nothing
happened so let's go back and see why so
if we go to our manage rules you can see
that so as the G2 to G G10 is greater
than 50,000 but it only is being applied
to this h11 cell which really makes no
sense um so if we had wanted to get it
done the first time we needed to have
basically selected that G2 to G10 right
away um but we can do that now so let's
get rid of this and we're going to say
G2 to
G10 and that is hardcoded in there
that's should be fine still um but let's
see what it
does and so now every every single thing
is highlighted and why is that uh that's
because when we changed it it also
changed the format of it because we
changed the cell that we were looking at
so we need to come back here and that's
why again you want to do this the right
way the first time we're going to come
back here we're going to give it this
range and we're going to get rid of
these dollar
[Music]
signs and now we're going to hit okay
and so now it's being applied G2 to G10
and G2 to G10 and we'll keep it like
that and we'll apply it and now it works
properly so now everything that's above
50,000 is being highlighted again if
that was confusing um it it is confusing
it genuinely is and so if you wanted to
do this right the first time without
having to make a bunch of changes you'd
want to highlight these before you start
and then you want to go in and create
the rule we'll do this really quick just
to kind of show you what I'm talking
about we'll say equals we'll give it
this range
get rid of these real quick because
again I don't want this hardcoded in
there it will ruin our formula and then
we'll say greater than 30 um and we'll
give this nice green uh and so now if
they're over the age of 30 it will be
highlighted and we didn't have to go
back and change anything we didn't have
to go back and fix anything like we did
in the first one um that was all for
demonstration purposes but again you
need to really be aware of that that is
something that I think think almost
everybody's going to mess up at some
point if you don't already know about it
then you definitely are going to make
that mistake now if we come over here in
this area uh we go to our manage rules
and not just the current selection but
this whole worksheet then you can see
that we have these two formulas now you
can go in and edit any of these by
double clicking or clicking on it and
then hitting edit rule you can also
delete these rules or duplicate these
rules um I just wanted to show you what
you are able to do with them but if we
uh go ahead and we get rid of this um so
let's say we delete that rule and we hit
apply uh you know the rule is going to
go away that's that I mean it's as
simple as that so that is how you can
create your own rule I want to be again
very specific in the fact that that is a
confusing piece and if you mess that up
you're going to be you know fixing a
bunch of different stuff and not
understanding why your rule is not
working properly it's just because it's
confusing those dollar signs are are
really important to watch out for and
that is all all there is to it with
conditional formatting again conditional
formatting is um you know it's not
anything super confusing we've looked at
more complicated things but it's a
really really useful tool to use to look
at these patterns and Trends super
quickly and to find um these outliers or
these specific values that you're
looking for very quickly and if you're
looking at just thousands and tens of
thousands or hundreds of thousands of
rows this is one of the fastest ways to
find these things without having to kind
of wait and filter and use these um
these these filters right here because
again this can just take forever um and
so if you haven't or if you've never
worked with a ton of data and tried to
use this before it can take honestly
like 10 minutes for something simple
that you could do with conditional
formatting in like 10 seconds so
definitely something to mess with and
use when you are working with your own
data sets uh I hope this was helpful I
mean honestly I use this all the time so
you know I hope that somebody out there
can can use this uh for their own work
that they're currently using thank you
guys so much for watching I really
appreciate it again huge shout out to
you me for sponsoring this Excel series
if you like this video be sure to like
And subscribe below I'll see you in the
next
[Music]
video what's going on everybody welcome
back to another Excel tutorial today we
will be looking at
[Music]
charts
now if you have data in Excel and you
want to visually show that with bars or
graphs or anything like that you can do
that really simply and I'm going to show
you how to do that today and a lot of
people are a little bit intimidated
because they think it's a little bit
complicated but I promise you by the end
of this video you will know how to do it
like a pro it's not that difficult it's
just you need to know where to look
where to click and how to actually
filter through things to make sure that
you're visually showing the things that
you want to show but before we actually
jump into the the tutorial I want to
give a huge shout out to the sponsor of
this Excel series and that is udem me
you may not know this but I probably get
at least 15 to 50 companies every single
month reaching out to me wanting to
sponsor the channel and promote their
product and I turn down almost every
single one because I either don't know
their product or I don't believe in
their product and so I'm not going to
you know go and promote that on my
channel but unud me is one that I have
consistently promoted over the past year
and that's because I truly believe in
their product I've been taking courses
off their platform for years and I've
honestly learned so much and I cannot
recommend them enough so if you want to
take a full-fledged Excel course I have
my recommendations in the description if
you want to check those out thank you
again to UD me for sponsoring this Excel
Series so without further Ado let's jump
onto my screen and get started with the
tutorial all right so let's jump right
into it right here we have the Dunder
Mifflin sales report and over here we
have all the products that they were
selling along with the months that they
were sold in and so in January they sold
450 reams of paper down here we have the
total it items per month and so in
January they sold 898 units of uh
products or or things that they sold at
the very end we have the year end total
so this is the total amount of paper
that they sold throughout the year now
we're going to use this data right here
for all of our charts now you may not
have data exactly like this it can come
in lots of different flavors but you're
going to get the basic gist of how to
use charts how to edit it how to
customize it to fit what you need and
then we're going to kind of put it right
over here and kind of create its own
sheet where we can kind of visualize all
the things that we want to
show so let's jump right back over here
into sales and first thing we need to do
is kind of highlight the data that we're
going to be working with now I'm going
to start with everything but um you know
I'll show you along the way we don't
actually want everything but we can
filter that stuff out as we go so let's
go right here and we're going to insert
and we're going to go over to charts now
this is the chart section there's lots
of different types of charts um but the
first thing that we're going to be
looking at is right here this is a 2d
column or kind of like a bar chart and
we're just going to click right here and
we're going to pull this
down so now that we have this down here
there are a few things that I want to
show you before we actually really get
into it I kind of want to show you the
options that you have so if you go up
here we have different uh chart Styles
and so if I hover over them you can see
that each one kind of looks a little bit
different and it really doesn't matter
uh it doesn't really change the data in
any way just how you visualize it and so
if that is important if that is
something that you um you want to stick
with a certain theme or a certain look
then go for that uh the other thing
that's really nice to have over here is
this switch row and column so right down
here you can see this purple and you can
see this red those are our rows and
columns and we can switch that right
here so if we go like this now instead
of the months being right here the
months are the colors and the actual
product is right here let's click it
again and it'll go back and so now we
have this kind of Time series now we
have January through the end of your
total now this one is one that I think
is super helpful you know it you can do
it down here as well if you go to this
filter um but both of these are super
helpful because you sometimes just want
to select all the data and then kind of
get in there and mess with with it
something that we want to get rid of is
this total items per month so we want to
remove that and then we also want to
remove this year-end total because both
of those are are kind of the end result
they're not the actual data per month or
or per product so we're going to get rid
of those and we're going to apply that
and as you can see just right off the
bat our data is changed dramatically uh
and that's because we aren't including
these these large large numbers that
were kind of throwing off uh the
visualization for us so this one right
here as is is already pretty good um
what we can do right here is we can
change this and we're just going to
say products
sold per
month now what we can do if we want to
move it to another um to another sheet
is we can actually move the chart and we
can select where we want to move it we
can move it to chart sheet and we can do
that or something that I do um almost
99% of the time I just copy and I come
over here and I'm going to paste it and
so now we have this um this chart right
over here as well as back here and so I
typically tend to do that because now we
can still go over here and change this
one as much as we want so if we want to
go in here we can alter this one and it
won't affect the other one so we just
have basically two copies so we're going
to keep this one right here this is
going to be our first
visualization um and as I said said it's
it's fairly straightforward if you've
ever done any types of charts or graphs
before um right here it's January
February March April May and if you
hover over these you can see that that's
the the paper and if we just glance you
know the paper is their biggest product
by far and so that blue um which is
their paper is going to be the biggest
every single month so that makes perfect
sense now what if we want to change up
uh the the kind so what if we want to
change up the kind of visualization that
it offers us well we have a lot of
different options let's go right over
here to change chart type now this is
going to offer you just about everything
you could possibly imagine or want and
even things that you absolutely would
never ever want ever um and so I'm going
to show you some of the good ones and
I'm going to show you some just
absolutely insane ones that uh Excel
came up with which cannot I could not
imagine a scenario that these are ever
used um but Within These columns you can
do they're called cluster columns uh
these stacked columns so would look just
like this those are often used as
well um and then we have ones that
they're just not used often let's look
let's take a look at this one right
here I mean it's tough it's tough to
look at um but let's let's put it right
here this is basically the same thing
that we just had except visualized in a
different um we'll call it more unique
way
uh and let's for the sake of it let's
put it over here um these two things
show the same information they show the
same data just one is shown well and one
is not shown well um I'm not a fan of
these 3D type of
visualizations I I just don't like them
but maybe you do and and you want to use
that that's fantastic let's go back um
something else that you'll probably use
a lot are things like these um these
line graphs okay so these are line
graphs and they're different types so
they're these stacked um 100% stacked
line lines with markers different
flavors for this this type of line graph
and so you can go in here and take a
look again um not my favorite but they
have it as an option if you CH so choose
to do this um but I kind of I'm kind of
a simple guy um but I'm going to go in
here and it's pretty cluster
um I want to kind of take the ones that
have the highest
sales or the highest total amount sold
so that would be paper manila folders
and three ring binders so let's go in
here we want to keep paper we want to
keep uh manila
folders and we want to keep three ring
binders and let's apply that and so now
it's a lot cleaner and we're just going
to copy this and we're going to put it
over here and I'm just putting these all
over here for you U because we'll look
at this at the end and just kind of see
different options and and ways to do
things as we have gone through this
tutorial so let's go back here now
something else that we haven't looked at
is the actual colors and color schemes
that you can do so let's go right here
to these chart Styles and we can go to
color now color is um something that
probably is quite overlooked um in
actual charts and graphs some terrible
colors like this or or this um where
they're really close together especially
when you have a lot of them um for
example let's just pretend we put all of
them back really quickly it is near
impossible to distinguish these colors
um we
wouldn't we wouldn't want that let's go
back to this color you know when you
have it like uh in some of these colors
at least it at least distinguishes them
so you can kind of see what you're
working with with um but when you have
it in these monochromatic options
sometimes they're just impossible to
distinguish so be sure to choose the
right colors that you're using so that
if somebody who's never seen this data
before looks at it they can easily
distinguish uh the product and the month
that you are looking at but let's go
just back up here we'll choose this
default option um well let's choose this
one right here this one's nice although
there's lots of yellows and oranges
let's see this one this one's not bad
greens blues uh and like yellows so
that's nice um other things that we want
to look at and there are these chart
elements right here other things that we
can add are things like data labels um
and right here it's super messy um but
if we went back and we got rid of some
of these things like the printer Staples
highlighters pens and total we apply
that it's a little bit easier to
distinguish um
and that's you know something that you
may be interested in doing you can also
add this data table at the bottom which
is the actual columns and rows that you
have for this visualization right here
now let's expand this quite a bit I'm
going to make this extremely large if
you have something like this it actually
can be pretty nice um you know maybe we
get rid of these data labels but it can
be easy because you're putting it all in
one place you can also make this two
separate visualizations so you can have
one visualization just like this and
right underneath it you can have the
actual rows and columns but this option
allows you to put it all in one so let's
put this back down because that is way
too big and uh wait let's expand it a
little bit now if you notice right here
we have our Legend up top um it is
possible to actually change that you can
go right here and you can move this um
kind of wherever you want um but it's
not exactly easy to put based off how we
have it right here if we go into to this
chart elements we go down to Legend and
we hit this little arrow right here we
can select it on the right the top the
left and the bottom or we can just go to
more options uh which allows us to push
it anywhere but um let's say I want to
do it just like this I'm going to put on
the right and I actually want to bring
it down right here and you know that's
just an option if you want to kind of
customize it a little further makes a
little cleaner uh you can do that with
almost any of these things so if you
click on this oops if you click on this
you can move this anywhere as well so if
you want to move this over here on top
of it you can and make it look terrible
or you can move it uh right back over
here you know this is something that you
can move around uh you just kind of want
to make sure you're doing it the right
way so let's get this back where was
there we go now before we go any further
let's copy that and put it right over
here with our other uh charts and graphs
and if you see over here on this side we
have this this format chart area notice
I haven't showed you this at all yet
that is because I genuinely just don't
use this almost at all um there are some
good stuff in here um and I'm sure that
you know if you were someone who really
wants to go in there and super customize
it you can do that um but I honestly I
just never get in here and I never you
know change the glow or the Shadows um
just not something I use and some of
these are only for these three 3D
formatting which I never use and so I'm
not going to show you and walk through
these things again I I really don't use
it and so if you want to go in there and
mess with it uh you know by all means go
for it it's just not something that I
want to take the time to show you and
with that being said let's go back over
to this chart sheet that we have and it
was super super easy to get these um
charts and graphs and and and whatnot
there are lots of different options
again if we go back here and we go up
here to chart design and go to the
change chart type and again there are a
ton of different options like a pie
chart um like this it's it's you know
you can try to figure this out and use
these um but you know I wanted to show
you the ones that you'll probably use
the most which are these columns and
line charts and they all kind of are
similar in their own way this bar chart
is basically you know this column chart
just on its side and so they all have
their different flavor they all have
their different way of visualizing the
data but but in essence they're using
the data in a similar way to to
visualize it and represent the data
itself especially things like these box
and whisker plots or these waterfall
charts uh you know these are things that
usually require specific data to kind of
use uh and and so I'm just using data
that you'll probably see the most of um
like this this sales data so I hope that
this given you a pretty good um you know
quick understanding of how to use these
how to customize them how to copy and
paste them over to to a different sheet
to create some type of little uh chart
and visualization sheet that you can use
to show your employers and and visualize
the data that you are working with thank
you guys so much for watching I really
appreciate it again huge shout out to
you to me for sponsoring this Excel
series if you like this video be sure to
like And subscribe below and I'll see
you in the next
[Music]
video
what's going on everybody welcome back
to the Excel tutorial Series today we'll
be looking at how to clean data in
[Music]
Excel now knowing how to clean data in
Excel is actually extremely useful and
there are a ton of techniques to do this
I'm going to be showing you the ones
that I probably use the most I feel like
are the most helpful to kind of do the
bulk or the majority of the data
cleaning that you're going to do in
Excel like I said there's so many
different ways and very specific things
that you can do but I'm going to
highlight some of the bigger ones that I
find the most useful and some of you may
be thinking well I'll just do my data
cleaning in SQL or python or when I get
it ready to put it in Tableau um but
honestly a lot of the data cleaning at
least a lot of the big stuff I tend to
do in Excel IF the data set is small
enough to fit in Excel and so I think
it's actually really really useful to
know how to do this because you'll most
likely be doing it more than you think
now before we jump into the tutorial I
want to give a shout out to the sponsor
of this video and is brand new sponsor
it is unlocked by Z by HP unlocked is a
movie that's actually broken up into
four parts and each of them have a
unique data science challenge associated
with it now I'm going to read this next
part because it's extremely interesting
each challenge represents a different
topic so there's data visualization text
analysis audio signal processing and
computer vision and you can submit your
answers in your work on their website
for a chance to win one of 10 zbook
Studio laptops or a free trip to the
kaggle World Championships so I'll leave
a link in the description where you can
go watch the movie and then do the
challenges and then submit your answers
for a chance to win you should also go
check out their hackathon where you can
do these projects with other people just
like you who are trying to figure out
these answers and submit them to win as
well so go check that out thank you
again to the sponsor of this video
unlocked by Z by HP now without further
Ado let's jump onto my screen and get
started with the tutorial all right so
let's jump right into it I have this US
president data set I got the base data
set from kaggle uh but I added some of
my own data and then I messed some stuff
up as well just to kind of um
demonstrate some of these things that
we're going to be looking at today this
is not a full project so you know we're
actually going to be using this to
create any visualizations or anything
like that so you know all this is just
for demonstration purposes but we will
be doing a full project in about two or
three videos uh in this Excel Series
where we're going to be doing from start
to finish with a real data set so you
know if that's something that you're you
wanting then we will absolutely be doing
that now something that you may be
wondering is how do you actually
identify what you need need to clean in
the data what do you know to look for
well some of the obvious things are
things like formatting and
standardization so things like you know
this James Monroe is in all caps that
happens all the time within real data um
and and so you know you want to
standardize that or this all lowercase
you want to standardize that you want
that all to be the same there's also
things like um right here or we have
this wig and this wig with a bunch of
random stuff after it this happens all
the time where it's not completely
standardized um and you may even notice
um you know there are some spelling
errors in here and I'll we'll kind of
look through that in a little bit and
then you know there are things like
additional spaces where there shouldn't
be spaces there are things like
currencies that you need to be aware of
if you were importing this into or going
to be importing this into a SQL database
um things like currencies can be just a
problem or be really um unnecessary it
may actually cause more issues in the
long run so you may just want to you
know take that to the base value and
then dates are always an issue always
always always um so always look at your
dates make sure they're they're
formatted correctly make sure they're
all the same these are the types of
things that right when I glance at this
data set these are things that I'm
looking for um one other thing that is
actually the first thing that we're
going to start out with is you want to
make sure that your data is not
duplicated because if your data has
duplicate data in it and you don't want
that it's not supposed to be there there
are some specific use cases where
duplicated data is okay um you know you
want to get rid of that and it's very
easy to do in Excel uh the first thing
we're going to do we're going to go uh
to this data tab we're going to go right
over here and we're going to get see if
there's any uh duplicates in our data so
we're just going to go up to remove
duplicates it's going to automatically
choose all of your columns to to check
against so it's going to for from a all
the way through I it's going to see is
the exact same data in all these rows
and if it is it's going to get rid of it
um and so we're going to click okay and
it did find one duplicate and I'll show
you that one real quick um because you
know it was right here so Barack Obama
was here twice and then I'm going to hit
control I hit control Z to go back I'm
going hit control y to go forward and it
removed that uh that row completely now
in this example you may be able to spot
that with your eye but in a real data
set where you have 10,000 100,000 rows
there's absolutely no way you're going
to see that or very very unlikely that
you are going to see that there's
duplicated data in there so just running
a a a quick um dup or or removing of
duplicates that is really important to
make sure that you um have gotten rid of
those things so that's one of the first
things that I do um we're going to go
into a lot of these different uh columns
and I'm going to kind of show you
different techniques or things that I do
when I look at actual data so I'm going
to come right over here I'm going to
insert and this is what I actually do I
I usually create a separate column
especially when I'm working with this
because I don't want to change this one
um I don't want to go in here and you
know say um equals upper equals proper
Etc there's a lot of different ways that
you can change um names or not a lot but
the main ones that you can change names
and all of them are completely okay so
for example I'm going to hit equal upper
oops upper and I'm going to go like this
and close my parentheses so I selected
this S I close my parenthese hit enter
it is and I'm going to hit um in the
bottom right I'm going toit double click
this and it's going to apply to all of
them it is completely okay to have your
data like this if you want it to be like
that um if you want it to be all lower
you can do that if you want it to be in
proper case you can do that um there are
oops there are different um uses for all
of them and honestly as long as it's all
the same typically it's okay but if um
you know for example if you're selling
this to like a third party company or
something like that they may have um
what they want for their ingestion
process when they take your file in if
you send you know a weekly file or a
monthly file they may want it exactly
how they want it and you can change that
to to what they want um but as long as
it's standardized for you it's all the
same for you that is a good thing so now
we have all of these um in the proper
case that's typically what I I do or I
use upper those are the ones I use the
most I don't usually use um lower and if
you go in here and you type in
lower you know it changes it to all
lower I don't typically do that um and
I'm gon to add I'm oops I'm gonna say
president Dash fixed and so now all of
these names um all of these uh different
uppercase and lowercase these are all
fixed and and it just makes it so much
easier to read and you don't have
different um uppercase and lowercase
issues it's all the same so I'm going to
keep keep that right
there uh if we move a little bit to the
right if you look at this prior now this
prior is a mess it it has stuff all over
and to be honest this is not really
something that I would probably be using
um like in a real data set I would look
at this column and I would say this is
pretty useless um if I had a very
specific use case for this this data in
this column I might try to you know
parse it out and do something but I
don't uh this this is a completely
useless com to me so I'm actually going
to skip this one I'm going to go to this
party one and this party one to me it
looks pretty important because this is
something that I know I can Group by um
and I can create visualizations with and
and kind of break that out and if you
look right here we're going to add um
we're going to add a filter so now let's
open up party and take a look so if we
look right here we have Democratic
democratic-republican Federalist
nonpartisan repu Republican Republicans
wig and wig with a a date and some
information in the back of it and then
some blanks um and it's really important
when we're when we're looking at these
um ones that we think we might Group by
that we have these um properly grouped
so Republican and Republicans to me
right off the bat looks like a spelling
error and so I'm just going to deselect
All I'm going to go to Republican
Republicans and it's literally
Republican all the way down except for
for this last one and to me that's just
something that I would update so I would
just go right here I do that if I didn't
do that and then I try to create let's
say a pivot table on here I'll have its
own group of Republicans and it wouldn't
be added to Republican and maybe that's
on purpose but let's just presume that
we know this data extremely well and
that's not supposed to be like that
right again that that just comes back to
knowing your data really well
understanding what it um you know what
it should look like and we know that it
should not be like that so we're going
to fix that uh the next thing that we're
going to fix um and as you can see it it
got rid of it next thing we're going to
fix is this wig
um that's just like an error that's
that's some issue on the the data side
and we're just going to fix that by
updating it and that's it I would always
be keeping um a a copy of this with the
raw data uh somewhere else because this
is presumably like a working document
this is not
a um you know you aren't saving over
your original file let's just say that
and then let's take a look at these
blanks real quick um okay so there are
these rows right here that have nothing
I think we're okay but if we see
anything different 47 48 okay so yeah
it's just these ones right here that
have no data in it anyways it's just
seeing it in the filter so not an issue
at all so okay we're looking good we've
gone all the way over we we fixed this
President we skipped this one um we we
cleaned up this party and I kept this
one in here because I'm not exactly sure
if that's a Democratic or republican so
I'm going to keep it its own thing um
I'm not a huge uh history buff in that
aspect the next one right here is um the
next one right here is really easy uh
this is something that happens all the
time especially on actually most often
it's happens on numerical data so like
uh you know there'll be a number of 1,1
and then there'll be a space after it
for absolutely no reason uh and it
happens all the time it does happen like
this as well um where you'll see this
and all you got to do is do trim and
select the the cell we're going to close
that parenthesis and we're going to
apply that all the way down what is so
fantastic about the trim is that it's
really intuitive and it knows basically
everything it needs to do for example um
it gets gets rid of the um spaces before
it gets rid of extra spaces in the
middle and um it'll get rid of extra
spaces at the end um which you wouldn't
be able to see but they are there and
they they absolutely can cause issues if
you have spaces at the end that you
cannot see um let's take this one for
example like if I had spaces at the end
that can cause issues when you insert or
or or put that into a database um that
happens a lot with numbers um you know
when you're putting that into SQL
that can cause issues and so you really
it is important to actually do that trim
um and you can do that on all of your
columns or just ones that you know
you're having issues with but once you
import that data into SQL you will know
if there's an issue or not when you
actually try to start using it so we're
going to say Vice and we're going to say
fixed oops there we go uh this next one
is one that you'll run into a lot when
you're working with numerical data you
will encounter so many different issues
um one that I run into a lot is I I've
worked with a lot of cost data or
pricing data and when it's in an Excel
it h it sometimes comes in with um these
currencies like a dollar sign a pound
sign things like that and when you put
that into
SQL it just is a nuisance right you're
not going to be able to run um it's
going to go in as a text or it's going
to be like a string right because it has
that special character and you don't
want that you don't want to have to then
go in and then change things around you
just want to be able to start um you
know doing calculations on those numbers
so what you can do is sometimes it'll
come in as a text sometimes it'll come
in as um currency which I think this
one's a currency we are just going to
change that to be a number and then
we're going to get rid of these
oops and get rid of those that it
doesn't look as pretty but that is much
more useful than actually having the
currency on there with the decimals this
actually is so much easier when you when
you want to use it for almost anything
because you're able to add and uh do
things properly in other systems in
Excel I think it does understand it um
but you know that can cause issues so
there is how you do that the next thing
that we're going to look at is these
dates and just notoriously whenever I
see a date field I know there's going to
be an issue with it it's very rare
that I get a date field that is perfect
uh it just it is genuinely is um is a
novelty when that happens and most of
the time it has to do with um let's say
a date comes into Excel and it's in a
text format or date comes into Excel and
they're not the same in this example
they are not the same um and we just
want them to all be similar they say
date on if you look right here it says
date it says date it looks like it
should be the the same um but if we go
like this it all looks the same right
there's no issues at all if we were to
um try to use that it may or may not be
an issue but we don't want to leave that
to chance later on if you're using this
with python or something like that it
can cause issues U maybe not in SQL
because it may um see the underlying um
what's in the underlying cell not just
what we see but some systems won't and
so you want to make sure that they're
all the same
and so you know what we were doing back
here with um oops with the party and we
were looking at this uh this filter and
identifying the issues I usually do that
on date fields as well and and
oftentimes um I know just for just for
demonstration purposes ofttimes I will
get something like that and then I'll
come up here and I'll notice that
there's this one random number that
happens all the time all the time um and
so you know you want to make sure that
you um that you look at these things and
just just do at least a quick glance if
not kind of doing a kind of a deep dive
into it but all we're going to do is
we're going to do both of these and
we're going to do a short date and let's
take a look and see if that fixed it and
so now they are all the same format and
that is fantastic that is exactly what
we want we're going to go back through
here we're going to get rid of these um
again this is a
working um this is a working document
oops uh we need to we're I'm going to do
um control shift down oops let me go
back up do control shift down and copy
and what I'm going to do right now is
I'm actually going to copy let me do it
right here I'll show you sometimes I do
this does just depends I'm going to go
right here I'm going to hit rightclick
and I'm going to paste as a value which
means it's not going to take the
calculation or the formula that I just
did
uh it's going to actually paste it as
that value so we just replaced it um
right here you can see up here it says
equals trim of
G2 this now now that I copied and pasted
it over as a value um it got rid of that
um calculation and now it is actually a
string so we don't need this anymore and
I'll do the same thing over here as
well I'm going to control shift down
copy and I just hit the right key uh or
the left key sorry now I'm going to
right click and I'm going to do paste as
a value and again it has this proper and
now it doesn't have the proper it's
actually the value that was here so
that's really important to note uh and
we're going to get rid of that one and
so now what we have is is already
looking much better now one of the last
things I we're going to look at is
deleting columns that we are not going
to use and this is why it's so important
to keep a backup or or or the raw data
not in this file because if you start
saving over this file and this is your
raw file uh that can mess up a lot of
things and that happens to me before and
it's terrible and then you have to
request another file or you have to go
back and find it or something like that
it's terrible um so so this is our
working document so we can mess with
this and do whatever we want for our
purposes now for us um I can already
tell you that this prior is a bunch of
nonsense and we do not need it we're not
going to use it for anything and it and
if we have um this is a small very small
data set this only has like um let's say
you know one two three four five six
seven eight we have like eight columns
that we're you know kind of using that
has data eight or nine now that's a
small data I've had ones with literally
like hundreds um and and it has so many
columns uh so much data and sometimes
it's good to just trim it back to the
things you know you're going to use this
to me is absolutely useless um we're
going to delete that
and then right over here it's pretty
redundant um it's just one number off
but if we scroll down just a little bit
um it goes it's basically just counts
it's a you could even call it a unique
um identifier if you want sure why not
but we don't need both um so we're going
to get rid of this first one and now we
have more of the useful and relevant
data rather than the stuff that we
absolutely know that we are not going to
use um these date updated and date
created we may never use them but we
might um so it doesn't hurt to keep it
on hand those other ones are ones that
we are almost certain we will never use
again keep a backup just in case you
need it you can always go back and get
it so you know if you go back to what we
started with and you look at what we
have now it is much cleaner it's much
more usable and these are small subtle
changes um especially with this very
small data set of only like 50 rows or
or 46 rows but you're going to be
working with data sets that are
thousands tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands of rows and you need to know
how to kind of look at this data
standardize it um format it properly for
what you're going to be using it for if
you're keeping it in Excel there are
different things that you may do than if
you're putting it into a database or
going to be using it in you know um
using python to to access it so you need
to kind of know your use case but these
are some things that I do all the time
to kind of clean up the data before I
use it for something whether I'm
creating pivot tables or I'm inserting
it into or I'm putting it into SQL these
are things I do all the time and so
hopefully that helps give you kind of an
idea of some of the things that you
should be looking for when you're
actually cleaning data and it's really
important to understand why you're
actually making these changes and the
reason you're making these changes
because some of the things that I did
today may not be things you want to do
on a different data set that has
different uses and different um purposes
for so you know take everything that
I've said and and apply it um with a
little grain of salt to your data set
because your spefic specific needs may
be different than what I wanted when I
was cleaning my data set so I hope this
was helpful I hope you this gave you a
small glimpse of some of the things that
I'm looking for when I clean a data set
or I get a new data set in and I'm kind
of you know analyzing it figuring out
what I need to fix in it I hope this has
been helpful uh with that being said
thank you so much for watching I really
appreciate it if you like this video be
sure to like And subscribe below and
I'll see you in the next
[Music]
video
what's going on everybody welcome back
to the Excel tutorial Series today we're
going to create an entire project in
[Music]
Excel now if you've never done a
complete project in Excel where you take
the data you clean it then you create an
actual dashboard where people can click
on things and filter things this is
going to be a really great learning
opportunity as well as potentially you
know a simple project that you can use
for your portfolio or you can spice
things up and go a little farther than
what we're going to be doing in today's
video I will walk you through every
single step of the way and hopefully we
learn something together and without
further Ado let's jump right into it
let's jump onto my screen and get
started with the project all right so
this is the data set that we're going to
be working with I will leave a link in
the description to my GitHub where you
can go and download it so you can be
working with the exact same data set
that I am using now before we actually
get into this data and start looking at
it I'm going to show you what the final
dashboard is going to look like um we're
going to create a few different types of
visualizations nothing too crazy um and
then we'll create some filters as well
so we can kind of you know create some
interactive filters with our data so
let's go right on over to our data set
now I'm going to hide this because we
are not going to use that but what I am
going to do before we do anything is I'm
going to create a
dashboard and I'm going to create a
pivot table oops
and I'm going to create a working sheet
so um all these things have different
uses and I'll explain that as we go
along so this is our data set um I'm
going to copy this over to our working
sheet when I go into you know an Excel
and I'm working on something I don't
like to you know use just the one that I
was using in case I mess something up
and it saves over or's some issue I like
to create a working sheet and keep the
raw data right over here it just makes
my life easier I don't have to save it
and then you know open up a different
Excel to compare them so we have our
bike buyers this is our working sheets
this is our raw data this is the one
we're actually be working on today so
let's um let's start looking at it
really quick and just kind of glance and
see what data we're working with and
then we'll start cleaning it up making
it more useful for what we are going to
be using it for and then we'll start
building out the dashboard so right here
we have an ID that should be be a unique
ID to each person uh this is their
marital status so married or single this
is their gender male female we have
their income children their education
their occupation do they own a home how
many cars they own how long their
commute is the region where they live
their age and if they purchased a bike
and this column right here is extremely
important this is going to tell us
whether they did or did not buy a bike
so we got their information they're
looking for a bike but they either
decided not to buy a bike or they did
buy a bike and we're going to be using
that one a lot in in this video and so
um you know this is basically the data
set that we're working with um some of
the demographics and and information
behind the person so what we want to do
when we are cleaning the data before we
do anything uh I like to see if there
are any duplicates in here um what we're
going to do is come right up here we can
go to
uh where is it right here we got remove
duplicates so we're going to click on
that it selects every single one we just
want to see if there's any useless
duplicated data that we do not need uh
and the data is a header so we're going
to click
okay all right so we had a ton of
duplicates in there uh for whatever
reason so yeah we do have duplicates in
there so I'm glad we did that otherwise
we would have uh you know not good data
and we don't want that let's start right
over here um the ID of course we're not
going to change the marital status and
gender are M's s's fs and M's um this
isn't inherently a bad thing to have it
like this but you know we have to think
about it from the perspective of someone
who's going to be using this dashboard
do they know what M ands is do they know
what M uh and F is and if they don't
it's better to just spell it out for the
most part um so let's just do that so
we're going to click on the column B
we're going to hit controll H that's
going to bring up our find and replace
now there's an m in both of these
columns and there's different things one
is married and one means male so we're
going to do is we're going to search by
columns um and we'll have match case I
don't think that's going to change
anything but that just means an exact
match uh and we're going to do m equals
and we're going to replace it with
married and we'll replace all awesome
and then we do s is
single this one is super easy we're
going to do the exact same thing right
here so column C to hit contrl H we'll
do still has by column so we'll do m is
male we'll replace all of those and F is
female and replace all those that's
great uh you know the next column right
here is income and in a SE in a previous
video I talked about how I don't
typically like it in this format and
that's true um if you're doing calcul
ations on it or or any other thing it
can mess it up sometimes having the
dollar sign or it being a currency we're
not really going to mess with it too
much right now um what we can do is just
kind
of make sure all of it's currency um
we'll just go like that to make it a
little simpler but we're not going to
change it to like a
numeric um we will use this in the
visualization we'll see how it looks and
if we need to we'll come back and change
it if not we'll keep it how it is um so
so that's all we're going to do to that
one uh the children those look good we
have
education partial College partial High
School this looks fine to me um if
there's any spelling errors or anything
like that of course we need to clean
that up it doesn't look like there
is
occupation skilled manual manual okay
those should be separate are they a
homeowner should just be yes or no all
right we have Cars 1 2 3 4 good night
who owns four cars um and then we have
the commute distance uh and you know
there's nothing terrible about this it's
giving you ranges um which can be a good
thing I say let's keep it for now but I
have a feeling when we get further and
we start using in the visualization we
may want to change this so let's just
hold off for now um but if needed we
will come back to this and we'll change
this um and then we have our region and
that looks totally fine and we have our
age now when you're using ages typically
you have some type of like age bracket
or or age range and you do that because
there are so many ages in here right
it's 25 all the way down to 89 and if
you're using that in some type of
visualization it could just get really
messy and so you'll create kind of you
know just brackets around these so that
you can kind of condense it and make it
a little bit easier to understand so
let's do that and just create a new
column and then then we can use that for
our dashboard so let's go right up here
we're just going to create a new column
uh we'll call this age
brackets and what we can do is we can
use an if statement to kind of say if
it's older than or less than and and and
kind of give them these ranges um that's
one way to do it and that's the way
we're going to do it right now so let's
go up here and what we want to do is we
want to say is going to we're going to
say equals and we're going to do if and
we're going to close that parenthesis
now what we're going to say is if
this we'll go right back up here if this
is less than so we're going do this 31
and we're going to say comma so if they
are less than 31 what do we want to call
them what do we want their their you
know name to be we'll call them
adolescent oops that's not how you spell
adolescent adolescent um and then if
they're not what we're going to do is
we're going to say it's
invalid okay and let's just see if this
one works
first all right it's not working at all
um okay so basically what we did was um
incorrect we did it backward uh we want
to do I said uh L2 is greater than 31 no
we want to do like this so let's do that
now all right and it should pull up
where if they're under the age of 31 so
if they're 30 or below is basically what
it's saying so if they're 31 they'll be
invalid but if they're 30 or below it's
adolescent so it is working properly um
and let's see what it see what it says
perfect so this one is working and and
now what we want to do is we actually
want to build on this and make it uh
kind of like a nested if statement if
you've ever heard of that or done that
before so this is our first first if
statement and this is going to be this
is invalid this is our value if false
statement this whole statement is going
to become our value if false for a
different if statement um so let let me
write it out and hopefully that'll make
sense but we're going to say if do open
parentheses and we're going to do it
like this and let's just get rid of this
for a
second all right uh what did I do and
let me do
oops give me a
second okay we have our if let me just
write that out again we have our if
there we go so now what we're going to
do is we're going to write basically the
next part of it so we're going to say if
that L2 is and we're going to do this
time we're going to do greater than or
equal to 31 so now it's going to include
that 31 so right here we did anything
less than 31 so it's 30 and below this
one is going to be 31 and above so we're
going to say these people are middle
Ag and if not then it's going to go to
this if statement and then we need to
close it I believe so now let's try this
all
right fantastic now if um everybody
should be in one of these areas right
everyone should either be an adolescent
or middle age because basically all
we're saying is is if they're older than
31 or 30 or below that's all these two
statements do so we have um you know our
next group now we can add and go even
further into this and now we can use
this entire thing as the um what was it
called the value if false section so
that's what we're going to do we're
going to do one more so we're have three
different categories so we're going to
say if and do uh an open parenthesis and
we're going to say if oh actually Let's
Do It
um let's not do it to this one
let's do to this top one just
easier uh so we're going to say if open
parenthesis we're going to say L2 and
this time we're going to say anybody
over the age of 50 uh or we can do 55
let's do 55 so we'll do 55 and we're
going to call them
old and we'll do a comma and this is the
value if false statement and we need to
close our parenthesis so let's try this
anybody over the age of 55 should have
old um you know maybe we'll do 54 so
anybody who is 55 is considered old I
think that's fair I think that's fair
guys oops I should have
done I should have done that to this one
let me get out of this and we'll do
54 my dad is 55 that's why I'm doing it
like this this is fre
dead CU he should be in this old
category to be fair so now we have
adolescent adolescent middle-age and old
these are three categories so we can now
have these buckets these different
groups of Ages and it's much more usable
than these individual ages um and so we
will be using this in our in our
dashboard for sure now our next one is
the purchased bike uh and we're not
going to do anything with that so you
know that is that is that one and you
know there wasn't a ton to clean up here
we removed some duplicates um I don't
know why it says that what did I do
married married what does this mean even
mean I did I write that did I mess this
up guys
oh when I did the m and the S uh
replacement in there it replaced it with
married and single it's supposed to say
marital status
oops thanks for catching that guys
thanks for catching that I hope that's
how you spell marital uh we'll see so
uh we are going to keep it just like
this now what we are going to
now now what we are going to do is build
pivot tables with this data so we had
our raw data we have our working sheet
and now we want to create pivot tables
and pivot tables is how you actually
help build your dashboards or help build
your visualizations so we're going to go
right here we're going to hit whoops get
rid of that we're going to go right here
we're going to insert and we're going to
say pivot table and it's going to ask us
what
range so we're going to go back to the
working sheet and we'll just click here
and hit control
a this is going to select all of our
data for us so it's really easy and
we're going to hit okay and so now we
have all of
our pivot I don't need I don't need to
pull it out that far that was way too
far and now we have all of our pivot
table information over here and so that
should make it really easy to you know
actually build out so what we're going
to do is start selecting what columns
and what data we actually want to work
with so the first one that we're going
to build out is a dashboard that is
basically looking at the average income
of somebody who either bought or did not
buy a bike so we need in this one we're
going to need their income that's
definitely going to be a value right
here um but we want to break it out by
male and female so let's look at their
gender we going to pull that down into
the rows so
um this is basically a sum and no let's
look
at let's make this an average so I just
went to the um I clicked right here I
went to the value field settings and
we're just going to do an
average all right and then we are going
to make these um and as you can see
there's four decimal points um we'll
keep it as is right now but we may need
to go back and change something then
we're going to look at if they purchased
a bik or not and we're going to put that
right here so so we can see that uh
right here for the people who did not
buy a bike the females their their
average salary was 53,000 the average
salary for the average salary for males
was 56,000 for yes the ones who did buy
a bike the average salary was 55 for
female and 60 for male so the people who
had a little bit more money are buying
bikes and you can also see that uh the
men are making more money in this data
set just overall in general um so let's
make the visualization really quick but
you know I don't know I'm not a huge fan
of these decimal points and maybe we can
just change that in the visualization
we'll see um oops that's not what I
meant to
do um let's do that so what we are going
to do is we're going to click into here
we're going to click insert and we're
going to go to these recommended charts
and it's going to bring up basically
every single type that we would want um
and we can just click in here and see
which one looks good uh oh yeah I love
those 3D ones those are my favorite you
guys know that uh let's let's use this
one right here pretty simple um whoops
let's pull this right over here and as
is it looks pretty good um you know it
shows male female we have the average or
the incomes right here whether they did
or did not purchase it um and so at a
glance it's pretty easy to see let's see
if there's anything um you know if you
want to change up style-wise go for it
I'm just going to keep it as is um but
let's see if there's anything we need to
add right do we want to add these access
titles uh for the most part I I tend to
do that um it makes it pretty easy to
see so we can go in here and we can just
click it like this and we'll say
income and we'll say oops and we'll do
gender so that's what that
is and and let's go back in here do we
want to add a chart title we definitely
want to add a chart title uh for most of
these we'll add a chart title for sure
so we'll say average
income per
purchase um I don't know if that's 100%
right but we'll we'll we'll use it uh if
we need to change it to be you know by
gender or something we can but um for
now let's see do we want to add data
labels uh definitely not uh a data table
um we can do this it may make it a
little easier to read I will say that
again these numbers are just these
decimal points are really throwing me
off let's go see if um we can change it
in here let's go
to see if we can just make these numbers
okay and um we can keep it like that or
we can even do something like this add
commas yeah I'm going to keep it just
like this I I think this just looks the
best um again I'm I'm getting adding
commas here I'm changing the um decimal
place right here it just makes it look a
little nicer a little cleaner um so
let's keep this exactly how it is um we
can always change things if we want to
uh if we want to come back to it so we
created our pivot table and then we
created our visualization basically
exactly what we're going to do for all
of these because again all of these need
um you know all of these need pivot
tables in order to create the
visualization so let's um get out of
here we're going to scroll down and
we're going to create our next pivot
table and once we get done with all of
the pivot tables that we need all the
visualizations that we need then we will
um we will start so we're going to do
control a we're going do okay and
basically do the exact same thing that
we did um this time we're going to look
at the distance so for this one I wanted
to see you know I try to you know I
created this already I've already done
this entire project through but I
haven't really talked about why or what
we're going to look at for this one you
know know we're looking at is their
income does it change whether they
bought or didn't buy one um so if they
said yes you know is there a reason are
they making more money is you know are
price points are the customers do they
make more money so you we cater to them
or not uh that's a good question uh
another thing is you know we're we sell
bikes or this person sells bikes so
commuting distance definitely makes a
difference you know does the person who
is buying a bike live one mile away from
where they work or 20 miles away uh this
will help us determine this next
visualization will help us determine you
know who who is doing that or who's
buying it so what we are going to do is
we are going to look at the um that one
that we were looking at earlier the
commute distance so we're going to bring
that right over here so we have these
you know one mile 10 Mile 1.2
Etc now we are going to uh again we're
going to look at if they purchased a
bike
that's really important and let's make
that the column as well so now what we
have is a count of these Nos and yeses
whether they did or did not buy a bike
um one of the issues I already see and
we'll I'm going to visualize it and then
I'll show you that this 10 miles you
know it's right next to the 0.1 so it's
not an order um and that could be that
could be an issue um so we may have to
revise that somehow to put it at the
very bottom because we can either do
ascending
or descending uh either one I don't
think is going to work so we may have to
work through that in just a second um I
don't know if I did that my I plan for
that um yeah so it has this big dip
um yeah so let's let's create it um
that's okay we're going to figure this
one out together because I honestly um I
didn't plan for this one so okay we have
0.1 miles that's exactly where it needs
to be the one the two the five that's
exactly where it needs to be this 10
miles is not and let's see if I change
that 10 10 plus miles to 10 miles plus
let's see if that'll put it down here
because I I don't know if it's looking
at I don't know if it's reading it weird
um but let's go into this working sheet
and let's go right here and we're going
to do controll H and we'll do oops not
this
one um 10 miles plus let's get that in
there and we're going to do
10 uh
miles plus I I don't know if that's
actually going to work um we will see so
let's go back to the pivot
table let's re go to the data let's
refresh uh no it didn't it didn't change
it um okay so let's think about this
maybe if we change it to like a letter
it might change down here so start it
with uh miles that could work um let's
try it it okay it's already
selected let's do the 10 plus miles okay
so let's
do
um M uh more than 10
miles and we'll replace all let's get
rid of
this let's go to the pivot and refresh
all right okay so it's not perfect but
it works
um and for what we're doing I think
we'll keep it how it is so we have our
second one uh and you know there are
different ways you can kind of change
this one um you know on the last one we
did a ton of different stuff we can
do just
do commute
distance and we can
say what do we want to say on this one
what is this oh this is the count um do
we have to do we have to keep this
one um no there we go I'm just going to
do um just one and
say commute
distance and let's add a
title chart title we can make this one
um let's
say
distance per customer uh that's not 100%
true because it's no or yes um that's
that's the important part of this it's
distance um average distance uh let's
see we'll just say customer
commute all right and we'll keep it just
like that all right perfect I don't
think um let me see I don't think
there's anything else we need to add on
that one all right now let's go right
down here we're going to create our very
last one uh we only had three so you
know sometimes you'll have a ton
sometimes you'll have like one on each
sheet and you'll create multiple sheets
but um do contr a um now we have our
thing now this one we're going to be
looking at these age brackets that we
were looking at that we created um
something that I do honestly a lot is is
kind of bracket things in into groups
like this and you know for this I'm just
kind of made them up but you know it's
good to know how to do this because I I
promise you this one happens a lot or I
use this one a ton and then we just want
to look at who purchased a bike uh so
the same thing as we did before so like
purchase a bike count of the purchase um
you know pretty easy so we just have to
count of either no or yes for these age
ranges um and let's go to the insert
we'll go to
recommendation um I personally like a
good line for this one um so
let's this is already interesting we
could do something like
this that's nice see this one versus
this it just adds a dot it looks nice
we'll keep that one
um so just really quick at a glance
really interesting people under the age
of 30 are not buying that many bikes um
age 30 to
54 uh 31 to 54 buying a ton of bikes uh
they buy more bikes or look at bikes
more than anybody really interesting um
but yeah we'll make the dashboard in a
little bit um let's make these chart
titles we'll
do vert oops the
horizontal we just call
this age
bracket um and then we'll add a chart
title um again you can add some extra
stuff if you want
to um but you don't need to uh none of
this other stuff we really need I'm just
kind of looking at the stuff we do need
or do want uh so what do we want to call
this one let's call it customer
age brackets um and it's not perfect but
we'll keep it as is for comparison um
let me see if I can copy
um or or use this um real quick instead
of the age brackets I'm going to get rid
of this and use the age
and then let's
use um let's insert
recommendation we use a
line and we'll use this
so This compared to this just think of
it like if a customer or consumer or or
not a customer if somebody you're
working with is trying to use this
dashboard to understand this dashboard
this is going to be just it's going to I
don't know it might melt their brain
just makes no sense it makes sense it's
just all over the place it's really hard
to make sense of this it really is I
mean you can kind of see a pattern going
up around like the mid-30s and then it
Trends downward but it's hard to see um
it really is so doing these um these
brackets really helps and you can even
add you know adolescent um you know 0o
to 30 underneath it and in fact we may
want to do that um why not why not let's
do that oh whoops um so why don't why
don't we do that why don't we go back
I'm just going to I'm doing this on the
Fly why don't we go
back uh what am I doing
whoops and this is all calculated but
let's do
adolescent 0
to
30 let's do
middleaged 31 through
54 and then old 55 plus let's see if
this breaks anything I hope it doesn't
um and we'll go back to our pivot table
let's refresh the
data uh okay it did mess with
stuff okay never mind guys that was a
terrible idea don't do that um perfect
uh let's get rid of that that was a
terrible idea don't do that I'm glad we
tested it out though I like I like to
see if it was going to work no it messed
with the um the Order of Things um I I
intentionally named them adolescent
middle- Ag and old because it's it it
makes sense for the visualization um but
you know if if I change something and it
messes with it I'm not going to mess
with it it was just an idea on the Fly
guys come on all right so let's start
building out our dashboard now um when
we're building our dashboard what I
personally like to do is to have this
pivot table sheet and then I will copy
them over and later we'll hide these
other sheets beats um and I'll explain
that a little bit but I like to have
this this one for us so we're going to
copy this so I just click on it hit
controlc we're going to paste it right
over
here uh let's just make them small for
now that's oh gosh no let's not do that
oh these look terrible okay anyways
um let's copy this one
over
oops okay what did I just
do oh I didn't copy this one
whoops it's not
copying okay we're going to go
copy hit
paste
fantastic oops guys look away this is
this is tough to watch this is tough for
me to watch I'm the one doing it it is
tough for me to watch all right let's go
to this last one I'm I'm gonna try it
again all right it worked this time so
now we have um our our three
visualizations this is perfect but now
we actually want to create a dashboard
now how do you do that how do you make
it look nice U and then we're going to
add some you know filters and stuff like
that how do we make it look nice um what
happened here what changed what did we
do oh my goodness gracious all right
let's copy
this let's paste this let's get rid of
this I don't even know how that happened
I've never seen that before that was
wild uh Excel is trying to destroy my
whole video I mean I'm doing this for
you Excel good night okay no problem at
all what we're going to do and how you
make this at least look nice um first
off we can get rid of these grid lines
pretty easily and I recommend when you
do that when you make a dashboard just
makes it look cleaner makes it look like
an actual dashboard um let's go to view
and grid lines so we can get rid of
these grid lines it just makes it look
nicer um we're going to make you know we
can choose any color here here I'm just
going to get choose a
color I like this and let's we're we're
basically creating like a header right
if you're using like Tableau or
something um we're going to merge and
center so it takes every single cell
that we have highlighted creates it into
one let's call this um bike sales uh I
have I think I called it bike sales
dashboard let's just call it that um you
know see what happens let's get that
let's make it white and and make it much
larger than it
is okay okay
um sure let's do that doesn't look bad
um what is it doing there we go uh let's
bre that Center perfect um it's not
perfect but we're going to use it all
right so now we kind of want to organize
these and you know everybody has their
different way of doing it uh I'm just
going to start building it out myself
self and just see how it
looks uh and then we'll go from there I
like this one there um we can
put this one I I this one's a kind of a
longer one so I'll probably put it at
the bottom let's see how it
looks um but we'll put this one right
here try to line it up geez let's let's
zoom in a little bit let's try to line
this up see what it looks
like let's extend it to the
end that doesn't look too bad uh needs
to move up just a hair and I'll show you
how to kind of align these in a second
but um that looks not bad and we'll kind
of try to align these as well let me
zoom out and extend this the length of
this just to make it look nice um you
know now what you can do and you know
this is something that's pretty simple
is you can get both of these and we're
going to go to shape format and we can
just align these it's really nice to
align especially if like the top and
maybe like the left to right but like
we're going to align these to the top
and they just kind of align themselves
on the very top now these look much
better this one is a larger dashboard or
a larger visualization so I'm going to
keep it how it is um and I'm going to
keep this one how it is so it is going
to be a little bit smaller as you can
tell and then we'll have this one um and
I'm going to do that
um I this is going to bother me if I
don't align these so let me do this I'm
shape format align to the
right and it's not exactly what I wanted
to happen
because oh jeez what am I doing that's
not exactly what I wanted to happen I
actually wanted this one to align uh
this one to align with this one it did
the opposite um so let me just scoot
this back all right visually looks fine
but that's how you do it if you want to
do it um I I I if you have multiple of
them like this it you can make it look
bad so we have our dashboards this is
already looking really good I I like how
this looks colors are coordinated it we
have a kind of a theme throughout um and
it looks nice I actually I actually kind
of want to change this one um
to
um let's
see maybe if I did like that it look
nicer than all of them yeah this does
look nicer um it doesn't change much
either guys I'm should I do it all right
we're going for it we're changing the
design on the Fly should I do it for all
of
them let's
see it doesn't fit doesn't fit um all
right guys just ignore what I'm doing uh
don't do any of this I'm just messing
around at this point so this is really
great to have it really is and what we
want to do is there are other elements
there are other things that people would
like to feel a to filter by and be able
to look at but it's not in this
visualization um to be more specific one
field that's could be really interesting
is married versus single are single
people buying more or um married people
buying more you know it it'd be nice to
filter on it so we're going to click on
uh any of these actually and we're going
to go up to Pivot chart analyze and
we'll click insert slicer now we can
choose which ones we want to be able to
filter on all at the same time or one at
a time I'm just going to do the first
one by itself and then I'll show you how
to do other ones um but this one is the
marital status so this is the married
single the one we were just looking at
and we can drag this right over
here bring it in a little
bit all right and we don't need all that
space so we're going to boop boop boop
boop all the way up
now while we're doing this um it only
because we selected this uh this
visualization it only is working on that
one right now we of course wanted to
apply to all of them is not hard to do
all we're going to do is we're going to
click on we're going to make sure we're
clicking on this we're going to go up to
slicer we're going to hit report
connections um and if you remember we
have this um this pivot table that we're
working with um and this is where all of
our pivots are coming from so we're
going to actually apply it to all of
them this is our sheet U and this is the
name of the pivot table now again we
created that fourth one we're not using
it but we're going to apply it to all of
them so now when we click on it it's
going to apply to all of them so at a
quick glance let's see what single
people are doing
um interesting interesting um you know
when I'm looking at the just these
numbers right here married people these
individuals are making a lot more like
eight um sometimes eight to like 10,000
more on average than their single
counterpart um you know again that's a
rough estimate but it's it's interesting
so now what we can do is we're going to
create more of these so we're going to
go to uh pivot chart analyze we're going
to go to slicer now we already did
marital status but what if we want to
look at things like uh region and maybe
something like their education so let's
bring up both of those and look now two
of them come up so let's add the region
right here
we'll bring that in just a little bit
see if we can match it nailed it all
right now we're going to put that up
we'll bring this one
down just like this bring it over see if
I can match it again come
on N almost nailed it I don't know if I
nailed it but it's close all right kind
of bring this up a little bit bring this
up and we have to do the exact same
thing that we did with this one because
right now again it only applies to that
one um chart so what we want to do is we
want to go to slicer report connections
add it to all of them okay do the same
thing with education or connections bada
bing bada boom We are looking good and
now uh let's get rid of all of them it's
just going to be everybody so now we can
kind of slice and dice and choose what
we want we want to look at people who
have a bachelor's degree who live in
Europe and are single
and this is the information that we have
on those people so now we can narrow it
down by certain demographics even
further and look at this key information
so we may not you know look at counts
and averages of these things but we're
able to filter on them uh and that's
really great to know so bachelor's
degrees on average are making 60s 70,000
um let's look at um let's look at
graduate
degrees okay a little
more um but you know again I'm just
looking at random stuff um but you can
mess around with this take a look at
some stuff um this to me I want to make
this color darker I feel like it look
nicer darker there we go oh yeah that's
way better this to me is it's a good
dashboard right you have key information
that you're looking at nice
visualizations it's color coordinated
you have these slicers on the side um to
me this is a fantas fantastic just
simple dashboard and there are so many
other things that you can do with this
data and you can make it unique and you
can add your own spin on it and I highly
recommend that you do that push yourself
go past what we just did today and add
your own stuff and and use this and then
you can add this to your portfolio
website and show this off and show
people that you know how to use Excel
which is a fantastic thing to know how
to use and show off so with that being
said I hope that this project was
helpful I hope that you learned
something along the way I know I did um
I was learning things as we were going
and I hope that you didn't mind that I
took some detours along the way um for
your amusement as well as my learning uh
so with that being said thank you so
much for joining me I really appreciate
it I hope you have a good day and
[Music]
goodbye what's going on everybody
welcome back to another video today we
are starting our Tableau tutorial
[Music]
series now this series is for absolute
beginners so if you have never used TBL
blow before you are in the perfect place
I'm going to take you all the way from
the very beginning of installing it and
just understanding what Tableau is and
how you can use it all the way to
creating dashboards and sharing it now
personally I hate those videos that are
like 3 hours long and they just expect
you to go through it uh i' like to break
my videos up in chunk so if you have
ever done my sequel tutorials you'll
know that I like to break things up so
it gives you time to try them out and do
them yourself and then you can move on
to the next video so I'm going to be
breaking this up into five separate
videos but in this video I'm going to
show you how to install Tableau for free
I'm going to show you the user interface
we're going to download a data set that
you can find on kagle and then we will
build our first visualization together
with that being said let's jump over my
screen and we'll get started all right
so the very first thing that we need to
do is you need to actually download
Tableau so we're not going to be using
Tableau we're going to be using a free
version called Tableau public it has a
lot of the same features except of
course it's not uh every single feature
that regular Tableau has but it is
absolutely perfect for learning it and
for using it and and you can even build
um you know dashboards and share those
for your
portfolio um I'm going to put this link
in the description so you can just go
and click on that and and all you have
to do is input your email right here
we're going click download the app um
and then it should start to download and
then you can save that and then you're
going to open this up now I'm going to
open it up I don't know what it's going
to do I already have it downloaded um
but it should open up and look hopefully
like what you're seeing on my screen in
just a second let see what it does um I
hope you can see this but it says
Tableau public um it says I already have
it set up but you're going to click
install and go through all that um all
that setup stuff uh so I'm going to exit
out of here but I'm going to go over
here and type in table of public uh and
it's 20 21.3 that's the current version
that they have out if you're doing this
in the future they may have you know
different versions um so you should be
able to pull this up right here now um
I'm going to go and get our data set
that we're going to be using and I'm
going to show you how to get that as
well and then we will actually jump into
Tableau and start uh using it so let's
go over here I'm going to get a data set
from kagle I wanted something pretty
generic uh to show you in future videos
I'm going to show you some special or
not special but just different
visualizations that you might use um and
we'll get different data sets for those
because of course not one data set
covers all these other types of
visualizations so um we're starting off
pretty simple right here we're going to
be getting one called video game sales
um and we can take a really quick look
at it um here are some of the fields
that you're going to be having uh like
rank name platform the year genre and
then some sales data and this is what it
actually looks like it's called VG sales
so video game sales it's then a
CSV and um you know here are the fields
and we have our data and all we are
going to do is we're going to download
that and I will save it now when you
download it it's going to be saved into
a zip file so we need to go to our
downloads uh let's refresh this here's
our archive we need to go in here you
can just copy it and paste paste it
right back into here um and just so you
know that is a uh a CSV so be aware of
that so what we want to do is we want to
come in here now since it is a CSV this
is not we're not going to be using
Microsoft Excel we're going to be using
the text file so we'll come in here
we'll take VG sales now uh one thing I
want to do before I do that is I'm going
to rename mine uh VGC
sales1 um I've already prepared for this
and so I already have that in there um
but so I want to make a distinct one for
myself you do not have to do that so
we'll come back here um and then we're
going to do text file and VG sales we're
going to open that
up
and when it pulls up right here um you
can bring in other tables and then you
can start to join them together and
create those relationships we are not
going to be doing that in this video
we'll do that in a separate one um as
for you know just getting started you
know we're not going to be using that
but you can see some of these things or
some of these fields and if you notice
they they um they're either ABC or
they're a number so it starts to
categorize what this field type is so is
it a string is it numeric it starts to
automatically do that and that's all
done within
Tableau and so it just kind of reads it
and that's what it does um what we going
to do is I'm going to click right down
here it's called go to worksheet um the
worksheets are where you're going to
actually start being able to build your
visualizations your charts your graphs
all these things um and so you know we
have this in here now and so we're just
going to click right here on go to
worksheet as you can see here is VG
sales1 you will not have the underscore
one if you did not add that like I did
uh but right down here you can see all
the fields that we just imported from
that data set and they even created one
right here for us uh they just generated
that field u based on the file so it's a
count of all the rows really so what I'm
going to do is I'm just going to walk
you through uh basically what we're
looking at some of the things that we're
going to be using today there will be
things that I don't talk about but I'm
going to highlight those in in in future
videos when we start using those or
going over them um and so let's just
start with the most obvious one it's way
over here I'm sure you saw it when we uh
this first came up on the screen because
it has all these different charts and
visualizations and graphs and uh these
will become available as you start
dragging and dropping our data into this
sheet and so if I go right here it says
for Scatter Plots try zero or more
Dimensions two to four measures so what
our dimensions are are right here what
our measures are are right down here and
so typically uh things like like you say
genre or names or or strings like that
are going to be these uh dimensions and
then a lot of lot of times the numerical
is going to be our going to be measures
next what I want to show you is right
here so you can take something like
Global sales and you can drag it right
here into your rows and then it takes
your rows and so it automatically
created a sum of global sales now if we
take that away and let's say we drag it
right here it's going to give us a
column
now you can also do it right up here you
don't have to um drag it on screen you
can
also just add it to the column or the
row that's typically what I do I it's
just more intuitive to me um or you can
drop it in this section right here and
it does its best to assign it some type
of um some type of visualization and so
that's what it always is trying to do it
is trying to say okay this is what
you're trying to do let me try to to get
the best visualization for the data that
you're giving me now while we are here
um it went down here into marks and
marks is a very important area it's
where you can add color size text detail
and Tool tip and I'm not going to go
into what all those are cuz I'm just
going to show you so let's start pulling
some fields in here and creating a
visualization and then I'm going to show
you how all of that works including
filters as well so the first thing that
we are going to look at is global save
and let's put that in the rows and then
I'm going to take year and I'm going to
make that the column and this is
basically exactly what uh I wanted to do
now as of right now it has only the year
and it's looking at Global sales for
everything but we want to break that out
a little bit better I Want to Break It
Out by let's do genre so different genre
of games now if I add that right here to
this column s it is going to break it up
by year and genre if I add it right here
is going to break it out by the year of
course but then in each individual row
has the different genre that's not what
we want we want to keep this type of
line graph uh and what we're going to do
is we're going to add it to
Marks and you can't really see it based
off of these colors but they're all
different so we have action J genre we
have the sports genre racing uh role
playing all these different genres
within it now we can get rid of that cuz
we don't need it
anymore uh and this is where these U
these marks really come in handy because
you can start basically doing what you
want with them so for the genre I want
to be able to see all these different
genres with different colors to me that
just makes the most sense so I'm going
to put color right here and
automatically it assigns every single
genre its own own color and gives us
this Legend right over here and so it's
really easy to see well when you have
smaller numbers is much easier but I
know that red is sports and I can go
right here and find red and that is
sports so it makes it a lot easier than
when it is all the same color blue so
what you can do after that is you can
also add things like uh a label to it so
if we take label and we or we take genre
put label you can click right here and
you can get rid of the labels that you
have and you can see them right down
here or you can also change uh the font
so if you want to make it orange or or
whatever color you can do all those same
things and you can also do things like
changing where you see these things so
for Action you're going to see it a ton
because for each year action is is at
the is on the higher end and so you're
seeing those in those mins and Maxes you
can also do it for a selected area so if
I come in here and I select it it's then
going to show me what those are so label
is really really uh useful really
helpful let me get rid of that really
quick uh you can also do it where the
lines end so line ends is at the
beginning and the end and you can also
take that away or put that back on so
labels are really important labels
aren't very helpful when you're doing at
least I don't find that it's super
helpful when you're doing things like
genre so when you're doing your
Dimensions so I'm going to get rid of
that and I'm actually going to bring
our Global sales over here and let's
label
that and right now I think it's labeling
the uh line ends we want to do the Min
and Max now if we do Min and Max on the
table it's just going to give us the Max
and the men which is zero and then
139.0 it's a little bit more useful if
we do it for each line uh this at least
gives us some context I probably
wouldn't do this in an actual visual
visualization but to give you some um
understanding just how it works so now I
know that um right over here the men and
the max or the men sorry the max for
these for action and for sports is right
around 138 139 so it's pretty easy to
see um and you can again go in here and
you can remove the max or remove the
mins whichever one you feel is best uh
you'll probably keep the maximums in
there for each category and so this is a
really quickly becoming uh a pretty
usable visualization and that's not the
only label that you can add we still are
using year over here so we can always
drop year in there as well we'll create
a label and so now we have let's see for
this one is a puzzle genre so we also
have the year that it had the maximum uh
sales and so you know just some things
that you can do you don't have to add
that now let's go up here and we're
going to take a look at filters because
filters are really important you know if
you are making this for a client or you
making this for somebody you want them
to be able to filter down uh to very
specific information that they want to
see so let's take uh the platform lots
of different
platforms um as you can see you know PS4
Xbox um if you're familiar with these
we'll click all of these um and we'll
click okay so now this is an option as a
filter and all we're going to do is
we're going to click on this Arrow right
here and we're going to say show
filter now right now all of them are
selected so every single one is being
taken into account for this
visualization but let's say we come down
here and we say okay I don't want to see
sales for any of these PS the original
PlayStation 2 three or four so I'm going
to get rid of this one this one this one
and this one and you could immediately
see the the changes that were happening
so now none of the numbers none of those
sales are being accounted for and and
being added to the sum of global sales
right here at
all so that is just how a filter uh can
work and you can also do that and you
can get rid of all of them and you can
go in and actually just pick very
specific sales so if you only want to
see the PlayStation sales you can go in
there and do that as well so really
really handy filter are things that you
at least want to have as an option for
most of your your visualizations at
least that's what I found especially
when you're doing client facing work
they like to uh get in there and mess
around and look at different look at it
in different ways and so that's one that
I I think is is really useful to to
have the very last thing that we want to
do is we want to actually add this to a
dashboard now let's say we add come
right down down here and we add a new
worksheet and actually we might change
one more thing on that last one but
we'll just make a really simple one um
we'll just give it genre and we'll give
it Global sales as the
rows um and this Nifty button right up
here which is a sorting button so I'm
going to sort like that I'm going to add
the genre in just as we did I'll give it
different colors perfect now we have two
really quick different visualizations
right what I want to do is just show you
how to combine those because what you
are going to do is you're going to
actually come in here and you're going
to do new dashboard that's what this
button is right here now when we come in
here the size is extremely small it's
very easy to fix that all we're going to
do is Click right here we're going to go
to this range or this dropdown and we're
going to click automatic so now it is a
much larger size for us to actually drop
our visualizations
into uh and let's put sheet sheet one
and we'll put uh let's put it up top so
now it looks a little bit like this uh
not perfect but again if I wanted to
make this look a lot better I definitely
would and then you can go over here and
you can rename these things you can also
do that back when we were in our actual
worksheets but you can also do it here
as well and then start um you know
customizing it and building it out
that's not what this video is for that
is the last video we're going to build
an entire dashboard it'll be kind of
like a small project you put that in
your portfolio um if you have gotten
this far and you want to jump straight
into it and you don't want to wait for
these other videos to come out or you
don't you just want to jump straight
into creating an entire portfolio
project I have an entire portfolio
project series that covers SQL Python
and Tableau and so go check out that
series I have one video dedicated to
Tableau it's like 45 minutes or an hour
long and it covers a lot of the things
that we're going to hear in here as well
as a few other things but I appreciate
you checking out this video in future
videos we're going be going over things
like creating bins calculated Fields
doing joins and then creating a final
project and putting it all together so
thank you so much for joining me I
really appreciate it if you like this
video be sure to like And subscribe
below and I will see you in the next
[Music]
video
what's going on everybody welcome back
to the Tableau tutorial Series in this
video we're going to be going over bins
and calculated
[Music]
Fields all right so let's jump right
into it the first thing that we're going
to look at are bins and bins are
basically just groupings or ranges of
numerical values so we cannot create
bins uh for genre name platform or
anything like that we have to do
something with this sign right here
which means that it is a numeric so year
or all this sales data or this ranking
data and we're going to use what we
worked on in our very first tutorial and
so what we're going to be using to kind
of demonstrate how bins work is this
year right down here so right now we
have a range of 1993 all the way up to
2018 and we're going to create some bins
to group and create ranges for these
years and it's pretty simple all we're
going to do is I'm going to come right
over here to year and this little drop
down on the side and we're going to go
down to create and go down to
bins now it's going to say the size of
Bin and it's going to give you a
recommendation based off of the
information that is already provided the
Min and the max the ranges of these
values you know you don't have to do
this but usually um it it does give some
good estimation on what you might be
considering if you were thinking hey
maybe do a bit of like 20 and they're
recommending two think about why they
might be doing that we're going to
change ours to five and you can always
change what this field is going to be
I'm just going to give it an old
exclamation point just to um really
spice things up here so we're going to
click okay and as you can see it adds it
right up here is no longer um it is no
longer a numeric now it is a categorical
so it now it's this is no longer just uh
1 2 3 4 five its ranges its groups and
we're going to get rid of this year
really quick actually let's keep it up
there for a second uh see what happens
but we're going to bring this up and
we'll get rid of this year and this is
is what kind of it spits out for us now
I did look at the data um when I was
prepping for this there are some nulls
in the Years um and so all we're going
to do for this is we're just going to go
like this and we're going to exclude the
nulls uh probably not something you
should be doing uh if you're doing this
for work but this is for demonstration
purposes so we can do it ever we want
but as you can see we now have these
ranges so this range starts at
1990 and it includes 1990 all the way up
to 1994 and then it's 1995 to
1999 and so just really quickly we can
tell that the years 2000 to 2004 were a
huge huge huge uh season or group of of
years for game sales so these are the
global sales for for these video games
and so it is really helpful it's very
useful um you can do this on a lot of
different information we could do this
on the sales data you can do this on age
you can do it on years like we did and
it can be very very useful and so uh
really quickly that is how bins work I
would say it's pretty straightforward
now this is a perfect time to segue into
the next part of the video which is
calculated Fields uh right over here on
this left hand side we see that the
global sales which are in millions goes
all the way up to 900 million and
created these beautiful bins right down
here but let's look at Within These from
1999 to 2015 let's see which of these
has the highest percentage of course
it's going to be this one but we can do
something called a quick table
calculation uh we'll create a our own
calculation later I'll show you how to
do that but we're going to do a quick
table calculation and we're going to do
the percent of total and so now we have
these bins and instead of just seeing
the total amount of sales that they had
we see the actual percentages based off
these year ranges which is really useful
something that you could absolutely put
uh in some real work that you do for a
client now really quick just to show you
something that you can do if you click
control and you drag this over here you
can actually save that calculation so we
can say
percentage of global sales and that
actually saves it as uh you know a
measure for us so that was a quick
calculation but let's look how to
actually create a calculated field so if
we do this right here what is going to
come up is just the global sales and you
can do a lot of what you would basically
do in Excel multiplication division
subtraction a few other things but we're
going to keep it super super simple
today all I'm going to do is I'm going
to take Global sales and I'm going to
subtract I'm going to do an open bracket
and I'm going to say EU sales and it
auto completes for me I'm going to click
okay and created calculation 2 I'm going
to come in here and I'm just going to
say Global sales
minus EU
sales and let's drag this over these are
different um one's percentage one is in
terms of sum and so I'm just going to
bring this in right here and so now we
are comparing against the same thing and
if we look at the global sales we have
probably right around 9 50 million-ish
in this 2000 to 2004 bin and for Global
sales minus the EU sales we're looking
at you know 650 million so there is a
noticeable difference and this is just
one of the ways that you can use
calculated fields to actually just show
the difference between two numbers or
you can do more advanced calculations
depending on the data that you actually
have so that's it for this video I hope
you learned a little bit more about bins
and calculated fields in the next video
we're going to looking at a ton of
different visualizations and graphs and
charts and just exploring what options
really are out there for visualizing our
data thank you guys so much for joining
me I really appreciate it if you like
this video be sure to like And subscribe
below and I will see you in the next
[Music]
video what's going on everybody welcome
back to the Tableau tutorial Series in
this video we're going to be looking at
lots of different visualizations
including the scatter plot and density
[Music]
Maps now before we jump into the
tutorial I have some very exciting news
in just two days on October 7th I going
to be partnering with alter X to host a
webinar this webinar is completely for
data analysts who are wanting to change
careers to become a data analyst now you
did hear that right I will be the host
of the event but but we will be bringing
on guests as well who are industry
experts who actually change careers to
become data analyst much like myself
they'll be sharing their stories of how
they actually transition careers along
with the tools that they found extremely
useful and helpful to make that switch
and they'll be giving lots of advice
along the way so if you are somebody who
is wanting to change careers to become a
data analyst or just wanting to learn
about data analytics this is an absolute
fantastic place to learn a lot more
about that I will leave a link in the
description so be sure to go and sign up
for that again I'm going to be there so
so it should be really fun without
further Ado let's jump onto my screen
and start the tutorial now we are about
to look at a ton of different
visualizations uh over here you can see
just an array of them but not all of
them are ones that I actually think are
useful or ones that I would actually
recommend using and so I'm going to take
you through some of the ones that I
absolutely think are worth learning and
using and trying out uh and I'm just
going to kind of just show you how I
might use them how they might look how
you can navigate them a little bit now
before we do that we do need to go
download one data set it's this
Starbucks location worldwide yes we're
going to do a little bit of longitude
latitude here and all we have to do is
click this downloads button and it will
download we're going to do that into
downloads we'll save that uh yeah I've
already done that but you know I'm doing
this with you guys I'm doing it for you
so let's go to our
downloads now we have have here we want
to come in here we're going to copy it
or um you can cut it and then we're
going to paste it here yeah replace it
perfect and now we have it ready to go
we'll come in here let's do a new sheet
and I already have it in there but uh
I'm just going to show you what I would
do do new data source we'll do text file
we'll do directory and we will open
it and let's see what data we have in
here before we actually begin uh just
super quickly we have the brand so um
whatever company has it and then a bunch
of um location information street
address City the state this is all in
the United States so that's basically it
and what we are going to do is we're
going to go over to this sheet
three and we have this directory 2
that's the one I just pulled in exact
same thing as directory but so the first
VIs visualization that we are going to
look at is a bar and line graph so what
we're going to take is the year right
here take these Global sales and these
na
sales and we're going to be doing this
one right here so this has a combination
of two separate uh types of
visualizations so sometimes you just
have lines sometimes you just have these
uh these bar graphs or the bar charts
and we're combining the two and it's
very nice I like how this looks now if
you notice if I put this na sales behind
it now it kind of cuts off so now this
Global sales is in front we're going to
you know put that back I just wanted to
show you that uh right here there's all
some of global sales some of Na sales so
if we go into this all we click this
drop down we can change it to a line um
we can change it basically whatever we
want I just hit contrl Z to reverse that
but what we can do is we can go in here
and we can change this color and let's
see if we can just make it red is that
[Music]
possible see what I did I made it orange
that works for me um just something to
stick out a little bit more choose
whatever color you want and this is a
really nice visualization this is one
that I have used in the past we're
looking at Global sales versus the na
sales and so it's very easy to see the
distinction between the two and how one
was doing a specific year versus how the
other one was doing in that same year so
I really like this if you want to do
something uh like keeping it consistent
you can do two bars I don't really like
this one as much um and you can again
you can really change it up um there's
lots of different ones that you can do
again I prefer the line but you know do
whatever you think is best I'm going to
change it back because this is not how I
want to keep it but there you go so that
is the first one that we are going to
look at let's move on to the second one
and we actually will be using our our
Starbucks data here
now when you bring in data that has um
any type of map or or um address or
postal code or things like that or or
country it's typically going to create
this latitude and longitude it's going
to generate that now what we want to do
is bring this longitude right up here
and this latitude right
there and if you do the show me right
now it's giving us this but what we want
to do is add what we're looking for so
what will we actually be trying to
search for on this map you can do
anything from like a postal code um and
it will drag us right here let's come
over to this this allows us to kind of
scroll around a little bit um we're
going to mess around with this one for
just a little bit and me see if I
can that's nice that might be too big
let me back up one so at least in the
Continental us a little bit down here
this these are the postal codes so right
now we're looking at post codes uh
and there are a lot that you can do with
this um really color will make almost no
difference it just becomes this mess so
you don't typically want to do something
like that at least not for this let's go
to size and if we make it really small
you can kind of see these groupings
these pairings um typically of like
larger cities or major major
metropolitan areas and so you can do
this and it's and it's really really
easy I don't recommend uh labeling this
I don't even know if it'll do it um it
would be an absolute mess to try to
label all these
postcodes well let's bring this out and
let's bring these State and provinces in
now right now we have these little tiny
tiny uh dots on here and I think what we
want to do is not increase the size size
but over here we want to actually do
this and make it a map so now it's going
to fill in all the states we can you
know why not we'll add some color here
um but we
can it hasn't numbered I didn't think
they were numbered
um oh that's interesting I haven't seen
that I didn't look at that before I was
just found that interesting but now we
can see what uh what states Starbucks is
in and as you can see they're in all 50
states but it's something interesting to
um look at to think about now if we go
right up here we can again choose a
different type and we're going to go to
the density now right now it's just
doing a density on the uh the state
we're going get rid of that we're going
to bring back postal code I'm just
switching it up on you a little bit and
you can do it as small or as big as
you'd like um you know I like to do
somewhere in the middle um probably
right right about there is fine um I
don't think it's going to make sense to
really add any color here again all
these poster codes are different so it's
just going to be complete mish mash but
this is kind of how you can use a
density map and you can do this with uh
countries you can do this with postal
codes you can do this with any type of
kind of like address or location based
data so that is how you can use a map
again there's lots of different ways to
use a map and so I'm not going to show
you every single way but in a really
brief way this is how you can use a map
to actually visualize your data that
does have location uh based information
in it so let's go over to sheet three uh
and this data that we have over here it
just allows for a lot of different types
of visualizations so we're going to use
this one um and there are lots of other
ones that you might see out there like
this one right here uh we obviously
wouldn't be using this we might do
something like this change the
label um and maybe add why have both of
these in here um let's get rid of this
oops that's not what I meant let's
actually add that let's do the sum of
global sales and we'll just make that
into a label as well
so what you can do with these and and
how you're able to use them and
visualize them again these are not
you'll see these often but these are not
often ones that I would recommend you
use that's very similar to these packed
bubbles um you can as these Global sales
in here again add the label it just uh
it sometimes is not as straightforward
the information that it's trying to tell
you right you kind of have to search for
it a little bit you kind of have to look
around um but you can find some good
visualizations in here for very specific
types of data and so these are just ones
to consider uh one that you'll see all
the time is uh this guy right here and
uh let me see if I can expand this a
little bit because this
is very small um let's see we have the I
just want Global
sales and let's label
that the
size I how do I expand this haven't done
this in a while let me just expand this
I don't use pie charts what is
happening this is a incredibly large pie
chart oh my gosh I am making this um
this is becoming a problem there we go
uh and what I actually wanted to do was
label the uh genre as well as I've been
doing in all the other
ones and we'll label this now look
whether you are a fan of pie charts or
not you have to understand that people
use them uh some people just like how
they look and for certain data it can do
well for things that have a lot of
different um groupings or categories it
usually isn't super great but it does
give you some type of order of things
give you a quick glance and people use
them right so let's not pretend like
it's like the the the Hideous stepchild
all right people use it people have it
in their dashboards and their
visualizations all over so it's best to
just know what they look like know how
to do them know um how to use them best
again I'm not a super huge huge fan of
it myself I've used it once or twice but
one to look out for and again you can
come over to here and use is called a
box and a whisker plot um it's good for
these large um distributions you know
this is
like the median upper upper lower lower
I don't use these a lot but I know a lot
of people who love them something to
just look at and or mess around with it
a little bit it's pretty I think
straightforward and it does give you
some good insight into your data if you
know how to use it now there is one last
one that I want to show you I'm just
going to create it on a new sheet make
it easy uh we'll do year here we'll do
some of let's do na sales why
not and we are going to make this like
this now it's very similar to a line
chart but when we break it out by the
genre and we add some color you know
it's just a different way to visualize
this information you can uh you know
potentially add some stuff in here like
some labels if you uh want to depending
on how it looks for you but this is just
another way to visualize the data so
wanting to give you guys some options
wanting to give you some things that you
might want to look at if you haven't
already used these before four these are
ones all every single one that I've
showed you are ones that I've at least
used once um this one I maybe have
literally only used once but the first
ones that I showed you the ones I
pointed out as the ones that I really
wanted you to know are great
visualizations to learn how to use and
learn how to make useful for the data
that you have with that being said that
is all that we are looking at in this
video again I tried to keep it super
easy just wanted to show you some
different visualizations the data that
you can use to get those visualizations
and just some other options in case you
wanted to get a little bit uh
spontaneous a little bit out there a
little bit funky uh to show your boss or
something like that thank you guys so
much for watching I really appreciate it
if you like this video be sure to like
And subscribe below and I will see you
in the next
[Music]
video
what's going on everybody welcome back
to another video today we're looking at
joins in
[Music]
Tableau now before we get into the
tutorial I want to give a huge shout out
to today's sponsor and that is udem me
they were having a massive Black Friday
sale and so everything is about 85% off
so if you've been looking at a course
now is the time to buy it if you are
looking at learning and taking an actual
full Tableau course there are fantastic
ones on UD me that I have taken myself
so be sure to go and check out UD me
while they're having this huge sale I
will include a link in the description
if you want to check them out now let's
get into the tutorial all right let's
get started and first we're going to
start off in Excel I'm going to kind of
walk you through the data that we're
working with and then we're going to put
it into Tableau and I'm going to show
you how to do all those joins in Tableau
so the first table that we have is this
demographics table we have employee ID
name of employee employee age and
employee gender now look right here
because this will be important uh going
forward in the demographics table we
have 10 uh individuals and they each
have an employee ID now when we go to
the job title we have our employee ID
employee name and the job title but this
one is missing Ryan Howard is missing
his employee ID and then the very last
one there are only seven employee IDs
and no names um and so we're going to
use all of that and I'm going to show
you how to actually do the joins into
Tableau Tableau does a really fantastic
job of visualizing for you so it takes a
lot of the guesswork out um I am going
to include a link to my joins video in
SQL because these two are very closely
connected and and if you understand how
the joins work in in SQL you'll
understand how the joins work in Tableau
it's almost the exact same thing so with
that being said let's jump over to
Tableau so I'm going to pull this up
going go right over here and now we have
uh where where we can connect to our
data and so we're going to click
Microsoft Excel I'm going to scroll down
here to Tableau joins file I'm going to
open this up and I have it open so I
can't use it so let me get rid of that
and let's open it again perfect so now
what we're going to do and I'm going to
show you how to actually open up the
joins um in a second but what you need
to understand is when you first come
here Tableau doesn't automatically allow
you to to use the joins they use
something called relationships and there
are joins on the back end but they call
it relationships because they are
inferring all of these things they're
trying to go in and make that inference
for you so it takes a lot of the work
off of you and most of the time that
works and and you know you just plug
these two things in here like a
demographics and the job title and it is
going to you know help you build those
what they call relationships and you can
click on this and learn how the
relationships differ from joins again
there's not a huge difference but it's
not as custom customizable and you can't
as easily do left joins or full joins or
all these things that we're about to
look at so uh I'm going to take this one
off and what we're going to do to
actually be able to look at the joins
and and choose what joins we want to use
is we're going to do this dropdown we're
going to click open and so now we are in
a place where we can actually create the
joins uh and again it's just much more
customizable and so um back when I was
using
regularly I would use the relationships
when it was pretty simple and
straightforward cuz almost they almost
always got it right but uh you know the
joins it it just makes more sense in the
way it visualizes it for me so most of
the time I'd be using the joins so let's
pull over this job title right here and
it's going to make this connection now
before if you remember just about you
know 30 seconds ago when it connected
them it was just a line and and so it
gave us the this option down here to
kind of edit the relationship but now
it's giving us this visualization and so
let's click on it really quick and what
is going to come up is the different
types of joins that you can do you can
do an inner join a left join a right
join and a full outer join and then you
can actually choose the different uh
data sources and how you're connecting
them so again um I'm going to walk
through a little bit of this but I think
the sequel video that I did on this
shows it so well um I would highly
recommend using that um and I recommend
learning SQL too so you know two birds
one stem so I'm going to get into each
of the joins how they work what data is
going to be displayed um and these
visualizations are really going to be
helpful and I think that it's it's just
nice that they have it because it's a
little reminder okay um you know this is
what this joint is or this is what that
joint is so super super simple so right
now we have the demographics table and
we have the job title table and so what
it's doing right now and let's get rid
of this what it's doing right now is
it's doing an inner join and so it's
pulling everything that overlaps if it
matches on the employee ID and the
employee ID and so right now you only
see one through n but if you remember in
the demographics table we had uh 1,000
all the way through 10 so where's that
10th one well the 10th one is not there
and that is because in this job title
employee ID it only went up
to9 and then Ryan Howard just didn't
have an employee ID in there for
whatever reason so that data is going to
be missing now when you are using actual
data sets very large data sets which we
will use in the next video when we walk
through an entire
project um when you use large data sets
this can be the difference between clean
data and very wrong data and and
visualizing it correctly and showing
completely wrong numbers and so you
really need to be sure you understand
how your data works together when you're
doing these joins so how can we fix this
how can we um make it to where we can
see all of the data well right now we're
only making it to where if the employee
ID is equal to the employee ID so we
only are going to see through 109 and
through 109 we're never going to see
Ryan so there are two different types of
joins that we could do to make it see it
and then there's something else that we
can join on to where we can see that
data the first that we can look at is
the right uh join and what this does is
it's going to take everything that is
the same but also everything from this
job title table regardless of if it has
a match in the demographics table so
it's pretty you know this visualization
does it all it's going to show
everything in the right table regardless
and it's only going to show things from
this table if there's a match so let's
try this one and we should see Ryan
Howard in the job title table so let's
click on it and if we scroll down there
going to be n n n n n until we get to
over here where we now have the data
that we had in that actual table but
again this wasn't a match and so we
weren't able to see that data so this
gives us a way to where we can see all
of it um all everything from that right
table this job title table and now we're
going to click on the full outer now the
full outer is going to take everything
from both regardless of if there is a
match at all and so right here you're
going to see Ryan Howard and Ryan Howard
now why are there two different rows for
it well because in the demographics
table there was an employee ID so we're
seeing the employee ID Ryan Howard his
age and his gender and over here there
was no match right but in the job title
table again this one didn't have an
employee ID and so we we are going to be
able to see this data but over here it
has no match and so that's why showing
us two different rows is because there
was no connection there was no match
there that's what a full outer joint is
going to do now just for uh the purposes
of seeing what this one does as well we
have the leftand table um and now we are
able to see the 110 or or 1010 that we
didn't see before um and it's putting in
nulles over here because there's no
match so that's that is um what we have
so far now like I said just a second
going to go there is a way that we can
do this without using the employee IDs
we're allowed to use a different join
Clause now there is the name of the
employee in both of them this one is
called name of employee and in the job
title it's called employee name they
don't have to have the same column name
in order to join it you can do whatever
you want so I'm going to get rid of this
one and now we are only tying it on the
employee name and let's do an inter
join and it should be basically
everything um except the only piece of
data that wasn't filled in which is that
110 over on the job title table and so
this way was a slightly different maybe
uh less thought of way because normally
you do it if there's an ID you go on the
IDS but because we had a lack of data
for in in one of the tables in the job
title table we decided to use a
different column to to join on and now
we're able to look at all the data
together so super quickly that is an
inner join a left join a right join and
a full outer join and it's pretty easily
visualized here and you're able to uh
change what you're joining on right here
but you're also you can do multiple so
if we want to do the employee ID and the
employee ID you can do that as well and
you can keep going as as many as you'd
like um and
right here or you can change some of
these things uh I don't there aren't a
lot of use cases for this um but you
know you can absolutely do this um and
mess around with this as seen I'm not
going to go through it in the tutorial
because again 95 plus perc of the joins
you're doing you're going to want to do
it to where this equals this um and if
you want to get into where it doesn't
equal or or all these other things which
is more complicated I think it's much
better to learn that in SQL uh that's my
personal preference and so um again all
in the SQL tutorial if you want to check
that one out so you're able to join on
multiple things now let's get rid of
that one because we can actually bring
in this salary one as well and what
you'll see right down
here is that we have our employee ID and
this is all coming from the demographics
so employee ID name of employer employee
age employee gender then right over here
we have the job title table so employee
ID job title employee name job title and
then right over here was or is our
salary table and so we have employee ID
salary and employee salary so again this
is a way that you can put all of this
data into one place and and just a
second we'll go into the
worksheet right down here I'm going to
show you kind of how it looks because it
looks a little bit different um than
previous tutorials and so I want to show
you how that actually all works together
um but again you can create these joins
um as well and do the exact same thing
that we just looked at and customize the
joins customize what you're what you're
um uh joining on and then you have your
finished product and so right now we
have our demographics plus Tableau joins
file and we can rename that if we want
I'm going to call this um demographics
plus joins
demo and click enter and so now that is
saved so so now let's go down to the go
to worksheet we're going to click on
that and so up here on our left side
this may look a little bit different
than it normally does um because it's
broken out um on the measure names and
the measure values it's broken out by
the tables that they were joined on so
we can pull in the employee gender now
and we can pull in the employee name now
um and we can pull in the employee ID
again if we want to from the job title
table and we can pull in the employee ID
from the salary table we could do that
if we wanted to it makes no sense uh uh
for actually creating any visualizations
but you know you can do that and so you
probably you wouldn't be able to do that
if you hadn't joined these together and
so down here in the measure values the
values that we have are from the
demographics table and the salary table
all of the um all of the stuff from the
employee title none of those things were
um values and so we can't use there are
going to be no values down here and so
really quick let's take the name of the
employee let's take their salary sure
why not um let's order
that let's take the employee
salary we'll do
color and uh expan this out a little
bit maybe one more time oops just like
that and there you go so that is how you
do joins in Tableau and I think Tableau
does a really fantastic job of making it
pretty simple they have the different
types of joins when you click on that
that join button and it shows you the
inner and the left and the right and the
full outer and they make it pretty
simple um and and and it's just really
useful to be able to see that while
you're creating it and see the output
below like we just did a second ago it
it just makes it so simple to create
those joins and then just keep going
because you already know what your
output is going to be and you can kind
of mess around with it and make sure
you're getting the data that you need in
the very next video we're going to be
doing an entire project in tap we're
going to be using a lot more data and
it's going to be a a complete project
that you can add to your portfolio and
it's going to be a really good time so I
hope that you joined me for that one I
appreciate your time I hope that this
was helpful thank you guys so much for
watching I really appreciate it if you
like this video be sure to like And
subscribe below and I'll see you in the
next
[Music]
video
what's going on everybody welcome back
to the Tableau tutorial Series this is
our very last video in the series and
today we'll be doing an entire
[Music]
project now if you're watching this
video I hope that you watch the other
four videos in this series just so you
can get the basics down you kind of know
what you're doing uh this won't be a
crazy hard project this is a beginner
tutorial Series so I'm trying to make
this super easy so you can follow along
nothing super comp complicated I promise
and if you were wanting to go above and
beyond and just make a lot of different
dashboards or try a lot of different
things there's a ton of data in here and
so I'll show you some of the things that
I would do you know as we go through it
of the things that I would be looking at
and some of the different visualizations
that I might do as well but again in
this video we're going to be singing to
a lot of the basics but I'll switch over
my screen in just a second I will show
you the final product and then we will
actually walk through step by step of
how to do the entire dashboard and at
the end you should have a completed
project that you can add to your
portfolio or you know just share on
LinkedIn if you want to do that as well
with that being said let's jump over to
my screen and let's get started all
right so let's get me off screen and
show you what we're going to be working
on today this is the final dashboard
that we're actually going to be building
and so it's nothing crazy right I'm sure
you have seen all of these things before
um and I'm just going to help you kind
of build it out show you what to do the
buttons to click um and it's really
going to be a simple walk through by the
end of this you should be able to do all
these things very easily and I highly
encourage looking at at the data and
looking at these visualizations and
seeing what else you can do with it
there's a lot of different colors a lot
of different visualizations um that you
can do with this data I'm just showing
you this today and so the more you go
out there and the more you do this on
your own and you mess around with stuff
and and choose different things and see
how it all works the better you're going
to get and so I highly highly encourage
doing that uh so what we are going to be
working with today is an Airbnb data set
I'm going to show you that in just a
second and I'm going to show you the
data and we're going to just jump right
into it all right so this is the data
set that we are going to be using this
is the Seattle Airbnb open data set and
let's scroll down really quick um
there's three different csvs in here and
so this is some of the data that we're
going to be working with um some date on
listings and some pricing and then
there's the actual listing that shows um
the actual street address the location
the price the bedrooms all of these good
stuff stuff and then there's a
reviews um and it has you know some
comments and you know talks about some
of the reviews so this is what we're
going to be working with but you don't
have to go in here and download it I
have already combined all these csvs
into one I've put it on the GitHub so
I'll have a link below so you can just
click on that and you don't have to do
all the stuff that I did to get this set
up um just so you know this is from 2016
so this data set is a little bit old if
you want to you can come right here and
I will leave this link as well and you
can get the data set from you know what
is this a couple weeks ago uh this is
they they are continuing to update this
this is always updated and so you can go
ahead and download these but some of
these are the CSV Dogz um so you may
need to like convert it I don't want to
go through that process um on you know
in the video and so I am just going to
go with what is literally in kaggle um
and use that but if you want want to
have an updated one for your project I
just advise you to go in here and grab
it yourself and that should be perfectly
good so go ahead and download the data
set from the GitHub and we should be
good to go so this is the Excel that I
was just talking about this has all of
our csvs in one place this is you know
an Excel workbook so in this reviews
actually let's start with the listings
because that's kind of where it all
stems from uh we have our listing and
the DAT or the data in here is um you
you know really extensive there's a lot
of data in here so let's get over really
quick um the listing refers to the
actual home that they're renting out the
Airbnb so it shows their
location um and there's a lot more
location information over here I'm
getting into it in in just a second so
there's the neighborhood the city state
um zip code all stuff that you know may
be useful there's a latitude and
longitude it shows what type of property
it is so that's really really good um
right over here it has you know how many
bathrooms bedrooms and beds um you know
sometimes if it's a five bedroom house
it has seven beds so that's why there's
those two different um Fields I don't
know if you're familiar with Airbnb and
and you know what they have on there but
just something to note uh they have the
price this is the price per day this is
a weekly price a monthly price and if
there's a deposit needed uh and then a
cleaning fee as well so a bunch of
financial data that's you know super
useful we go into it a little bit but
there's so much you can do with that um
you know if you want to dig into that
and that's kind of it the rest of it's
pretty uh pretty useless um and there's
a lot so there's so much data in here
almost you know more than half by far is
nothing you would put in any type of
visualization um and this is pretty
common uh you're not going to
get data every column where you're going
to be able to use it a lot of times it's
just a lot of useless junk and so you
have to know what you're looking for and
know uh you know what's actually useful
so that's the listing then we have
reviews
now what's really a little bit confusing
in here and something that you just need
to kind of understand about the data um
and something that if you're if you get
a data analyst job you need to
understand your data because it's very
easy to come in here and say okay
there's an ID ID field and here's an ID
field so that means that those are the
same well not in this case um this ID
field is actually the review reviews ID
not the reviewer ID that refers to like
the person this is the reviews ID this
listing ID is the actual ID right there
so really important to
note um and then the L and so then they
just have their comment there what they
left as a review and then on the
calendar um I don't know why I'm
scrolled down uh we have this listing
idea again so again that listing ID is
equal to the ID in this listing table
and we have a date in a price so this
refers to a specific location and on
this day they got $85 for it somebody
rented it out um and so then there's
these like T's and Fs um let's try to
find a blank one really quick here's a
blank one so there's these T's and Fs uh
the t means that it was taken um the f
means that it's vacant I don't know
exactly what it means uh what a TF means
but that we can deduce that much from
this and so you can see when and how
much this person was making or this
homeade uh in that time so really really
good data in here there's a lot to work
with um and and so we're just going to
be kind of I'll give you a little bit of
a use case for it in a second and then
we're going to start trying to answer
some of those the building out some of
the visualizations for that use case uh
again you could have 20 different use
cases for this data or more um honestly
for this data where you can build out
different dashboards and different
reports literally with just this data
but you know we're doing a pretty
General broad project and so it's hard
to answer all of them so let's jump over
to Tableau we're going to get started on
this and we are going to build out
everything all right so let's come right
here uh this is a Microsoft Excel we'll
open that up do this one we will open
it and give it just a second says it's
executing the query it's pulling the
data in all right so we have our
calendar our listing and our reviews
those are the different tabs at the
bottom we're going to start with the
listing this is the the kind of the main
one has um you know the there's I didn't
show you but there's about
3,600
locations that they had in
there uh let's just have it update
automatically I don't know why we need
to click on that but um so we have this
list listings we have our calendar and
our
reviews what we're going to do is going
to come in here and we're going to open
it as we did in our very last video uh
for the joins so now that we've opened
it we can kind of go in here and we can
do the joins as um as needed and so
let's go over here and we're going to uh
let's start with
calendar put it right there that was
super slow I
apologize all right let's wait for it
to get the data start setting everything
up did not think it would take this long
I
apologize no take your time so let's
click on here and right now it has the
uh the join based on the price which
obviously is not going to work um and if
you remember there is no ID in this
calendar it's just just the listing ID
um we can actually look right here
there's just the listing ID so we're
actually going to put listing ID is
equal to
ID and right down here we can see that
we have a lot of of well you can't see
it um but we show that there is a lot of
data um and so we know that that is
correct we know that that is now pulling
in data correctly because it's showing
up down here so that's a good thing now
in this listings there there are about
3600 um about 3600 listings and
so that all the data that's in listings
is going to be in there but on the
calendar because we converted from a CSV
to an Excel workbook it isn't able to
store as much information so some of the
ones in calendar may have gotten cut off
so we can just keep at this inj join
because we know that if it's in listings
it is going to be in calendar we know
that it if it um there may be some in
calar Cal that aren't in listings so if
we really um you know if we really
really wanted to we could do a full
outer or something like that I I haven't
really thought through this as I'm
talking through it in my head but we
know that uh everything that's in
listing is going to be in calendar and
so you know we don't really need to do
anything other than an inner
join and we can also pull in these
reviews and it's going to do the same
thing as before where just kind of
pulling in the data and it defaults to
ID equals ID now we know that that is
not correct um because the ID in here is
referring to the review ID we need to go
to the listings ID so we need the ID be
able to you know be part of that
listings ID if we do the
ID it goes down to
2,555 rows if we do how it's supposed
and because that's just you know it's
random luck there happen to be some
numbers that are in both fields um that
tie together if we do the correct one
where we hit the listing ID it bumps it
up to I think 2, 373,000 oh maybe more
than that uh 23 million rows right a lot
lot lot more and so it's super important
to get these joins right to tie them
together on the right Fields if you just
do it based off what Tableau tells you
because it has that automated um you
know it goes into these fields and says
okay these are the same exact column
name so they're most likely going to be
what you're looking for well it was
incorrect in this point so it's really
important to check those things and make
sure you're pulling in the right data
again we're going to keep it that inner
join um you know if you wanted to you
know try to see if there's any other
data that correlate we're keeping it
simple today but sometimes you need to
join on multiple things uh so just uh a
you know a tip so let's get out of here
um and we are good to go so this is our
listings plus Tableau full project
that's what we'll that's what we'll be
working with um and we we were able to
tie all three of these um you know as
you call them tables or sheets or
whatever you want to call them we were
able to tie them together so let's go
over here to our first
worksheet uh let's
see all right so this says Tableau
public only works with less than 15
million rows of data we have 23 million
rows of data that is uh that's a problem
um and when I did this before it didn't
do that so I you know we're going to
work through this together so this is
date reviews I believe this is date for
um this is date for the calendar which
is going to be a lot of rows of data and
so I'm sure that's part of it let's
see let's do
years we only want 2016 oops we only
want
2016 let's do okay
let's see what that does let's see if
that gets us under what we need um we
only want 2016 data
anyways so if it's in 2017 we were going
to take it out um anyway so we'll see if
that gets us underneath I have
absolutely if this T ends up taking like
20 minutes I will just cut it and you
know you won't have to wait as long as
I'm waiting so let's see how long it
takes all right so it took about 20
minutes and it did absolutely nothing
um one thing I do know is that we don't
actually use this review tables at all
um just for demonstration purposes so
we're going to remove that and let's see
if that helps us in any
way if it does we're just going to keep
it as is um you know the reviews table
is really just for demonstrating how to
do the joint
but we weren't actually using any of the
data for any of the
visualizations although you
could again I'm going to see how long
this takes uh and I'll cut
ahead all right so that worked uh
perfectly it apparently took out all the
data that we needed all the rows that we
needed to get under that level again I
was just doing that to show you the that
that joins how you needed to change the
columns to make sure that it joined
properly we don't actually use for any
of the visualization so their end
product is going to be totally fine I
don't know why uh this didn't happen to
me when I when I created this whole
thing already um so just going to move
forward because uh I make mistakes so uh
let's keep moving the first one that we
are going to make is that uh is that
colorful one I'll probably pop it up on
screen so you can see it uh well if I
remember I'm going to pop it up on
screen um it's the colorful one it's the
price by ZIP code so we're going to be
looking at these zip codes and kind of
see
um you know how
expensive is each zip code um and before
we actually start I just remembered I
want to talk to you about the use case
for this
data I want to imagine you to imagine
that you're working for somebody they're
like hey where you know I want to start
an Airbnb business I want to know where
I should go where should I buy up buy a
home put it up on Airbnb and start
renting it out where's the best place
you know what are some of the fact fact
that I should be looking at uh and so
that's kind of what our use case is so
we're going to some of the things that
he cares about are things like bedrooms
um location which is really important
and how much price he's actually going
to get how much money can he charge and
so he's trying to optimize that to make
sure that whatever rental he gets he can
make a the most profit from instead of
choosing something that you know he
thinks would work but you know in the
end he's actually not making that much
money so those things are important so
that's our use case we're trying to help
this guy out help him find a really good
Airbnb um so let's take a look at these
zip codes real quick we have uh quite a
few of them and there's one that's null
uh we'll exclude that or if if it
doesn't have a zip code we'll just
exclude those because they're not going
to show up on the these visualizations
anyways um and so we want to look at the
price so we just want to find uh the
price which should actually be down
here and not the sum
uh no we want to look at the average
price and let's order that this is great
um so this is the most expensive one uh
ZIP code 98134 at
$26 uh
per for the average price uh but let's
give that some color really quick Let's
uh where's the ZIP code it's up here so
let's take that zip code we're going to
put it right over here we're going to do
color and it's going to give it some uh
assorted colors now these colors are
going to um when we do the map in just a
little bit these colors will um match
what we're doing in there and so you
know I I like to try to color coordinate
things um we're not doing going too
crazy with the colors today so this is
our very first visualization
congratulations it is uh it is complete
so uh we can label this one and we can
just
do price by zip code and I'll make that
bold I don't know I usually like it bold
we'll apply we'll do like that and boom
first one is done uh and this is our
starting place to say uh Hey person
who's looking to buy this Airbnb here
are the zip codes where they are able to
charge the most um for for their Airbnb
so let's go over to the second sheet and
we are going to be doing the map and so
um map is pretty easy
but it it's pretty easy Once you
actually get the data that you need
although there's a lot of different data
that you can use for the actual U map
right here you need something that shows
um the location and there's a lot of
things that show location in here in
fact they already um provide a latitude
and longitude and then at the bottom
they generated a latitude and longitude
from from some different um fields and
then there's just a bunch of different
um State there's um States there's zip
codes there are uh I think another one I
yeah like country there's a lot of
location data in here so which one do we
want to use we want to stay consistent
we don't want to deviate from that and
start using different um L long
longitude and latitudinal uh coordinates
because that could throw off our our
results completely we want to stay
consistent with what we're using so we
actually want to use this ZIP code but
when we pull it up here it's going to
give us uh basically the same um you
know it's going to show these zip codes
but we were going to right over here
we're going to click on this one and now
it's going to separate them out so now
we have all of these um you know kind of
separated out what you might get when
you first do this um is it might look
like this you may have to zoom in um I
know that that happened to me the other
time excuse me go to here that's what
happened to me uh just when I first did
it so uh know that that may happen
and we want to change the colors the
exact same way that we did them before
so we're just going over here we're
doing color and these colors do um they
do should match up with the um with the
other ones let me um exclude this let me
see if it does 98134 that's the
blue and right over here 98134 that's a
blue I I I believe believe they are
going to be the same yep and so just
scrolling back if you look at the ZIP
code on the far right uh they are the
same so if you're looking like this
section right over here I I'm just
wanting to make sure I'm not going crazy
uh before I get into this and realize
I'm not correct at all so uh now what we
want is you know this doesn't really
give us any information if I was just to
glance at this map I would have no idea
what you're trying to show me um any
information off this so we want to show
some actual
information so first thing that we're
going to do is we're going to actually
add the label to this so that you can
see it you know when you're going over
here and you see okay here's this um zip
code um in the dashboard when we create
it you can click on this but if you just
want to do it visually without having to
click anywhere you'll be able to see
okay 98134 that's right here so this
location right here is you know able to
charge a lot of money it's probably a
really nice neighborhood so um and we
can back that up by putting the average
price so these these two visualizations
are really they really go hand in hand
we're going to add oops not the
sum this one needs to be the average so
you go to this measure the sum go to
average and there you go and these
should match so this should be
206.125
206.000 so this all matches um and we
can uh we can actually change that size
a little bit if you want to actually get
it in um get it within each of these
things you know adjust it as you see
fits I think that's fine right there um
no need
to mess with it
anymore all right so let me see I think
that is everything for this one I don't
know if I want to add anything else uh
no I'm going to keep it how it is so
that is our second visualization again
these ones are directly uh correlated
and and you know this there's just
different ways to visualize it this one
you can see actually on the map where it
is and the average price this one you
can see from highest to lowest so again
you know sometimes when you're doing
these visualizations you're going to
have these accompanying um uh these
accompanying visualizations in your
dashboard that's very normal so let's
move over to the third one and for this
third one um you know something that our
guy was looking at is he's like okay
well you know I'm thinking about listing
it on Airbnb but I also want to live in
it so I want to know the best times to
actually um you know put it on the
market for people to be able to use and
so I was like okay man no problem uh
let's let's take a look at when when are
people spending the most money in
airbnbs and we actually had that
calendar um if you remember let's look
let's see this calendar so we have this
available the date the listing all of
that stuff um and let's look at the date
in
here uh and we obviously don't want it
like this we want it to be more uh more
of a Time series and we're going to do
be doing that based off of uh the price
for the calendar so let's go see if we
can find that really
quick okay here's the price
where is that calendar
one let me see okay there's the calendar
oh
here I totally forgot where that was
supposed to be o that looks
terrible okay um let's see let's let's
start working on this because this needs
some work obviously uh this is the worst
visualization I have ever seen um so we
need to work on this a little bit what
we need to do is we need to change oh
whoops we need to change some the way
that these dates are are seen so right
here is a these are two separate things
so if I go right here and I Do by
quarter it's just going to change the
quarters here right that's that isn't
really helpful we actually want to keep
the year here what we want to do it is
by year we want to separate it by year
um but we want to separate it let's just
do I don't know let's try weak and see
what it looks like okay this is great
this is this is what we're looking at
again um if we went back and Chang this
like quarter it uh changed it quarter
and then change it to week it would show
the
quarters but it wouldn't
show everything right this isn't all the
data that we need and so you know you
really need to make sure that you're
doing this correct I by default it's
almost always year but if you're looking
at it via quarter so like let's say
somebody comes in you say hey what
quarters I Want to Break these out by
quarters um and not year-over-year
that's how you would do this but in the
year we want to break it out by uh the
week and you see this huge drop off um
at the end well that is actually because
the data doesn't go past that um there's
just like one day of data or one one um
week of data in here with actual um with
January of 2017 data so it just drops
off because this is an this is the sum
so it only adds up to like um 591 th000
compared to like the 2 million so we
want to get rid of that um and how do we
do that uh let's see I think it's
filter how's it format no it's not
format what am I thinking bear with me
uh let's a filter well I was looking for
it I just couldn't find
it uh let's bring it back to the 31st
let's see if that fixes what we need
perfect uh that's all you had to do um
and the reason that this is helpful and
often times you'd have several years
worth of data in here um and then you
could have you could do even do
something like this um like this one
where it has multiple
lines the reason that this is helpful is
because if I'm telling my friend let's I
mean just I'm going to say it's a friend
or business partner whatever you
whatever you want to use this use case
for I'm GNA tell him hey the beginning
of January all the way until like you
know even February it's like really low
it's half so there's not a lot of people
traveling because everyone travels when
at the end of the year so in November
December for the holidays to visit
family um and then in the summer for
vacations I would tell him just based
off this one thing I would say hey over
the summer and then at the end of the
year and during the holidays that's when
I would be renting out your air BNB okay
so just this one very simple
visualization can help him understand
the best times um to do that that may be
an intuitive you may have already known
that but you can prove it with the data
which is always really helpful um and
let's see is there anything else that we
need to do with
this uh I'm just going to label it and
I'm going to say
um
revenue for
year
let's do bold do apply there we go do I
label this last one I didn't let's label
that last
[Music]
one and we'll
do price per zip
code price per zip code we'll just keep
it at that keep it
simple um and let's do that all right I
believe we have two more so we have done
um we've done three of them um we got
the zip codes we've got the um you know
the time of the year now something else
that he was wanting to know is um you
know just how things affect it and
something that's going to affect the
price of the actual Airbnb is going to
be the amount of bedrooms so the the
larger the house the more bedrooms the
more it's going to cost typically so we
can take a look at that let's pull in
these bedrooms
um and that will be our
columns uh no it won't what we need to
do um and so I I knew this was going to
happen I just forgot it until right uh
until right now what we this right now
is actually a um it's a a value right so
it's a number and that's totally um
reasonable because if we go right here
we do count distinct that's because
there's only seven values right it goes
there's zero bedrooms 1 2 3 4 5 5 six 7
all the way up to seven bedrooms right
now it has it as a numerical value we
want to um change that to create it as
um these measure names not a value so
we're going to um we're going to remove
this we're going to go right down here
we're going click this drop down and
we're going to say convert to
Dimension and so now we're going to add
it as a dimension so there that looks um
much more normal I really quick I'm
going to I'm going to keep these in here
for a second but we're going to get rid
of these nulls and zeros because if a
home has zero bedrooms that's a
problem um and so we want to look at the
price again let's go down here in the
listings it should be the price now this
is the price for the location per day um
if you want to look at monthly or or you
know stuff like that they have that data
um but we're just going to do the price
the average price not the
sum um although this is is helpful so
just really quick before we change it
this is going to show you which ones
make the which ones are bringing in the
most money it also may show you which
ones are the most common um those are
all different visualizations that we can
do but the one that brings in the most
money uh that brought in 63 or that has
$63 Million worth of um worth of
listings so they all add up those one
bedrooms are doing phenomenal half of
that are two bedrooms at 30 million
three bedrooms at 18 million and so on
and so forth so there's a ton of
one-bedroom ones we may even keep we
could even keep that in there um you
know if we wanted
to um and then we do something similar
later but you can keep something like
this in there what we will do really
quick though is we're going to do the
same thing that we've been doing is
keeping
average um and we are going to get rid
of this cuz if it doesn't have the
bedrooms you know that's not helpful to
us and if it has zero bedrooms that's
that's genuinely a problem I will not be
renting an Airbnb with my family uh that
has zero bedrooms in it so now we have
this and would be really helpful to be
able to see that in the visualization I
mean it's just kind
of hard to see it as is I
mean it just does not hurt to add that
right here do a label um why is it
angled like that maybe I just need to
move it out
more that looks much better um that's
the average price that cannot be right
that's the sum that's why so let's go
over here let's make that average as
well much better because uh if the price
was $3
million for a three-bedroom I would not
be going there so this is really really
useful information for our friend right
if um he wants start you know get into
those one that one bedroom area you know
you're not going to be making a lot of
money it may be low cost UPF front but
he's not going to be making a lot of
money it significantly goes up when you
reach these five and six bedroom homes
which makes sense I mean if it has five
or six bedrooms in it it's probably a
really large really nice home and you
can charge a lot more money and our
friend is uh extremely wealthy he can
buy whatever he wants and so he may be
looking at these um larger on seeing
that there's a much higher return um on
his investment the higher and the more
bedrooms he goes so we're going to keep
it just as it
is um and let me see is there's anything
else that we want to do with this no
we're going to keep it just like this uh
and the last one is by far the easiest
and we actually just discussed it a
little bit we want to know you know
what's his competition look like so um
for those for the bedrooms specifically
so let's go back up to the
bedrooms we want that one to be right
here in our rows so we show um these and
then we just want to count of um how
many listings there are so we can do
that via the listings ID so here's our
listings each ID represents one location
or one home so we're going to do that
right here uh that looks absolutely
terrible that looks terrible what am I
doing wrong here um let me see
uh one thing we need to do is we want to
get rid of these nulls and
zeros do that really
quick um and then we don't want to do
just the ID because I I'm realizing now
uh what I'm doing I need to convert this
to a numeric so we can do a count on it
so let's um oops let me see what what is
happening this is terrible all right
let's put this back let's make let me
see if I can just um
do an
attribute let's
do the
[Music]
count and let's
do
text um no it needs to be a distinct
count because that's that's basically
like
um a count of the numbers themselves not
each individual ID okay it took figuring
out I'm going to keep that in there
because you guys need to see uh a lot of
you guys like seeing when I make
mistakes so you know makes it feel like
when you make mistakes it's okay um and
I'm all about that so I'm leaving that
in there you guys can see me fail a
little bit um I just forgot how to do
that for a second and this is exactly
what we're looking for right we want we
now it showed us in that visualization
that we were looking at earlier before
we um switched it to the average price
this is showing us that there are for
one bedrooms there's 1,800 one bedroom
two that 483 3 that have 206 four that
have 55 only five that have 20 and six
that have five so the more you go up the
less and less it is or the less and less
competition there's going to be now is
there a lot of demand for four-bedroom
five-bedroom six-bedroom uh that's for
our friend to figure out um well maybe
we'll help them out with that later um
in the with the data you know we could
look at the reviews that we had um
there's so much data in here and we
could absolutely figure that out but for
what it's worth giving him this initial
stuff and he'll have follow-up questions
for us later that's how it always works
I promise um so now we're good with this
one let's label this one did I label the
last one I will go back and look um
distinct I I'm going to butcher this one
I'm going do a distinct count
of of bedroom listings I don't that may
not make sense at all but we're keeping
it so we're going to do bedroom apply
okay let me see if I added the label on
this one I didn't let me do that real
quick we do
average price per
bedroom again I'm
oops you didn't see that I'm just going
with whatever is coming to my head this
probably wouldn't be what I would keep
if I this or like an actual project but
it works for now so we have our five
visualizations 1 2 three four and five
and let's create our dashboard that's
going to be this button right here so
we're going to click that we are going
to uh go right here and we're going to
say automatic because we want to use
this entire area and so now we're just
going to start um you know pulling them
over and I'm just going to start from
the very first one and go to the very
last one keep it really simple so this
very first one we'll pull it over it you
know it's going to take up the entire
space until you start adding all the
other ones we'll include this one right
here um and well let's leave it as it is
you know we'll adjust it once it gets to
its final place now we have number three
We'll add this one on this side it looks
terrible right now but give it a second
uh then we have number four we're going
to add that across the top okay it's
already starting to look a little
better and um maybe I I you don't have
to keep this in here
um but you definitely
can uh let's start to adjust things a
little
bit
oops okay
let's see if I can zoom in one more NOP
I'm going to do it just like that
actually let me
[Music]
see if I can make it even just a little
bit closer perfect uh that's the the
best you're going to get um if you
didn't see I use this um magnifying and
then I could click on the area that I
wanted to see so we're going to keep
that just like
that we're going to move this over
because that is um definitely not as
important um and then we're going to
move this way over as well so keep it
just like that again this is something
where if you want to you can click on
this um it didn't I don't know why uh I
can't remember how to get those
connected but it's you definitely can um
but okay I was just clicking on the
wrong one that's
why that is why but you can click over
here and you you know it'll filter um
based on so if I go to this one oops
[Music]
dang oh jeez what am I doing oh this is
a
travesty okay let's try to get this
back all right I'm not touching it guys
you get the gist you can mess around
with it yourself I'm not messing this up
okay so the next thing we need to add is
the very last one that's going to go
right up here and then we're just going
to kind of move it off to the
side
and let's
see going
add yeah have this caption um if you've
never seen something like this
before um and I actually want to make
this bigger as
well oh jeez give me a second it's it's
kind of lagging a little
[Music]
bit and make this a little bit tall
maybe I don't want it as wide but I
definitely want a little
[Music]
taller give it a second yeah let me
scooch this
[Music]
back just like that that's fine uh we
can keep it like that in my original one
I didn't have this um um you can get rid
of this if you want you know you can um
you know just exit out right here if you
want to do that but there you have it uh
this is the entire thing so we started
from the very start um we started with
this one then this one uh did some um
and this is you know all the zip all of
our ZIP code work then we took a look at
the calendar where we looked at the
price and did some time series
visualization and then we're looking at
the bedrooms and and the count of
bedrooms and so this should be really
helpful for a friend it should be an
initial dashboard to get him going and
once he sees us he's going to have a
million other questions and he's going
to want another dashboard for different
data that's in there he's going to ask
about okay well what if I want to do it
weekly or you know I want to rent it out
for the month or you know how many um
reviews are people five star reviews are
people giving on you know W bedroom two
bedroom three bedroom these are all
things that you know he may ask and then
we'd have to build out in the real world
this is what happens all the time you
know they make a request and then
they're like oh this is great but I also
want this so um you know your friend is
is going to be right in line with just
about everyone else um that has ever
gotten a dashboard uh for work or for
personal use with that being said this
is it um we have done the entire thing
now if you want to share this it is
super super easy to share um and I'm
going to try to remember how to share it
uh so we're going to do save to tap
public
As and we're going to do this and we're
going to make it um let's do Air BnB is
it like is it a capital B is it like
that no that doesn't look right
Airbnb uh we'll do full project and
we'll
save and that is being created right now
um and I will save this so if you guys
want to go look at this you can um and
I'll provide a link in the description
as well for that and see if yours looks
um similar to mine or better than
mine give it a second CU it's
thinking all right so here it is so
here's our final our final project um
and if you followed step by step then
you should get this exact or very very
similar to this one again I encourage
you to if you want to have the upto-date
data to go to that um Link in the
description that has um the the most
recent data and they update that I
believe monthly so you can go there get
the most recent data and then you can do
stuff and you can create a beautiful
project just like this um but with the
you know the most recent data again I
use the kaggle data just so you guys can
remember and I encourage you to look at
the different data points that are in
the Excel there is so much in there and
you can use uh honestly like there's
probably 30 or 40 other fields that you
could be using in there that we never
even touched um but for this project
we're keeping it pretty simple and so so
go do that make completely unique
dashboards and and visualizations and
create projects and add it to your
portfolios so that you can create uh a
fantastic portfolio website and get a
job and that's what this is all about um
it's about upskilling and and getting
these skills that you can you know get a
job or or do better in your job so I
hope this has been helpful I really
appreciate you guys joining me and and
doing this entire project with me I have
no idea how long this is this probably
this could be like an hour for all I
know um so thank you so much for
sticking with me this entire time if you
like this video be sure to like And
subscribe below and I will see you in
the next
[Music]
video what's going on everybody welcome
back to another video today we're going
to be starting our powerbi tutorial
series
now I am super excited to start this
series with you guys we are going to be
breaking this up in about six or seven
videos I don't really like those super
long videos where it's like four hours
long I like breaking mine up into chunks
so that's what we're going to do this is
the beginner series and so we're going
to start with the very Basics and we're
just going to work our way up and I'm
going to walk you through every single
step of the way it'll be very easy to
follow everything will be provided for
you so that all you have to do is really
follow along and by the end of it you
should know powerbi a lot better you
should have a lot more com using it now
before we actually jump onto my screen I
want to give a huge shout out to the
sponsor of this video and that is udemy
you guys know that I absolutely love
udemy I've been using them for years and
that is no exception when it comes to
powerbi I have taken some of the best
powerbi courses ever on udemy so I
highly recommend you checking out the
ones that I have in the description
these are ones that I actually took and
I loved the most so if you're looking
for a full powerbi course I highly
recommend checking out you to me thank
you so much again to our sponsor and now
without further Ado let's jump onto my
screen and get started with a tutorial
all right so the first thing I'm going
to do is download powerbi desktop I will
leave this link in the description so
you can just click on it go to it and
download it we're going to click this
download free button and once we click
it you can go to the Microsoft store and
I already have it downloaded so when you
see it uh it'll already say downloaded
but um for you you can go in here you
can click download and it will download
it for you I'm on Microsoft uh but it
may look a little bit different for you
if you're on a different system but once
that is done we are going to open up
powerbi so let's go right down here to
our search let's go to
powerbi and it is going to open up for
us all right so right away this is what
it's going to look like when you open it
and we're going to go right over here to
get data and let's click on that it's
going to open up this window and it's
going to give us a lot of different
options for where we can get data from
now some of these are free and some you
need to upgrade from but you just taking
a quick glance through here you have a
ton of options there's databases there's
um you know blob storages there's post
create SQL or different SQL databases um
there's Google analytics there's a lot
of places and you can go through the
process to connect to that data and you
can pull that data in from those data
sources now for what we are doing we're
just going to be using an Excel I'm
going to leave the Excel that I'm going
to be using in the description you can
go and download it and walk through this
with me so what we're going to do is
click on Excel workbook and we're going
to click connect so we're going to go
right here in our powerbi tutorials
folder and we're going to click on
apocalypse food prep so let's click on
that and it is going to connect and pull
that data in now right here we have our
Navigator and so if you had a lot of
different sheets you can click on that
and choose which ones to pull in I just
clicked on it right over here and we're
able to preview the data but I can't
load or transform it yet I need to
select which sheets I'm bringing in so
we only have ones that's the only one
we're going to bring in so you can go
ahead and load the data or you can click
on transform data it's going to take us
to powerbi power query which is going to
allow us to transform our data so I'm
going to have an entire video on how to
transform the data but I'm going to give
you a really quick glance at it to kind
of show you what it is so right up here
it says our power query editor this is a
the window to basically transform your
data and get it ready for your
visualizations now you can do this in
Excel if you want to and do that before
forand or you can do it here and there
are lots of things that we can do in
here as you can see at the top again
I'll have an entire video dedicated to
just power query but let's take a quick
look at the data and see if there's
anything we want to transform quickly
before we actually go and start building
our
visualizations so over here we have the
store where we purchased it we have the
product that we purchased the price that
we paid and the date that we bought it
now the first thing that jumps out to me
is that this just says date on it um we
might want to say date
uncore purchased and we're going to hit
enter and if you noticed right over here
on these applied steps it says renamed
columns everything that you do every
single step that you apply to transform
this data is going to be right over here
and if I want to if I go back and I say
you know I really didn't want to rename
that column I can just click X and it is
going to get rid of that and take it
back to its original state so again I'm
just going to say purchase
and we're going to enter that now this
is our apocalypse food prep so this is
food that we are buying for the
apocalypse um for this example and if we
look at our products we have bottled
water canned vegetables dried beans milk
and rice and all of that stuff makes
sense except for the milk U milk will
not stay or last long in the apocalypse
so I think what we're going to do is
we're going to filter that out really
quickly and we're GNA click okay and
right over here again says filtered rows
and so now if we scroll down there's no
milk so what we are going to do is we
are going to go over here to close and
apply and it is going to actually load
the data into powerbi
desktop so on this left- hand side it
immediately takes us to the report Tab
and what we want to do is go right here
to the data
Tab and take a look at our data so again
there's our date purchased and as you
can see the milk is not in there another
tab that we're going to take a look at
um and again in this report tab this is
where we actually build our
visualizations the data is where we can
see the data and and change it up a
little bit and change some small things
about it like sorting The Columns or
even creating a new column and over here
we have this other Tab and is called
model and this is especially useful when
you have multiple tables or multiple
excels and you need to join them to kind
of connect them together we don't have
that but in a future video I'm going to
walk through how to use this entire
higher tab so now let's go back to the
data Tab and I want to just look at the
data really quickly before we go over to
the report Tab and we start building our
first visualization as you can see I've
been buying these different products in
different months so this rice I've been
purchasing in January February March and
April and I've been buying it from three
different locations because I wanted to
see if I was spending less money at one
location on all of the products so then
I would just shop there in the future
and save a lot of money or if there were
specific products that were really cheap
at one location but others they were
cheaper at a different location so I
should just buy like the dried beans at
Costco but everything else I should be
buying at Walmart and so that's what
we're going to look at in just a little
bit so let's go over to the report tab
right up here at the top there's this
data section so you can kind of choose
if you want to add any more data now
that we are here we can also write
queries or transform the data like we
were looking at in the power query
editor window over here in the insert we
can add a new visualization or a text
box and then in the calculation section
we we can create a new measure or a
quick measure and then over here we have
share where you can actually publish
your report or your dashboard online now
over on the visualization section on
this far right this is a very important
area this is where a lot of the actual
creating of the dashboards happen so
let's take a look really quick and we'll
get into a lot of these things as we're
actually building our dashboard so we're
not just sitting here looking and
talking we're going to be actually
building and doing all right so we're
going to click right here on this drop
down on sheet one it's going to show us
all of our columns now two of the things
that we wanted to look at were where are
we spending the least amount of money
buying the exact same product that'll
help us determine where we want to shop
and the second thing was should I be
buying all my products at the same place
or are there certain products that
they're going to be cheaper at a
specific store and I should buy it there
so let's start out with the first one
which we're just going to see uh with
the store and the
price uh where we're spending the least
amount of money and just at a quick
glance we can see we're spending the
least amount of money at Costco at $210
versus Target 219 and Walmart at 225 and
that really answers our question but we
want to visualize it better be able to
see it in an easier way so we're going
to go right over here and we can click
on a lot of these but the one that
probably makes the most sense is the
stocked column
chart and it's going to show Walmart
Target and Costco now they're all the
same color let's add a legend so we're
just going to drag store over here down
to this Legend and let's make this
larger while we're working on it so now
we can see we're spending the most
amount of money at Walmart right in
between at Target and then at Costco is
the lowest and so right there we know
that Costco is the place to go for our
apocalypse food prep but is it going to
be that way for every product I don't
know let's take a look let's put this up
in this corner and let's start a new one
we're going to need to select the
product for sure and the price and
probably Additionally the store as well
and let's click
on let's not do this one we need a
clustered column chart that's what we
need let's bring this over here let's
expand this quite a bit and so really at
a glance this is giving us everything
that we need we can see each product
right here and we can see how much we're
paying per store and so for Rice we're
paying it looks like a lot more for our
rice at Walmart while at Target is
actually where we are paying the least
now if we look at all of these it looks
like for Costco the only one that we're
really paying a lot more on is on our
rice but for our dried beans our bottled
water we're paying quite a bit less and
really it's pretty negligible for these
canned vegetables we're paying maybe
what 60 cents 50 60 cents more per can
so that's pretty negligible but for the
big ticket items um we're really
spending a lot less at Costco if we
wanted to SP to save just a little bit
more money we could go to Target for our
rice now if I want to make this more
like a dashboard and we're only keeping
these two things I'm going to kind of
size them kind of like this whoops going
to show you that in a little bit I'm
going to size them a little bit like
this so now that we have that looking
good we want to change the title of both
of these so what we're going to do is go
over here in our visualizations and
format your visual uh and we are going
to go to this General go to Ty TI and
now we can name it anything we really
want for this we're going to say best
store for
product and while we're in here one
other thing that I wanted to do is I
want to go to this visual go right down
here to these data labels now we haven't
added any data labels so I'm going to
click on and you'll see exactly what it
does uh it just puts the labels and the
numbers above it so you don't have to
actually like hover over it and see what
it is now it is actually rounding these
numbers so what we're going to do is go
down here we're going to go down to
values and we'll go down to display
units and it's on auto so it's Auto
rounding those numbers and we're just
going to say none so we can see the
actual value of these
numbers and we can do the exact same
thing over here it probably is a good
thing to do um and it just is going to
visualize it a little bit differently in
here but you can always change that if
you want to go over here to
title and we're going to say total by
store and now we're going to take a look
and so in a matter of minutes we were
able to take our data from an Excel put
it into powerbi transform it a little
bit then we're able to create these
visualizations that gave us concrete
answers to some very important topics we
now know that Costco is the place to go
for basically every single product
except if we're buying rice and if we
want to save just a few dollars we're
going to head over to Target and that's
genuinely going to change my shopping
habits for the next several years until
the apocalypse happens so in future
videos we're going to dive into a lot of
the things that we looked at today but
just in more detail and then at the very
end of the series we're going to have an
entire project where we really use every
single part of powerbi and create a
beautiful dashboard and so that's all we
have for our very first video in our
powerbi series I hope it was helpful if
you like this video be sure to like And
subscribe below and I'll see you in the
next
video
[Music]
what's going on everybody today we're
continuing our powerbi tutorial series
and in this video we're going to be
looking at Power
[Music]
query Now power query is really great
because it allows you to actually
transform the data before you actually
get it into powerbi so if you want to
make any changes like adding or deleting
a column or changing the data type or a
ton of other things you can do all of
that in power query now without further
Ado let's jump on my screen and get
started with the tutorial all right so
before we jump over to powerbi and start
using power query I wanted to take a
look at the data and this is the Excel
from our last video called apocalypse
food prep and in that video we went
through and we bought some rice some
beans water vegetables and milk all for
the apocalypse getting prepared for that
now we decided to buy some additional
things like rope some flashlights duct
tape and a water filter several water
filters and after we purchased those uh
our boss or whoever we're working with
or somebody decided to go and make a
pivot table now in this pivot table they
kind of broke it out by Costco Target
and Walmart and had all the items had
some subtotals as well as some Grand
totals right here and then they decided
to kind of copy and paste that into this
and you'll see this a lot when you're
working with uh people who use Excel
they like to kind of make things like
this maybe make it into like a table or
or format a little bit differently but
you'll see stuff like this a lot so this
is what we're going to actually pull
into Power query and work with now we're
going to imagine that this is all we
have this is the only thing we were
working with and I'll kind of reference
this pivot table a little bit but we're
going to pretend this is all we have and
we want to transform it to make it a lot
more usable to where we can make
visualizations with it so let's hop over
to powerbi and pull this excel in so
what we're going to do is click import
data from Excel we're going to click
apocalypse food prep and click open and
then it's going to bring up this window
right here now this is where we can
choose what data to bring in so we can
take a preview and just click on it real
quick and this is the pivot table that
we were looking at so it does have that
pivot table so we are able to pull in
just a pivot table and then we have the
purchase overview where it's kind of
that formatted um thing that we're just
looking at with all the colors we're
going to pull both of those in so we're
going to pull in the pivot table and the
purchase overview now we could just load
it or we could transform it and we're
going to click transform and that's
going to bring us to power query so
let's click on transform data so now
really quick before we actually jump
into working through this and
transforming it I want to show you what
the power query editor looks like so if
we go right over here we have our
queries and these are the tables that we
actually pulled in and we can click on
those and kind of go back and forth
between them now up top we have our
ribbon and the ribbon offers a lot of
functionality we have things like remove
columns keep rows remove rows split
columns these are all things that we're
likely to use when using this power
query editor there's also another tab
called transform where there's a lot of
functionality here as well things like
unpivoting a column or transposing
columns and rows and using a first row
as a header some of the things that
we'll be looking at today there's also
another tab called add a column and this
one's pretty self-explanatory where you
can add additional columns like deleting
a column creating an index column or a
conditional column those are the three
main ones there's also view tools and
help but we're not going to really be
looking at those today and then on the
far right side we have our query
settings you can do things like change
the name so we call it pivot table
2022 and it'll update right over here on
our query side and we have our applied
steps now our applied steps are
extremely important and very very useful
anytime we make any change to transform
this data it's going to be documented
right here and then we can go back and
look at it or we could even delete that
change in the future if we want to and
go back to a previous version of what we
just did so when we loaded the data into
powerbi it did a few things for us it
shows the source the navigation and it
promoted the headers and then it also
changed the data type so if we want to
check we can actually see those things
or change those things like this Source
right here we can click on this little
icon and it's going to bring up the
actual path where we got this file so if
we wanted to change that or or it
changes in the future future we can come
here and we can change this file path
but we're not going to do that right now
so let's click on cancel and let's go
back down to change type so it promoted
these headers and obviously these
headers are not correct we're looking at
this pivot table and not the purchase
overview but it changed these column
headers and so in the future if we
wanted to we could easily change those
but it did that for us and it changed
the type as well so if you look right
here it says
abc123 all the way over here it's where
it just says ABC ABC means it's only
going to be text where abc123 means it
could be basically anything uh text or
it could be numeric so now let's go over
to purchase overview and this is the one
that we're actually going to be working
on the most but we might be looking at
pivot table just a little bit to kind of
reference it and see some of the
differences so before we do anything
let's just take a look at how powerbi
decided to take this data in so it chose
this apocalypse food prep overview as
kind of the First Column and that was
kind of our header or the title of what
we were looking at before and then all
these other columns are basically column
1 2 3 four fivs so that's something that
we're going to want to change in just a
little bit there's also all these blank
uh columns right here at the top and
kind of these null values as we go along
and we'll take a look at those and we
kind of we going to want to get rid of
some of this and just clean this up to
make it more usable for our powerbi
visualizations this may be perfectly
fine and acceptable in an Excel but when
you're pulling it into powerbi the real
reason you're pulling it in is to create
visualizations not just it to look good
in an Excel so we're going to need to
clean this up quite a bit so let's go
right up top the first thing that I want
to do is I want to get rid of these top
rows so we're going to go to this top
ribbon and we're going to click remove
rows and we're going to select remove
top rows and we're going to select two
because we have one two rows of all
nulls and those are completely useless
we just want to get rid of them right
away so let's cck Okay and it removed
those the next thing that we want to do
is these this location product and all
these dates these are actually the
column headers that we wanted so what we
need to do now is we want to go over to
transform and we want to say use first
row as
headers and just like that we have
location products and these dates as our
headers exactly how we wanted them now
let's say for whatever reason you know
we made a mistake and we needed to go
back we would just select remove top
rows and that would be perfectly fine
now you can see over here it promoted
the headers but it's also changed the
data type so before if we went to before
we removed the headers these were all
abc123 abc123 because it had a lot of
different data types in there so it just
kind of made a generic data type but
when we promoted these headers the first
thing that it decided to do was also
change this data type for us giving us
its best guess as to what this data type
is and it decided to do this decimal so
this one two is a decimal but we're
actually going to change that and all
you have to do is click on This 1.2 uh
or or the data type that it has right
here for you and we're going to click on
fixed decimal number and let's do
replace
current and now it's just a little bit
better so now it's 2.70 2.5 and that's
normally how we would read uh values
like this because this is money so we
would normally read it to the second
decimal just like that and if we have it
on the second decimal for some we should
probably have it on the second decimal
for all all of them so really quickly
I'm going to go through and I'm just
going to change that and it should be
pretty quick so hang with me for just a
second all right that is perfect now for
the purposes of what we're about to do
we don't actually need these subtotals
or this Costco total Target total and
Walmart total as well as the grand total
really we want to get rid of those and
so what we're going to do is we're going
to go right over here we're going to
click on this drop down and we're going
to try to filter this data before we
actually load it into power VI so we're
going to filter and we're going to say
remove empty and let's remove those and
it's going to take out all of those
nulls if we wanted to try to filter this
out by saying something like Costco
total or Target total we could do that
by going right here clicking this drop
town on products going to text filters
and saying does not contain and let's do
insert and we're going to say does not
contain and we want to say total and
let's click okay okay and again it
filtered out all of those things so
there's a few different options that you
can do if you want to filter out rows
that contain either null values or
specific values now the next thing that
we're going to do is actually get rid of
a column this grand total column and so
what we're going to do is we're going to
click on the very top part where it says
grand total we're going to go back over
here to home and we're going to click on
remove columns and it says insert that's
because we're on this filtered rows one
right here um but what we're going to do
is just insert that and it'll insert
right there that's totally fine we can
just move it to the bottom now we got
rid of this column entirely now this
looks really good visually I like how
this looks I like how everything is set
up the biggest thing about this is that
when you're actually wanting to use this
for visualizations these columns as
dates doesn't really work too well and
so what we're going to want to do is
we're going to want to transpose this or
pivot this to where these dates are
actually rows so what we're going to do
is select the first date which is
January 1st all the way through April
1st and we're going to hit shift and
click on that April 1st right there to
select all of them at the same time and
then we're going to go over here to the
transform Tab and we're going to click
unpivot columns and let's see what this
does and so now what we've done is we've
basically recreated our original Excel
that we had so let's go back and take a
look really quickly at that so this
looks almost identical to what we have
in powerbi right now and this is
extremely usable and very good for
visualization
and is much much better than this but
again we were pretending that this is
what we were given at the beginning so
you have to imagine you know somebody
just handing you this and you need to
make it much more usable for
visualizations in the future which
happens a lot and we actually wanted to
create this we just weren't given this
now a few last things that we might want
to do is we want to clean this up just a
little bit we're going to select the
data type and change this to date and
then we're going to select the value and
I double clicked on the value and I
actually want to call this cost uh or
product cost
productor
cost and then for the location I
actually want this to be called
store so now this looks really good but
I want to show you one thing really
quickly on this pivot table 2022 so
let's go back here this looks very
similar to how we had it when it first
started one thing I wanted to show you
uh really quickly and I want to click on
this first one we're going to make make
this our column header and then we're
going to try to Pivot or unpivot this
January February March April so really
quickly let's do that so we're going to
transform use first row as
headers so now we have this January
February March April now if you notice
these are not dates these are actually
texts it says January February March and
April so if we go to do this and we
click
unpivot and here's the columns that are
cre cre when we unpivot it it is January
February March and April these are not
dates so we cannot go and change this to
a date because that would error out
because it's actually text so it's
something that you want to look out for
it's something that you need to be aware
of and you can change that in the pivot
table so you want to be aware of how it
actually sits and looks in the Excel or
whatever data source you're pulling from
before you actually pull it into Power
query to transform and now the very last
thing that we need to do to finalize all
of this is go over here to close and
apply and once we click that everything
that we've worked on is going to be
applied to the actual data and it's
going to load into powerbi to create our
visualizations so let's go ahead and
click on that and so now the data has
been pulled into powerbi let's go right
down here to data and we can see the
data right here if we need to transform
this data again we can bring it back
into the power query editor window by
just clicking the transform data button
and it's going to bring us right back so
I hope that this was helpful thank you
so much for watching if you like this
video like And subscribe below and check
out all my other videos and everything
data analyst related I'll see you in the
next
[Music]
video what's going on everybody welcome
back to the powerbi tutorial Series
today we're going to be taking a look at
building
[Music]
relationships now when you import
multiple tables from either the same
data source or multiple data sources you
want to tie them together so that when
you're creating your visualizations
everything is connected so in this
tutorial we'll be walking through how to
create those relationships to make sure
that all of your tables are connected
properly and without further Ado let's
jump onto my screen and get started with
the tutorial all right so before we jump
over to powerbi and start creating our
relationships and our model I want to
take a look at the data in Excel we
realized we were buying so many products
for the apocalypse that we decided to
start our own store and we have several
customers and some client information
down here and so I wanted to take a look
at some of the columns and these tables
that we're going to be looking at first
thing we have is the apocalypse store
these are the things that we are selling
I know it's a very limited inventory but
these are the really high sellers these
are the ones that I wanted to sell so we
have this product ID our product name
price and production cost then we have
this apocalypse sales this is how many
sales we've actually made to our
customers so we have this customer ID
our customer name product ID order ID
unit sold and the date it was purchased
and then we have our customer
information right here here are all of
our clients so we have this customer ID
customer address city state and zip code
so now that we've taken a look at our
data let's go and load it into powerbi
so we're going to say import data from
Excel we're going to choose this model
right here we're going to click open and
we are going to want all three of these
so I'm going to click on all of them and
we're just going to load it we're not
going to transform the data at
all so now the data has been loaded
let's go right over here on the left
hand side to our model Tab and let's
scoot this over just a little bit and
move back and we're going to move these
tables up to where it's a little bit
easier to
see so right off the bat you can already
see that there are these lines between
these tables so there are already
relationships that powerbi has
automatically detected and created from
my experience powerbi actually does a
really good job at creating these
relationships automatically but we're
going to go in and take a look at these
and kind of see what everything means
and then we're going to go back and
create these relationships from scratch
just to make sure that we know how to do
every single part so to get it started
let's double click on this line
connecting the customer information
table to the apocalypse sales
table and it's going to bring up this
edit relationship page right here so
this line right here connecting these
two tables actually gives us quite a bit
of information without actually having
to click into this edit relationship
page what this is showing is that we
have a one to many relationship and
there's only one or a single crossfilter
direction and you can find both of those
things right down here and I'm going to
walk through what those mean in just a
little bit on this page you can also see
the columns that powerbi decided to
choose in order to tie these two tables
together now for our example they
decided to use the customer and customer
right here from the customer information
table as well as the apocal sales but I
don't really want to use those
specifically because on this apocalypse
sales table I might remove this customer
information and just keep the customer
ID it may have chosen these customer
columns because they have the exact same
name and really the same information but
I want to use this customer ID anyways
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
click on that column and click on this
column and then I'm going to click okay
and if we go back into it by double
clicking again we're going to see that
and now save that and if we did what we
just did before which is kind of hover
over it it's going to show us what those
two tables are joined on so opening this
back up let's go down here to this
cardinality and cross filter Direction
cardinality has several different
options that you can choose from you
have one to many one to one one to many
and many to many now for this example
we're looking at apocalypse sales and
we're going apocalypse sales down to
customer information now there are a lot
of rows in the apocalypse sales but
there's very few in this customer
information and there's only one
customer per row whereas in the
apocalypse sales up here the customer
can have several rows for several
different orders so that's why the
cardinality is many to one now if we
flip this and we say we want the
customer information here and we want
the apocalypse sales down here we tie
that together now it's going to flip and
it's going to say one to many now let's
look at the cross filter Direction and
there's only two options here it's
either single or both and if we choose
both and we click okay this now goes
from a single arrow pointing in one
direction to two arrows pointing in both
directions but what does this really
mean so in order to demonstrate this I'm
going to put this back to a single
Direction and what we're going to try to
do is connect the data over here or the
columns over here to the columns in this
apocalypse store so let's go over here
to build a visualization and what we're
going to do is we're going to take this
customer information and let's just say
we want to look at state so I'm going to
click on state right here and I'm just
going to make this into a table and the
customer information table is only tied
right now to the sales table so we're
actually going to go over to the
apocalypse store and we want to see how
many product IDs are being bought in
these different states so really quickly
we're going to come up here and create a
new measure and all we're going to say
is this measure is the count of
Apocalypse store product ID and we're
going to create that and now we're going
to select it so it's added to that table
so now what this is showing is that
there are 10 product s which there are
10 products for each of these states but
that's not actually technically correct
because not every state purchased these
10 different items if we go back to our
model and we change both of these
to a both
Direction and then we're going to go
back and see what changed in our
numbers so now let's go back to our
visualization and now we can see that
Minnesota actually only ordered seven
different product IDs Miss Miss 8 New
York 99 and Texas 10 this is actually
much more accurate than before when you
use the both option it takes these
tables and treats them as if they are a
single table but the single option is
not going to do that and so for our
example if we're trying to connect this
table to this table and one of the last
things that I want to show you is this
option right down here which says make
this relationship active now if we don't
click list and there are other options
in here that connect these things like
the customer to the customer then that
may be the active relationship but if I
select this is the active relationship
that means this is going to become the
default relationship between these two
tables so now let's come out of here
we're going to click cancel we're going
to zoom in just a little bit and bring
these tables a little bit closer so we
can zoom in just a little bit more now
we are going to go ahead and delete
these so we're going to say delete yes
and delete yes so just for demonstration
purposes we're going to build these
relationships from scratch so we're
going to come over to the customer
information table and we're going to
drag it all the way over here and put it
on top of this cust ID or the customer
ID in Apocalypse
sales and it's going to automatically
create that relationship and we can open
this up and as you can see it created
the relationship between this customer
ID in the apocalypse sales and the
customer ID in the customer information
it also defaulted the cardinality from
many to one and the cross filter
direction to single so we're going to go
ahead and change that to both and click
okay
and then we're going to come over here
to the product ID in Apocalypse store
and drag this over the product ID in the
apocalypse
sales and again if we open it up it
created that relationship for us it
created the cardinality automatically
and we're going to change this cross
filter direction to both and click okay
and so on a really small scale that is
how it works of course it becomes a
little bit more complex the more tables
that you add and the more relationships
that are created but this is how you're
going to actually create the
relationships in the model tab within
powerbi I hope that this tutorial has
helped you understand this concept a
little bit better thank you guys so much
for watching I really appreciate it if
you like this video be sure to like And
subscribe below and I'll see you in the
next
[Music]
video what's going on everybody welcome
back to the powerbi tutorial Series
today we're going to be taking a look at
Dax
[Music]
now DAC stands for data analysis
expressions and it's basically a library
of functions and operators that help you
build formulas you can use Dax to create
measures and calculated columns within
powerbi which can really give you a lot
of insight into your data honestly it is
not super complicated and hopefully by
the end of this video you'll have a lot
more confidence actually using Dax and
powerp so without further Ado let's jump
onto my screen and get started with the
tutorial all right so let's take a look
at our tables and data before we get
started so we have two tables the
apocalypse sales the apocalypse store
for this apocalypse sales table we have
the customer product ID order ID unit
sold and the date it was purchased and
then for the apocalypse store we have
product ID product name price and
production cost now these are joined
together or they do have a relationship
together via the product ID so what
we're going to be using are these new
measures and new columns to create our
Dax functions so really quickly let's go
over to this report Tab and let's drop
down our Fields over here so we can see
everything and so to get us started
we're going to go right up here to
apocalypse sales we're going to
rightclick and click new measure and
it's going to open up this right here
which is basically our bar where we can
create our functions and so right here
it's automatically given us the name
measure but we can change that and we're
going to say count of sales so now we
can start writing our Dax function
that's just going to be the name of it
and what's going to show up right over
here once we click enter so let's go
over here and we're going to say count
and as we're typing it's automatically
giving us options it has something
called intellisense if you've ever used
other Microsoft products intellisense is
their kind of autoc completion that
helps you look at other options very
quickly and so we're just going to click
on this count and it's prompting us to
put in a column name and so we can come
down here and we can select one or we
can type it out and it'll try to predict
and help us choose which column to
select so for us we're going to use this
order ID but let's just start typing it
out we'll say order ID and then we can
click on it and we're going to close
this parenthesis and click enter or you
can go over here and click this check
mark but we're just going to click
enter and so over on this right side it
finalized that and save that and we can
actually look at that by clicking on
this box next to
it and we want to look at the this in a
table so now we can see that there are
74 sales now for this we want to see
who's buying our products we want to see
what our what our client name is so
we're going to go over here we're going
to choose customer and we're going to
put customer on top of sales and we're
just going to take a look at it like
this so now we can see that our number
one customer is Uncle Joe's Prep shop he
has 22 orders now they have the most
orders with us but it doesn't
necessarily mean that they're spending
the most money with us but we can take a
look at that later the next thing that I
want to take a look at is how many
products we're actually selling what are
our big products that we're selling we
have 10 different items but I don't know
exactly which one is selling the best if
if one is doing really poorly and
getting no orders this is something that
I want to look into so all we're going
to do is go right back up here to
apocalypse sales again right click and
select new measure and for this one
we're going to call it the sum of
products sold
and all we're going to start out with is
by doing sum and if this seems familiar
to something like Excel you're 100%
correct it is very similar and remember
these are both Microsoft products so
there's going to be similar
functionality in both of them and so
this Dax is going to have a lot of
similarities to exactly how it has it in
Excel so we're going to do an open
bracket and now what we're going to
choose is this units sold we want to sum
up all of these units sold and see how
many we actually selling so we're going
to say units sold I'm going to hit tab
it's going to autocomplete that I'm
going to close my parenthesis and I'm
going to come over here and click this
checkbox so now it's created that
measure and we're already selected in
this table so all we have to do is click
the check mark and it's going to show us
that we have 3,000 total products sold
and we can go through here and see what
the big sellers are and probably the
biggest one that I see right off the bat
is this multi- Tool Survival Knife so
these Dax functions that you can write
can be very simple and lead to really
good insights that you can use for the
visualizations later on now I want to
take a look at the difference between
something like sum which is an
aggregator function and something like
sum X which is an iterator function
because if you add X to some of these
aggregator functions you can create them
or or make them into an iterator
function so you can have some and some X
or average and average X adding X onto
the end of them can make them to an
iterator function so let's take a look
and see how that actually works I'm
going to show you the difference and
then I'm going to talk through the
difference at the end so really quickly
let's go back to our data and let's go
to the apocalypse store now what we have
right here is we have the price and we
have the production cost and we want to
see how much profit we're getting from
each of these as well as we can take a
look at the unit sold and see how much
money we are actually making so what
we're going to do is we're going to come
back over here we're going to go to
apocalypse store we're going to right
click and create a measure and in just a
little bit we're going to be creating a
new column and that'll kind of show the
difference really well so we're going to
create this new measure and we're going
to name it
profit and we're going to come over here
and what we're going to do is we're
going to take the sum oops we're going
to start with our sums we're going to
take the sum of the
price and then we're going to close that
parenthesis and we're going to subtract
the sum of the production cost so all
that does is it says if something cost
$20 if we sold it for $20 and it only
costs us $10 that's $10 in profit for
that item and then what we're going to
want to do is we're going to actually
want to encapsulate that really quickly
because we're about to use multiply and
then we're going to sum and now we're
going to take the units sold so how many
units were actually sold at that profit
that we just made so let's see if that
works and let's click the check right
here and so we have the profit so let's
click on the profit oops that's not what
I wanted to do let's use a new one or
let's create a new uh table we're going
to click
profit let's make it a table and I'm
going to pull this right over
here now we have our profit but I really
want to know is which customer is
spending the most money at my store so
we're going to come right over here
we're going to click on customer and I'm
put customer at the top and just at a
glance we can see that Uncle Joe's Prep
shop is spending the most money at the
store now now what I want to show you is
the difference between sum and sum X so
what I'm going to do so I'm going to go
back to this profit and going to copy
this this entire thing and we're going
to go back here to this table now we
just created a measure and we were able
to break it down by each customer so
let's go back over here now let's go up
here to home and we're going to create a
new column and we're going to call this
profit
profit underscore column and we're going
to literally paste the exact same thing
into here and we're going to hit
enter and each row is the exact same
thing so what it's doing is it is going
through the price and it's adding all of
it up and calculating it at the bottom
it's adding the production cost it's
going all the way down and calculating
it at the bottom and then it's going
over and looking at how many units it
sold and then it's performing this
calculation up here and then it gives us
the total and it's doing it for every
single row but that's not really what we
wanted to show what we wanted to show is
the profit for each row what we wanted
to say is here's the price for the Rope
the production cost for the rope and
then how many units we actually sold and
then it'll calculate that and give us
the actual profit for just that row but
we cannot do it by just using this sum
what we need to do is use something
called Su X so let's add another column
let's go back to home say new
column and now we're going to
say profit underscore oops underscore
column underscore sum
X and now we're going to use sum X and
hit Tab and we need to choose the table
that we want to put this in so we're
going to say apocalypse sales because
that's the table that we're looking at
right here we're going to say comma and
now we need to input an expression which
it says it Returns the sum of an
expression evaluated for each row in a
table before when you're just using sum
it's looking at all of these combined
now it's taking it row by row so what
we're going to do is basically input the
same thing as we did before I'm going to
copy I'm going to paste that it's not
going to be correct I need to get rid of
these
sums but it's basically the exact same
equation give me just a second and let's
get rid of this
some and let's see if this works so
let's click the check
button and now this looks a lot better
so what this is now showing us is at a
row level this nylon rope made us 51,000
almost
$52,000 the waterproof matches made us
$115,000 and we can go down and look at
each item and see how much that actually
made us versus this profit column and so
that is the biggest difference between
sum and sum X hopefully that made sense
I know that sum and sum X and and the
difference between an aggregator
function and iterator function can be a
little bit confusing especially if
you've never done it before but
hopefully that was a good example for
you to understand that concept now let's
go back over here to apocalypse sales
right here we have a date purchase now
in the Dax function we have some ways
that we can interact with dates and so I
want to take a look at those really
quickly so we're going to go right up
here and click on new column and we're
just going to leave that as column but
what we're going to say is day so
there's a few different ones we have Day
dates YTD next day previous day and
weekday and they all are pretty
self-explanatory if you click on it
let's click on weekday it says it's
going to return a number from 1 to 7
identifying the day of the week of a
date so let's use this really quickly
and so we're going to say date
purchased and and click tab hit
comma and it's going to give us a three
different options basically it's a one a
two and a three um right here if you hit
this button read more you can read more
on it this is going to say Sunday is
equal to one Saturday is equal to seven
I like this one personally which is
Monday equals one in my brain it just
makes more sense so I'm going to click
on two I'm going to close that
parentheses and we're going to I guess
I'll say uh let's say day of week for
the column
let's click that
checkbox and now Saturdays are equal to
sixes Mondays are equal to one this
allows us to see which day of the week
people are buying the most products on
or or which day of the week is somebody
submitting their orders on and so let's
go over to our report let's get rid of
this we just going to move this oh jeez
I hate moving stuff sometimes all right
really quickly I want to show you the
difference between what we just did and
what we already have so we have this um
date purchased and let's make that into
a bar
graph and what we're going to be taking
a look at is actually the units sold so
right here we have this and obviously
for we don't want 2022 we're going to
get rid of the year we only have one
quarter right here we can see January
February March so we can tell that
January has the most sales or the most
units sold in that month if we get rid
of that we go down to day we do have
some information but we don't know what
day of the week it is it could change
from month to month and it's really hard
to tell exactly what if there's any
pattern there at all that's where what
we just created comes in handy so let's
recreate this exact same thing but
instead we're going to use day of week
so we're going to select day of week and
unit sold let's drag that down and move
this over right here and this day of the
week should be on the
xaxis and it's really easy now to see if
there's a pattern here there's really
not at least not for this fake data that
we have um but just I I want these uh
data labels on really
quickly um it's not easy to see if
there's any pattern again Monday has the
most so maybe that that I mean it goes
down a little bit and then it picks back
up so maybe middle the week is our least
uh sales day our Wednesdays and
Thursdays are a little bit lower than
the rest and the beginning and the end
of the week tend to be the highest again
not a huge pattern but you know it's
much easier to see if there is a pattern
from week to week or what day of the
week now that we use this weekday
function and so this can be really
really useful let's go back here to our
data now we're going to look at our last
Dax function for this video let's go up
here and create a new column and we're
going to be looking at something called
the if statement now if you've ever used
Excel I'm sure you have heard of this
and you can do the exact same thing here
in powerbi and so we're going to name
this one order size order undor size and
so all we're going to say is if we're
going to click on this one right here we
need to perform our logical test and
then we want to say if it's true what's
our value and if it's false what is our
value so what we're going to be looking
at is units sold so we're looking at
order size so we're going to say if unit
sold is greater than
25 what's going to happen if it is true
if the order is larger than 25 you want
to say it's a big order and if it's not
we want to say it's a small
order super simple we'll close that
parenthesis we'll click okay and now
really quickly we're able to see if this
is a big order or a small order and so
that is all I have for you today there
are a lot of other dox functions but the
ones that we looked at today are ones
that are very common ones that you'll
see the most and there can be a lot of
really complex and intricate Dax
functions that you can create and in our
project at the end of this series I will
be sure to include some more complex Dax
functions but hopefully this gave you a
good introduction into Dax so you know
how to use it a little bit better thank
you guys so much for watching I really
appreciate it if you like this video be
sure to like And subscribe and check out
all of my other videos on everything
data analyst related I will see you in
the next
video
[Music]
what's going on everybody welcome back
to the powerbi tutorial Series today
we're going to be looking at how to
drill down in
[Music]
visualizations so when I say drill down
I mean you're basically adding another
layer beneath the top layer of the
visualization and when somebody clicks
or drills down in that data they can see
more insights and more information on
the top level of data when you drill
down you can also drill up and I will
show you how to do that in this tutorial
so without further Ado let's jump on my
screen and get started with the tutorial
all right so before we get started I
wanted to remind you that you can find
the data that we're going to be working
with in this tutorial in the description
you can go and download it from my
GitHub now the two tables I'm going to
be looking at are apocalypse sales and
purchase tracker and if you've ever
created any visualizations you've
probably seen something like this where
you'll have the store and the price and
this is the the things that we actually
bought so this is the total amount of
Apocalypse prepping uh equipment that we
bought and we'll put the store in this
Legend right here and you've probably
seen something like this and if you're
anything like me you're going to be in a
meeting and you're going to be
presenting this and some higher up is
going to be like hey Alex that looks
great but I want to you know see what
things we actually bought in Target and
how much this cost can you create a
visualization for that and you're going
to be like well I could or I could use
drill down so you could have done this
in the first place uh which you should
have so what we're going to do is all
we're going to do is we're going to say
we're going to say the product right
here and these are going to be the
actual things and we're going to put it
right under store now you can't see
these things right but there is a a
hierarchy here so once we added this
these options became available let's
take it out and all those just
disappeared and then if we add it back
right here they came back and so you can
do right here which is is click to turn
on drill down you can go to the next
level in the hierarchy or you can even
expand all down one level in the
hierarchy so let's look at each of those
really quickly so let's click on this
one it's just going to turn on drill
down mode so now if I go and I click on
target it's going to drill down into
these and if we want to I can then put
product under this
Legend and we can see all of those
things but of course if we go back up
it's going to be all broken up into this
clustered column chart which is more
like
um this which isn't exactly what we were
going for but it works now uh let me get
rid of this I actually want store in the
legend now if we turn that off and we
click it doesn't do that anymore so what
it does now is it just highlights
Walmart it highlights Costco it
highlights Target so we're going to keep
that on uh but we can also do something
called going down in the next level of
hierarchy so let's click on that and so
now this is going to go down to the next
level down to this product level because
that is the next level and now it's
going to show us each of those things
but it's going to have it broken out by
the store and so it's a completely
different visualization but all within
the same Realm of the data that we're
looking at and what we actually care
about so let's go back up in the
hierarchy and then let's use this one
right here which is expand all down one
level in the hierarchy and so this one
is again extremely similar except it
just visualizes it differently and now
what it's doing is Walmart rice Target
dried beans Costco rice so instead of
having an all uh like this one where
it's stacked on top of each other it's
breaking it down individually so this
one column would become three separate
columns now I'm going to minimize this
right here uh I'm actually going to go
back up in the hierarchy just for visual
purposes now I'm going to show you one
more example we're going to use this
apocalypse sales up here and this is one
that I actually use all the time so the
one you've seen you know you'll get
stuff like that especially if you're
working with like sales and stuff but I
work in operations right so I have a lot
of order IDs product IDs stuff like that
now this one this one genuinely I use
quite often I'll have a customer U let's
make it we'll just go like this we have
a customer and we have unit sold and
let's use the customer as the legend so
let's make this one quite a bit
larger and I'll have something like this
and they'll say okay well we want to see
the order ID s that go with it because
we want to know what orders are actually
happening for each of these people
obviously I'm not using this exact data
but very very very similar and all you
have to do is take these order IDs and
slide it right under here under customer
and this visualization right here is
something I've done a thousand times
because what happens is is someone some
stakeholder in our company is saying hey
Alex we want this and we want to know we
want to drill down on this IP address we
want to drill down on this certain
database we want to drill down on
something and we want to see the order
IDs within them so then all you do is
you turn on drill mode or drill down
mode you'll click on it and you can see
every single order ID that's in there
and then they can go and look those up
in their system and resolve them or
whatever they're trying to do with it
and it helps a ton and it's very very
useful this one is extremely applicable
and that's really all drill down is
again you have these different
hierarchies as well um but for different
things it's not as useful as you can see
we also have this hierarchy which again
is not as useful so it just depends on
the data that you're using and how you
want to use this drill down effect but I
promise you that drill down is used all
the time especially when you're giving
presentations where people want to know
more information than just the the
visualization that you're presenting so
I hope that this has been helpful I hope
that you understand drill down a little
bit better if you like this video be
sure to like And subscribe and check out
all my other videos on powerbi thank you
and I'll see you in the next video
[Music]
what's going on everybody welcome back
to the powerbi tutorial Series today
we're going to be taking a look at
conditional
[Music]
formatting now conditional formatting
may sound familiar because we looked at
it in the Excel series and it's very
similar how you use it in Excel versus
how you use it in powerbi conditional
formatting allows you to take a table or
a matrix within powerbi and use those
cells to color code them and create
gradients and different visualizations
within the actual table or Matrix I'm
excited to start this one so let's jump
over my screen and get started with the
tutorial all right so before we get
started if you want to use the data that
we're using in this video you can find
it in the description on my GitHub now
conditional formatting is super simple
and you've most likely used it in Excel
before but you can also use it in
powerbi and let me show you how to do
that so the first thing we're going to
do is come over over to our apocalypse
store and we're going to pull up our
product name as well as the price and
what we can do is come over here and
we're going to go to price and it has to
be under the columns so you can't come
over here and do this we're going to
come right over here to price and we're
going to right click and let's go to
conditional formatting and we have
background color font color icons and
web URL let's take a look at background
color first this is most likely the one
that we'll look at the most so we're
going to get this pop up and I'm going
to slide this over now there's a lot of
different things we can customize in
here and the first thing I want to take
a look at is format style we have the
gradient and what it's going to say is
the lowest value will be this color
highest value will be this color it'll
give us this gradient color scale and so
we'll use that in just a little bit but
we can also create rules kind of like an
if statement and if it is between this
range and this range we give it a color
and if it's between a different range
and a different range we'll give it a
different color so we'll also try that
one and then we have this field value uh
and this one is one that uh honestly I
don't use that much I've used it maybe
once and what you can do is select a
text field like customer and you can do
some summarizations on the first and
last and that is it so what we're going
to do is we're going to look at gradient
specifically for not the customer but
we're going to go back to the apocalypse
store and we're going to do it on the
price now what I'm going to do is keep
it as the count because this is what the
default is and we're going to go back
and fix it later but what we want our
lowest value to be is this bright green
showing that this it's a cheap product
it's easy to purchase the high value
ones are going to be just the shade of
red more expensive and we'll do it on
the count now remember the count is on
each of these and we're not doing a
count of how many are sold we're doing a
count of each product so it's just one
per row so it all should be the same
color let's take a look so it is all the
same color but what we really want to
show is the actual price not just the
count of the price so let's go back to
conditional formatting we're going to
click the background color again and
this time we're going to change the
summarization now you can do sum you can
do average minimum maximum it really
doesn't matter for this example the
number is the same regardless of really
which one we choose so we can just
choose the minimum and it's going to
choose the minimum of each row which is
the price so we're just going to select
minimum for this example we'll select
okay and it should correct it
accordingly which means the bright green
is the lowest and it goes all the way up
to the highest which is the red now
let's go over here to apocalypse sales
we'll add in the units
sold and let's move that out a little
bit and I'm doing that on purpose
because we're about to look at something
within the conditional formatting so
let's go to unit sold and we'll look at
the conditional formatting for this one
now if you noticed we now have a new one
on here called data bars now we're able
to see data bar bars on unit sold and
not price because unit sold is something
like a sum an average something that's
aggregated but let's take a look at
datab bars because I want to show you
how to use this and then we'll go back
to the background color so for data bars
we are going to taking a look at the
lowest to the highest value again we're
going to go from bright green all the
way
to this exact red it's going to be from
left to right and what it's going to
show you is if it is a positive number
which all of these are is going to be a
green bar basically representing the
number that you see in here along this
line so let's click
okay and we're going to be able to see
the highest numbers and let's scooch
this over quite a bit so you can kind of
get a better understanding and we're
going to do it from highest to lowest so
we sold the most multi-tool survival
knives at 477 and so this entire bar
this row is entirely filled up or almost
all the way filled up while as it gets
lower and as we sell only 182 solar
battery flashlights the bar is going to
represent that and show that now I'm
about to completely mess up this
visualization on purpose because it's
about to get very messy to show you that
you can do a little bit too much uh it
is possible what we're going to do is
we're going to go right over here to
this background color unit sold and
instead of gradient let's look at rules
now with the price we just did a
gradient scale but we can do basically
groups of these and say if a number is
greater to or equal than this number
then it's going to be a certain color
and then if it's in a different range we
can give it a different color so we're
going to say if it's greater than or
equal to zero and we're going to say
number not percent and if it's less than
266 because we have 265 right here let's
make it a nice uh like gold a beautiful
lovely mustard gold just just great now
we're going to say if it's greater than
or equal to we'll do 260 6 6 because
this is less than 266 so it should be
greater than or equal to 266 number and
if it is less than we'll say
500 now we want to do this one and we'll
give it uh let's do like a peach and
we'll click okay and now we have another
conditional formatting on top of that
that can give us more information now
again you should not do this it's just
too many now let's go one step further
and make it even more ridiculous and
show you one more thing before I show
you how you may actually want to use
this uh let's go back to unit sold we're
going to rightclick go to conditional
formatting and you can do something
called icons um font color is the exact
same thing as background color except it
changes the the font and so I'm not
really going to look into that one icons
are very simple extremely similar to
Excel and how you've seen them and the
rules that you can apply to them are
basically the same as if you're doing
like a gradient and it's these if
statements that we saw before now it
Auto gives us this right here which
basically says 0 to 33% 33 to 67 67 to
100 if it's in the bottom 3% it gives us
this red the middle is yellow and the
top is green so we can go through and
change all of this but honestly this
looks pretty good so let's click on
it and so the ones that are our least
sellers are these red ones right here
and the top sellers are up here now this
is just based on unit sold and this
looks absolutely terrible so let's kind
of take this exact information but make
it a little bit better so we're going to
create a new visualization or at least a
new table so let's click on product name
and we'll take the price unit sold and
revenue and what I think makes the most
sense for looking at revenue is these
data bars right here but there's only
one problem I can't do that because it's
not summarized like unit sold was but
what I can do is to get that those data
bars is I can come right down here
instead of saying don't summarize I can
summarize it and I can just click the
sum so it now was summarized it's the
exact same number but if I right click
on here as sum of Revenue I go to
conditional formatting I can now use
those data bars and so we're going to
use those data bars and we're going to
say for the lowest value and the highest
value and let's just make it a
nice maybe a darker green I don't want
it to well that's that's hideous let's
make it this color right here a nice
dark green and there's no negative so it
doesn't really matter we're going to go
left to right and you can show the bar
only but we're going to keep it because
I want to see it and we're going to go
just like this we're going to
order and this is pretty telling um
honestly I did not think the
weatherproof jackets were performing so
well but I mean they are by far a number
one seller so you know our weatherproof
jackets multitool survival knives and
the nylon rope are perform outperforming
all of our other products so those my
might be the ones that I focus on the
most while duct tape the n95 masks and
waterproof matches I mean those are
those are garbage so I might be looking
to replace those in the near future with
some other items that might sell a
little bit better so that's how you use
conditional formatting and it's actually
pretty useful there are a lot of times
where I've done something like this in
an actual visualization for work and it
looks something like this it just
depends on what you're visualizing but
this is very much a simple thing that
you can do to just add a little bit more
information and and actual visual
to this little chart or table that
you're going to create sometimes it's
just better to have these simple
visualizations on this table rather than
just having the numbers themselves makes
it a little bit more easy to read and
understand so again I hope that this was
helpful thank you guys so much for
watching I really appreciate it if you
like this video be sure to like And
subscribe and check out all my other
videos on powerbi and I'll see you in
the next
[Music]
video
what's going on everybody welcome back
to the powerbi tutorial Series today
we're going to be taking a look at bins
and
[Music]
lists now bins and list are really
useful because they allow you to group
things together to analyze and visualize
them easier so in this tutorial I'll
show you how to create your bins and
lists and then we'll create some
visualizations to show you how it can be
helpful so without further Ado let's
jump on my screen start with a tutorial
all right so before we get started I
wanted to let you know you can go and
download the data that we're going to be
using in this tutorial in the
description below is on my GitHub so we
are going to be looking at bins and
lists today um and for this we're going
to be going over here to this apocalypse
sales uh and let's open up our data
right over here and we want to look at
apocalypse sales really quickly I feel
like more people would know what a bin
is so we'll kind of start with a list
just go a little bit backwards than we
normally would uh I'm going to use this
customer or we're going to use this
customer column right here for a list
really quickly and you can do that in
two ways you can come up here and you
can right click on the customer and go
to new group or you can come over here
under this uh the Field section on the
far right and go to customer rightclick
and click new group so let's click on
that
now and right now is only giving us the
list type it's not giving us bins
because bins have to be numeric so we
really can't do that at the moment um so
we're going to call this just customer
groups just or or we'll actually call it
list just so it's easier to recognize
when we create it and so all we're going
to do is we're going to basically group
these but it's going to be called a list
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to select and we're going to
select and we're going to say group and
click on this group button and then it
creates this Alex the analyst apocalypse
Preppers and uh this prep for anything
prepping store so that it kind of named
it for us but if we double click on it
then we can rename this and we can call
this the best prepping
stores and then we have these last two
and we can we can click on one and then
click control and click on the other one
so we get both of them and then we can
click group and we can call this and
we'll double click and we'll call this
the worst prepping stores
um and then that's it and that's all we
have to do and what we're then going to
do and if you want to undo this and you
want to switch it up and do whatever you
can click on group but we're not going
to do that we're going to click
okay and here is the column that it
created and it basically tells us what
list we put it in if it's Uncle Joe's
Prep shop that's in the worst prepping
stores list and if it's the Alex the
analyst apocalypse Preppers that is in
the best prepping stores so it's kind of
like an if statement you could even
create a calculated column do it on this
customer create an if statement this is
just a lot faster and a lot easier than
doing that but it basically would do the
exact same thing now you can use lists
as well on things like numeric so let's
say we have order
ID and we'll go to new group and it's
going to Auto go to bin because
typically that's what you'll use but you
can do list as well and let's say you
know we want to say we want to call
these like we'll group these and call
these the
first um we'll call this the first
customers or the first orders because
we're looking at order IDs look at the
first orders and then we will go back
here we're going on the left side we're
going to click oops we're going to go
back to the top we're going to hit shift
group all of these and we'll say the
latest
orders and you absolutely can do this um
again this is kind of like an if
statement right so you're saying if it
falls between this range and this range
then it's called the first orders and if
it's between this range and this other
range it's the latest orders um again
it's just a much simpler version of an
if statement and so you don't have to
write it all out you can just have this
user interface kind of do it for you uh
and and it's really really useful so now
let's talk about bins and by far the
easiest way to demonstrate this and I'll
show you one other way uh but by far the
easiest ways to show this is by using
age and so uh for absolutely no reason
whatsoever these customer IDs uh who are
right here in this customer information
they decided to give us some of their
buyer information who are actually
buying their products on their website
or in their store they just decided to
give it to us as well as some uh simple
demographic information I I don't know
why but what we're going to use bins for
is grouping these age brackets so you
know you might be interested in say well
I want to know if my core population who
are buying my products are within a
certain range and you don't want to look
look at every single age because then it
just you know in your visualizations
it's not going to look right you want to
kind of group them make it easier to
visualize so what we're going to do is
we're going to go through here and we're
going to basically go by tens so 10 20
30 40 50 60 and see what age bracket
these people fall in so we're going to
go to age we're going to right click and
we're going to say new group and we're
going to go to bin and we'll leave it as
a default age bins um and you can do two
things you can do the size of the bins
which splits it uh uh which splits it by
this number right here or you can go
based on the number of bins so if you
only want to do five different bins
it'll calculate that for you and it'll
say okay if you only want five bins
you're going to have to do it at 12.2 if
you want 10 bins it can be 6.1 but it is
completely up to you on how you want to
do that um you can do the size and we'll
just say every 10 which is what we're
going to do or you can go through and
then you can create you know the how
many many bins you actually want so
let's go ahead and click okay and it's
going to create those bins for us so if
somebody is 78 they're going to be in
the 70s bin if somebody's 41 they'll be
in the 40 bin if somebody is 29 they'll
be in the 20 bin and so on and so forth
so when we go to visualize this we don't
have you know 71 72 73 74 have a lot
more things on our visualization it'll
just be the 70 or it'll just be the 20
now we can also use bins on dates as
well so let's go back to apocalypse
sales we have this date purchase so we
can create a bin for this as well so
let's go to date purchased let's go new
group now you can also create a list and
that's totally fine if you would like to
do that um and it would look kind of
like this where you can go through and
you can select it and you can say okay
this group all these dates you can group
those and say this is going to be
January uh and you can do that and
that's totally okay um but for this one
we're going to do bins I think it's a
little bit easier to do bins because
what we can do is go right here and we
can specify if we want seconds minutes
hours days months or years and so um for
the data that we have it goes January
February and March so we're going to do
months and we're going to say the bin
size is going to be one month so each
month should have its own bin so it'll
be three bins total so we're going to
select
okay and as you can see on this right
side we have January of 2022 and that
correlates to the January over here then
it goes down to February and then it
goes down to March and then when we
visualize this uh we don't have to do
this the hierarchy stuff that we do in
here where we filter it down down to
months we can just use this right here
and that will be our month's column so
now let's go over to our visualizations
and we'll see how this looks really
quickly we're not going to look at all
of them but we will take a look at few
of them so the first one that we can
look at is age so let's look at the
buyer ID and then we'll do age as well
and so let's spread this
out and we can see our distribution of
our buyers so it looks like we have very
few uh who are in the 10 range thank
goodness and we can even put the age
right under here under the age bins and
we have this now we kind of have this
drill down and so if we go right here
and we drill down right there this will
actually give us the breakdown so this
is what it would have kind of looked
like our visualization would have looked
like if we had just kept it the age cuz
now we're drilling down into the age and
so it looks like we have one 18-year-old
and maybe a 20-year-old as well um let's
go back up yeah so it looks like we only
have one buyer ID yes so there's only
one 18year old so of legal age to start
buying you know all these prepping
equipment and probably uh buying online
and stuff like that which makes sense
right so uh this gives you kind of a
quick breakdown in the bins rather than
um doing it the alternative way so now
let's take a look at the customer list
as well as the unit sold and it looks
like the best prepping store uh is
actually performing much worse
surprisingly uh than the worst prepping
store and so I hope this gave you a
really good idea of how to use bins and
lists within powerbi thank you so much
for watching if you like this video be
sure to like And subscribe and check out
all my other videos on powerbi I'll see
you in the next
[Music]
video
what's going on everybody welcome back
to the powerbi tutorial Series today
we're going to be taking a look at all
types of
[Music]
visualizations now when you're working
in powerbi there are a lot of different
options to create visualizations and you
may not always be sure which one to use
and so that's what this video is for I'm
going to walk you through a lot of the
visualizations that I like and I use a
lot as well as kind of point out some of
the ones that I don't like as much so
that you get kind of a feel for the ones
that I think are really popular and that
are used the most so without further Ado
let's jump into powerbi and start taking
a look all right before we jump into it
there is a link in the description where
you can get the data that we're going to
be using for these visualizations if you
want to practice them yourself before we
actually get into it we do need to
combine this and if you download that
Excel and you see this you'll have to do
the same thing all we have to say is
that this product ID is the same as this
product ID purchased and now we are good
to go do one to many and it's okay if
it's one way so right over here under
this visualizations tab there are lots
of different options and it can be a
little bit overwhelming you don't really
know which one to choose there are some
in here that I have almost never used
for my job ever so I'll Point those out
as we go through but the main focus is
going to be focusing on the ones that I
do use that I have used and showing you
how to actually create that
visualization Maybe spice it up just a
little bit but we have a lot of them to
go through so let's jump right into it
and the very first one that we're going
to start with probably the easiest one
and the one that you'll recognize the
most is a stacked bar chart and what we
going to do is go ahead right over here
to the product name and we want this
unit sold as well so we're going to
click product name and it's going to go
straight into the Y AIS for us and then
we're going to click unit sold and that
will go into the x-axis automatically it
just kind of intuitively knows but
sometimes it will make a mistake and
then you can just fix it or flip it and
we do want this uh let me make this much
larger we do want this to be a little
bit more colorcoded that is what this
Legend is down here so what we're going
to do is drag this product name down to
the legend and now we have each product
as its own
color and in previous videos we have
gone through and looked at some of these
Visual and general options that you have
when you're actually creating these
visualizations but we're going to do
some of them while we're in here as well
so we're just going to go down here
we're going to choose data labels and
we're going to shrink that and if you go
higher the higher you go the less you
see so if you want all of them all the
way down to the green we're going to go
right about there and we're going to
make it smaller so now we can go ahead
and click anywhere outside of that
visualization and now we can create a
new one if we had just kept it like this
where we were still interacting with
this visualization and we clicked on a
different one it would have then changed
our visualization completely which we
don't want so let's hit contrl Z click
out of it and now we can create a new
one let's go right over here to this
100% stacked column chart I'm going to
click on it drag it over here and make
it much larger and we're going to come
right over here to this customer
information and we're going to click on
customer and then we're going to go up
to unit sold and click on unit sold and
we want to break these out and so
basically what this is doing is it's
breaking it out by each of these shops
and we can see the total of what they're
buying the units sold but we want to see
exactly what products make up this
percentage of this 100% so we're going
to go right over here to product name
we're going to drag that down to the
legend and as you can see now we have
each of these products and each of the
products is up here so this backpack we
can see the backpack right here backpack
right here and right here and we can see
which customer is buying what percentage
of their purchases so for this prep for
anything prep store they have a very
large percentage 40% is duct tape so
they're buying a lot of duct tape so
really quickly we're able to see what
clients are purchasing or which clients
are purchasing what products the most so
just like this Alex analyst apocalypse
Preppers they're buying a lot of water
purifiers we like drinking clean water
um you know that's just what my audience
likes and so you know we can easily get
a quick glance of that again we're going
to go in here I tend to like putting
these data labels on here that's just
what I preference
so you know something like this it looks
nice it looks clean um we can always go
back and change these names which we'll
do for this one so we're going to go
over here go to title we'll go down to
the text and we'll do
customer
oops customer purchase oh jeez
breakdown pretend I'm really good at
spelling and we're going to do it just
like that we'll get out of there so now
we have customer purchase breakdown and
that looks really nice it's a good uh a
good visualization and we're going to
bring that right over here we're going
to have a lot on the screen so I may
have to uh make them smaller or larger
to fit
everything all right so let's go on to
our next one another really common
visualization is this one right here
which is the line chart and the line
chart is great especially when you're
using things like dates I have found
this one to be the best best and a lot
of people use this as well so we're
going to go right over here and click on
date purchased and then units sold and
on the x-axis you can see it's broken up
by year quarter month and day so we
don't want to do it that high level we
only have three months of data in here
so we're going to get rid of the year
we're going to get rid of the quarter
and then we at least have this and let's
break it out because right now we're
looking at all of the units sold so
we're going to drag the product name
right down here to the legend and now it
breaks it out by the actual product and
for each month in January February or
March you can follow these products and
see how they did in each of those months
and if we wanted to we can come right
over here to the filter on the product
name and we could filter it by maybe the
top three so let's do multi-tool
survival knife the nylon rope and the
duct tape and we can have it just like
this and you know you can do those for
any product that you want but again we
just want to do it for those three just
for an example and that really doesn't
give us a ton of information we could
even go down to the day and you know it
might give us a little bit more
information and so we'll keep it like
that and we can go over here change the
name as well we're not going to do this
for all of them again we're just looking
at the different types of visualizations
I think are really good to know but
we'll change this one as well to
products
purchased by
date we'll keep it just like that again
nothing fancy we're just trying to look
at a bunch of different stuff so let's
put this over here down here now let's
click out of there and there are other
ones in here um that are definitely
useful and you absolutely can use um
like this one is a stacked bar chart
this one is a stacked column chart it's
basically the same thing just a
different orientation like we went to
here it's just a different orientation
it's the same thing um just like this
clustered bar chart custom column chart
it's just its orientation either
horizontal or
vertical then we have things like an
area chart uh stacked area chart not
really things that I've used too much in
previous positions one that I have use
though is a line and clustered column
chart so it kind of combines a few of
these with you know you have these bar
charts as well as line charts into one
visualization so let's look at this one
because this is one that I have used
several times in my actual job so for
our x axis we'll use the product name
then we'll look at something like the
price and so let's make this a lot
larger so you can actually see it so now
we have the price and now we can look at
something like the production cost and
that can
be our line ya AIS so now we're looking
at the price of it how much someone is
actually paying for it and then we're
looking at how much it's costing us to
actually produce that product and so
really quickly at a glance you can kind
of see that it's around the halfway to
2/3 point on most of these you can see
that the production cost is always lower
than the actual price because of course
we're out here to make a profit on these
products so let's minimize this one
we're going to put this one right down
here let's make it even smaller let's
click out of that and the next one that
we're going to take a look at is a
scatter chart so let's click on that and
make it much larger
oops there we go so let's use the price
and the production cost again and so our
x axis is the price our y y AIS is the
production cost but now we need to fill
in this values right here so let's go
over here and click on the product name
and drag that into values and so now we
have our values we just don't know what
they are but we can see it so let's drag
this down to Legend as well and it
breaks it out and we kind of have this
scatter plot and you know for this fake
data that we're using it doesn't really
show a lot U but if you're using real
data you can definitely find outliers
and Trends and patterns using this type
of visualization let's go ahead and make
that one small as well drag it right
down into the
corner now let's go right over here and
we have the the dreaded pie charts um
and dut chart now look I think it's kind
of a joke in the data analyst Community
about pie charts and doughnut charts but
at the same time people use them and
they request them and so sometimes
you're going to use it whether you like
it or not so let's click on the dut
chart and let's make this one a lot
larger and let's go over here and let's
click on
State and we're also going to click on
total purchased and that's really all
you have to do these ones are pretty
straightforward you can change a few
different things like where these labels
are if you want them inside you can also
do that and that would look totally fine
um again I'm just not a super huge fan
but you will get this one requested
people like this and want to see it and
the reason a lot of analysts don't like
using this is because when you start
glancing at these it's really hard to
tell the difference between these sizes
if you look at something like this you
can easily see that this is larger like
if you're looking at this one the
multi-tool survival knife is obviously
the longest and it gets shorter shorter
shorter shorter but when you start
getting in here it's really hard to
approximate the size I would not be able
to tell the difference between this 5.63
5.78 two uh 7.72 I would not be able to
tell really the difference between these
or or kind of the the difference between
them very easily that's why a lot of
people don't want to use them in general
so again I want to show you this one
because I think it's worth noting and
worth knowing how to use but I don't
really push people towards this because
I don't think it's the best
visualization available most of the time
all right the next two are super easy
but are used all the time uh maybe more
than some of these even but they're just
so easy to use so I'm kind of saved them
for last this one is the card and all
the card is is it displays one number or
multiple numbers if you want to use a
multi- card but we'll just look at the
card for now all we're going to look at
is the total purchased and it's just
going to display it just like this and
you can make it as large or as small as
you'd like and normally it goes on like
the top and you'll put card here a card
here um just for example I'll kind of
show you how this might look so it look
something like this right and at the top
it'll have different usually High
overarching information and this is
super common to see and I'm sure if
you've looked at other people's
visualization you'll see something like
this this is usually totals or averages
or something like that in here where
it's super easy to look at so like right
here this is total purchased and we can
go in and look at the minimum and then
we can go over here and this one can be
account and so it gives us a lot of
information just at a really quick
glance and then we have all of our more
in-depth colorful visualizations that
kind of have more information than just
a single piece like the card does and
then the very last one that I'm going to
show you is this one right here which is
the table and this one is obviously
extremely popular it's like an little
Excel table and we can go in here and we
can get the customer wherever that is
and then we'll also get the unit sold
and this is what it looks like and it's
super easy and oftentimes you'll have it
like on the side as well uh and all the
other visualizations over here and so
you know if we're going to take all
these visualizations and pretend they
were like a real thing you know there's
a lot in here but we'll just kind of
really quickly do this um you know we
might have something like this and we'll
make this larger and make this
wider and you know we have a lot of
information just in here and this is not
a project so don't go put this on your
portfolio I'm just threw a ton of random
visualizations on you know this
dashboard but you can already see a lot
of these you most likely have seen in
other people's work in other people's
visualizations on LinkedIn or on YouTube
these are very common very very popular
and again we did not go through all of
the ones over here there are maps that
you can use but I haven't used Maps ever
in my job there are things like gauges
and decomposition trees and waterfall
charts and uh tree maps and all these
different things but I really have never
used those in my actual job and I don't
see them a lot in others people's work
either otherwise I would be telling you
to learn these and use these but again
try them out see which ones you like if
you like this video be sure to like And
subscribe below and go check out all the
other powerbi tutorial videos that I
have on my channel and I will see you in
the
[Music]
next what's going on everybody welcome
back to the powerbi tutorial Series
today we are going to be working on our
final
project
now this is our final project of the
powerbi tutorial Series so if you have
not watched all of those videos leading
up to this I recommend going and
watching those videos so you can make
sure that you know all the things that
we're going to be looking at in today's
project I am really excited to work on
this project with you because I think it
is a really good one and it uses real
data that we collected about a month ago
where I took a survey of data
professionals and this is the raw data
that we're going to be looking at and so
I think it's just really interesting
that we collected our own data and now
we're using for a project we're going to
transform the data using power query and
then we're actually create the
visualizations and finalize the
dashboards as well as create a theme and
a different color scheme to kind of make
it a little bit more unique without
further Ado let's jump onto my screen
and get started with the project all
right so before we jump into it I wanted
to let you know that you can get the
data below it is on my GitHub you can go
and download this exact file that we're
going to be looking at now in the past
several projects we have been using this
fake apocalypse data set you know it was
fun it was you know what whatever this
data set is real this is a real data set
it was a survey that I took from data
professionals I posted on LinkedIn and
Twitter and all these other places and
we had about 600 700 people who
responded to the questions so before we
actually get into it and start cleaning
the data and doing all this stuff in
powerbi I just wanted to show you the
data all right so this is the CSV that I
downloaded from the survey website that
I used and this is completely raw data I
haven't done anything to it at all let's
go through the data really quickly and
we'll kind of see what we have and we
are not going to make any changes at all
in Excel we're going to do all of our
Transformations or at least a few
transformations in powerbi because again
this is a powerbi tutorial and project
so I want you to kind of learn how to
use that and not use Excel because you
can go through my Excel tutorial if you
want to do that so let's just look at it
in Excel and then we'll move it over to
powerbi and actually start transforming
the data so we have this unique ID these
are all the people that actually took it
oops don't want to do that we have an
email which this was completely
Anonymous I didn't collect any data or
user data on this then we have the date
Taken um and let's get into the actual
good information then we have all of
these questions so we have question one
which title fits you best and they can
choose things now uh let's add a filter
really quickly that we can look at this
now you had the pre-selected ones which
were like data analyst architect
engineer but then there was an option
where you could say other and you could
spe specify what that was so if you look
in here we're going to have all these
different other please specify with
different titles right and there were a
lot of them now typically what you want
to do is really clean this up and we're
not going to be doing a ton ton ton of
data cleaning but we are going to do
some in powerbi but none in here but
typically with this amount of data and
the way that it's formatted we would do
so much data cleaning um with this one I
mean I mean there is a lot of work to be
done um like this current year salary
this is one that I would absolutely be
cleaning up because it's ranges and it
has a dash and a k and and all these
numbers this is something that I would
be cleaning up and using but we're not
going to be cleaning this up right now
so anyways let's just get into it let's
see what questions we asked uh we have
the yearly salary what industry do you
work in favorite programming
language then there were a lot of
different options this is like one
question where they picked multiple
options so is how happy are you in your
current position with the following you
have your salary work life
balance um then we have co-workers
management upward Mobility learning new
things um and they could rank it from
zero to 10 so some people ranked upward
Mobility a 10 some ranked it a zero or a
one um and again they can answer however
they want how difficult was it to break
into Data very very difficult very easy
um if you're looking for a new job we
have you know what would you be looking
for remote work better salary Etc we
have male female which country you from
and then this is more like demographics
so if you're a male how old you are and
this was in a Range so this is like a a
a sliding bar so you could slide it to
the exact age you had there's some
people who are apparently 92 um which if
that's true I mean good for you man or
woman actually really quickly I'm going
to see just just while we're here I'm
going to see if this is a male male or a
female oh it's a female from India very
cool um so we have all this information
and it is a lot of information when you
have something like this I mean there is
so much data cleaning that can be done I
mean I already see like 20 plus
different things that I would need to do
to make this a lot better um and we also
have date Taken and the time taken as as
well as how long it they took on it like
the time spent really just really
interesting data but again this is a
beginner tutorial Series this is the
beginner project so we're not going to
get do anything too crazy I will be
using this exact data set in a future
video doing a lot more data cleaning and
creating a much more advanced
visualization with what we have and what
we're looking at right here but for this
video we're just going to be doing a
pretty simple visualization and D
dashboard that you can use uh to
practice with or put on your portfolio
if you know that's where you're at right
now so let's get out of here and let's
put this into powerbi so let's exit out
and let's come right over here to import
data from Excel we'll click on powerbi
final project and
open give that a second doing this all
in real time we only have the one so
we'll do be we won't be practicing any
joins or anything but we're not going to
load it we're going to transform this
data so let's put it into to power query
editor and now we have all of our data
in here and it should look extremely
familiar now when I'm looking at this
when I start looking at this information
I kind of need to know beforehand what I
want to get out of this do I need to
clean every single column do I just need
to clean a few of them do I need to get
rid of columns that's kind of where my
head's at and so right off the bat I can
already tell you that there are columns
that we can just delete to get out of
our way so we're going to do that at the
beginning so that we don't have to do
that later on or they're just in our way
so I'm going to click on browser and
then I'm going to hit shift and I'm
going to go over here to
refer and I'm just going to go up here
to remove columns and everything that we
do is going to go over here to this
applied steps if you've been following
this series um you know we can remove
things add things but anything we do
will show up right over here so we can
track it and go back if we need to now
one column that I know for sure that I'm
going to be using quite a bit is this
which title fits you best in your
current role because I I specifically
wanted to do a breakdown of different
people's roles and how much they make
and different stuff like that so I know
that I want to use this but as we saw
before there's kind of the issue is is
it's not very clean right it has data
analyst data architect engineer
scientist databased developer and then
like a hundred different options and
then a student or or none of these right
um and so for the purpose of this video
right here we are not going to take
every single one of these options
because this involves a lot more data
cleaning let me give you an example this
says software engineer this also says
software engineer and with AI these two
would typically be combined or
standardized to software engineer but
it's not very easy to do that in powerbi
we could do that in Excel but not really
in powerbi or even SQL if we pull this
from a SQL database um and you can find
lots of different you know options of
that we have data manager and data
manager if we separated these out these
would be different options when we
created our visualizations and we don't
want that so what we are going to do uh
and this is going to be kind of a an
easy way out to just make sure that this
is pretty clean and doesn't we don't
have a thousand different options we're
going to create this to other so we're
to simplify this a lot and then we're
going to use this so we'll have maybe
six or seven options instead of the you
know let's say 50 that we would have if
we actually did the harder work which
just break it out standardize it and
clean it up that way so what we're going
to do is we're going to click on this
right here and we're going to go up here
to split column in this ribbon up top
we'll go to split
column and we want to do it by a
delimiter and if you notice let me see
if I can move this over if you notice we
have other and then we have this
parenthesis and in no other option or
way is there parenthesis so what we're
going to do is we're going to use a
custom and we're use this open
parenthesis what that's going to do is
it's going to separate it by this
parenthesis it's going to leave the
other it's going to create separate
columns um just one separate column for
each of these and we can do that at each
occurrence or we can do the leftmost and
we really we only need it for the
leftmost because there's only one of
these uh left-handed or left-sided uh
brackets or or what is it whatever this
is called and then let's go and click
okay and it should create another column
so it's going to have 0.1 Point 2 and
now we have if we click on this now we
only have these options we have analyst
architect engineer data scientist
database developer other and student
looking or none that is what we want it
makes it so much simpler and it's not
perfect but again I'm trying to show you
what we are able to do in powerbi so now
we're just going to remove that column
and we're going to go and do the exact
same thing to this one as well because I
know that we want to use this and I
really wanted to use this one as well
but if we look at this one also um
there's a lot so I said what is your
favorite programming language and people
there were pre-selected answers like
JavaScript Java C++ python R things like
that and then there was an other option
and in this other option I mean it was
free text so they can fill it in as they
want I mean there's four five six
different ways that people put SQL that
is something I would standardize and you
know that would be the way I cleaned it
but that's not how we did it in here so
we're going to do the same thing we're
going to keep that other so we're going
to split this column again we're use a
delimiter and for this delimiter though
we're going to use a colon so we're
going to say we're going to do a colon
right there we'll just do the leftmost
we'll click okay and then we have our
options and it's much simpler now I
really would have rather kept all these
and because sql's in there quite a bit
but you know a lot of people don't think
SQL is even a programming language so uh
we're going to delete that column now
one that I just skipped and I kind of
wanted to go back to is this current
yearly salary I really want to use this
let's see if we can use it I here's what
I want to do with it and this is not
perfect um for this video I want to try
it what I want to do is break up these
numbers 106 125 and then take the
average of those numbers so then we'll
use some docks in there so we'll take
106 125 create that into two separate
columns then we'll create a third column
that will give us the average of those
two numbers so we'll do 106 plus 125
divided by two and then we'll have the
average of that now that is not perfect
but it's going to give us at least you
know an average of kind of roundabout
number because they gave us this range
they said my salary is between 106 and
125,000 so if we say that their salary
was
112,000 at least gives us it makes it
usable it's a numeric value instead of
being this which is text which we really
we could use and and I'll show you how
to do that because we're going to keep
this column I'll create a copy of this
and I'll show you the difference between
this and using the average but for but
for this data cleaning portion let's
just try it let's see what we can do and
see if we can make it work so first
let's create a duplicate so we're going
to uh duplicate the column so now we
have this copy at the very very end and
we can use this one instead of having to
use the original way way way back here
so we're going to leave that one how it
is and we're going to use this one so
let's go ahead and split this one up
we're going to click on the column
header then we're going to click on
split column and we'll do it by digit to
non-digit and if you look at it right
here it's broken it out kind of um in
the fact that now in this one we just
have numeric values and in this one we
have k- numeric or just Dash numeric and
now this can be easily cleaned whereas
this one we can just completely get rid
of because it's only K so we'll just
remove that column and then in this one
we're going to rightclick we're going to
click on replace values and so if it
just has we're just do a k we'll replace
with nothing we'll do okay and then for
the last one we'll go to replace values
and we'll do the dash or the minus sign
and we'll place that with nothing and so
now we have our values as well oh we
also have a plus let me get rid of that
because that's when some people had 250
or 225,000 plus so for that one the
average is just going to be 225 we'll
have to specify that in our dock I
forgot but actually if somebody has
225 let me find this plus really quick
uh let me filter by it because that's a
lot faster what we actually want to do
for the purpose of this one is we want
to put 225 here so that when we do 225
plus 225 divide by two it comes out to
225 that's just what we're going to put
it as and there's only two people so uh
I'm actually going to replace this I'm
going to do replace values I'm G to say
Plus
with
225 and we'll click okay awesome we can
unfilter these select all so we're going
to go right up here to add column we're
going to say custom
column and we're going to go right over
here actually let's make it uh
average salary let's make it average
salary so we're going to insert this I'm
going to
say parentheses and we're going to say
plus this
insert and close the parenthesis divided
by two and it says no syntax errors have
been detected let's click on okay and
it's giving us an error so it's saying
we cannot apply operator plus to types
text and text which makes perfect sense
these aren't uh numbers so let's make it
a whole number and let's make it a whole
number and then let's see if this will
actually work
no or maybe we just need to try a whole
another one so let's try transform or
add column custom
column let's try this all again see if
uh I can make it
work
insert do this
one
plus this
one and we'll do divid by two and let's
try this one and there we go so now
let's get rid of this column
columns and we can actually remove these
ones as
well because now we have this
um average salary
column which when we look at this or
when we use this uh we can let me see if
I can just move this way way way over
all right I might cut because this is
taking forever so if you take the
average of these two numbers you'll get
53 if you take the average of 0 and 40
you'll get 20 so now we have this
average salary and again when we get to
the actual visualization part I'll show
you why this isn't as useful as having
this average salary and just a reminder
this is not perfect uh I wouldn't
typically do this especially if I had it
in Excel or if I was you know creating
this survey in a different way I would
probably have a very specific value
where they could do it on a slider but
this is how it is so we've at least made
it usable or more usable in my mind and
we have a few other things that we can
change like what industry do you work in
where we can break this one out so I'm
going to go ahead and break this one out
as well
as this one right here which country do
you live in I'm going to break bro both
of those out to where it's the country
or other I'm not going to have these
other values although there are a lot of
them because there's a lot of people who
live in these different countries but we
can't really do that super well in here
because again the same issue kept
happening Argentina Argentina Argentine
a Australia so we can't normalize those
values unless we spend just a copious
amount of time doing that so I'm going
to go ahead and do these I'm going to
fast I'm going to fast speed this so it
goes a lot faster so I'm just going to
go silent and let this happen really
quick and then we'll get to the end and
we'll actually start building our
visualizations all right so we've split
them up and as you can see we have all
the these options as well as other and I
think you know there is let me tell you
there is so much more that we could do
with this I mean just so many other
things but this is like what the bare
minimum of what we need for this project
so let's go ahead and close and apply
this and if we need to come back at any
point and actually fix anything or
change anything we can so it's not like
that's permanent um so as you can see we
have everything over here we have all
our data as it is transformed in here as
well and now we can start building out
our visualization let's go back to our
report and let's start building
something out all right so let's add a
title to our
dashboard we want to make this right at
the
top we call this the
data
professional
survey
breakdown and let's make make that quite
a bit
larger make it bold why not and we'll
put that in the
center and now let's um let's add some
effects let's change that background to
something like it's too dark something
like this and I do not like that Boldt
let's take that
off there we go so something like this
just as a quick title to what we're
about to do what we are about to build
so we're going to start off with the
most simple visualizations that we're
going to do and we'll kind of work our
way towards kind of the harder ones so
the first one that we're going to start
off with is a card and the cards are
obviously like just super super easy
they usually just display one piece of
information so we're going to go right
over here to the very bottom at the
unique ID and we're going to select it
and we're going to say a account of
distinct or account it doesn't matter um
it says 630 count of unique ID now we're
not going to keep that as is we're
actually going to go right over here
we're going to say rename for this
Visual and it says count of unique ID
but we're going to say count
of survey takers and you can say
whatever you want here but in in general
that is what it is we're we're counting
how many people um you know took this
survey and that's just a kind of a total
maybe I should say total amount or of
survey takers but you can say count of
survey takers how many people took this
survey so let's click out of there let's
click on card let's make it about the
same size we're going to drag it up
here and try to make them about the same
we will in a little bit we'll make them
the same size um but for this one we're
going to look at age so we're going to
look at current age so I'm going click
on that and we'll say want the average
age so our average age taker is almost
30 years old so let's go right over here
we're going to say rename for this
visual we'll say a average age of
survey oop this might be too
long average age of survey taker again
name it whatever you'd like so again
these are meant to be highlevel numbers
so when somebody's looking at your
dashboard they can just really quickly
glance at this and know exactly what it
is instead of like some of these other
visualizations that we're about to
create they don't really have to dig
into it look at the x- axis the y axis
the the different uh Legend colors and
whatnot they can just see these high
numbers and get a really quick glance of
the data now let's create our first
visualization and what we're going to do
for that one is a clustered bar chart so
let's go ahead and click on the
clustered bar chart we can create as
small or as large as we'd like and for
this one we're going to be looking at
the job titles now remember we kind of
changed the job titles or you know U
transform those if you want to say that
so we're going to look at Job titles and
then we're going to look at their
average salary and if you remember we
transformed that one as well we have a
average salary now this one is it looks
like a text right now so it may not work
properly and what we're actually going
to do is go over
here I want to see the average
salary so let's click on average salary
and see if we can change this data type
from a text to a decimal number let's
click yes I forgot to do that when we
were transforming it and there we go
this is perfect um so now we can go
back and we can select our average
salary and as you can see it has this um
this function symbol and so now we can
click on it and it'll look a lot better
and although this says average salary as
the title it's actually doing a count or
the sum so we can click average right
here and what we want to do is actually
break this down by the job title and so
now we can see data scientists are
making the most by far far they're
making average of 93,000 at least from
the survey takers that took it then we
have our data Engineers making
65,000 data Architects are making 63 and
then where the data analysts data
analysts are right here making 55 so
again we had 630 people take this survey
and so the vast majority of them were
data analysts so this one's probably the
most accurate out of all of them and I
actually don't like how this looks as
the cluster bar chart let's try the
stocked bar chart and put this as the
legend that's more what I was going for
I don't know I didn't want as skinny
because when you're doing this one it
typically they have multiple options per
um uh x axis and so I think that's why
it was that little skinny line but this
one is more what I was looking for but
let's make that smaller and let's
definitely change that title because
good night um this is like incredibly
long let's go over here to this format
visual ual we'll go to the general the
title and we're just going to say
average salary by job title just like
that and this looks a lot better now
we're not going to kind of format all
our whole dashboard yet we're going to
create our visualizations and then we're
going to kind of organize everything and
kind of play Tetris with it to make it
look the best so we're just going to
minimize this and put it right up here
for now um but we will go back and kind
of make everything look better at the
end and actually while we're here I also
want to change this as well so rename
for this we're going to say job title
Oops why did I do that
job title and for this one we're just
going to
say name average
salary there we go looks much better
much cleaner uh took away a lot of the
anxiety that I was feeling about two
minutes ago when we first put that up
there so let's go on to our second
visualization the next one that I'm
interested in is actually what
programming language people were using
the most so we have salary there's a
thousand different things we can look at
in here but I want to know you know what
is people's favorite programming
language so let's take a look at that so
we have favorite programming language
let's find that so we have our favorite
programming language and we also have
how many people actually took it or the
unique people so right now this is
columns we don't want that let's um
let's do a clustered column chart click
on this right here and it looks
like here we go that is kind of what
we're looking for and instead of count
of unique ID we'll say count
of let's do count of
Voters and for favorite program language
we'll
say favorite oops favorite programming
language and get rid of that as well and
then we're going to go into here also
and change the title and say favorite
programming
languages or favorite pro programming
language just like this now let's make
this a lot bigger so you can see it but
really quickly at a glance you can see
python is by far the most popular are
other C++ JavaScript Java now all we're
seeing is the count so it's all the same
it's just blue we can see how many
people voted for each one but if we
wanted to break it out similar to how we
did with the job titles we could still
do that so all we'd have to do is break
it out uh or bring this job title down
to the legend and now breaks out like
this and that's not exactly what I was
going for I was going more for something
like this where we can see the still the
whole count but now we can see who is
actually V voting for these things so
I'm just not a huge fan of the colors
that are pre-selected here and kind of
the whole theme of this dashboard at the
very end we're going to completely
revamp this change a bunch of colors the
background and make this look a lot
nicer rather than just the white
background like we have it um and so for
now let's
just make this a lot smaller and put it
into this corner these will not be
staying there but we need to we need
room to create our next visualizations
and just just a cleaner space to do
things now the next thing that I really
want to include is a way to break down
where they're from their country because
especially something like salary is very
dependent on your country whereas the
average salary in the United States for
a data analyst may be like 60,000 in
another country it could be 20,000 that
could bring down the average quite a bit
so we need a way to be able to break
that down now we can do something like a
filled map and there's no problem with
that at all um
but you know for what we're building
what we're creating it's not probably
going to work out the best I mean this
looks okay we could stick it in the
corner or something um and you can do
that and that's perfectly fine I think
what I'm going to do is something like a
tree map which I don't use a lot but I
want something where they can just click
on it they can look at the
values
distinct they can look at the values and
just click on it and it'll be right
there for them so they don't have to
filter it out on their own or no
geography and look at this map they can
just read Canada other United Kingdom
India United States and click on that
and so for example let's click over here
on United States the numbers change
quite a bit now the average salary for a
data scientist is
139,000 for data analyst it's 80 and if
we look at India you know the average
salary for a data scientist is 68 the
average salary is 26 for a data analyst
that doesn't mean that they make less
money in India that just means that the
cost of living is probably lower in
India therefore they don't need the
higher US Dollars salary because again
this was all done in US dollars so just
something to think about uh let's click
out of that so we'll keep that one as
well so now let's create our next
visualization and this is one that I do
not get to use enough in my actual job
so we're going to use it in this project
um and it's going to be this gauge right
here so let's add that one put it right
over here we're going to add two of
those let's just go ahead and add
another one while we're at it because
we're going to have them kind of like
right here right next to each other the
first one and these ones are really good
for kind of looking at these kind of
surveys and I don't get to work with
surveys enough but we can see you know
how happy are they in terms of work life
balance so we can add that we're going
to add work life balance um and right
now it's doing a count and we don't have
minimum or maximum values in there yet
so it's going to look kind of weird but
we're going to look at the average rate
or the the average score of these then
we're going to pull this over to the
minimum value and we want to put that at
the minimum and pull this over and add
the maximum value so now it actually has
zero to 10 and it shows that the average
person is happy with which one was this
their average person is happy with their
work life balance uh they rate about a
5.74 overall now let's really quickly
change the title of this because this is
ridiculous I want to say happy with work
life balance
so this is their rating uh you know
change it to whatever title you want
that's what I'm going to do and we'll
also do happy with their salary let's
click on salary We'll add that to
minimum and we'll add the maximum value
as well to make sure that we know how to
use
that and then we'll take the average so
not many people are happy with their
salary I'm just finding out I mean this
is a real survey this is real data so I
mean it's h pretty interesting let's go
to the title let's go to happy with or
maybe it's happiness happiness with
salary maybe that's what we should make
it and I'm going to change that over
here as well I think it sounds better
some of this I've already planned out
some I haven't this is not something
I've planned out so uh so we're going to
say happiness with work life balance
happiness with salary really interesting
um we may go back and tweak these just a
little bit in the future but the very
last visualization that we're going to
do is male versus female kind to got to
have that in there um I don't typically
like pie charts and dut charts but uh
you know I'm feeling I'm just feeling it
so let's try it um and we will
do let see let's make this larger so we
have male
female and what do we want to look at
like what do we want to measure so we
have male versus female we can measure
anything um but maybe what we'll do is
the average salary again I mean we've
kind of only looked at salary once
in this one right here um and a little
bit of like how happy they are but we'll
look at the average salary between males
and females and then we'll look at not
the current age Oops I meant average
salary and then we'll look at the
average and it looks like the average
salary is actually really close versus
males versus females 55 for female
versus 53 for male so actually the
females are a little bit higher
congratulations so they're just a little
bit higher in terms of pay so now we
need to start organizing all of this
cleaning it up making it look a lot
better than it does right now it looks
great uh you know but we can do a lot
more with this so I'm gonna we're we're
going to keep these or all these kind of
over on this left hand side I'm GNA put
this I want this up here we also need to
change that title I want this up here um
and again we're going to kind of change
the theme as we go
I I just want to format it
right we'll have it just like this let's
change the title of
this let's go to title and we're going
to say country of survey
takers uh I'm not the the survey takers
I'm not really stuck on that if you find
something better you think of something
better I would go with that but um you
know it definitely doesn't look bad and
where did this where did my other
visualization go there goes um I think
this one I want to make kind of more
tall um so I might move it this way jeez
this is such a I hate I hate having a
lot of visualizations on here it just
really is annoying to me so what we're
going to do I think we're
gonna step this to the side put this to
the side as
well I want to make it to where it's
just okay I didn't want it to cut
off we'll do that might make these
um make these a little bigger actually
so I want it to kind of match the
size like right there I'll match this
perfect this one I kind of want to bring
over
here and bring it down a little bit
maybe something like
this maybe I'm not sure I'm not I'm not
sold on that um I added a few different
visualizations that I didn't have in my
original so now I'm kind of having to do
this on the fly so I might fast forward
some of the parts where I'm like really
thinking about it or taking too much
time on it but I'm going to bring this
down a little bit actually because I
don't like how close that is to um the
the text above it but one thing we do
need to
do I'm going to put this up kind of like
this I think that looks fine I think I'm
going to put this at the very bottom so
let's make some room for
it all right just like that stretch it
to the side and we'll lower
it and I think we'll keep that as
is kind of like this um okay there's a
lot going on in here and there are some
things I'm just noticing as we're
walking through this that I kind of
missed um like I need to change some
titles and stuff like that so let me go
ahead and change some of those things so
we're going to do
title do average
salary by gender or by
sex do like that average salary by sex I
also don't like that it's in the middle
um I don't like that it's on the outside
I want them on the inside for this so
let's go to the details let's go to
inside and see if that looks any better
oh that looks terrible um let me see if
I can change that maybe I don't no I
definitely want it
um I guess we'll do outside I you can't
even see the information oh the decimal
is crazy long um let me go and see if I
can change that decimal to just like a
whole number or like
1.1 uh because that's a problem so maybe
I need to go over here to the
value all right so I think I want to
change this one it's just not working
out exactly how I wanted and you guys
know if I make mistakes I'm going to
keep it in here so you guys can see it I
I hoped that this was going to turn out
better but it didn't um one that I do
want to add because this is kind of a a
breakdown and a nice visualization I
want to add this difficulty piece so I
want to add this how difficult was it
for you to break into data science let's
get rid of these and I want to click on
this really quickly see what it gives us
um values okay so now this shows us
percentages um of how easy it was again
it's neither easy nor difficult
difficult easy very difficult very easy
these numbers make absolutely no sense
we need to kind of order them a little
better so I'm going to come over here to
slices we have our colors over here we
want very difficult to be like the most
difficult um so we're going to make that
red and then we want difficult to be
maybe like an
orange let see if we can find an orange
there we have an orange this does not
look red enough there we go oh
no no no very difficult is red difficult
is orange we have neither easy nor
difficult and that's kind of a neutral
um let's see if we have something
neutral in
here kind of like this yellow I don't
know let's try it out then we have easy
and very easy and these will be like our
Blues so I'm going to keep that um I'm
going to keep that kind of like a dark
blueish and then our blue for super easy
is just going to be like really blue U
and that doesn't look bad the I mean
look I'm I'm not a color person I I'm
not great with colors and we're going to
kind of organize this in just a little
bit but this looks better to me um but
we need to change up some stuff as well
like the title need to
do difficulty to break into
Data there we go
and we're also going to
change this title right here we're just
say
difficulty difficulty difficulty this
looks better to me um again not perfect
and there's a thousand different things
you could have done but that's just what
we're going to do I need to go through
here and see what I need to change so
right off the bat I can see I need to
change this
um to let's see right here I'm going to
rename this job title just like we did
in this one right here uh count of
Voters that's fine progr language
breaking into difficulty happiness
happiness average count okay okay so
what we have here is very close to a
finished product now it's not 100%
complete I mean I I do want to make it
look a little nicer rather than just the
typical white so what we're gonna do
we're GNA go up here we'll go to uh what
is it View and we have all these
different filters and we're just going
to play around with it see if we can
find something that we like um this
doesn't look too bad it's not really my
style we can do this one Frontier this
is pretty neat I kind of am digging this
we might come back to it I like the
natural tones I don't know why I said
tones like that but I did um this one's
not bad but I don't I don't it's not
that's not my I don't like how dark that
is um and so maybe it's like you know we
change like the background color of all
of these as well as match it with um
match it with something else whatever
you want genuinely you customize this
however you want I kind of like this one
it's kind of groovy man and um it's not
perfect by any means but what we can do
and we can customize this current theme
we can come in here customize this theme
however we'd like I personally don't
want color five which is the data
analyst color I don't like it to I don't
want to go go and change it because I
don't like it but I don't really like
that color per se you know I might want
to choose a different color um but it
has to be like this muted like that it
has a style to it so you can come in
here and you can customize this and make
it however you'd like and and really
mess around with it play play around
with it for me uh I'm just going to keep
it how it is because I don't really want
to mess with it and break it or anything
like that so U let me just put that up
just a tiny bit so this is it this is
the project I hope that it was helpful
um I am not joking when I say that I'm
because I'm gonna do a different project
I'm gonna go really in depth in another
project it's probably gonna be like a
two-hour project it's going to be crazy
long um well for a YouTube video but I
can see doing thousand different things
with this data creating a really great
dashboard really cleaning the data which
is a large part of of actually doing
this and we didn't do much data cleaning
at all there's just so much you can do
with this and so really dig into this
see what you like see what you don't
like see what you want to clean what you
don't want to clean you could put it in
SQL you could put it in um Excel and
just and just standardize the data to
make it a lot more usable do whatever
you want with it I mean I I took this
survey for you guys that we could use it
so go out and use it and make the best
dashboard that you can possibly do so I
hope that this was helpful I hope that
you enjoyed this thank you so much for
watching this video If you like this
thank you so much for watching if you
like this video be sure to like And
subscribe below and I'll see you in the
next
[Music]
video
what's going on everybody welcome back
to another video today we're going to be
starting our Python tutorial
[Music]
series now I am extremely excited for
this series we're going to be walking
through all the things that you need to
know to get started in Python we'll be
looking at variables data types for
Loops y Loops operators and a ton more
after this beginner series we're going
to be going into another set of Series
where we look at pandas mat plat lib
Seaborn web scraping and more now in
this video we're just going to be
setting up our environment to where we
can learn python in future videos in
this series we're going to be using
jupyter notebooks for all of our
tutorials because I feel like it's a
really great place to learn the basics
but then in future videos I'll show you
different idees that you can use for
your python code I genuinely cannot wait
to get started on this series I
absolutely love python so without
further Ado let's jump on my screen I'm
going to show you how to install jupyter
notebooks all right so let's get started
by downloading anaconda anaconda is an
open- Source distribution of python and
R products so within Anaconda is our
Jupiter notebooks as well as a lot of
other things but we're going to be using
it for our Jupiter notebooks so let's go
right down here and if I hit download
it's going to download for me because
I'm on Windows but if you want
additional installers if you're running
on Mac or Linux then you can get those
all right here now if you are running on
Windows just make sure to check your
system to see if it's a 32bit or a 64
you can go into your about in your
system settings to find that information
I'm going to click on this 64
bit it's going to pop up on my screen
right here and I'm going to click
save now it's going to start downloading
it it says it could take a little while
but honestly it's going to take probably
about 2 to three minutes and then we'll
get going now that it's done I'm just
going to click on it and it's going to
pull up this window right here we are
just going to click next because we want
to install it this is our license
agreement you can read through this if
you would like I will not I'm just going
to click I agree now we can select our
installation type and you can either
select it for just me or if you have
multiple admin or users on one laptop
you can do that as well for me it's just
me so I'm going to use this one as it
recommends now it's going to show you
where it's installing it on your
computer this is the actual file path
it's going to take about 3.5 gigs of
space I have plenty of space but make
sure you have enough space and then once
you do you can come right over here to
next and now we can do some Advanced
options we can add Anaconda 3 to my path
environment variable
and when you're using python you
typically have a default path with
whatever python IDE or notebook that
you're using I use a lot of Visual
Studio code so if I do this I'm worried
it might mess something up so I am not
going to do this it also says it doesn't
recommend it again messing with these
paths is kind of something that you
might want to do once you know more
about python so I don't really recommend
you having this checked we can also
register in AA 3 as my default python
3.9 you can do this one and I'm to keep
it this way just so I have the exact
same settings as you do so let's go
ahead and click install and now it is
going to actually install this on your
computer now once that's complete we can
hit next and now we're going to hit next
again and finally we're going to hit
finish but if you want to you can have
this tutorial and this getting started
with Anaconda I don't want either of
them because I don't need them but if
you would like to have those keep those
checked and you can get those let's
click finish now let's go down and and
we're going to search for Anaconda and
it'll say Anaconda Navigator and we're
going to click on that and it should
open up for us so this is what you
should be seeing on your screen this is
the Anaconda Navigator and this is where
that distribution of python and R is
going to be so we have a lot of
different options in here and some of
them may look familiar we have things
like Visual Studio code spider our
studio and then right up here we have
our Jupiter notebooks and this is what
work we're going to be using throughout
our tutorials so let's go ahead and
click on launch and this is what should
kind of pop up on your screen now I've
been using this a lot um so I have a ton
of notebooks and files in here but if
you are just now seeing this it might be
completely blank or just have some you
know default folders in here but this is
where we're going to open up a new
Jupiter notebook where we can write code
and all the things that we're going to
be learning in future tutorials and you
can use this area to save things and
create folders and organize everything
if you already have some notebooks from
previous projects or something you can
upload them here but what we're going to
do is go right to this new we're going
to click on the drop down and we're
going to open up a Python 3 kernel and
so we're going to open this up right
here now right here is where we're going
to be spending 99% of our time in future
videos this is where we're going to
write all of our code so right here is a
cell and this is where we can type
things so I can say print I can do the
famous hello world
and then I'll run that by clicking shift
enter and this is where all of our code
is going to go these are called cells so
each one of these are a cell and we have
a ton of stuff up here and I'm going to
get to that in just a second one thing I
wanted to show you is that you don't
only have to write code here you can
also do something called markdown and so
markdown is its own kind of you could
say language but um it's just a
different way of writing especially
within a notebook so all we're going to
do is do this little hashtag and
actually I think it's a pound sign but
I'm G to call it hashtag we're going to
do that and we're going to say first
notebook and then if I run that we have
our first notebook and we can make
little comments and little notes like
that that don't actually run any code
they just kind of organize things for us
and I'm going to do that in a lot of our
future videos so just want to show you
how to do that now let's look right up
here a lot of these things are pretty
important uh one of the first things
that's really important is actually
saving this so let's say we wanted to
change the title to I'm going to do a AA
because I want it to be at the beginning
um so I can show you this I'm do AA a
new notebook and I'm going to rename it
and then I'm going to save that so if I
go right back over here you can see AAA
new notebook that green means that it's
currently running and when I say running
I mean right up here and if we wanted to
we go ahead and shut that down which
means it wouldn't run the code anymore
and then we'd have to run up a new
cluster uh so let's go ahead and do that
I didn't plan on doing that but let's do
it so we have no notebooks running and
right here it says we have a dead kernel
so this was our Python 3 kernel and now
since I stopped it it's no longer
processing anything so let's go ahead
and say try restarting
now and it says kernel is ready so it's
back up and running and we're good to go
the next thing is this button right here
now this is an insert cell below so if I
have a lot of code I know I'm going to
be writing I can click a lot of that and
I often do that because I just don't
like having to do that all the time so I
make a bunch of cells just so I can use
them you can delete cells so say we have
some code here we'll say here and we
have code here and then we have this
empty cell right here we can just get
rid of that by doing this cut selected
cells we can also copy selected cells so
if I hit copy selected cells and I can
go right here and say paste selected
cells and as you can see it pasted that
exact same cell you can also move this
up and down so I can actually take this
one and say I wanted it in this location
I can take this cell and move it up or I
can move it down and that's just an easy
way to kind of organize it instead of
having to like copy this and moving it
right down here and pasting it you can
just take this cell and move it up which
is really nice now earlier when I ran
this code right here I hit shift enter
you can also run and it'll run the cell
below so you can hit run and it works
properly if you're running a script and
it's taking forever and it's not working
properly at least it's you don't think
it's working properly you can stop that
by doing this interrupt the kernel right
here and anything you're trying to do
within this kernel if it's just not
working properly it'll stop it you can
restart it then you can try fixing your
code you can also hit this button if you
want to restart your kernel and this
button if you want to restart the kernel
and then rerun the entire notebook as we
talked about just a second ago we have
our code and our markdown code we're not
going to talk about either of these
because we're not going to use that
throughout the entire series the next
thing I want to show you is right up
here if you open this file we can create
a new notebook we can open an existing
notebook we can copy it save it rename
it all that good stuff we can also edit
it so a lot of these things that we were
talking about you can cut the cells and
copy the cells using these shortcuts if
you would like to we also go to view and
you can toggle a lot of these things if
you would like to which just means it'll
show it or not show it depending on what
you want so if we toggle this toolbar
it'll take away the toolbar for us or if
we go back and we toggle the toolbar we
can bring it back we can also insert a
few different things like inserting a
cell above or a cell below so instead of
saying This plus button you can just say
A or B adding above or below we also
have the cell in which we can run our
cells or run all of them or all above or
all below and then we have our kernels
right here which we were talking about
earlier where we can interrupt it and
restart those there are widgets we're
not going to be looking at any widgets
in this series but if it's something
you're interested in you can definitely
do that and then we have help so if you
are looking for some help on any of
these things especially some of these
references which are really nice you can
use those and you can also edit your own
keyboard shortcuts and now that we
walked through all of that you now have
anacon and jupyter notebooks installed
on your computer in future videos this
is where we're going to be writing all
of our python code so be sure to check
those out so we can learn python
together thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you were able to get
everything installed correctly I am
super excited for this series ahead of
us if you like this video be sure to
like And subscribe below and I will see
you in the next
[Music]
video
hello everybody today we're going to be
learning about variables in Python a
variable is basically just a container
for storing data values so you'll take a
value like a number or a string you can
assign it to a variable and then the
variable will carry and contain whatever
you put into it so for example let's go
right over here we're going to say x and
this is going to be our variable we're
going to say is equal to now we can
assign the value to it so let's say I
want to put
22 x is now equal to 22 so we won't have
to write out the number 22 in later
scripts that we write we can just say x
because X is equal to 22 it now contains
that number so now we can hit enter and
say print we do an open parentheses and
we'll say x now I'm going to hit shift
enter and now it prints out that 22
because we are printing x and x is equal
22 this is our value and this is our
variable one really great thing about
variables is that it assigns its own
data type it's going to automatically do
this so we didn't have to go and tell X
that it's an integer it just
automatically knew that 22 is a number
so we can check that by saying type and
then open parenthesis and writing X and
we'll do shift enter again and this says
that X is an integer type now we only
assigned an integer to X let's try
assigning a string value or some text to
a variable so we'll say Y is equal to uh
let's say mint chocolate chip I'm
feeling some ice cream today so we'll
say mint chocolate chip now if we print
that again we'll do print open
parenthesis Y and do shift enter it'll
print mint chocolate chip and if we look
at the type we can see that the type is
a string this time and not an integer
now again we did not tell it that X was
an integer and Y was a string it just
automatically knew this let's go up here
really quickly we're going to add
several rows in here because we're about
to write a lot of different variables
and really learn in- depth how to use
variables the next thing to know about
variables is that you can overwrite
previous variables right now we have
mint chocolate chip and that is assigned
to the variable y so if I go down here I
say print y I hit shift enter it's going
to print out mint chocolate chip but
if I go right above it I say Y is equal
to and let's say chocolate if I print
that out it's now going to say chocolate
whereas up here I'm reassigning it to Y
it's still going to say mint chocolate
chip so if I come right down here and I
copy this and I'm going to paste this
right here initially it is going to
assign y to Chocolate but then right
here it will automatically overwrite y
as mint chocolate chip and when we hit
shift enter it's going to show mint
chocolate chip variables are also case
sensitive so if I come up here and I say
a capital Y this is a lowercase Y and
this is a capital Y it is going to print
out the correct one instead of mint
chocolate chip and then if I go down
here to the print and I type the capital
Y it will give us the mint chocolate
chip up till now we've only assigned one
value to one variable but we can
actually assign multiple values to
multiple variables so let's do X comma y
comma Z is equal to and now we can
assign multiple values to all of those
so we can say
chocolate and then we'll do a comma oops
a comma then we can say vanilla and then
we'll do another comma and we'll say
rocky road now this is going to assign
chocolate to X
vanilla to Y and Rocky Road to Z so what
we can do is we'll say
print and we'll go print print print and
we'll say X Y and Z so it prints out
chocolate vanilla and rocky road and
these are our three different values we
can also assign multiple variables to
one value and we can do this by saying X
is equal to Y is equal to Z is equal to
and we can put whatever we would like
let's do root beer float then we'll come
back up here we'll copy this and let's
print off our X our Y and Z and they are
all the exact same now so far we've
really only looked at integers and
strings but you can assign things like
lists dictionaries tupal and sets all to
variables as well so let's go right down
here so let's create our very first list
I'm going to say icore cream is equal to
and that is our variable right there the
ice cream is our variable so now we're
going to do an Open Bracket like this
and we're going to come up here and copy
all of these values and we're going to
stick it within our list so now within
ice cream we have three string values
chocolate vanilla and rocky road all
within this list so what we can do is we
can say x comma y comma Z is equal to
icore cream so so now these three values
chocolate vanilla and rocky road will be
assigned to these three variables X Y
and Z and we can copy this print up
here and we'll hit shift enter and now
the X Y and Z all were assigned these
values of chocolate vanilla and rocky
road now something that we just did
which is really important or something
that you really need to consider is how
you name your variables so right here we
have ice cream now this to me is exactly
how I usually write my variables but
there are many different ways that you
can write your variables so let's take a
look at that really quickly and let's
add just a few more because I have a
feeling we're going to go a little bit
longer than what we have so there are a
few best practices for naming variables
first I'm going to show you kind of what
a lot of people will do I'll show you
some good practices and I'm going to
show you some bad practices as well that
you should avoid doing the first thing
that we're going to look at is something
called camel case and let's say we want
to name it t test variable case oops
case now if we have a test variable case
the camel case is going to look like
this we'll have lowercase test and then
we'll have uppercase variable and
uppercase case is equal to this is what
this variable is going to look like and
we can assign it a nilla
swirl and this is what your camel case
will look like it's going to be
lowercase and then all the rest of those
uh compound words or however you want to
say that these letters are going to be
capitalized to kind of separate where
the words end and begin let's go right
down here we're going to copy this the
next one is called Pascal case so Pascal
case is going to look just a little bit
different instead of the lowercase at
test it's going to be a capital T in
test so test variable case again this is
a very similar way of writing it very
similar to camel case U but just a
capital at the beginning now let's look
at the last one and this one is my
personal favorite this one is going to
be the snake case now this one is quite
a bit different in the fact that you
don't use any capital letters and you
separate everything using underscore so
we're going to write
testore variable underscore case now
typically let me have them all in there
typically these are the best practices
these are what you typically want to do
but probably the best one to to use is
this snake case right here what a lot of
people say is that it improves
readability if you take a look at either
the camel case or the Pascal case which
you will see people do it's not as easy
to distinguish exactly what it says and
the name of a variable is important
because you can gain information from it
if people name them appropriately so
when I'm naming variables I usually
write it in snake case because I just
find it a lot easier to read because
each word is broken up by this
underscore score so now let's look at
some good variable names these are all
ones that you can use or could use let's
do something like test VAR so test VAR
is completely appropriate we can also do
something like testore VAR oops
underscore we could do underscore test
underscore VAR you'll see that often as
well well people will start it with an
underscore you can do test
bar capital T oops capital T capital V
in test VAR or you could even do
something like test VAR two now adding a
number to your variable is not
inherently a Bad Thing usually it's
semif fround upon but there are
definitely some use cases where you can
use it but one thing that you cannot do
is do something
like putting the two at the front if you
put the two at the front it no longer
works it won't run properly at all so
we're going to take that out so we can't
do that so I'm going to use this as an
example of what you should not do you
also can't use a dash so something like
test- var2 that doesn't work either and
you also can't use something like a
space or a comma or really any kind of
symbol like a period or a backslash or
equal sign none of those things will
work within your variable now another
thing that you can do within your
variable is use the plus sign so let's
assign this we'll say x is equal to and
we'll do a string we'll say ice
cream is my
favorite and then we'll do a plus sign
and we'll say period now what this will
do is it will literally add these two
strings together so let's do print and
we'll do X so now it says ice cream is
my favorite one thing that we cannot do
in a variable is we cannot add a string
and a number or an integer so we can't
do ice cream as my favorite two if we
try to do that it will give us this
error right here so in this error it's
saying you can only concatenate a string
not an integer to a string so only a
string plus a string for this example
you can also do and we'll say x is equal
to or we'll say
y we'll say Y is equal
to 3 + 2 and it should output five
because you can also do an integer and
an integer now so far we've only been
outputting one variable in the print
statement but you can actually add
multiple variables within a print
statement so let's go right down here
we're going to say let's give it some
more right there so we'll say x is equal
to ice
cream and we'll say Y is equal
to is and then the last one Z is equal
to my favorite and we'll do a period at
the end now we can go to the bottom and
we can say print x + y + C and when we
enter
that and when we run and when we run
that we get ice cream is my favorite now
we can actually add a space before is a
space before my and when we hit shift
enter it says ice cream is my favorite
you can also do this exact same thing
with numbers as well so we'll say x = to
1 2 and what Z is equal to three so this
should equal six now one thing that we
tried to do was assign to one variable a
string plus an integer and that did not
work but what you can do is you can take
something like this and you can say ice
cream and we'll get rid of this one and
we'll get rid of the Z now saying plus
is actually not going to work let's try
running this
so again we can't concatenate these but
what we can do in the print statement is
we can separate it by a comma so when we
add this comma it should work properly
let's hit enter and it says ice cream 2
again this makes no sense but you are
able to combine a string and an integer
separating by a comma now this is the
meat and potatoes of variables there are
some other things as well but some of
those things are a little bit more
advanced and not something I wanted to
cover in this tutorial although we may
be looking at some of those things in
future tutorials
but this is definitely the basics what
you really really need to know about
variables I hope that this video was
helpful if it was be sure to like And
subscribe below and I will see you in
the next
[Music]
video hello everybody today we're going
to be talking about data types in Python
data types are the classification of the
data that you are storing these
classifications tell you what operations
can be performed on your data we're
going to be looking at the main data
types within python including numeric
sequence type set Boolean and dictionary
so let's get started actually writing
some of this out and first let's look at
numeric there are three different types
of numeric data types we have integers
float and complex numbers let's take a
look at integers an integer is basically
just a whole number whether it's
positive or negative so an integer could
be a 12 and we can check that by saying
type we'll do an open parenthesis and a
Clos parenthesis and if we say the type
of 12 it's going to give us an integer
or if we say a -2 that is also an
integer we can also perform basic
calculations like -2 + 100 and that'll
tell us it is also an integer so whether
it's just a static value or you're
performing an operation on it it's still
going to be that data type if those
numbers are whole numbers whether
negative or positive now let's take this
exact one and let's say
12 and we'll do+
10.25 when we run this it's no longer
going to be a whole number it'll now be
a float so let's check this and now this
is a float type because is no longer a
whole number it's now a decimal number
and the last data type within the
numeric data type is called complex
let's copy this right down here now
personally this is not one that I've
used almost ever but it is one just
worth noting so you can do 12 plus and
let's say 3 J
and if we do this it's going to give us
a complex the complex data type is used
for imaginary numbers for me it's not
often used but if you do use it J is
used as that imaginary number if you use
something like C or any other number
it's going to give you an error J is the
only one that will work with it now
let's take a look at Boolean values so
we'll say Boolean the Boolean data type
only has two built-in values either true
or false so let's go right down here and
say type
true and when we run this it'll say bu
which stands for Boolean we can do the
exact same thing with false that is also
Boolean and this can be used with
something like a comparison operator so
let's say 1 is greater than 5 and let's
check this this is giving us a Boolean
because it's telling us whether one is
greater than five let's bring that right
down here this will give us a false so
it's telling us that one is not greater
than five and just as we got a false we
can say 1 is equal to one and this
should give us a true so now let's take
a look at our sequence type data types
and that includes strings lists and
tupal let's start off by looking at
strings in Python strings are arrays of
bytes representing Unicode characters
when you're using strings you put them
either in a single quote a double quote
or a trible quote I call them
apostrophes it's just what I was raised
to call them but most people who use
Python call them quotes so right here we
have a single quote and that works well
we can do a double quote and that works
also and as you can see they are the
exact same output and then we have a
triple quote just like this and this is
called a multi-line so we can write on
multiple lines here so let's write a
nice little poem so we'll say the ice
cream vanquished my longing for
sweets upon this diet
I look
away it no longer
exists on this day and then if we run
that it's going to look a little bit
weird it's basically giving us the raw
text which is completely fine but let's
call this a
multi-line and we're going to call this
a variable multi-line and we're going to
come down here and say
print and before I run this I have to
make sure that this is Ran So now let's
print out our multi-line and now we have
our nice little poem right down here now
something to know about these single and
double quotes is how they're actually
used so if we use a single quote and we
say I've always wanted to eat a gallon
of ice cream and then we do an
apostrophe at the end obviously
something went wrong here what went
wrong is when you use a single quote and
then within your text within your
sentence you have another apostrophe
it's going to give you an error so what
we want to do is whenever we have a
quote within it we need to use a double
quote these double quotes will negate
any single quotes that you have within
your statement they won't however negate
another double quote so you need to make
sure you aren't using double quotes
within your sentence if you want to do
something like that you need to use the
triple quotes like we did above so we
can do double double and then let's
paste this within
it
and anything you do Within These triple
quotes will be completely fine as long
as you don't do triple quotes within
your triple quotes we'll say this is
wrong so even though it's between these
two triple quotes it doesn't work
exactly again you just have to
understand how that works you have to
use the proper apostrophes or quotes
within your string and just to check
this we can always say here's our
multi-line we can always say type of
multi-line and that is still a string
one really important thing to know about
strings is that they can be indexed
indexing means that you can search
within it and that index starts at zero
so let's go ahead and create a variable
and we'll just say a is equal to and
let's do the all popular hello world
let's run this and now when we print the
string we can say a and we're going to
do a bracket and now we can search
throughout our string using the index so
all you have to do is do a colon and we
can say five what this is going to do is
is going to say zero position zero all
the way up to five which should give us
the whole hello I believe let's run this
and it's giving us the first five
positions of this string we can also get
rid of the colon and just say something
like five and then when we run this it's
actually going to give us position five
so this is 0o 1 2 3 4 and then five is
the space let's do six so we can see the
ACT ual letter and that is our w we can
also use a negative when we're indexing
through our string so we could say -3
and it'll give us the L because it's NE
-1 2 and three we can also specify a
range if we don't want to use the
default of zero so before we did 0 to
five and it started at zero because that
was our default but we could also do two
to five let's run this and now we go
position 0 1 and then we start at 2 L L
now we can also also multiply strings
and we have this a hello world so we can
do a * 3 and if we run this it'll give
us hello world three times and we can
also do a plus a and that is Hello World
hello world now let's go down here and
take a look at lists lists are really
fantastic because they store multiple
values the string was stored as one
value multiple characters but a list can
store multiple separate values so let's
create our very first list list we'll
say list really quickly and then we'll
put a bracket and a bracket means this
is going to be a list there are other
ones like a squiggly bracket and a
parenthesis these denote that they are
different types of data types the
bracket is what makes a list list so to
keep it super simple we'll say one two
three and we'll run this and now we have
a list that has three separate values in
it the comma in our list denotes that
they are separate values and a list is
indexed just like a string is indexed so
position zero is this one position one
is the two and position two is the three
now when we made this list we didn't
have to use any quotes because these are
numbers but if we wanted to create a
list and we wanted to add string values
we have to do it with our quotes so
we'll say quote cookie
dough then we'll do a comma to separate
the value and then we'll say
strawberry and then we'll do one more
and this will just be chocolate and when
we run this we have all three of these
values stored in our list now one of the
best things about list is you can have
any data type within them they don't
just have to be numbers or strings you
can basically put anything you want in
there so let's create a new list and
let's say
vanilla and then we'll do three and then
we'll add a list within a list and we'll
say
Scoops comma spoon and then we'll get
out of that list and then we'll add
another value of true for Boolean and
now we can hit shift enter and we just
created a list with several different
data types within one list now let's
take this one list right here with all
of our different ice cream flavors we'll
say icore cream is equal to this list
now one thing that's really great about
lists is that they are changeable that
means we can change the data in here we
can also add and remove items from the
list after we've already created it so
let's go and take ice cream and we'll
say ice cream. append and this is going
to append it to the very end of the list
we do an open parenthesis and let's say
salted caramel now when we run this and
we call it just like this it's going to
take this list add salted caramel to the
end and we'll print it off and as you
can see it was added to the list and
just like I said before let me go down
here we can also change things from this
list so let's say ice cream and then we
need to look at the indexed position so
we're going to say zero and that's going
to be this cookie d right here we can
say that is equal to so we can now
change that value so let's call that
butter econ and now when we call
it we can now see that the cookie dough
was changed to butter peacon another
thing that you saw just a little bit ago
is something called a list within a list
basically a nested list so we had Scoops
spoon true let's give this and we'll say
nested uncore list is equal to now when
we run this we now have this nested list
so if we look at the index and we say
zero we'll get vanilla if we say two
we'll get Scoops and spoons now since we
have a list within a list we can also
look at the index of that nested list so
let's now say one and that should give
us just spoon and you can go on and on
and on with this you can do lists within
lists within lists and all of them will
have indexing that you can call now
let's go down here and start taking a
look at tupal so a list and a tupal are
actually quite similar but the biggest
difference between a list and a tuple is
that a tupal is something called
immutable it means it cannot be modified
or changed after it's created let's go
right up here we're going to say
Tuple and let's write our very first
tupal so we'll say Tuple score
Scoops is equal to and then we'll do an
open parentheses now these open
parentheses you've seen if you do like a
print statement but that's different
because that's executing a function this
is actually creating a tupal which is
going to store data for us so we'll say
one 2 3 two and one let's go ahead and
create that Tuple and we can just check
the data type really quickly and it's a
tupal and just like we saw before a
tupal is also index text so if we go at
the very first position which is a one
we will get the output of a one but we
can't do something like
aend and then add a value like three if
we do that it's going to say Tuple
object has no attribute append it's just
because you cannot change or add
anything to a tupal just like we were
talking about before typically people
will use tupal for when data is never
going to change an example for this
might be something like a city name a
country a location
something that won't change they
definitely have their use cases but I
don't think they're as popular as just
using a list so now let's scroll down
and start taking look at sets but really
quickly let me add a few more cells for
us and let's say
sets now a set is somewhat similar to a
list and a tupal but they are a little
bit different in the fact that they
don't have any duplicate elements
another big difference is that the
values within a set cannot be accessed
using an index because it doesn't have
an index because it's actually unordered
we can still Loop through the items in a
set with something like a for Loop but
we can't access it using the bracket and
then accessing its index point so let's
go ahead and create our very first set
so we're going to say daily uncore pints
then we're going to say equal to and to
create a set we're going to use these
squiggly brackets I don't know if
there's an actual name for those if I'm
being honest I call them squiggly
brackets and that's what we're going to
go with we're to put in a one a two and
a three so let's go ahead and run
this and let's look at the type and as
you can see it is a set now when we
print this out it's going to show us one
a two and a three and those are all the
values within our set but if we copy
this and we'll say daily pant log this
is going to be every single day maybe I
had different
values now when we run this and we do
the exact same thing now when we print
this it's going to have just the unique
values within that set now a use case
for set and this is something that I've
done in the past is comparing two
separate sets maybe you have a list or a
tupal and you convert that into a set
and that will narrow it down to its
unique values then you can compare the
unique values of one set to the unique
values in another set and then we can
see what's the same and what's different
so let's go down here and let's say
wife's
uncore daily just copy this right here
we'll say is equal to let's do our
squiggly lines let's do one two let's do
just random
numbers so now this is my daily log and
this is my wife's daily log and now we
can compare these values so let's go
right down here let's say print we'll do
my daily logs and then we'll do this bar
right here and this is going to show us
the combined unique values it's
basically like putting them all in one
second set and then trimming it down to
just the unique values so we'll take
wife's daily pintes log and when we run
this we actually need to run this first
when we run this we should see all the
unique values between these two sets and
so as you can see 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 24 31
so these are all the unique values
between these two
sets we can also do another one and
instead of this bar we're going to do
this symbol right here which I believe
is called an Amper sand
don't quote me on that but when we run
this it's going to show what matches
that means which ones show up in both
sets so the only ones that show up in
both sets are 1 2 3 and five we can also
do the opposite of that by doing a minus
sign and this is going to show us what
doesn't match and so we have four 6 and
31 now where is our 24 that was in our
wife's daily pints log it's in this one
but we're subtracting the values on this
one so let's reverse reverse this and
we'll say daily pints
log and let's run it now those are our
other values so we're taking the values
of this and then we're subtracting all
the ones that are the same and getting
the remaining values and then for our
last one we can get rid of this and
we'll do this symbol right here and this
is going to show if a value is either in
one or the other but not in both so
let's run this so these values are
completely unique only two each of those
sets now the very last one that we're
going to look at in this video is
dictionaries so let's go right down here
let's add a few cells and let's say
dictionaries now I saved dictionary for
last because this one is probably the
most different out of all the previous
data types that we've looked at within a
data type we have something called a
key value pair that means when we use a
dictionary it's not like a list where
you just have a value comma value comma
value we have a key that indicates what
that value is attributed to so let's
write out a dictionary to see how this
looks so we're going to say
dictionary cream and just like a set we
use a squiggly line but the thing that
differentiates it is that in a
dictionary we'll have that key value
pair whereas in a set each value is just
separated by a comma so let's write name
and this is our key and then we do a
colon and this is then where we input
our value so we're going to say Alex
freeberg and then we separate that key
value Pair by a comma and now we can do
another key value pair so we'll say
weekly intake and a colon and we'll say
five pints of ice cream do a comma and
then we'll do favorite ice creams and
now what we're going to do is we're
going to put in here a list so within
this dictionary we can also add a list
we'll do MCC from mint chocolate chip
and then we'll add chocolate another one
of my favorites so now we have our very
first dictionary let's copy this and run
it and let's just look at the
type and as you can see it says that
this is a dictionary let's also print it
out now if we want to we can take our
dictionary cream and say dot values with
an open parenthesis and when we execute
this we'll see all of the values within
this dictionary so here's our values of
Alex freeberg five mint chocolate chip
and chocolate we can also say keys and
when we run this all of the keys the
name weekly intake and favorite ice
creams and we can also
say items so this key value pair is one
item and this key value pair is another
item now one difference between
something like a list and a dictionary
is how you call the index but you can't
call it by doing something like like
this where you just do a bracket oops
and say zero so this would in theory
take this very first one right our very
first key value pair that's going to
give us an error how you call a
dictionary is actually by the key so it
doesn't technically have an index but
you can specify what you want to call
and take it out so we're going to say
name and this is going to call that key
right here and when we run this we'll
get the value which is Alex freeberg one
other thing that you can do is you can
also update information in a dictionary
which we can't with some other data
types so for this for the name it was
Alex freeberg now let's say Ste freeberg
and when we update that I'm also going
to
print the dictionary get rid of this so
it's going to update Christine freeberg
in that value of the name so let's go
ahead and run this and now it changed
the name from Alex freeberg to Christine
freeberg we can also update all of these
values at one time so let's copy
this and I'm going to put it right down
here I'm going to say dictionary.c
cream. update then we're going to put a
bracket or not a bracket but a
parentheses around these so now what
we're going to do is update this entire
thing let me take this say print this
dictionary now we can update this to
anything we want so instead of here I
can
say I'll say
weight and because of all that ice cream
I now weigh 300 lb so let's run this and
as you can see it did not delete our key
value pair right here instead it just
added to it when you're using the update
we can't actually delete that's the
delete statement and I'll show you that
in just a second but all we did was
added this new value it also is going to
check and see if you changed anything
with your key value pair so we can go in
here here and change this value and
we'll say 10 so now when we run this the
value of this key value pair was changed
but let's say we do want to delete it
we'll say deel that stands for delete
part of this dictionary cream and now
let's specify the key which will also
delete the value with it well let's
specify the key that we want to get rid
of and let's say
wait and then let's print that
again and as you can see the weight was
deleted from that dictionary so that is
all we're going to cover in this data
types video thank you guys so much for
watching I really appreciate it if you
like this video be sure to like And
subscribe below and I'll see you in the
next
[Music]
video hello everybody today we're going
to be taking a look at comparison
logical and membership operators in
Python operators are used to perform
operations on variables and values for
example you're often going to want to
compare two separate values to see if
they are the same or if they're
different within Python and that's where
the comparison operator comes in right
here you can see our operators you can
also see what they do so this equal sign
equal sign stands for equal we have the
does not equal the greater than less
than greater than or equal to and less
than or equal to and honestly I use
these almost every single time I use
Python so these are very important to
know and know how to use so let's get
rid of that really quickly and actually
start writing it out and see how these
comparison operators work in Python the
very first one that we're going to look
at is equal to now you can't just say 10
is equal to 10 let's try running that
really quickly by clicking shift enter
it's going to say cannot assign to
literal that's because this is like
assigning a variable we're trying to say
10 is equal to 10 and then we can call
that 10 later but that's not how this
actually works what we're trying to do
is to determine whether 10 is equal to
10 so we're going to say equal sign
equal sign and then if we run that by
clicking shift enter again it's going to
say true now if we put something else
like 50 in there and we try to run this
it's going to say false so really what
you're going to get when you use these
comparison operators is either a true or
a false if we take this right down here
we can also say does not equal and we're
going to use an exclamation point equal
sign and that says 10 is not equal to 50
and that should be true you can also
compare strings and variables so let's
go right down here and we're going to
say vanilla is not
equal to chocolate and when we run this
it'll say false now if it was the same
just like when we did our numbers it
should say true and we can also compare
variables so we'll say x is equal to
vanilla and Y is equal to chocolate and
then when we come down here we can say x
is equal to Y and it'll give us a false
and we say X is not equal to Y and it'll
give us a true the next one that we're
going to take take a look at is the less
than so let's copy this one right up
here let's scroll
down and let's say 10 is less than 50
now this will come out as true now let's
say we put a 10 in here before 10 was of
course less than 50 but is 10 less than
10 no that's false because they are the
same so if we want an output that is
true all we would have to add is an
equal sign right here and this would say
10 is less than or it is equal to 10 and
now it's true of course we can say the
exact same thing by saying greater than
so 10 is equal or greater than 10
that'll be true because 10 is equal to
10 we can also say 50 is greater or
equal to 10 because 50 is obviously
greater than 10 now let's look at
logical operators that are often
combined with comparison operators so
our operators are and or and not so if
you have an and that returns true if
both statements are true if it's or only
one of the statements has to be true and
the not basically reverses the result so
if it was going to return true it would
return false I don't use this not one a
lot but I will show you how it works so
let's actually test that out so before
we were saying 10 is greater than 50 and
of course this returned false so now
let's add a parentheses around this 10
is greater than 50 and we're going to
say and we'll do an open parenthesis 50
is greater than 10 now this statement
right here is true 50 is greater than 10
so we have a true statement and a false
statement but this and is going to look
at both of them and it's going to say
they both need to be true in order to
return a true so let's try running this
and we still have a false if we want it
to return true we're going to have to
change this to make it a true statement
so 70 is greater than 50 and 50 is
greater than 10 when we run this it
should return true now let's look at the
or so let's copy this and we'll say 10
is greater than 50 or 50 is greater than
10 now this is a false statement and
this is a true statement so if even one
of them is a true statement the output
should be true and again we can do this
even with strings so we can do
vanilla and
chocolate there we go and vanilla is
actually greater than chocolate because
V is a higher number in the alphabetical
order so V is like 20 something whereas
chocolate is three right so actually
looks at the spelling for this so if we
say or here it will come out true and if
we say and here it should also be true
because V is greater than C and 50 is
greater than 10 so this should also be
true now let's copy this right here and
we're going to say not so what we had
before is 50 is greater than 10 that
returned true but now all we're doing is
putting not in front of it so instead of
returning true it's going to return
false so now let's take a look at
membership operators and we use this to
check if something whether it's a value
or a string or something like that is
within another value or string or
sequence our operators are in and not in
so it's pretty simple if it's in it's
going to return true if the sequence
with a specified value is present in the
object just like we were talking about
and for not in it's basically the exact
same thing if it's not in that object so
let's start out by taking a look at a
string we're going to say ice _ cream is
equal to I love chocolate
ice
cream and then we're going to say love
in ice cream and that will will turn
true so all we're doing is searching if
the word love or that string is in this
larger string we could also just do that
by literally copying this and putting
this where this is so we can check is
this string part of this string and
it'll say true we can also make a list
so we'll say Scoops is equal to and then
we'll do a bracket and we'll say 1 2 3 4
4 five and then we'll say two in Scoops
so all we're doing is searching to see
if two is within this list and that
should return true now if we put a six
here and we said not in it will also
return true because six is not in Scoops
and that is true and just like we did we
could also say wanted underscore Scoops
and we'll say eight so I wanted eight
Scoops so we can say wanted Scoops in
scoops and this should return true
because there's not an eight within the
Scoops that we wanted and if we said in
and we said we wanted eight is that
within our list that we created and
that's going to return a false so that
is a quick breakdown of comparison
logical and membership operators I hope
that this was helpful thank you guys so
much for watching if you like this video
be sure to like And subscribe and I will
see you in the next
[Music]
video
hello everybody today we're going to be
taking a look at the if statement within
python now it's actually the if LF else
statement but that's a mouthful so I'm
just going to call it the if else
statement now we have this flowchart and
I apologize for being blurry but this is
the absolute best one that I could find
right up top we have our if condition
now if this if condition is true we're
going to run a body of code but if that
condition is false we're going to go
over here and go to the LF condition the
LF condition or statement is basically
saying if the first if statement doesn't
work let's try this if statement if this
LF statement is true it goes to this
body of code if it's false it'll come
over here to the else and the else is
basically if all these things don't work
then run this body of code now you can
have as many ill if statements as you
want but you can only have one if
statement and one else statement so
let's write out some code and see how
this actually looks let's first start
off by writing if that that is our if
statement and now we have to write our
condition which is about to be either
met or not met so we'll say if 25 is
greater than 10 which is true we'll say
colon and then we're going to hit enter
and it's going to automatically indent
that line of code for us and this is our
body of code so if 25 is greater than 10
our body of code will execute so for us
we're just going to write print and
we'll say it worked now if we run this
it's going to check is 25 greater than
10 if that is true true print this so
let's hit shift enter and it worked now
let's take this exact code we'll paste
it right down here and we'll say is less
than and right now this if statement is
not true so it's not actually going to
work as you can see there's no output
there's nothing that happened really but
it did check to see if 25 was less than
10 but it just wasn't true now we can
use our else statement so we're going to
come right down here and we're going to
say else and we'll do a colon and we'll
hit enter again automatically indenting
and we're going to say print and we're
going to say it did not work dot dot dot
so what it's going to do is it's going
to come up here and check is 25 less
than 10 no it's not so this body of code
is not going to be executed it's going
to go right down to this else statement
now this else statement is going to be
printed there's no condition on this so
the if statement has a condition 25 is
less than 10 this has no condition so if
this doesn't work if this is false it's
going to come down here and it will run
this body of code let's run this by
clicking shift enter and as you can see
our output is it did not work now let's
go back up here and put greater than
because this is now true it's going to
say if 25 is greater than 10 print it
worked and then it's going to stop it's
not going to go to this lse statement at
all so let's run this and our output is
it worked so what if we have a lot of
different conditions that we want to try
let's come right down here this is where
the LF comes in so so really quickly
let's change this to a not true a false
statement we're going to go down and say
LF and we're going to say if it is and
let's say
30 we'll say LF
worked so now it's going to check is 25
less than 10 no it's not let's look at
the next condition is 25 less than 30
and if it is we'll print L if worked so
let's try running this and L if worked
now we can do as many of these LF
statements as we want we can do let's
just try a few of them right here so
we'll say if 25 is less than 20 is less
than
21 and let's do 40 and let's do 50 so
we'll say LF lf2 lf3 and lf4 now if you
look at this the first one that is
actually going to work is this 25 to 40
right here once this one is checked and
it comes out as true none of the other
LF or L statements will work so let's
try this one it should be
lf3 and this one ran properly now within
our condition so far we've only used a
comparison operator we can also use a
logical operator like and or or so we
can say if 25 is less than 10 which it's
not and let's say or actually and we'll
say or 1 is less than three which is
true if we run this now it will actually
work so we can use several different
types of operators within our if
statement to see if a condition is true
or not or several conditions are true
there's also a way to write an IFL
statement in one line if you want to do
that so we can write print we'll say it
worked and then we'll come over here and
say if 10 is greater than 30 and then
we'll write else print and we'll say it
did not work just like we had before
except now it's all occurring on one
line so let's just try this and see if
it works so it's saying print it worked
if 10 is greater than 30 which it wasn't
so it went to the lse statement and then
it printed out our body right here
although we didn't have any indentation
or multiple lines it was all done in one
line now there's one other thing that we
haven't looked at yet uh and I'm going
to show it to you really quickly and
that's a nested if statement so when we
run this it's going to say it worked it
works because it says 25 is less than 10
or one is less than three since this is
true it's going to print out it worked
but we can also do a nested if statement
so we can do multiple if statements as
well so we're going to hit enter and
we'll say if and we'll do a true
statement here so we'll say if 10 is
greater than five let's do a colon hit
enter then we'll say print and then
we'll type A String saying this nested
if
statement oops
worked now let's try this out and and
see what we get so it went through the
first if statement it said it was true
and it prints out it worked this is
still the body of code so it goes down
to this next if statement and it says if
10 is greater than five we're going to
print this out and you could do this on
and on and on it can basically go on
forever and you can create a really
in-depth logic and that actually happens
a lot when you start writing more
advanced code so I hope that this was
helpful I hope that you understand the
IFL statement better I hope that you
understand how nested if statements work
as well thank you guys so much for
watching if you like this video be sure
to like And subscribe below and I'll see
you in the next
[Music]
video hello everybody today we're going
to be learning about for Loops in Python
the for Loop is used to iterate over a
sequence which could be a list a tupal
an array a string or even a dictionary
here's the list that we'll be working
with throughout this video and I have
this little diagram right here which
kind of explains how a for Loop works
the for Loop is going to start by
looking at the very first item in our
sequence or our list and that's going to
be our one right here it's going to ask
is this the last element in our list and
it is not so it's going to go down to
this body of the for Loop now we can
have a thousand different things that
can happen in the body of the for loop
as we're about to look out in just a
second then it's going to go up to the
next element and ask is this the last
element reached so it'll be no again
because we'll be going to the two and
then the three and then the four and the
five once it reaches the five it'll go
to the body the for Loop and then when
it asks if that's the last element the
answer would be yes because it's
iterated through all the items within
the list and then we would exit the loop
and the for Loop would be over now that
may not have made perfect sense but
let's actually start writing out the
syntax of a for Loop so we can
understand this better to start our for
loop we're going to say four and and
then we're going to give it a temporary
variable for this for Loop so it's a
variable as it iterates through these
numbers it's going to assign the
variable to that number so for this one
we're just going to say number because
it's pretty appropriate because these
are all numbers and then we're going to
say in integers now right here you can
put just about anything this could be
the list this could be a tuple this
could be a string even but that is what
we're going to iterate through so we're
saying for the variables each of these
numbers within this list of integers and
then we're going to write a colon this
is the body of code that's going to
actually be executed when we run through
and iterate through our list so for our
first example we're going to start off
super simple and all we're going to do
is say print open parentheses and say
number as it iterates through the 1 2 3
4 and five number becomes our variable
that is going to be printed so during
that first loop our one will be printed
because that will be assigned right here
then through the next iteration the two
will be assigned and'll be put right
here in each Loop until the very end so
let's hit shift
enter and as you can see it did exactly
that now in this body and I'll copy and
paste this down here in this body we
really can do just about anything we
want we don't even have to use this
variable number right here we can just
print yep if we wanted to and what it's
going to do is for each iteration all
five of those every time it Loops
through it's going to print off yep so
let's hit shift enter and it printed it
off for us so really we weren't even
using the numbers within the list we
were really just using it as almost a
counter now let's copy this integers
once again let's go right up here and
let's go copy this for Loop that we
wrote now we do not have to call this
number this can be anything you want any
variable name that you'd like to name it
we could call it
jelly and we can
do jelly plus
jelly I think you're getting the picture
right when it Loops through that one
it's doing 1 plus one when it Loops
through the two it's doing two plus two
that is basically how a four Loop works
now for a dictionary it's going to
handle it a little bit differently so
let's create a dictionary really quickly
so we'll say ice
cream dictionary is equal to we're going
to do a squiggly brackets so we're going
to say name and we're going to say colon
we need to assign our value for that
item so we're going to say Alex freeberg
we'll do our next one separated by a
comma and we'll say weekly intake and
I'll say five Scoops per week the next
one we will do is favorite ice creams
and for this one we're going to do
something a little bit different for
this we're going to have a list within
this dictionary so we'll say within our
list of my favorite ice creams we'll say
mint chocolate chip and I'll just do MCC
for that and we'll separate that out by
a comma and we'll say chocolate so now
we have this dictionary ice cream dick
and within it we have my name my weekly
intake and my favorite ice creams with a
list in there as well let's hit shift
enter and now we're going to start
writing our for Loop now the for Loop is
going to look very similar but to call a
dictionary it's just a little bit
different so we're going to say four the
cream in icore
creamore
dictionary. values and then we're going
to do parentheses and then a colon now
we're going to print the cream so in
order to indicate what we actually want
to pull we have to specify within the
dictionary what we want are we pulling
the item are we pulling the value we
need to specify this so that's why we
have this dot values right here so let's
run this and see what we get so as you
can see we are pulling in the values
right here that's why we're pulling in
Alex freeberg 5 and mint chocolate chip
SL chocolate now we are able to call
both of those both the key and the value
so let's go right down here and we can
do both the key and the value so we can
pull two things at one time and we're
going to do this by saying do items so
we could also do do key if we just
wanted to do a key but we want to do
items so we going to do both of them
so we're going to go right down here and
say for key and value in ice cream
dictionary. items print and let's write
key and then we'll do a comma and then
let's give it a little arrow or
something like that uh something like
this and then we'll do a comma and we'll
say value and let's print this off and
see what we get so it's looping through
and for each key and value it's saying
here is the key so that's the name then
we have weekly intake then we have
favorite ice creams it's giving us a
little arrow and then we're also
printing off the value so we have name
Alex freeberg weekly intake five
favorite ice creams mint chocolate chip
and chocolate so now let's talk about
nested for Loops we've looked at for
Loops we understand how they work and
why they do what they do but what about
a nested for Loop a for Loop within a
for Loop for this example let's create
two separate lists let's create
flavors and let's make that a list by
making it a bracket we'll do vanilla the
classic
chocolate and then cookie dough all
great flavors so that's our first list
and then we're going to say toppings and
we'll do a bracket for that as well and
we'll say hot
fudge and then we'll do
Oreos and then we'll do
marshmallows is how you spell
marshmallows
I think it's an e that looks wrong I
might be spelling it wrong but that's
okay so let's save this by clicking
shift enter and now we have our flavors
and our toppings so now let's write our
first for Loops we're going to say 41 as
in our number one for loop we're going
to say in flavors and we'll do a colon
we'll click enter now we can write our
second for Loop so we're going to say 4
two in toppings and then we'll do a
colon and enter and then we're going to
say print and we'll do an open
parenthesis and then we're going to say
one so we're printing the one in flavors
and then we're going to say one comma
I'm going to say topped with comma 2 so
what this is essentially going to do is
we're going to say for one we're going
to take the very first one in flavors
and then we're going to Loop through all
of two as well so we're going to Loop
through hot fudge Oreo
and marshmallows and once we print that
off then we will Loop all the way back
to Flavors and look at the next
iteration or the next sequence within
the first for Loop so let's run this
really quickly and see what we get so as
you can see it goes vanilla vanilla
vanilla and vanilla is topped with the
hot fudge the Oreos and the marshmallows
and then we start iterating through our
second one in our first four Loop so
there's that hierarchy so we're
iterating completely through this one
before we actually go to the very first
for Loop and start iterating through
that one again now that is essentially
how a nested for Loop works these nested
for Loops can get very complicated in
fact for Loops in general can get very
complicated the more you add to it and
the more you're wanting to do with it
but that is basically how a for Loop and
a nested for Loop works thank you guys
so much for watching be sure to like And
subscribe below and I'll see you in the
next
[Music]
video
hello everybody today we're going to be
taking a look at while Loops in Python
the while loop in Python is used to
iterate over a block of code as long as
the test condition is true now the
difference between a for Loop and a
while loop is that a for Loop is going
to iterate over the entire sequence
regardless of a condition but the while
loop is only going to iterate over that
sequence as long as a specific condition
is met once that condition is not met
the code is going to stop and it's not
going to inter through the rest of the
sequence so if we take a look at this
flowchart right here we're going to
enter this while loop and we have a test
condition right here the first time that
this test condition comes back false
it's going to exit the while loop so
let's start actually writing out the
code and see how this while loop works
so let's create a variable we're just
going to say number is equal to one and
then we'll say while and now we need to
write our condition that needs to be met
in order for our block of code beneath
this to run so we're going to say while
number is less than five and then we'll
do colon enter and now this is our block
of code we're going to say print and
then we'll say number now what we need
to do is basically create a counter
we're going to say number equals number
+ 1 if you've never done something like
this it's kind of like a counter most
people start it at zero in fact let's
start it at zero and then each time it
runs through this while loop it's going
to add one to this number up here and
then it's going to become a one a two a
three each time it iterates through this
while loop now once this number is no
longer less than five it'll break out of
the while loop and it will no longer run
so let's run this really quick by
hitting shift enter so it starts at zero
and it's going to say while the number
is less than five print number so the
first time that it runs through it is
zero and so it prints zero and then it
adds one two number and then it
continues that y Loop right here and it
keeps looping through this portion it
never goes back up here to this line of
code this is just our variable that we
start with and then once this condition
is no longer met once it is is false
then it's going to break out of that
code now that we basically know how a y
Loop Works let's look at something
called a break statement so let's copy
this right down here and what we're
going to say is if number is equal to
three we're going to break now with the
break statement we can basically Stop
the Loop even if the while condition is
true so while this number is less than
five it's going to continue to Loop
through but now we have this break
statement so it's going to say if the
number equals three we're going to break
out out of this while loop but if this
is false we're going to continue adding
to that number just like normal so let's
execute this so as you can see it only
went to three instead of four like
before because each time it was running
through this while loop it was checking
if the number was equal to three and
once it got to three this became true
and then we broke out of this while loop
the next thing that I want to look at
and we'll copy this right down here is
an else statement much like an if
statement but we can use the lse
statement with a while loop which runs
the block of code and when that that
condition is no longer true then it
activates the else statement so we'll go
right down here and we'll say else and
we'll do a colon and enter and then
we'll say print and we'll say no
longer less than five now because this
if statement is still in there it will
break so let's say six and then we'll
run this and so it's going to iterate
through this block of code and once this
statement is no longer true once we
break out of it we're going to go to our
else state St now as long as this
statement is true it's going to continue
to iterate through but once this
condition is not met then it will go to
our L statement and we'll run that line
of code now the L statement is only
going to trigger if the Y Loop no longer
is true if we have something like this
if statement that causes it to break out
of the while loop the L statement will
no longer work so let's say if the
number is three and we run this the L
statement is no longer going to trigger
so this body of code will not be run now
the next thing that I want to look at is
the continue statement if the continue
statement is triggered it basically
rejects all remaining statements in the
current iteration of the loop and then
we'll go to the next iteration now to
demonstrate this I'm going to change
this break into a continue so before
when we had the break if the number was
equal to three it would stop all the
code completely but when we change this
to continue which we'll do right now
what it's going to do is it's no longer
going to run through any of the
subsequent code in this block of code
it's just going to go straight up to the
beginning and restart our while loop so
what's going to happen when we run this
is it's going to come to three it's
going to become three it's going to
continue back into the while loop but
it's never going to have that number
changed to be added to one to continue
with the while loop this will basically
create an infinite Loop let's try this
really quickly and as you can see it's
going to stay three forever eventually
this would time out but I'm just going
to stop the code really quick so if we
just change up the order of which we're
doing things we're going to say there
and we're going to put this down here
so what it's going to do now instead of
printing the number immediately and then
adding the number later we're going to
add the number right away and then we're
going to say if it is three we're going
to continue and it's going to print the
number so let's try executing this and
see what happens so as you can see we no
longer have the three in our output what
it did was when we got to the number
three it continued and didn't execute
this right here which prints off that
number so that really is the basics of
the while loop I hope that this was
helpful I hope that you learned
something in this video If you did be
sure to like And subscribe below and
I'll see you in the next
[Music]
video hello everybody today we're going
to be taking a look at functions in
Python a function is a block of code
which is only run when you call it so
right here we're defining our function
and then this is our body of code that
when we actually call it is going to be
ran so right here we have our function
call and all we're doing is putting the
function with the parenthesis that is
basically us calling that function and
then we have our output throughout this
video I'm going to show you how to write
a function as well as pass arguments to
that function and then a few other
things like arbitrary arguments keyword
arguments and arbitrary keyword
arguments all of these things are really
important to know when you are using
functions so let's get started by
writing our very first function together
we're going to start off by saying DF
that is the keyword for defining a
function then we can actually name our
function and for this one we're just
going to do first underscore function
and then we do an open parenthesis and
then we'll put a colon we'll hit enter
and it'll automatically indent for us
and this is where our body of code is
going to go now within our body of code
we can write just about anything and in
this video I'm not going to get super
Advanced we're just going to walk
through the basics to make sure that you
understand how to use functions so for
right now all we're going to say is
print we'll do an open parenthesis we'll
do an apostrophe and we'll say we did it
and now we're going to hit shift enter
and this is not going to do anything at
least you won't see any output from this
if we want to see the output or we
actually want to run that function and
some functions don't have outputs but if
we want to run that function what we
have to do is just copy this and put it
right down here and now we're going to
actually call our function so let's go
ahead and click shift enter and now
we've successfully called our first
function this function is about as
simple as it could possibly be but now
let's take it up a notch and start
looking at arguments so let's go right
down here and we're going to say Define
number underscore squared we'll do a
parenthesis and our colon as well now
really quickly when you're naming your
function it's kind of like naming a
variable you can use something like X or
Y but I tend to like to be a little bit
more descriptive but now let's take a
look at passing an argument into a
function the argument is going to be
passed right here in the parentheses so
for us I'm just going to call it a
number and then we're going to hit enter
and now we'll write our body of code and
all we're going to do for this is type
print and open parenthesis and we'll say
number and we'll do two stars at least
that's what I call it a star and a two
and what this is going to do is it's
going to take the number that we pass
into our function it's going to put it
right here in our body of code and then
for what we're doing it's going to put
it to the power of two and so when the
user or you run this and call this
function this number is something that
you can specify it's an argument that
you can input that will then be run in
this body of code so let's copy this
right here and then we'll put it right
down here into this next cell and we'll
say five and so this five is going to be
passed through into this function and be
called right here for this print
statement let's run it and it should
come out as I believe 25 that is my
fault I forgot to actually run this
block of code so I'm going to hit shift
enter so now we've defined our function
up here and now we can actually call it
so now we'll hit shift enter and we got
our output of 25 now now in this
function we only called one argument but
you can basically call as many arguments
as you want you just have to separate
them by commas so let's copy this and
we'll put it right down here now we'll
say number squared uncore custom and
then we'll do number and then we'll do
power so now we can specify our number
as well as the power that we want to
raise it to so instead of having two
which is what you call hardcoded we can
now customize that and we'll have power
power and now when we call this function
we can specify the number and the power
and both of those will go into this body
of code and be run and we can customize
those numbers so let's copy
this and we'll
say 5 to the power of three and let's
make sure I ran this so let's do shift
enter and now we will call our function
and let's hit shift enter and we got 5
to the^ of 3 which is 125 and just one
last thing to mention is if you have two
arguments within your function and you
are calling it right here you have to
pass in two arguments you can't just
have one so if we have a five right here
it's going to error out we have to
specify both Arguments for it to work
now let's take a look at arbitrary
arguments now arbitrary arguments are
really interesting because if you don't
know how many arguments you want to pass
through if you don't know if it's a one
a two or a three you can specify that
later when you're calling the argument
so you don't have to do it upfront and
know that information ahead of time so
let's define our function so we're going
to say Define and then we're going to
say number underscore args and we'll do
an open parenthesis and a colon now
within our argument right here typically
we would just specify here's what our
argument will be it will be number or it
will be a word right but what we're
going to do is something called an
arbitrary argument so it's unknown so
we're going to put star and then we'll
say args now you will see something
exactly like this typically if you're
looking at tutorials that'll have star
args in there or if you're looking at
just a generic piece of code this is
what it will look like but for us we're
going to actually put number so again we
have the star and then we have our
arbitrary argument right here and then
we'll hit enter and we're going to say
print open parentheses and this is where
it's going to get a little bit different
so we're going to say number and then
we're going to do an open bracket and
let's say zero and then we'll do that
times and then we'll say number again
with a bracket of one so in a little bit
once we run this and then we call this
number args function right here we're
going to need to specify the number zero
and the number one that's going to be
called so let's go ahead and run this
and then we are going to call it and
let's say 5 comma 6 comma 1 2 8 so right
up here we did not know how many
arguments we were going to pass through
it could be five it could be a thousand
we could also call in a tuple and that's
what this is right here we're calling in
a tupal so what it's going to do now is
when it calls this number it's going to
call the very first within that tupal
which will be that five and then it'll
also call in this number which will be
the first position which is the six so
let's hit shift enter and it's going to
multiply these numbers together so 5 * 6
is equal to 30 now like I just said this
is a tuple so we don't actually have to
write out these numbers like we just did
we can pass through a tuple when we are
actually calling this function let's do
that right up here let's just create um
let's call it argor Tuple and we'll do
open parentheses and we'll do the same
numbers let's just copy it make it
easier and now we've created this tupal
right here which we can then pass in and
this is a lot more handy a lot more
specific and this is most likely how
someone would do something like this but
let's now create this and now we can
copy args Tuple and pass it through now
really quickly this is going to fail and
I'm doing that on purpose but I want to
show you what you need to do in order to
pass through this
tupal so right now it's going to say
Tuple index is out of range all you have
to do in order to use this is you have
to specify a star before it just like
you did when you're creating your
argument up here you have to put a star
in front of our Tuple that we just
passed through and now let's try running
this and now it works properly now the
last two things that we're going to look
at are keyword arguments and arbitrary
keyword arguments there are more things
that you can learn and do within
functions but again I'm just trying to
teach you the basics to make sure that
you understand how they work so let's go
right up here and a keyword argument is
kind of similar to this right here and
let's actually copy this and put it
right down here now a keyword argument
is very similar in that you're going to
specify your arguments right here but
what we did up here let me bring this
down
when we actually called the function
what we did was we just put in a five
and a three and when we did that it
automatically assigned number to five
and power to three and that's totally
fine and you can do that but if you want
a little bit more control you can use a
keyword argument so right here we could
say power is equal to five and number is
equal to three so I just switched it
around right number was assigned to five
and Power was assigned to three but I
just switched it to show you how this
might work so let's run both of these
and now it's 3 to the^ of 5 which is
243 so that essentially is a keyword
argument again it just gives you a
little bit more control you don't have
to put them in specific positions like
if you're just calling multiple
arguments now let's come right down here
we're going to create basically another
custom function uh so for this one we're
going to write Define number underscore
bar and then we'll do an open
parenthesis a colon and enter and what
this one is is this one is a keyword
argument or an arbitrary keyword
argument now to specify an arbitrary
argument all we did was a star and then
we input number but if we're doing a
keyword argument we actually have to
have two stars right here so let's start
taking a look and again if you're doing
arbitrary it means we don't really know
how many keyword arguments we want to
pass into our function so we're just
going to put star our number and then
later within our body of code and when
we're calling it we'll be able to
specify it and just like the arbitrary
argument before the arbitrary keyword
argument means we really just don't know
how many keyword arguments we're going
to need to pass into our function so to
demonstrate this let's write print do an
open parenthesis and we'll say my oops
need to do an
apostrophe my number is we'll do just
like that little space and we'll say
plus and this is kind of where it gets a
little interesting or a little bit more
tricky so we're going to say is number
so This Is Us calling our number and
then we're going to do a bracket and
then I'm actually going to go to calling
the function it's a little bit backward
or a little bit different than what you
might think but when we're calling it
what I'm going to do is I'm going to say
integer is equal to let's just do some
random number now when we're calling
that keyword within our body of code
what we're going to do is we're going to
actually type out integer just like this
and this looks a little bit different
but what this allows us to do is we can
put as many keyword arguments in here as
we want later and I'll show you in just
a second but for us we're just creating
this key and this value when we are
calling it within the function so now
when we create this and we run
this oh whoops I forgot this has to be a
string um so let's run this
again now we will say my number is
2309 then we're we're going to add we'll
say plus and this isn't going to look
great but we'll say my other number
because this will all be in the same
line that's okay my other number and
then we'll say number and we can specify
again what we want in there so now we
can go down here to where we're calling
it we'll put a comma and we'll say
integer oops
integer 2 is equal to we'll do a random
number and then we'll put in two right
here and then we'll add plus right here
so we don't error out we'll create this
we'll run this and as you can see both
numbers were passed through again the
syntax is terrible but now you can see
that you have this arbitrary keyword
argument right here and all we have to
do is put number number and we can pass
through as many of these arbitrary
keyword arguments as we want as long as
we just specify within our function when
we're calling it so that's all we're
going to look at in today's video on
functions there are of course other
things that you can do within functions
and it can get a little bit more
advanced but I wanted to show you the
basics the meat and potatoes of things I
definitely think you should know in
order to get started using functions I
hope that you were able to understand
functions better because of this video
if you did be sure to like And subscribe
below and I will see you in the next
[Music]
video hell hello everybody today we're
going to be talking about converting
data types in Python in this video I'm
going to show you how to convert several
different data types including strings
numbers sets tupal and even dictionaries
so let's start off by creating a
variable we'll say numor int is equal to
7 and we can check that data type by
saying type and then inserting our
variable number undor int and that will
tell us that our data type for this
variable is an integer let's go ahead
and create another one we're going to
say num underscore string is equal to
and for this one we'll also do a seven
but let's check the type and we'll do an
open parentheses and we'll say the type
of num string and that one is a string
now let's say we wanted to add those
we'll say Num uncore Sum so the sum of
numor int plus numor string now when
we're adding these two values it is not
going to work it's going to give us an
error and it's going to say unsupported
op brand for INT and string so it cannot
add both an integer and a string what we
need to do in order to add these two
numbers is to convert that string into
an integer so let's go right up here
let's add another cell and let's say
numor string undor converted is equal to
and we want to convert it into an
integer so all we have to do to convert
it into an integer is type int and then
we're going to say num underscore string
and that is as easy as it's going to get
all we have to do is say integer with
our numb string inside of it and then
it's going to convert it and we can even
check it right after by saying type num
string converted and let's run this and
now we can see that it was converted
into an integer so now let's add that
num string converted right
here let's copy and replace that string
with the string
converted and let's actually print out
that numor sum and it worked properly
now we did not specify what type of
value this Num Sum was going to be but
because it was two integers in here it's
going to automatically apply that data
type of integer to that Num Sum let's go
right down here and now let's look at
how we can convert lists sets and tupal
so now let's say we have a listor type
and that's equal to 1 2 3 and we can
check it again by saying
type and that is a list let's say we
want to convert it to a tupal it's
fairly easy all we're going to do is
write Tuple say listor type that list
uncore type is now going to be a tupal
and we can check that by saying type and
wrapping it around this Tuple and it
shows us that it is converting that list
into a tupal now we can also convert a
list into a set but it may change the
actual values within it let's check that
out really quickly so let's say we have
this list and let's add a few more
values to this just like that now let's
say we want to convert it to a set so
we're going to run this and we'll say
set of listor type and let's try running
this and see what the output is so this
is something that you really need to be
aware of when you are converting data
types because set does not act the same
as a list a set is basically going to
take the unique values in the list and
convert it to a set and it fundamentally
changes the data that was in that
original list and just to check the data
type we can say
type I'm just doing this for all of them
and as you can see that is now a set now
let's go down here and take a look at
dictionaries now let's say we have a
dictionary called dictionary type and
we'll do a squiggly bracket and we'll
say name name and we'll do a colon and
we'll say Alex then we'll do age and a
colon and we'll say
28 and then we'll do
hair
colon and so really quickly let's take
that dictionary type and just confirm
that it is a dictionary and it is and
now what we're going to do is take a
look at all of the items within that
dictionary so we're going to do
dictionary type. items open parenthesis
and this is going to show us all the
items within it now we can also take
this and look at something like the
values and when we run that these are
our values So within our dictionary we
have items and that's what this is right
here this is one item and then within
that we have our values which are right
here so Alex 28 and Na and then we have
something called a key and this is the
key the name age and hair are all keys
and we can look at that by saying dot
keys so let's say we want to take all of
the keys and put that into a list what
we're going to do is we're going to take
this right here say
list we'll do an open parenthesis we'll
type that in right there so it says a
list and we're converting these Keys
into a list and let's run that and now
this is a list and let's just check the
type as well just to confirm
and as you can see it was converted
properly into a list and we can do the
exact same thing with
values and the values can also be
converted into a list now we can also
convert longer strings that aren't just
numbers like we did above in our very
first example so let's do longcore
string and we'll say I like to party now
we're going to take this string and
we're going to say list long string so
we're going to convert this string into
a list and let's see what happens so it
took every single character in that
string and put it into a list and we
could also do a set as well that one's a
lot shorter because it's only looking at
unique values so that is how you convert
data types in Python thank you guys so
much for watching I really appreciate it
if you like this video be sure to like
And subscribe below and I'll see you in
the next
[Music]
video
hello everybody today we're going to be
working on building a BMI calculator in
Python now before we get started I want
to show you this BMI calculator that I
found online and it shows you the basic
calculation that they use and that's the
one we're going to use in this video and
they also have this calculator right
down here and some ranges that we can
use for our calculator as well so for
reference I weigh about
170 I'm about 5 9 let's calculate this
so I'm about a
25.1 BMI which falls into the overweight
category that's unfortunate but we can
see exactly how this works and how ours
should work when we actually build it so
we're going to kind of reference this
throughout the video so let's go right
over here to our BMI calculator we need
to calculate weight and height and then
run this calculation right here so let's
go ahead and copy
this and we're going to put it right
down here
here and so now we have our calculation
so what we need is we need input from a
user and there is an input function
within python that we're going to be
using so let's actually give me a few
more cells so the first thing that we
need to calculate is their weight let's
type out weight right here we'll say
weight is equal to and this is where
we'll use our input function so we'll
say input and when we actually run this
it's just going to give us this blank
square or a user can input something
we'll say Alex so this is our output is
what the actual user input and it does
save it to this variable so if we say
print weight it will still print out
Alex now this is where we want the user
to just like we did before where they'll
input their weight so we want to kind of
give them a prompt for this we'll put a
string in here so I'll do a double quote
and then I'll say
enter your weight in and we're using
pounds
say pounds colon space so now when we do
this it'll say enter your weight in
pounds I'll say 170 and then when we run
this it does store that now let's do
print I should have saved it wait again
oops now it's only storing the value of
170 it's not actually storing this
string right here so that's really
important for when we do our
calculations
later um I'm going to I'm going to save
this right down here because I'm sure
I'm going to use that later um so we
have that it's working now we need to
also do our height so let's copy this
and we'll put it right here and we'll do
height and enter your height in inches
so now for this one if we hit
enter it's actually running let's stop
it really quick and interrupt it let's
try running this so it's going to say
enter your weight and pounds that's the
first input say
170 and then when I hit enter it's going
to prompt me for that second input and
so in inches 59 is 69 in and then I can
hit enter again and now we have both of
our inputs now we need this calculation
right down here and just like that so
now we have weight in pounds time 703
divided by height in inches by height in
inches so we actually have weight and
it's already written in there but I'm
just going to do like this we'll do
weight time 73 so that's pounds there
our weight and pounds * 703 divided by
now we have our height in
inches times the height in inches so
this is our calculation right here so
let's do this exact same thing let's run
this and this times of course is not
going to work whoops we need to do our
star for both of these all right now
this is our calculation so let's run
this so we have
170 and that's pounds and inches was 69
hit
enter and it says cannot multiply the
sequence of non- integer type of string
Ah that's because these are being stored
in strings they right down here I do and
we'll do type of height we run that this
is actually a string so we want to
change that because we don't need that
anymore
that so we don't want it to be a string
we need those to be integers or Floats
or really anything besides a string it
just needs to be numerical uh so integer
float really so let's do integer and
we'll wrap that input in it and we'll do
the same thing for this
one now we have an integer for our
weight an integer for our height so now
when we're running this calculation it
should work properly let's run this
again our pounds are
70 our height is 69 in
and it's not giving us our output
because we're not printing anything okay
so I just need to
do
print BMI so let's try this again 170
69 and there is our BMI 25.1 so it
worked the exact same as this one so
they input well we input our height we
inputed our or we inputed our weight we
inputed our height and then it
calculated rbmi the next thing that we
need to do is we need to kind of give
the user some context is that good is
there BMI in within a good range a bad
range we don't know uh so let's go ahead
and I'm going to see if I can copy this
know if this will work or
not let's go ahead and copy this right
down here perfect so what we now need to
do is we need to say okay if the user
has given us this input we want to give
them or tell them if they are a normal
weight overweight obese severely obese
anything like that and we have these
ranges so that should help us out quite
a bit so let's just write our if
statement and then we'll include it up
here but let's go down here and we'll
say if and then we'll do BMI and let's
just say BMI is greater than zero so if
it's greater than zero if they had any
input where the BMI was not zero which
should be every time if they do it
properly and they don't you know put a
string in there or something or type out
40 which maybe we should make a prompt
for that if that happens then we can say
if we'll do
BMI and now we need to give that first
range so this range right here so if
it's under 18.5 so we need to do a less
than so if it's less than
18.5 and it just says under it doesn't
say under or equal to so I'll keep it at
18.5 so if it's under
18.5 then let's give kind of the output
we'll say print
and the output or the basically the
prompt is underweight so we'll just say
you are
under under case underweight and just
like that um then we're going to pass
several ellf statements through here
well let's just say else so I guess this
would be like if they are if they don't
input something properly if something
messes up
maybe I we could write something like um
print
oops I'm thinking all this through we
can write print
enter valid
inputs or something like this or we can
always change that but let's really
quickly let's run
this okay so I'm not in that range uh
let's make the next one so then I can be
within a certain range
oops and we need we should need one one
more a minimum so we'll say
LF and
LF these next two are this 24.9 so it's
going to check this one first so if it's
18.5 or below 18.5 it's automatically
going to print this one so this next one
we don't have to do like a range or
anything we can just say if it's below
if it's between 25 and 29.9 so this one
actually should be less than or equal to
um this one is normal oh whoops
24.9 so this one is
24.9 this one is going to say you are
normal weight so let's run this
now let's see BMI was
25.1 oh guys I'm just messing up here I
apologize all right this is the one that
I was part of so now it's going to be
I'm part of the overweight crowd now now
let's run this and now our prompt is you
are overweight cuz remember the BMI was
saved right here as
25.1 down here if we run through this
it's saying no you're not in
oops get rid of that no you're not in
under 18.5 you're not under
24.9 if you under
29.9 you are overweight so that did work
properly so that's really good and I
don't think I want this to be our output
for person because we're going to add
this up here it's just going to give us
the BMI and then the output is going to
say you are overweight uh let's make it
a little bit more customized um I'm
going to say name is equal to input and
then we'll say
enter your
name um so it'll be enter your name
we'll do Alex
70 69 there's our BMI now it's going to
run through this logic or it will run
through this logic and just just a
second
when we actually finish this so then we
have
34.9 and let's do one
more oops and then this one's going to
be for
39.9 so this one was overweight this one
is
obese severely obese so we'll say
severely that you spell it really obese
and then anything that's over that 40
and over so if it's not this one
anything else should be S morbidly obese
so actually this lse statement right
here should
say uh you
are you are severely obese this is going
to say morbidly morbidly obese now I
added that name up here because I wanted
to add that down below actually so we're
we're going to say uh name plus and then
we'll do like
comma you are underweight so it'll be a
little bit more personalized uh I think
it'll I think it'll be a nice touch I
really do we'll do it like this and
we'll say you and let's go back and do
that to all of
them and let me see how quickly I can do
thiss oh whoops what I do get rid of
that
name plus u like that geez you guys are
seeing me mess up a h name plus you and
then name plus you so now let's run this
and now it's a little more personalized
it says Alex you are overweight so this
is all really good now this is an if
statement um what we had done before I
think is actually what we should put
right down here so we'll say l else and
then if that doesn't work we'll say what
do we say enter valid input we'll just
put that um and let let me see if I can
test this out don't I don't know if this
will error out or if this will even
work let me just see if I can mess with
it and see if I can get it to work
actually let's copy this we're going to
copy this whole thing we're going to
include it right
here and now we have basically our
entire calculator so um let's run this
enter your name we'll say Alex enter
your pounds 170 into your inches
69 and then it's going to say
25.1 Alex you are overweight and that's
perfect we could even go as far as
adding like some feedback we say you are
overweight and then it would be a period
and we could say um you need to exercise
more
stop sitting and writing so many python
tutorials so now if we run this we'll do
Alex
17069 it says Alex you are overweight
you need to exercise more and stop
sitting and writing so many python
tutorials period and that's it this is
the entire project um you can go a ton
farther you can include much more
complex logic you could even build out a
UI to create your own you know app just
like this where it has this input and
this UI you can build that out with in
jupyter notebooks with python um but
that's not really what this tutorial is
for this is just to kind of help you um
think through some of the logic of
creating something like this so you know
I hope that this was helpful I hope that
this was fun I like creating stuff like
this we have two other projects that
we're going to do and maybe I'll include
more but we have two right now that I
have planned um and I hope those those
are helpful this is probably our easiest
one and they'll get a little bit more
difficult in the next projects so I hope
that this was fun I hope that this was
helpful and that you can now kind of
utilize those python skills that you've
been working on if you like this video
be sure to like And subscribe below and
I'll see you in the next
[Music]
video hello everybody today we're going
to be creating an automatic file sorder
for your files and file explorer now out
of all the projects that we've done in
this series so far I think this one
might be the most difficult but I also
think this one is the most cool because
it has some real life applications so
without further Ado let's take a look at
some files that we have right down here
in my file explorer so I have this
beautiful picture of Rosie uh right here
this is a PNG file I have a CSV file and
a text file and I want to sort all of
them into their own folders depending on
what kind of file it is so if I go right
in here and I click on this one I go to
properties I can see that this is a PNG
file um if I go into this one I don't
need to but if I go into this one it's a
CSV file and of course this one is a
text file so I want three separate
folders in here and I want them to
automatically go into those folders
without me having to drag and drop and
going and clicking now we only have four
files here but imagine if we have
thousands of files
how much time that could save us so
let's get out of here and let's start
writing our code so we're going to say
import OS comma and then we're going to
say chut iil now OS obviously stands for
operating system shuil uh I don't know
what it actually supposed to stand for
but what it will allow us to do is do
some highlevel operations on our files
in file explorer so we're going to go
ahead and import those and now that we
have those imported
uh something that's going to be very
important for us to have throughout this
whole thing and this is anytime I'm
working with like directories or
something like this we want to get this
path down so I'm going to go ahead and
copy this
path and we're just going to say path is
equal to and we'll do this right here so
let's run this and I need to put an R
right here to make this a raw text um so
when you don't have the r uh it's going
to read in these you know these
backslashes and these colons and
different stuff if we do R it's just
going to read it in as the raw string
and that's what we want so here's what
we need to do there there's a few
different things that have to happen
when we are writing this out one thing
is is we need to go in here and we need
to see this path and we need to see are
there folders in here already um if not
we need to create a folder so that's one
of the first things that we need to do
the next thing that we need is it needs
to check each of these files
individually identify what kind of file
it is and then put it into the correct
folder so we have to create the folder
then check these and then place it into
the correct folder so let's go right out
of here so what we're going to start
doing is we're going to start working
with these paths and these directories
and some of these things you may never
have seen before but that's okay I'll
try to explain it as I go through so the
first thing that we're going to write is
os. list directories uh and what this is
actually going to do is show us all the
files in there we're going to say path
so it should show us all the files
within path and so here are our results
so we have the data professional results
fake text file our image and our other
image so this is actually showing us
what files are in that path and that's
super important because we're probably
going to have to Loop through this in
some way later um I wrote this all out
before so I kind of remember but I'm
doing this all off the top of my head so
I guarantee you throughout this I'll
make some mistakes but what we now need
to do is we need to create folders or
check if there's a folder and create it
if it isn't there that's um The Next
Step that we need to take so let's go
right down here and we want to check if
this path exists already so if that
folder already exists so we're going to
say
os. path. exists so this is going to
check does this path just like this path
up here does it already exist and then
we're going to do an open parenthesis
we'll say path so that's our path now we
need to add a folder name to this um we
could hardcode it so we could do plus we
could say CSV files and that could work
so it would say does this path already
exist and we can try running this and
it's going to say false so this doesn't
already exist but the thing is is we
need to create three separate path so we
could do this by just hardcoding it in
by saying CSV files image files um and
text files or we can just put this all
in a list and loop through it I think
it's just going to be easier to do that
or I don't know visually it's going to
be easier so we'll do uh folder undor
names and we'll say is equal to and
we'll create a list so I think I want to
call it CSV files comma um image files
or PNG files whatever you want to write
and then we'll do text
files do text files and then we can go
right down here um a little for Loop uh
I think what we'll do actually let's
write
folder underscore names um then we can
put something like uh let's write Loop
why not um so a little trick for the for
Loop is you going to say four and we'll
say Loop and and we'll just do a range
because we want it to basically go
through here we don't want it to
actually give us these file names we
just want it to count Zer one and two so
if we do range from Zer to two zero uh 0
one2 that should work if we do um this
then when it Loops through it's going to
call folder name and say zero which
would be CSV files image files and text
files um so
let's uh yeah I need a colon let's run
through this really quickly uh shouldn't
do
anything but what we can do now is we
can say okay if this does not exist what
we can do is actually create it so we'll
say
if not so if this does not exist then
what we're going to do is take
this and we'll say
os. make directory and then we'll do
just like that um I think it's make
directory S I can't I think that's
correct um so let's test this out really
quickly let's see if this
works and invalid syntax I I need a
colon okay so I just ran this let's see
if it did actually make those
folders let's refresh it and it didn't
so let's just print this off um so if
not let's just print let's see does this
actually
work let's do
if
okay ah okay so I think I know what
might be happening I think it's giving
us it actually be let let's check this
really quick go to python
tutorials oh
no I think it's
creating yeah it's creating these Python
tutorial images right here whoops okay
so I just figured it out um let's go
back into python tutorials don't take a
look at any of those notebooks those are
secret um we were creating them in the
wrong place um and that's because of
this right here we need a backslash so
we need to actually include a backslash
right here here in this path we didn't
have that um e y scanning string
literal okay so this back slash could
cause an issue let's see if I can do
forward slashes on all these just stick
with me guys I might cut this out I
might not we'll see if this is important
just going to keep talking while we're
doing it um let's run
this okay so now that we're doing these
forward slashes we're still checking
let's make sure we can still check those
files good now when we Loop through this
I'm not going to well yeah I can print
it off doesn't matter I'm going to print
it and we'll see if that name works and
then we're also going to
um uh I said if so if it exists then
make it no no no so if not I think the
not did make sense we just weren't sure
we had to do some um checking so if it
exists then we're going to create it and
we'll keep the print in there because it
doesn't really matter so it's going to
create the CSV an image but didn't
create the text let's see okay let's uh
I don't know why this would work but
let's run it okay so I think I just had
the wrong range so now we have our
images all through or we have our
folders all three folders now we need to
write a script that will read in these
and check and see what kind of file it
is and place it into the correct
folder so let's come right down here and
let's see what we need to do so now I
think we need to use this right here um
I think we need to Loop through this to
be able to check each one so we need to
name this so we'll just do um file name
is equal to run that so now we have this
file name um and what we can do is Loop
through this so let's say let's say for
file in file name so we're going to Loop
through this now when it goes through it
needs to check the it's going to check
the file path and in the file path it'll
say. txt CSV so let's say um if I think
it should be CSV Let's test it on this
one but if CSV is
in file name or actually it's file so if
if it's in
file and not in and oh not not in if
it's also not in this I believe because
we're going to check we're going to
check each of those folders so we're
going to Loop through and it's going to
check and see if the CSV so if that
string is in the
file then what we want to do is check
that it's also not in here that's
actually just the folder we also need um
also we're not doing that for Loop
anymore um
um okay I'm sorry I'm talking this
through I'm figuring it out as I go
because I may have forgotten some of
this so we're going to say this that's
the CSV files so we need to check this
one um let's do it like this oops okay
so it's going to check to see if CSV
files and I think it needs that in
between it so it's going to say the path
so there's our path plus slash C SV
files um actually no it needs to be like
this CU we're going to check that then I
got it all right I figured it out now
then we're going to check if this file
is in there yeah so that's right so it
says if the
CSV is in the
file um which is right where am I
looking oh file name so if it's in that
list of the actual files which is all of
these if we find CSV in any of these
files
and it's not already in here so it's
going to say path plus CSV files did I
say files yeah CSV files plus file okay
that all looks correct so if it's not in
there we're going to use shuttle. move
now this is how we actually move the
file it gives us the ability to move
what we want then we'll say move we need
to take it from our initial path to our
new path so we're going to specify we'll
separate by comma we need to spef ify
its original path which it should just
be
this without this I think it should be
file path because this is where it is
now it's in the FI this path with that
file name then we need to say we want to
move it to here that is what we want to
do
um yeah so let's check it with just this
one and see if it works okay it ran
through it let's go check
aha now that CSV file is gone perfect
that is exactly what we want it to
happen now we can just recreate this
for um for both our PNG files our image
files and our text files so we'll say LF
and
LF and let's do
PNG then we'll do image
files and image files because again
we're just doing the exact same thing I
can do text files the next one's going
to be text files text files so this
one's going to check for
txt now do we need anything else um
we'll just say else and we'll print off
print this file type is not included or
or if there's multiple files we'll say
there are files in this
path that were're not
moved okay so if we run through this
it's going to catch our CSV catch our
PNG catch our text and if not it'll say
there are files in this path that we're
not moved exclamation point all right
now let's run through
this
uh uh that's because if LF LF L
if and then it's going to this lse
statement uh I don't know let's let's
Circle back around to that in a second
all of them were moved properly that's
really
good really quickly I I'll I'll check
and see I just don't I'm G to take that
out for now so I'm just going to run it
um I'm we may or may not go back to that
but let's check and see if everything
worked properly so let's go into the CSV
file and we have our CSV file let go
into our image files and we have our
images and let's go into our text file
and there are our text files now is
there anything else that we need to do I
don't believe so but what I can do is I
can take all
this I can include it in
here and I'm going
to basically restart
it just to see if it works properly from
scratch right I just want to make sure
that I didn't miss it anything and we'll
delete
these so we have our I'm just going to
rerun everything we we
imported we created our path these are
our file names and then when we run this
it should take our folder names check
through them if they aren't already
created it's going to create it don't
need it to print so let's get rid of
that then for the file within our file
names and it check it it checks each one
we check if there's a CSV and if it's
already already in that file if it's
already in that folder I mean if it's in
that folder then it doesn't do anything
but if it isn't so and not it's not in
there it is going to move it to that
location so it's going to check CSV PNG
and text I think everything should work
properly let's run
this and it looks like it's working good
good good and perfect it worked exactly
how I had hoped um that's great so
this is the automatic file sorder in
file explorer project uh you can go even
a step further so I had to come in here
and manually run this you can go a step
further and put a timer on this where it
automatically does this maybe every hour
every day every 30 minutes you can run
this in your background especially if
you create um like a an execution for
this you can run this in your background
um if you are curious on how to do that
I think I did something something
similar to that in my web scraping
project um my Amazon web scraping
project if you want to go check that one
out but we're not going to do it in this
project this is all I wanted to show you
how to do so I hope that this was
helpful I hope that this project was you
know interesting and that you liked it I
hope that you learned something and so
if you did be sure to like And subscribe
below and I will see you in the next
video what's going on everybody welcome
back to another video today we're going
to be starting our python web scraping
tutorial series now this is more of a
continuation of the Python tutorial
series series but because we're going to
be focusing on web scraping for three or
four videos I wanted to just make it its
own little minseries in this series I'm
going to show you the basics of web
scraping how to actually look at HTML
how to inspect a web page how to pull
that data in and then even put it into a
CSV file so you can save it and use it
now in this series we're just covering
the basics which is a fantastic place to
start but in future series I'll be going
into some of the more advanced web
scraping topics as well so without
further Ado let sh up on my screen and
get started with web scraping now the
first thing that we need to learn is
HTML HTML stands for hypertext markup
language and it's used to describe all
of the elements on a web page now when
we actually go to a website and start
pulling data and information we need to
know HTML so we can specify exactly what
we want to take off of that website so
that's where HTML comes in and we're
going to look at the basics
understanding just the basic structure
of HTML then we'll go look at a real
website and you'll kind of see that's a
little bit more difficult than what we
just have right here but this is the
basic building blocks to get to what the
HTML actually looks like on a website
now this is basically what HTML looks
like we have these angled brackets with
things like HTML head title body and
then you'll notice that at the end we'll
have a body and then we'll have a body
at the bottom this forward SL body
denotes that this is the end of the body
section in HTML so everything inside of
this is within this body so there is
this hierarchy within HTML we have HTML
and HTML at the bottom which
encapsulates all the HTML on the website
then we have things like head and head
body and body now Within These sections
we usually have things like classes tags
attributes text and all these other
things things that we'll get to in
different lessons but one of the easiest
ones to notice and look at are tags
things like a P tag or a title tag now
Within These tags because this is a
super simple example we have these
strings here my first web page page and
this is what's called a variable string
and this is actual text that we could
take out of this web page now that you
understand the super basics of HTML
let's actually go to our website and I'm
going to have a link down below but it's
going to be this one right here this is
basically just a website that you can
you know practice web scraping on it's
called scrape the
site.com and what we're going to do is
look at the HTML behind this web page
and you can do this on any website that
you go on so we're going to right click
we're going to go down to inspect
now right off the bat this looks a lot
more complicated and a lot more complex
than the very simple illustration that
we were looking at but let's kind of
roll this up just a little bit you'll
notice we have HTML and HTML at the
bottom we have a head and there is the
end of the head and then a body and the
end of the body so in a super simple
sense it is similar but just the
information that's within it is a lot
more difficult now if we look at this
title right here this is our title tag
if we click this little arrow this is
our dropdown you'll notice that here we
have the string hockey teams forms
searching imp pagination now let's say
we didn't know we didn't want to click
on that and go find it there's something
that's super helpful within this
inspection page that you can click on
right here it says select an element in
the page to inspect it so we're going to
click on that and as we go through our
page and let's click on this title it's
going to take us to exactly where this
is in our our HTML this is extremely
helpful extremely useful for example
let's say the data I want is down here I
want to take in the Boston Bruins I can
click on it and it's going to take me to
where that is exactly in the HTML this
is where we can start writing our web
scraping script to specify okay I'm
looking for a TR tag I'm looking for a
TD tag I'm looking for the class called
team this is all information and things
that we can use to specify exactly what
we want to pull out of our web page now
there are other things that didn't
really look at as well in just our
simple illustration let's come right
over here there's things like HRS now
these are hyperlinks so if we went and
then clicked on this this is just
regular text but inside of it is this
hyperlink where if we clicked on it it
would take us to another website and
typically that's denoted by this hre
right here then you'll typically see
things like a P tag which usually stands
for a paragraph now the last thing that
I want to show you while we're here and
we're going to learn a lot more in the
next several lessons
but if we come right down here there is
this actual entire table here and let's
try to find this table and I'm having
trouble selecting the entire thing but
let's select this team name and if we
look at this team name you can see that
this is encapsulating the table this
table tag now these are super helpful
because it takes in the entire table now
if we wrap this up and we look just at
this it says class table and then we
have the end of this table tag now when
we open it it's going to have all of
this information so as you can see as
I'm highlighting over it we have these
th tags and we have these TD tags and
even these TR tags which is the
individual data and this is something
that we'll look at when we're actually
scraping all of the data from this table
in a future lesson so this is how we can
use HTML how we can inspect the web page
and see exactly what's going on kind of
under the hood and then in future
lessons we'll see how we can use this
HTML to specify exactly what data we
want to pull out thank you guys so much
for watching if you like this video be
be sure to like And subscribe below I
will see you in the next
[Music]
lesson hello everybody in this lesson
we're going to be taking a look at
beautiful soup and requests now these
packages in Python are really useful
these are the two main ones that I use
when I was first starting out with web
scraping it can get a lot of what you
want done in order to get that
information out now of course there are
other packages that you can use that may
be a little bit more advanced but again
this is just the beginner Series in a
future series we'll look at other
packages as well that have some more
advanced functionality so what we're
going to be doing is we're going to
import these packages and then we're
going to get all of the HTML from our
website and make sure that it's in a
usable State and then in the next lesson
we're going to kind of query around in
the HTML kind of pick and choose exactly
what we want we look at things like tags
variable strings classes attributes and
more so let's get started by importing
our packages what we're going to say is
from bs4 this is the module that we're
taking it from we're going to say import
and then we'll do
beautiful soup then we're going to come
down and we're going to say import
requests now let's go ahead and run this
I'm going hit shift enter and it works
well for me now if this does not work
for you you may potentially need to
actually install bs4 so you may have to
go to your terminal window and say pip
install BS 4 I'll just let you Google
how to do that if you need to do that
cuz it's pretty easy but if you're using
Jupiter notebooks through Anaconda like
how we set it up at the beginning of
this python series then you should be
totally fine it should be there for you
the next thing that we need to do is
specify where we're taking this HTML
from so what we need to actually do is
come right over here to our web page and
we need to get the URL so we're going to
go here we're going to copy this URL and
I'm just going to put it right here for
a second and what we're going to do is
we're going to be using this URL quite a
bit so we just want to assign it to a
variable so just say URL is equal to and
then we'll put it right in here now we
can get rid of that so now this is our
URL going forward this is where we're
going to be pulling data from let's go
ahead and run this now we're going to
use requests and what we're going to do
is we're going to say
requests.get and then we're going to put
in url now this get function is going to
use the request Library it's going to
send a get request to that URL and it's
going to return a response object let's
go ahead and run
this as you can see here I got a
response of 200 if you got something
like a 204 or a 400 or 401 or 404 all
these things are potentially bad
something like a 204 would mean there
was no content in the actual web page
400 means a bad request so it was
invalid the server couldn't process it
and you don't get any response if you
got a 404 that might be one that you're
familiar with that's an error that means
the server cannot be found the next
thing that we're going to do is take the
HTML now if you remember we come right
back here and we inspect this we have
all this HTML right here now on this web
page specifically right now it's
completely static it's not a bunch of
moving stuff or anything like that
usually when you're looking at HTML if
you're looking at something like Amazon
and those web pages can update but when
you actually pull that into python
you're basically getting a snapshot of
the HTML at that time so what we're
going to do is bring in all of this HTML
which is our snapshot of our website and
then we can take a look at it so we're
going to come right down here and now
we're going to say beautiful soup so now
we'll use the beautiful soup package or
Library so we need to say beautiful soup
and we're going do an open parenthesis
we're going to do two things there's two
parameters that we need to put in here
first we need to put in this get request
we actually need to name this and we'll
call this page we'll say page is equal
to and let's run this and now we're
going to put that page in here and what
we're going to say is do text so the
page is what's sending that request and
then the text is what's retrieving the
actual raw HTML that we're going to be
using then we're going to put a comma
here and what we need to specify is how
we're going to parse this information
now this is an HTML so what we're going
to do is HTML just like this this is a
standard this is already built into to
this Library so we don't need to go any
further but it's basically going to
parse the information in an HTML format
let's go ahead and run this let's see
what we get and as you can see we have a
lot of information and as we scroll down
I'll try to point out some things that
we've already looked at in previous
lessons
um something like this th tag that
should be very similar that's the title
then we have these TD tags and then of
course if we scroll down even further
we'll have things like ATR tag so these
are all things that we looked at in that
first lesson when learning about HTML
now again we want to assign this to a
variable so we're going to say soup
that's going to say equal to this
information information right here now
I'm not going to go into all the history
behind beautiful soup what I will say is
the guy who created this beautiful soup
Library uh what he said was is that it
takes this really messy HTML or XML
which you can also use it for and makes
it into this kind of beautiful soup so I
just thought that was kind of funny uh
but that's why we're calling it soup
right here and we're going to go ahead
and run this and we'll come right down
here and we'll say print soup and let's
run it and now we have everything in
here so we have our HTML L our head we
have some HR and some links in here
let's scroll down a little bit more and
then we have our body right there and of
course we have a bunch of information in
here now in the next lesson what we're
going to be doing is learning how to
kind of query all of this to take
specific information out and basically
understand a lot of what's going on in
this HTML to make sure we can actually
get what we need now if this looks
really kind of messy to you and it just
doesn't make a lot of sense there is one
more thing that I'm going to show you
and we'll come right down here so we'll
say soup. pry and if you've ever used a
different type of programming languages
uh pry is very common in a lot of them
where it'll just make it a little bit
more easy to visualize and see uh you'll
notice that it kind of has this
hierarchy built in whereas if we scroll
up there's no hierarchy built in it's
all just down this left hand side so if
you kind of want to view it and just
kind of visually see the differences
this does help a lot but it doesn't
actually help a lot when you're you know
querying it or using you know find and
find all which is what we're going to
look at in the next lesson so that is
our lesson on beautiful soup and
requests in the next two lessons we're
going to be looking at find and find all
as well as really diving into things
like variable strings and tags and
classes and all those things and then in
the last lesson we're going to do kind
of this mini project where we try to get
all the data from this web page that
we've been using from that table and put
it into a panda's data frame so thank
you guys so much for watching I really
appreciate it if you like this video be
sure to like And subscribe below and I
will see you in the next
[Music]
lesson hello everybody in this lesson
we're going to be taking a look at find
and find all really we're going to be
looking at a ton of different things in
this lesson this is where we really
start digging in seeing how we can
extract specific information from our
web page but in order to do that let's
set everything up where we actually
bring in the HTML like we did in the
last lesson and we're just going to
write all this out one more time just
for practice if nothing else and then
we'll get into actually getting that
information from the HTML so we're going
to start by saying from bs4 import
beautiful soup there we go and import
requests we'll go ahead and run this
then we're going to come up here grab
our HTML or sorry our URL so we'll say
URL is equal to and we'll have that
right here now we need to say page is
equal to and then we'll do
requests.get and then we'll put in our
URL right here and we're going to come
over here and run this and lastly we
need to say soup so we'll say soup is
equal to beautiful soup there we go and
then within our parentheses we need to
specify the page. text because we need
that and our parser which is
HTML
and there we go and let's go ahead and
run this let's print it out make sure
it's
working and there we go so we have our
soup right here all this should look
really similar to uh our last lesson and
so now we've brought in our HTML from
our page we have a lot a lot a lot of
information in here now really quickly
let's come over and let's inspect our
web
page now in here we have a ton of
information right we have bunch of
different tags and classes and all these
other things but how do we actually use
these well that's where the find and
find all is going to come into play and
they're pretty similar and you'll see
that in just a little bit but let's say
we want to take uh one of these tags and
let's come down let's say we just want
to take this div tag now there's going
to be a lot of different div tags in our
HTML but let's just come right here
let's go down and let's say
we're going to call Soup we're going to
say soup that's all of our information
we're going to say do find now within
our parentheses we can specify a lot of
different things but we're going to keep
it really simple right now we're just
going to say
di let's go ahead and run this what this
is going to bring up is the very first
div tag in our HTML and that's going to
be this information right here now let's
copy this and we're going to do the
exact same thing except we're going to
say find underscore all now let's run
this now we're going to have a ton more
information really all find and find all
do is that they find the information now
find is only going to find the first
response in our HTML Le that's the div
class container let's go back up to the
top that's our div class container but
find all is going to find all of them so
it'll put it in this list for you so
it's going to have this first one and it
goes down to uh this SL div which should
be right here and then we have a comma
which separates our next div tag so that
is how we can use it now what if we want
to specify one of these div tags we
pulled in a ton of them but we want to
just look for one of them well this is
something where the class comes in handy
because right now we have class is equal
to container classes equal to co
md-12 I don't know what these are at the
off the top of my head but um usually
they'll be somewhat unique and we can
use these to help us specify what we're
looking for for example just kind of
glancing of this we could also use this
a tag if we wanted to look at this so we
could say oh we're looking for uh these
hrefs so we have an hre here and this
right down here we have this hre as well
which again uh if you remember from
previous lesson that stands for a
hyperlink now something like the class
or the href um or these IDs these are
all attributes so we can specify or kind
of filter Down based off of these now
let's try it so what we can do is we can
do class first and this is kind of the
default uh within something like find
all is you can even do class underscore
we can come right back up we have this
div and then here's our class so again
we have to have the div and the class if
we took this a tag this is an a tag
which would go right here with the class
of something like navlink or something
like navlink again down here we need to
specify that more but we have our div so
we'll say CL Cole
md12 right here and let's go ahead and
run this and now it's going to pull in
just that information now we're still
getting a list because we have multiple
of these so this div class uh Cole md-12
doesn't just happen once if we scroll
down we'll see it multiple times
something like right here uh or actually
let me see right here so here's this
comma then here's our next one so we
have two of these uh div tags with a
class of coal- md-12 and in each of
these we have different information this
looks like a paragraph with this P tag
right here and let's scroll back up uh
so I also think we should try out doing
something like this P tag typically
these P tags stand for paragraphs or
they have text information in them let's
try to P tag really quickly and let's
just see what we get and let's run this
and it looks like we get multiple P tags
now if we come back here you can see
that there's this information and it's
this information that we're pulling in
and I'm just you know noticing that from
right here and then we have this
information right here and it looks like
there's one more which is this href
which looks like this open source so
data via and then that uh hyperlink or
that link right there so we have three
different P tags now just to verify and
make sure that that's correct what we
could do is come over here we're going
to click on this paragraph it's going to
take us to that P tag where the class is
equal to lead let's come over here and
look at this paragraph now we have
another P tag right over here with the
class is equal to glyphicon glyphicon
education I have no idea what that means
um and then we'll go to our last one
which is right here where the P tag is
equal to uh we have a tag HRA class uh
and a bunch of other information so
let's say we just wanted to pull in this
paragraph right here let's go here and
see how we can specify this information
so it looks like P or the class is equal
to lead that looks like it's going to be
unique to just that one so if we come
down here we're going to say comma and
it was class so you can do uh class
underscore is equal to and then we're
going to say lead let's try running this
and we're just pulling in that
information now let's say we actually
want to pull in this paragraph We
actually want this text right here and
this is a very real use case you know
let's say I'm trying to pull in some
information or or a paragraph of text
well let's copy this and what we're
going to then do is say. text and let's
run this now we're going to get an error
right here and this is a very common
error because we're trying to use find
all unfortunately find all does not have
a text attribute we actually need to
change this to find typically when I'm
working with these find and find alls
I'm using findall most of the time until
I want to start extracting text then
when I specify it I'll change this back
to find just like this now let's try
this and now we're getting in
parentheses this information now this is
all wonky it needs to definitely be
cleaned up a little bit but if we code
back up it's no longer in a list and we
no longer have things like these P tags
in here or this class attribute so we're
really just trying to pull out this
information now again this does not look
perfect we could even try to do
something like do strip look like
there's some white space uh that cleans
it up a little bit this definitely looks
a little better um and we could
definitely go in here and clean this up
more but just for you know an example
this is how we can then extract that
information now let's look at one more
example this is some information and
this is what we're going to do kind of
our little mini project in the next
lesson on let's say we wanted to take
all this information what if we wanted
to pull in something like the team name
that's going to be in right here in this
TR tag and each of these TR tags have th
tags underneath them so if we scroll
down you'll notice that each row is this
TR tag so let's go ahead and search for
let's do th let's just search for that
first so let's come right back up here
let's use this find
all and we'll get rid of this text for
right now and let's just say we want to
look for the TR is that what we said we
were looking for no th so let's say
we're looking for th let's go ahead and
run this so we're going to have
underneath this th we have team name
year wins losses and notice these are
all the titles so these titles are the
only ones with these th tags if we go
down you'll notice that the data is
actually TD tags so now let's go back
and look for TD we'll say
D and this is going to be a lot longer
we have a lot of information but these
are all the rows of data let's see if we
can just get one piece of this data
we're going to get back we want just
this team name that's all we're trying
to pull in for now um and then we'll try
to get this row and then in the next
lesson we're going to try to get all of
this information make it look really
nice and then we'll put it into a
panda's data frame so let's just get
this team name right now let's go ahead
we're going to say th
let's run this and we have this th and
now that we know we're getting this
information in we can
do find let's run this so there's our
team name we're just going to say. text
and again we can do do strip just like
that and Bam we have our team name so
you can kind of start getting the idea
of how we're pulling this information
out we're really just specifying exactly
what we're seeing in this HTML and
what's really really helpful and you
know something that I do all the time is
I'm inspecting it I'm just kind of
searching like how what do I want what
piece of information do I want then I go
ahead and click on it and then I'm
looking you know where is this sitting
in the hierarchy it's within the body
it's within this table with the class of
table then it's down here where this TR
tag and then this TD tag so I'm looking
kind of at the hierarchy and I'm
specifying exactly what I'm looking for
so that is what we're going to look at
in today's lesson that's how we can use
find and find all we were able to look
at classes and tags and attributes and
variable strings which is this right
here getting that text uh and variable
strings and we will look at find and
find all and how it's pulling that
information in and how we can specify
exactly what we're looking for now in
the next lesson which is definitely
going to be the most exciting one we're
going to try to pull in all of this
information so every single thing
because we'll be able to put all this
information into a data frame which then
we can use pandas to really search and
manipulate that data within that data
frame so with that being said that is
the end of this lesson if you like this
video be sure to like And subscribe I
will see you in the next
[Music]
lesson hello everybody in this lesson we
are going to be scraping data from a
real website and putting it into a p
and's data frame and maybe even
exporting it to CSV if we're feeling a
bit spicy now in the last several
lessons we've been looking at this page
right here and I even promised that we
were going to be pulling this data but
as I was building out the project I just
I honestly thought it was a little bit
too easy since in the last lesson we
kind of already pulled out some
information from this table and I want
to kind of throw you guys off so we're
going to be pulling from a different
table we're going to be going on to
Wikipedia and looking at the list of the
largest companies in the United States
by Revenue and we're going to be pulling
all of this information so if you
thought this was going to be easy in a
little mini project uh it's now a full
project because why not so let's get
started uh what we're going to do is
we're going to import beautiful soup and
requests we're going to get this
information and we're going to see how
we can do this and it's going to get a
little bit more complicated and a little
bit more tricky we're going to have to
you know format things properly to get
it into our Panda data frame to make it
looking good and making it more usable
so let's go ahead and get rid of the
this easy table we don't want that one
uh and we're going to come in here and
we're just going to start off this
should look uh really familiar by now
we're going to say from bs4 import
beautiful soup I don't know if you've
noticed but I've messed up spelling
beautiful soup in every single uh video
I've noticed uh let's run this and now
we need to go ahead and get our URL so
let's come up here let's get our
URL say URL is equal to and we'll just
keep it all in the same thing really
quickly because we know this by Heart by
now right uh we'll say request.get and
then URL to make sure that we're getting
that information it give us a response
object um hopefully it'll be 200 that'll
mean a good response and then we'll say
soup is equal to and then we'll say
beautiful soup and we'll do our page.
text now we're pulling in the
information from this URL and then we
use our parser which will be oops HTML
and let's go ahead and run this looks
like everything went well let's print
our soup now this is completely new to
you it's completely new to me I don't
know what I'm doing uh but it looks like
we're pulling in the information am I
right so we got a lot of things going
for us uh the uh stuff was imported
properly we got our URL we got our soup
which is uh not beautiful in my opinion
but let's keep on rolling let's come
right down here now what we need to do
is we we need to specify what data we're
looking for so let's come and let's
inspect this web page now the only
information that we're going to want is
right in here we're going to want these
uh titles or these headers whoops so
we're going to want rank name industry
Etc and then we are for sure going to
want all of this information let's just
scroll down see if there's anything
tricky in
here all right that looks pretty good
and there is another table so there's
not just one table in here there are two
tables in this page so that might change
things for us but let's come right back
and let's inspect our page by using this
little button right here and let's
specify in let's see if I can highlight
just this page oh it's not going oh
let's do that right there so now we have
this uh Wiki table sorter now I'm going
to actually come right here I'm going to
copy and I'm just going to say copy the
outer HTML just just going to paste in
here real quick and that's a ton of
information I didn't think it was going
to copy all of it and we're just going
to delete that I just wanted to keep
that class uh because I wanted to then
come right down here at the bottom and
just see what this table uh looks like I
don't know if it's part of it or if it's
a if it's its own
table um I can't tell let's look at this
Rank and let's come up so it says uh
it's under this
table and it looks like it's its own
table but it says Wiki table sort
sortable jQuery table sorter wikip
sortable jQuery table sorter so it looks
like there are two tables with the same
class which shouldn't be a problem if
we're using find to get our text because
we should be taking the first one which
will be this table and this is the table
we want um and if we wanted this one we
could just use find all and since it's a
list we could use index ing to pull this
table right um but I think we're going
to be okay with just pulling in this one
so let's go ahead and let's do our find
so we'll do
soup. find and we could find all or we
could just do find uh table let's just
try this and see what we get and if it
pulls in the right one that we're
looking for that' be great now this does
not look correct at all um I don't know
what table it's pulling in oh maybe it's
this right here this might be a table
yeah it is so we have this uh box more
citations so actually we are going to
have to do exactly like what I was
talking about uh let's pull
this and we well we could do comma class
uh right here and let's do both you know
what this is a learning opportunity
let's do both so let me go back up to
the top because I need these um and what
we're going to do let's come right down
here I want to add in uh another thing
actually I'll just push this one up
there we go so we're going to say findor
all let's run this so now we have
multiple and again we got that weird one
first but if we scroll down here's our
comma and then here's our wik Wiki table
sortable and then we have rank name
industry all the ones that we were
hoping to see and I guarantee you if you
scroll all the way to the bottom
um we're going to
see potentially Well Fargo Goldman Sachs
I'm pretty sure those are
um let's see yeah here we go like Ford
motor Wells Fargo Goldman Sachs that's
this table right here so now we're
looking at the third table but again
this is a list so we can use indexing on
this and we'll just choose not position
zero because that's this one right here
which we did not like well now we'll
take position one let's run this let's
go back up to the top and this is our
table right here rank name industry this
is the information that we were actually
wanting just to confirm rank name
industry Etc so this is the information
we're wanting and we're able to specify
that with our findall and this is the
information we want so we now want to
make this the only information that
we're looking at so I'm just going to
copy this we didn't need to use our
class for this one you could probably
could have um but we could so let's
actually um put this right down here
this will be our table we'll say equal
to but then I'll come right here and I'm
going to say soup. find this is just for
demonstration purposes we do table comma
class underscore is equal to and then
we'll look at this right here whoops me
do this and let's see if we get the
correct
output and let's run this and looks like
we're getting a nun type object uh if I
remember remember looks like the actual
class is this right here so let's run
this instead and I got to get rid of the
index there we go okay so we were able
to pull it in just using the find so the
find table class and it says Wiki table
sortable at least that's the HTML that
we're pulling in right here let me go
back because I don't don't know if
that's what I was seeing
earlier let's just get this rank let's
go back up
where's the
rank we go rank there we go so here's
our Rank and let's go up to the table
and there's our
class yeah and and that's just uh to me
that's a little bit odd so it says Wiki
table sortable jQuery Das table sorder
right here but in our
actual um in our actual python script
that we're running it was only pulling
in the wiki table sortable so it wasn't
pulling in the jQuery dot sorter why uh
I'm not 100% sure but all things that
we're working through and we were able
to uh we were able to figure out so
we're going to make this our table we're
going to say tables equal to uh soup.
findall and let's run this and if we
print out our table we have this table
now this is our only data that we are
looking at now the first thing that I
want to get is I want to get these
titles or these headers right here
that's where we're going to get first so
let's go in here we can just look in
this information you can see that these
are with these th tags and we can pull
out those th tags really easily let's
come right down here we're just going to
say th and we can get rid of this let's
run this now these are our only th tags
because everything else is a TR tag for
these rows of data so these th tags are
pretty unique which makes it really easy
which is really really great because
then we can just do worldcore titles is
equal to so now we have these titles but
uh they're not perfect but what we're
going to do is we're going to Loop
through it so I'm going to say worldcore
titles and I'll kind of walk through
what I'm talking about isn't a list and
each one is Within These th tags so th
and then there's our um string that
we're trying to get so we can easily
take this list and use list
comprehension and we can do that right
down here so I'm going to keep this
where we can see it um we'll do
worldcore
tore titles that's equal to now we'll do
our list comprehension should be super
easy uh we'll just say for title in
worldcore titles and then what do we
want we want title. text that's it um
because we're just taking the text from
each of these we're just looping through
and we're getting rank then We're
looping through getting name looping
through getting industry that's that's
it so let's go and print our world table
titles and see if it worked and it did
uh this looks like it needs to be
cleaned up just a little bit so let's go
ahead and do that while we're here
before we actually put it into the uh
P's data frame oops I just wanted uh I
just wanted this actually so what we're
going to do is try to get rid of those
back slash ends if we do dot strip that
may actually not work yeah uh because
this is a list what we need to do is we
can actually do it dot. text. strip
right here let's try to do it in there
there we go so now we have uh this and
now this world tables is good to go now
I'm actually noticing one thing that may
be odd yeah so we have rank name
industry goes to headquarters but then
in here we're getting rank name industry
and then the
profits which is
from this table right here which we
don't want uh let's scroll back up let's
kind of backtrack this and see where
this happened we did find all table
we're looking at the first one
right and then we're doing
[Music]
headquarters uh so we're doing print
table ah okay I think I found the issue
here and let's backtrack again this is
we're working through this together
we're going to make mistakes uh the
table is what we actually wanted to do
we just did soup. findall th which is
going to pull in that secondary table um
jeez we were not thinking here um so now
we need to do find all on the table not
the soup because now we were looking at
all of them oh what a rookie mistake
okay uh let's go back now let's look at
this now it's just down to headquarters
okay okay let's go ahead and run this
let's run this now we just have
headquarters now let's run this now we
are sitting pretty okay excuse my
mistakes Hey listen you know if it
happens to me it happens to you I
promise you this is you know this is a
project this a little U little project
we're creating here so we're going to
run into issues and that's okay we're
figuring out as we go now what I want to
do before we start pulling in all the
data is I want to put this into our
Panda's data frame we'll have the uh you
know headers there for us to go so we
won't have to get that later and it just
makes it easier uh in general trust me
so we're going to import pandas as PD
let's go ahead and run this and now
we're going to create our data frame so
we'll say PD dot now we have these world
uh table titles so what we're going to
do is pd. data frame and then in here
for our columns we'll say that's equal
to the world table titles and let's just
go ahead and say that's our data frame
and call our data frame right here let's
run it there we go so we were able to
pull out and extract those headers and
those titles of these columns we're able
to put it into our data frame so we're
set up and we're ready to go we're
rocking and rolling the next thing we
need let's go back up next thing we need
is to start pulling in this data right
here so we have to see how we can pull
this data in now if you
remember that we had those th tags those
were our titles as you can see I'm
highlighting over it but down here now
we have these TD tags and those are all
encapsulated within a TR tag so these TR
represent the row
right then the D represents the data
within those rows so R for rows D for
data so let's see how we can use that in
order to get the information that we
want so let's go back up here just going
to take this because again we're only
pulling from table not soup not soup
what were we thinking um and let's go
ahead and let's look at TR let's run
this now when we're doing this TR these
do come in with the head so we're going
to have to later on we're going to have
to get rid of these we don't want to
pull those in um and have that as part
of our data but if we scroll down
there's our
Walmart um we have the location these
are all with these TD tags and then of
course it's separated by a comma then we
have our td2 so above we had our td1 so
Row one row two Row three all the way
down now we will easily be able to use
this right because this is our column
data and we can even call it that column
underscore data is equal to we'll run
that um and what we're going to do is
we're going to Loop through that because
it was all in a list so we're going to
Loop through that information but
instead of looking at the TR tag we're
going to look at the T D tag so let's
come right down here we'll say for the
row in column
row and we'll do a colon now we need to
Loop through this we'll do something
like row. findor all all and then what
are we looking for we're not looking for
the TR looking for the TD and just for
now let's print this off see what this
looks like apparently I didn't run this
uh column data that's
why and let's run
this and what we actually need to do is
something almost exactly like
this and I'm going to put it right below
it um instead of of printing this off
because again this is all in a list
we're using find all so we're we're
printing off another list which isn't
actually super helpful um for each of or
all these data that we're pulling in
what we can do is we can call this uh
the rowcor data and then we'll put the
row data in here so we'll say four and
we'll say in row data so we'll just say
for the data in row data and we'll take
the data we'll exchange that and now
instead of uh World Table titles we can
change this into uh
individual row data right and now let's
print off the individual row data so
it's the exact same process that we were
doing up here and that's how we cleaned
it up and got this and we may not need
to strip but let's just run this and see
what we get there we go um and strip I'm
sure was helpful let's actually get rid
of
this yeah strip was helpful is the exact
same thing that happened on the last one
so let's keep that actually let's run
this and now let's just kind of glance
at this information let's look through
it this looks exactly like the
information that's in the table let's
just confirm with this first one uh 25
uh two what am I saying 572 754 2.4
2300 57275 2.4 2200 so this looks
exactly correct now we have to figure
out a way to get this into our table
because again these are all individual
lists it's not like we're just you know
putting all of this in at one time we
can't just take the entire table and
plop it into um into the data frame we
need a way to kind of put this in one at
a time now if you're just here for web
scraping and you haven't taken like my
panda series that's totally fine that's
not what we're here for anyways um but
what we can do we'll have our individual
row data and we're going to put it in
kind of one at a time time now the
reason we have to do that is because
when we had it like this and let's go
back when we had it like this it's
printing out all of it but what it's
really doing and let's get rid of it um
what it's really doing is it's kind of
doing it like this it's printing it off
one at a time and it's only going to
save that current row of data this last
one it's only going to save that as it's
looping through so what we actually want
to do is every time it Loops through we
append this information onto the data
data frame so as it goes through and
eventually it's going to end up with
this one but as it goes through let's
run this as it goes through it puts this
one in and then the next time it Loops
through it puts this one in and the next
time it Loops through Etc all the way
down um so let's see how we can do this
so we have our data frame right here
let's get rid of this let's bring our
data frame in now again like I just
mentioned if you don't know pandas and
you haven't learned that uh you know go
take my uh series on that it's really
good and we do something very similar to
this in that Series so I'm not going to
kind of walk through the entire logic um
but there is something called Lo which
stands for location when you're looking
at the index on a data frame and we're
going to use that to our advantage so
we're going to say the length of the
data frame so we're looking at how many
rows are in this data frame and then
we're going to say that's our length
then we're going to take that length and
use it when we're actually putting in
this new information pretty um pretty
cool so we're going to say df.loc then a
bracket and we're putting in that length
so we're checking the length of our data
frame each time it's looping through and
then we're going to put the information
in the next position that's exactly what
we're doing so let's go ahead and put in
the individual row data um so let's just
recap We're looping through this TR this
is our column data so these TR that's
our row of data then we're as
as We're looping through it we're doing
find all and looking for TD tags that's
our individual data so that's our row
data then we're taking that data each
piece of data and we're getting out the
text and we're stripping it to kind of
clean it and now it's in a list for each
individual row then we're looking at our
current data frame which has nothing in
it right now we're looking at the length
of it and we're appending each row of
this information into the next position
so let's go ahead and run this
it's working it's thinking and it looks
like we got an issue canot set a row
with mismatched columns now we're
encountering an issue not one that I got
earlier but we're going to cancel this
out we're going to figure this out
together so let's print off our
individual row data let's look at this
this one is empty uh this is I'm almost
certain is probably the issue um I
didn't encounter this issue when I wrote
these uh when I wrote this lesson um but
I'm almost certain that this is the
issue right here so let's do the column
data but let's start at position um
let's try one and not parentheses I need
brackets because this is a list right so
it should work and there we go so now
that first one's gone so now we just
have the information I didn't even think
about that um just a second ago but I'm
glad we're running into it in case you
ran into that uh issue let's go ahead
and try this
again and it looked like it worked so
let's pull our data frame down I could
have just wrote DF let's pull our data
frame down and now this is looking
fantastic now um these three dots just
mean there's information in there just
doesn't want to display it but it looks
like we have our rank we have our name
have the industry revenue revenue growth
employees and headquarters for every
single one so this is perfect now this
is exactly what I was hoping to get now
you can go in and use pandas and
manipulate this and change it and you
know dive into all the information in
there but we can also export this into a
CSV if that's what you're wanting so we
could easily do that by saying we'll do
DF do2 CSV and then within here we're
just going to do R and specify our file
path so let's come down here to our file
path then we'll go to our folder for our
output so we're just going to take this
path and let me do it like that so I
have this path in my one drive documents
python webscript being folder for output
so you know I already made this um and
I'm just going to put this right down
here now I do have to specify what we're
going to call this um we'll just call
this companies and then we have to say
CSV that is very important now if we run
this I already know just because uh we
have this Rank and this index here we're
going to keep this index in the output
not great uh but let's run it let's look
at our
output there's our companies and when we
pull this up as you can see this is not
what we want because we have this extra
thing right here now if we're automating
this this would get super annoying so
what we're going to do is go back and
just say index equals false let's go out
of here and now we're just going to come
right down here we're going to say comma
index equals false and so it's going to
take this index and it's not going to
import or actually export it into the
CSV now let's go ahead and run
this let's pull up our folder one more
time and let's refresh just to make sure
should be good and now this looks a lot
better so we're able to take all of that
information and put it into a CSV and
it's all there so this is the whole
project so if we scroll all the way back
up let's just kind of glance at what we
did here scroll down we brought in our
libraries and packages we specified our
URL we brought in our soup um and then
we tried to find our table now that took
a little bit of uh testing out but we
knew that the table was the second one
so in position one so we took that table
we were also able to specify it using
find but then we used the class and of
course we just wanted to work with that
table that's all the data we wanted so
we specifi this is our table and we
worked with just our table going forward
of course uh we encountered some small
issues user errors on my end but we were
able to get our world titles and we put
those into our data frame right here
using pandas then next we went back and
we got all the row data and the
individual data from those rows and we
put it into our Panda data frame then we
came below and we exported this into an
actual CSV file so that is how we can
use webs scraping to get data from
something like a table and put it into a
panda data frame I hope that this lesson
was helpful I know we encountered some
issues that's on my end and I apologize
but if you run into those same issues
hopefully that helped uh but I hope this
was helpful and if you like this be sure
to like And subscribe below I appreciate
you I love you and I will see you in the
next
[Music]
lesson so the first thing that we need
to do is import our Panda's Library so
we're going to say import we're going to
say pandas now this will import the
pandas library but it's pretty common
place to give it an alias and as a
standard when using pandas people will
say as PD so this is just a quick Alias
that you can use uh that's what I always
use and I've always used it because
that's how I learned it and I want to
teach it to you the right way so that's
how we're going to do it in this video
so let's hit shift enter now that that
is imported we can start reading in our
files now right down here I'm going to
open up my file explorer and we have
several different types of files in here
we have CSV files text files Json files
and an Excel worksheet which is a little
bit different than a CSV so we're going
to import all of those I'm going to show
you how to import it as well as some of
the different things that you need to be
aware of when you're importing so we're
going to import some of those different
file types and I'll show you how to do
that within pandas so the first thing
that we need to say is PD Dot and let's
read in a CSV because that's a pretty
common one we'll say
read
CSV and this is liter literally all you
have to write in order to call it in now
it's not going to call it in as a string
like it would in one of our previous
videos if you're just using the regular
operating system of python when you're
using pandas it calls it in as a data
frame and I'll talk about some of the
nuances of that so let's go down to our
file explorer we have this countries of
the world CSV you just need to click on
it and rightclick and copy as path and
that's literally going to copy that file
path for us you don't have to type it
out manually you can if You' like and
we're just going to paste it in between
these parentheses now if we run it right
now it will not work I'll do that for
you it's saying we have this Unicode
error uh basically what's happening is
is it's reading in these backs slashes
and this colon and all those back
clashes in there and this period at the
end what we need to do is read this in
as a raw text so we're just going to say
R and now it's going to read this as a
literal string or a literal value and
not as you know with all these back
slashes which does make a big difference
when we run this it's going to populate
our very first data frame so let's go
ahead and run it and now we have this
CSV in here with our country and our
region now if we go and pull up this
file and let's do that really quickly
let's bring up this country's of the
world it automatically populated those
headers for us in the data frame but we
don't have any column for those 0 1 2 3
so if we go back as you can see right
here there's this index and that's
really important in a data frame it's
really makes a data frame a data frame
and we use index a lot in pandas we're
able to filter on the index search on
the index and a lot of other things
which I'll show you in future videos but
this is basically how you read in a file
now if we go right up here in between
these parentheses and we hit shift tab
this is going to come up for us let's
hit this plus button and what this is is
these are all the arguments or all the
things that we can specify when we're
reading in a file and there are a lot of
different opts options so let's go ahead
and take a look really quickly really
quickly I wanted to give a huge shout
out to the sponsor of this entire Panda
series and that is udemy udemy has some
of the best courses at the best prices
and it is no exception when it comes to
pandas courses if you want to master
pandas this is the course that I would
recommend it's going to teach you just
about everything you need to know about
pandas so huge shout out to you me for
sponsoring this Panda series and let's
get back to the video the first thing is
obviously the file path we can specify a
separator which there is no default so
when we're pulling in this CSV when
we're reading in the CSV it's
automatically going to assume it's a
comma CU it's a comma separated uh file
you can choose delimers headers names
index columns and a lot of other things
as you can see right here now I will say
that I don't use almost any of these uh
the few that I'm going to show you
really quickly in just a second are up
the very top but you can do a ton of
different things and I'm just going to
slowly go through them so that's what
those are you can also go down here this
is our dock string and you can see
exactly how these parameters work it'll
show you and give you a text and walk
you through how to do this again most of
these you'll probably never use but
things like a separator could actually
be useful and things like a header could
be useful because it is possible that
you want to either rename your headers
or you don't have a header in your CSV
and you don't want it to autop populate
that header so that is something that
you can specify so for example this
header one I'll show you how to do this
uh the default behaviors is to infer
that there are column names if no names
are passed this behavior is identical to
header equals zero so it's saying that
first row or that first index which is
like right here that zero is going to be
read in as a header but we can come
right over here and we'll do comma
header is equal to and we can say none
and as you can see there are no headers
now instead it's another index so we
have index indexes on both the x- axis
and the Y AIS and so right now we have
this zero and one index indicating the
First Column and the second column if we
want to specify those names we can say
the header equals none then we can say
names is equal to and we'll give it a
list and so the first one was country
and what's that second one oh region so
right here that's the first um the first
row but we'll rename it and we'll just
say country region and when we run that
we've now populated the country and the
region uh we're just pretending that our
CSV does not have these values in it and
we have to name it ourselves that's how
you do it but let's get rid of all that
because we actually do want those in
there so we're just going to get rid of
those and read it in as normal and there
we go now typically when you're reading
in a file what you need to do is you
want to assign that to a variable almost
always when you see any tutorial or
anybody online or even when you're
actually working people will say DF is
equal to DF stands for data frame again
this is a data frame in the next video
in this series I'm going to walk through
what a series is as well as what a data
frame is because that's pretty important
to know when you're working with these
data frames but we'll assign it to this
value and then we'll say we'll call it
by saying DF and we'll run it and that's
typically how you'll do things because
you want to save this data frame so
later on you can do things like data
frame Dot and you can uh you know pass
in different modules but you can't
really do that it's not as easy to do it
if you're calling this entire CSV and
importing it every time so let's copy
this because now we're going to import a
different type of file so now we've been
doing read CSV but we can also import
text files now you can do that with the
read CSV we can import text files let's
look at this one we have the same one
it's countries of the world except now
it's a text file because I just
converted it for this video I'll copy
that as a path and so now when we do
this oops let me get
those quotes in there it'll say world.
txt it will still work as you can see
this did not import properly um we have
this country back SLT region and then
all of our values are the exact same
with this back SLT that's because we
need to use a separator and I'll show
you in just a little bit how we can do
this in a different way but with that
read CSV this is how we can do it we'll
just say sep is equal to we need to do
back SLT now let's try running this and
as you can see it now has it broken out
into country and region we could also do
it the more proper way and this is the
way you should do it and I'll get rid of
these really quickly but just want to
keep them there in case you want to see
that but you can also do read table and
let's get rid of this
separator and now we have no separators
just reading it in as a table let's run
this and it reads it in proper L the
first time this read table can be used
for tons of different data types but
typically I've been using it for like
text files um we can also read in that
CSV so let's change this right here to
CSV we can read it in as a CSV but just
like we did in the last one when we read
in the text file using read CSV this
read table you're going to need to
specify the separator so I'll just copy
this and we'll say comma and now it
reads it in properly again you can use
that for a ton of different file types
but you just need to specify a few more
things if you don't want to use the more
specific read uncore function when
you're using pandas now let's copy this
again we're going to go right down here
and now let's do Json files Json files
usually hold semi structured data um
which is definitely different than very
structured data like a CSV where has
columns and rows so let's go to our file
explorer we have this Json sample we
will copy this in as the
path let's paste it right here and we'll
do reor Json again these different
functions were built out specifically
for these file types that's why you know
each one has a different name so now
we're reading this in as the
Json let's read it in and it read it in
properly now let's go ahead and copy
this and take a look at Excel files
because Excel files are a little bit
different than other ones that we've
looked at
um so let's just do read uncore
Excel and let's go down to our file
explorer and let's actually open up this
workbook as you can see we have sheet
one right here but we also have this
world population which has a lot more
data let's say we just wanted to read in
sheet one we can do that or by default
it's going to read in this world
population because it's the first sheet
in the Excel file well let's go ahead
and take a look at that let's get out of
here and and let's say oops I forgot to
copy the file path let's go ahead and
copy as path and we'll put it right
here and let's just read it in with no
arguments or anything in there or no
parameters when we read it in it's
reading in that very first sheet so this
is the one that has all of the data now
let's say we wanted to read in that
extra sheet name or the second sheet
name we'll just go comma sheet undor
name say is equal to and then we can
specify sheet was it sheet one like this
yes it was so we just had to specify the
sheet name right here and then it
brought in that sheet instead of the
default which is the very first sheet in
that Excel now that definitely covers a
lot of how you read in those files again
you can come in here and hit shift Tab
and this plus sign and take a look at
all the documentation and you can
specify a lot of different things things
that I didn't think were very important
for you guys to know especially if
you're just starting out the ones that
we looked at today are what I would say
are like the ones that I use almost all
the time so I wanted to show you those
but if you're interested in any of these
other ones or you have very unique data
and you need to do that um you know it's
worth really getting in here and
figuring things out a few other things
that I wanted to show you just in this
kind of first video or this intro video
on how to read in files um one thing
that you may have noticed especially in
this file right here is we're only
looking at the first five and then the
last five so if we wanted to see all the
data all the data is in these like
little three dots right here right we
want to be able to see that data but
right now we can't and that's because of
some settings that are already within
pandas and all we need to do is change
that so this one has 234 rows and four
columns so obviously we can see all the
columns well let's just change the rows
all we'll say is pd. set uncore option
now what we need to do is we're going to
change the rows we're not going to
change the columns at least not on this
one so we'll say quote
display. max. rows now if we just run
this for whatever data we bring in it's
going to be able to show the max rows
and then we'll say
235 although there's 234 rows I'm just
going to be safe let's run
this and now it has changed it so let's
read in this file again and you'll see
how it's
changed now we have all the numbers and
we have this little bar on the right
that allows us to go down all the way to
the bottom and all the way to the top so
now we can actually look and kind of
skim and see our values I like that
better than just having that you know
shorter version um we can do the exact
same thing on columns as well so if we
look at this one this is our Json file
has the same thing right here we have
what was it 38 columns but we can only
see I think it's maybe it's 20 or
something like that I can't remember um
but we have 38 we can only see like
let's say 15 of them or 20 of them we'll
do the exact same thing and we'll just
say pd. set options.
max.
columns and we'll set that to 40 for
that one when we run this oops let's get
over here when we run this one again we
can now scroll over and see every single
one of our columns now that one is a in
my opinion a lot more useful I like
being able to see every single column so
definitely something that you should be
using especially when you have these
really large files you want to be able
to see a lot of the data and a lot of
the columns so when you're slicing and
dicing and doing all the things that
we're about to learn in this Panda
series you know you know what you're
looking at I also want to show you just
how to kind of look at your data in
these data frames as well that's also
pretty important so let's go right down
here and the very last one that we
imported was this one right here this
read Excel so this data frame is the
only one that's going going to read in
let's run it um this is the last one to
be run so this variable right here DF uh
it won't be applied to all these other
ones which we can always go back and
change those typically you'll do
something like data frame two you want
to do something like that um so let's
keep data Frame 2 oops so what we're
going to do is we're going to bring data
Frame 2 right down here and we want to
take a look at some of this data we want
to know a little bit more about it
something that you can do is dataframe
2. info and we'll do an open parenthesis
and when we run this it's going to give
us a really quick breakdown of a little
bit of our data so we have our columns
right here rank CCA 3 country and
capital it's saying we have
234 values in those columns because
there's
234 scroll up here because there's
234 uh rows that tells me that there's
no missing data in here at least not you
know completely missing like null values
there is something something in each of
those rows the count tells me it's non-
null so there's no null values and it
tells me the data type so it's ringing
in as an integer an object an object and
an object and it also tells us how much
memory it's using which is also pretty
neat because when you get really really
large data types memory usage and and
knowing how to work around that stuff
does become more important than when
you're working at these really small You
Know sample sizes that we're looking at
we can also do oops let me get rid of
that can also do data frame two
and we'll do shape and for this one we
do not need the
parentheses and all this is going to
tell us is we have 234 rows and four
columns we're also able to look at uh
the first few values or rows in each of
these data frames so we can just say
data frame 2. head and if we do that
it's going to give us the first five
values but we can specify how many we
want we can say head 10 it'll give us
the first 10 rows right here we can do
the exact same thing and let's go right
down here and we'll say tail so they'll
give us the last 10 rows within our data
frame now let's copy this and let's say
we don't want to actually look at all of
these values or all these columns we can
specify that by saying df2 and oops
let's get rid of all of
this and we'll say with a quote we'll
say Rank and now we can take just a look
at the rank data now we can't do that by
doing the index or at least not like
this if we want to use this index that
is right here we can but there's a very
special function called Lo and IO for
that and I'm going to have an entire
video on this because it does get a
little bit more complex but there's
df2 and there's Lo and I stands for
location and I location that's only for
the indexes whether it's the x axis or
the Y AIS those are the indexes and for
location it's looking for the actual
text the actual string of the index so
if we come up here that data Frame 2 we
can specify
224 and it'll give us this information
right here in a little different format
so let's go bracket and we'll say
224 and when we run this it gives us our
rank CCA country capital with our values
over here kind of like a dictionary
almost now let's copy this and we'll say
df2 do IO and right now these look the
exact same but we haven't really talked
a lot about changing the index and you
can change the index to a string or a
different column or something like that
and we'll look at that in future videos
the iock looks at the integer location
so even if these um let's go right up
here even if this index had changed to
let's say this rank or this CCA 3 or
country or whatever you make this index
the ILO will still look at the integer
location so that 224 would still be 224
even if it was usbekistan
so then when we look at this it's going
to be the exact same but if we had
changed that Index this Lo is the one
that we could search on and we could
search
usuzan is that how you spell usbekistan
hey I nailed it so that is how you use
Lo and IO again I just wanted to show
you a little bit about how you can look
at your data frame or search within your
data frame now in future videos I'm
going to dive a lot deeper into a lot of
the concepts that we just looked at
because I just kind of touched on them I
wanted you to have a brief introduction
to them so that in future videos I'm not
just dropping everything on you all at
once so hopefully this was a good quick
introduction to those topics uh you
should be able to read in a file now see
your data frame and kind of look at it
in a few different ways that we just
looked at and I hope that that was
helpful and if it was be sure to check
out all my other videos on Python and
pandas and if you like this video be
sure to like And subscribe below and I
will see you in the next
[Music]
video
hello everybody today we're going to be
looking at filtering and ordering data
frames in pandas there are a lot of
different ways you can filter and order
your data in pandas and I'm going to try
to show you all of the main ways that
you can do that so let's kick it off by
importing our data set so we're going to
say data frame is equal to and we'll say
pandas and I need to import my pandas so
we'll say import pandas as p
that's pretty important I think um so
pd. read CSV and we'll do R and then
we'll say the world population CSV so
let's run this all our data frame right
here and this is the data frame that
we're going to be filtering through and
ordering in pandas so let's kick it off
the first thing that we can do is filter
based off of The Columns so the data
within our columns so Asia Europe Africa
or whatever data we may have in that
column let's go right down here we're
going to say DF and then within it we're
going to specify what column we're going
to be filtering on so we're going to say
DF with another bracket and we'll say
rank so we're going to be looking at
this rank column right here and we'll
say in that rank column we want to do
greater than 10 and that's actually
going to be a lot of them let's do less
than so when we run this it's only going
to return these values that are less
than 10 we can also do less than equal
to you know all of these um comparison
operators so less than or equal to so
now we have all of the ranks 1 through
10 now if we look at these countries we
can specify by specific values almost
exactly like we did here but instead of
doing a comparison operator like we did
right here and including those names
let's say Bangladesh and Brazil we can
use the is in function almost like an in
function in SQL if you know SQL so let's
go right down here and we're going to
say specific underscore countries so
right now we're just going to make a
list of the countries that we want and
then we'll say
Bangladesh and
Brazil so let's go right down here and
we'll say okay for these specific
countries from the data frame let's do
our bracket we'll say in this country
column so we'll do data frame and then
another bracket for country so in this
country column we can do do is in and
then an open parenthesis and then look
for our specific countries so we're
looking at just this column and we're
saying is in so we're looking at are
these values within this column and
we're getting this error and this looks
very very odd let me um this doesn't
look right there we go I just had some
syntax errors I apologize made it way
more complicated than it needs to be but
here's how you use this is in function
so we're looking at Bangladesh and
Brazil and we return those rows with
Bangladesh and Brazil really quickly I
wanted to give a huge shout out to the
sponsor of this entire Panda series and
that is udemy udemy has some of the best
courses at the best prices and it is no
exception when it comes to pandas
courses if you want to master pandas
this is the course that I would
recommend it's going to teach you just
about everything you need to know about
pandas so huge shout out to UD me for
sponsoring this Panda series and let's
get back to the video we can also do a
contains function kind of similar to is
in except it's more like the like in SQL
as well I'm comparing a lot of this to
SQL CU When You're filtering things I
always my brain always goes to SQL but
in pandas it's called the contains so
let's do let's actually copy this
because I don't want to make the same
mistake again let's do that and we'll do
the bracket but instead of dot is in
we're going to do string. contains and
then an open parenthesis so we're going
to going to be looking for a string if
it contain if it contains let's do
United almost like United States or or
any other United so let's run this and
as you can see we have United Arab
Emirates United Kingdom United States
United States Virgin Islands so we can
kind of search for a specific string or
a number or a value within our data or
within that column of country now so far
we've only been looking at how you can
filter on these columns we can also fil
filter based off of the index as well
and there's two different ways you can
do it or two of the main ways there's
filter and then there's L and IO Lo
stands for location and IO stands for
integer location and if you've seen
other previous videos I've kind of
mentioned those so we can take a quick
look at all of those so really quickly
we need to set an index because the
index right now is uh not the best we'll
set our index to
Country so let's say
df2
is equal to DF do setor index and we'll
say country I'm just doing df2 because
later on I want to use that data frame
again so I'm just going to assign it to
another data frame so that we can just
easily switch back and forth so now we
have this index as the country and what
we can do is use the filter function so
let's go down here we'll say
df2
filter and we'll do an open parenthesis
and now we can specify our items so
these are actually going to be
specifying which columns we want to keep
so we're going to say items is equal to
then we'll make a list we'll say
continent hope that's how we spell
continent I'm always messing up with my
uh my stuff here my spelling then we'll
do CCA 3 because why not you can specify
whichever ones you want when we run this
it's going to only bring in those two
columns Now by default it's choosing the
access for us but we can also specify
which axis we want to search on so if we
say axis is equal to zero it's actually
going to search this axis this is the
zero axis this is the one axis so where
our columns are is one so if we go back
and do one we're searching on that one
Axis or those header axises again and
this is the default but you can specify
that so if you just want to search on uh
you know filtering right here you can do
that and let's actually copy this and do
that right down here just you can see
what it looks like but let's search for
Zimbabwe and we'll do Zimbabwe and we'll
be looking at the zero axis which is the
up and down on the left hand side and
when we filter on that we can filter by
Zimbabwe by looking just at the country
index we can also use the like just like
we did before and I'll show you the
exact same demonstration that we did
which you can say like is equal to and
instead of having to put in a concrete
um text text you can just say United
just like we did before and we're
searching where the axis is equal to
zero which again is this left-handed
access so now we're looking for United
and it's going to give us all of the
countries or all the indexed values that
have United in it like we were talking
about before we also have l and ILO so
we can say data frame 2. L now this is a
specific value so we'll do United States
so location is just looking at the
actual name or the value of it not its
position so if we search for United
States it's going to give us this right
here where it gives us all of the
columns for United States and then all
of the uh values for United States or we
can
do the io which is the energ location
which is not the exact same because
we're looking at the string for the L
we're looking at this string but
underneath it there still is a position
that's that integer location let's do a
completely random one let's just say
three if we look at the third position
it's going to give us ASM which I'm not
exactly sure what it is but it still
gives us basically the same kind of
output which is the columns and the
values so that's another way that you
can search within your index when you're
actually trying to filter down that data
now let's go look at the order bu and
let's start with the very first one that
we looked at let's do data frame that's
why I kept it because I wanted to use it
later now we can sort and order these
values instead of it just being kind of
a jumbled mess in here we can sort these
columns however we would like ascending
descending multiple columns single
columns and let's look at how to do that
so we'll say data frame and then we'll
do data frame look at rank again just
like we were doing above and let's do
data frame where it's less than 10 I
should have just gone and copyed this I
apologize so now we have this data frame
that is greater than 10 now we can do do
sortore values and this is the function
that's going to allow us to sort
everything that we want to sort so we
can do buy is equal to and we'll just
order it by the exact same thing that we
were doing or calling it on we'll do
rank so now what this is going to do
it's going to order our rank
column and as you can see it did that
one 2 3 4 5 we can also do it with
ascending or descending so if you want
to you can look here and see what you
can do so we'll do
ascending we'll say that's equal to
true and so that's the automatic default
so that didn't change anything but if we
say false it's going to be descending
from highest to lowest so now we have it
in the opposite direction now we don't
have to just order or sort this on one
single column we can do multiple columns
and we can do that by making a list
right here whoops make a
list just like that and we'll input
different ones as well so now let's
input our
country and when we run this it will
give us rank of
9876 as well as the country of Russia
Bangladesh Brazil now if you noticed the
country really didn't change because the
rank stayed the exact same that's
because there's an order of importance
here and it starts with the very first
one if we change this around and we look
at this
one and put a com right here
now the country is going to be descended
and the rank would come second so it's
not going the rank isn't going to really
have any effect here so now we have the
country United States Russia Pakistan
and the rank really didn't get ordered
at all now if we want to see how that
can actually work let's do continent
right here and actually put it right
here and do country here so if we run
this it's first going to come and it's
going to organize or sort the continent
then it's going to come come back and go
to the country and then it's going to
sort the country so keep so keep your
eye right here in this Asia area because
we're going to sort this differently
than ascending so we have ascending
false and that applies to both of these
it's false and false but we can specify
which one we want to do we can do a
false here and a true here so we'll do
false comma true and what this is going
to do is it's going to say false for the
continent so the continent right here is
going to stay the exact same and so that
is a lot of how you can filter and order
your data within pandas I hope that this
was helpful I hope that you enjoyed this
video if you liked it be sure to like
And subscribe below check out all my
other videos on Python and pandas and I
will see you in the next
[Music]
video hello everybody today we're going
to be looking at indexing and pandas if
you remember from previous videos the
index is an object that stores the
access labels for all Panda objects the
index in a data frame is extremely
useful because it's customizable and you
can also search and filter based off of
that index in this video we're going to
talk all about indexing how you can
change the index and customize that as
well as how you can search and filter on
that index and then we're also going to
be looking at something a little bit
more advanced called multi- indexing and
you won't always use it but it's really
good to know in case you come across a
data frame that has that
so let's get started by importing pandas
import pandas as PD now we'll get our
first data frame we say DF is equal to
pd. read CSV and I've already copied
this but we're going to do R and we're
going to put this file path so I have
this world population CSV I will have
that in the description just like I do
in all of my other videos let's run DF
and let's take a look at this data frame
so we have a lot of information here we
have rank country continent population
as well as the default index from zero
all the way up to 233 now if you haven't
watched any of my previous videos on
pandas the index is pretty important and
it's basically just a number or a label
for each row it doesn't even necessarily
have to be a unique number um you can
create or add an index yourself if you
want to and it doesn't have to be unique
but it it really should be unique uh
especially if you want to use it
appropriately for what we're doing the
country is actually going to be a pretty
great index because the country you know
is going to be all unique because we're
looking at every single row as a
different um country as well as the
population so let's go ahead and create
this country or add this country as our
index now we can do this in a lot of
different ways but the first way that
you can do this if you already know what
you are going to create that index on is
we can just go right in here when we're
reading in this file and we'll say comma
index underscore oops I I spelled that
completely wrong index uncore column and
we'll say that is equal to and then
we're going to say quote country so
we're taking this country and we're
going to assign it as the index now
let's read this in and as you can see
this is our index now it looks a little
bit different we didn't have this
country header right here which is
specifying that this is still the
country but you can tell that this is
the index based off the um bold letters
as well as it being on the far left and
all the regular columns for the data is
over here while the country header is
right here and it's lower than all the
others just a quick way that you can see
that that is the index now before we
move on I want to show you some other
ways that you can do this as well but
I'm going to show you how to reverse
this index before we move on and we'll
say data frame so we had our data frame
right here so we have data frame dot
we'll say reset index and then we'll say
in place is equal to True which means we
don't have to assign this to another
variable and all that stuff it'll just
be true so now when we run that data
frame again the index was reset to the
default numbers so now let's go down
here I'll show you how to do this in a
different way you can do DF do we'll say
setor index and then we'll just say
country so very similar to when we were
reading in that file and we said set the
index or that index column we said index
column equals country if we do this and
we run it in it works but if we say data
frame right down here it's not going to
save that if we want to save it just
like we did above we're going to say in
place is equal to true that is going to
save it to where we don't have to assign
it another variable so now when we run
this the data frame right here which is
going to populate this the data frame is
going to say in place is equal to true
so that country will now be our index
again let's run this and there we go
really quickly I wanted to give a huge
shout out to the sponsor of this entire
panda series and that is udemy udemy has
some of the best courses at the best
prices and it is no exception when it
comes to pandas courses if you want to
master pandas this is the course that I
would recommend it's going to teach you
just about everything you need to know
about pandas so huge shout out to UD to
me for sponsoring this Panda series and
let's get back to the video now what's
really great about this index is we're
able to search based off just this index
and so we can filter on it and basically
look through our data with it and there
are two different ways that you can do
that at least this is a very common way
that people who use pandas we'll do to
kind of search through that index the
first one is called lock and there's
lock and iock that stands for location
or integer location let's look at lock
first let's say df.loc and then we'll do
a bracket now we're able to specify the
actual string the label so let's go
right up here and let's say
Albania so we'll say Albania so again
this is just looking at the location
let's run this now it's going to bring
up all the Albania data just like here
where it's kind of looks like a column
in a column and we can get this exact
same data but using iock right here and
when we ran lock we were searching based
off Albania which is in the 01 position
so if we actually pull the one position
for that
integer the iock we can look at the one
position and this should give us the
exact same data now let's take a look at
multi- indexing and we'll come back to a
little bit of this in a second so multi-
indexing is creating multiple indexes
we're not just going to create the
country as the index now we're going to
add an additional index on top of that
so let's pull up our data frame right
now we have the country but let's do do
reset
index and we'll say in place equals true
oops let's run it so now we have our
data frame now let's set our index but
this time when we set our index we're
going to add the country as the index as
well as the continent as an index so
we'll say data frame. setor index then
we'll do a parenthesis and instead of
just doing country like we did before
we're going to create a list oops and
we'll do it like that and then we'll
say oops
continent and separate it by a comma so
we have continents and Country let's
just say in place is equal to true now
when we run this we're going to have two
indexes and let's see what this looks
like and let's run this so now we have
country as well as continent as our
index now you may notice that these
indexes are repeating themselves on this
continent index we have Europe right
here and Europe right here as well as
Asia and Asia and it looks a little bit
funky but we are able to sort these
values and make they look a lot better
so let's go ahead and try this we'll do
DF do sortore index and when we run this
it should sort our index alphabetically
and we can also look in here and see
what kind of things we can you know
specify we can specify the axis but it's
automatically going to be looking at the
zero this is zero and this is one so we
have two axes within our data frame you
can choose the level whether it's
ascending or not ascending in place kind
string sort remaining all of these
different things the only one that I
really you know think is worth looking
at is the ascending we already know some
of these other ones but if we look at
ascending let's run it now it's sorted
these and so now it's kind of grouped
together so we have Africa and all the
African ones as well as South America
and all the South American ones let's
really quickly say
pd. setor
option and we'll say display.
max. columns and just like this let's
run it and I need to specify whoops
specify right here let's see how many
rows we
have 235 so let's do
235 let's run this and now when we run
this you can see that Africa is all
grouped together and all the countries
are in alphabetical order under it and
then we go all the way down to Asia and
again just all in alphabetical order if
we wanted to we could say
ascending equals
true and then when we run this oh I
meant to say false and then when we run
this it's the exact opposite so it
starts with South America the last one
and then goes in reverse alphabetical
order we could also say false make it a
list and do comma
true and just like this and then it
would sort this First Column as false
and this next column as true so you can
really customize it but you know for
what we're doing we don't need any of
that we just need to be able to see this
right here so now when we try to search
by our index like we did before we did
data frame. Loke now when we did that
and we said you know let's say Angola
when we specified Angola it's not going
to work properly because it's searching
in this first index for the first string
that we have we can search Africa
let's search for
Africa and now we have all of the
African countries and if we want to
specify to Angola we can also go down
another level oops by doing Ang
Angola and now we have what we were
looking at before where we're calling
all the data within those but we
couldn't do it just based off Africa
because we had an additional Index right
here so once we called both indexes now
we get this view but let's look at that
I look really
quick when we run this let's just say
one because right up here oh we have
Angola zero and then one so you think it
may pull up Angola let's go ahead and
run this and it's still pulling up
Albania let's go right up here if you
remember when we didn't have the
multiple indexes it was pulling up
Albania the difference when you're doing
these multi- indexes is that the the L
is able to specify this whereas this one
does not go based off that multi-
indexing it's going to go based off the
initial index or the integer based index
so that's a lot about indexing in pandas
we'll cover even a few more things in
future videos as we get more and more
into pandas but this is a lot of what
indexing looks like within pandas and
again super important to learn how to do
and know how to do because it's a pretty
important building block as we go
through this Panda series so I hope you
enjoyed this video on indexing if you
did be sure to like And subscribe below
and I will see you in the next
[Music]
video hello everybody today we're going
to be taking a look at the group by
function and aggregating within panas
group I is going to group together the
values in a column and display them all
on the same row and this allows you to
perform aggregate functions on those
groupings so let's start reading in our
data and take a look so we're going to
do import pandas as
PD and then we're going to say our data
frame is equal to and we'll say pd. read
CSV we'll do an open parenthesis R and
our file path and we're going to be
looking at the flavors CSV right here so
right here we have our flavor of ice
cream we have our base flavor flavor
whether it was vanilla or chocolate
whether I liked it or not the flavor
rating texture rating and its overall or
its total rating now these are all my
own personal scores so you know I've
spent years researching this so these
are all very accurate but this should be
a low stress environment to learn Group
by and the aggregate functions so the
first thing that we can do is look at
our group by now you can't Group by well
you can you can Group by flavor but as
you can see these are all unique values
what we need is something that has
duplicate values or or similar values on
different rows that'll group together so
this base flavor is actually a perfect
one to group it on and we'll do that by
saying DF do group by do an open
parenthesis and we'll just specify base
flavor and this will then group together
those values and I need to make sure I
can spell properly this will group those
flavors together so let's run this and
as you can see it actually is its own
object so it has a group by data frame
Group by object so now that we've
grouped them let's give it a variable so
we'll say group underscore byor frame
let's say that's equal to Let's copy
this we'll run it and now what we need
to do is run our aggregations in order
to get an output so we're going to say
mean and that's all we're going to put
just for now just to get an output that
we can take a look off and then we'll
build from there so let's go ahead and
run this and right here we have our base
flavor which is now saying is the index
of chocolate or vanilla and then it's
taking the mean or the average of all
the columns that have integers notice
that it did not take the liked column
and it did not take the flavor column
because those are strings and they
cannot aggregate those and we'll take a
look at that later but it took all the
values that have integers and then it
gave us the average of those ratings
really quickly I wanted to give a huge
shout out to the sponsor of this entire
Panda series and that is udemy udemy has
some of the best courses at the best
prices and it is no exception when it
comes to pandas courses if you want to
master pandas this is the course that I
would recommend it's going to teach you
just about everything you need to know
about pandas so huge shout out to UD me
for sponsoring this Panda series and
let's get back to the video so right off
the bat as averages with chocolate I
have a much higher rating overall than
the ones with vanilla bases now we can
actually combine all of this together
into one line and we can do something
like this so we'll
say DF do group by and we'll say mean
just like this and this will actually
run it before we didn't have any
aggregating function on there so it
didn't run but now that we combine it
all into one it will run properly now
there are a lot of different aggregate
functions but I'm going to show you some
of the most popular ones or the most
common ones that you will see so let's
copy this right here so we can do dot
count and when we run this we can look
at the count and this will show us the
actual count of the rows that were
aggregated so for chocolate we have
three so there going to be three all the
way across and for vanilla we had six so
we're looking at a higher count of
vanilla which if you're comparing it to
this mean up here that could be a big
skew towards the chocolate because if
you have one or two good chocolates it
could really pull the numbers up whereas
if you had two good vanillas but all the
other ones were bad it pulls that
average down so knowing the count of
something something is really
good let's take a look at the next one
and we can do Min and Max and I'll just
run these really quickly we can do Min
and when we run this the first thing
that you should notice is that it now
has a flavor and a liked column and
that's because Min and Max will actually
look at the first letter in the string
or the first set of letters if there are
um you know chocolate something it'll
look at the first and then it'll
actually populate it so chocolate with
the CH chocolate is the very first or
the minimum value for that string and
for a cake batter that is the minimum
value in vanilla as well now with the
liked it's interesting because
apparently I liked all the chocolate
ones I'm going to go take a look so
chocolate I liked chocolate I liked
chocolate I lik so there is no no option
in this liked column so yes was the only
option and now let's look at Max
whoops and it should do the exact
opposite which is going to take the
highest value even if it's a string so
Rocky Road the letter r comes later in
the alphabet so that's what it's looking
at and so does vanilla and then we have
yes as well and then of course right
here it's taking the max value so before
when we were looking at Min I just
focused on those but it still does the
exact same thing to these integer um
columns as well so for the max value for
vanilla it was mint chocolate chip that
was our base so I had a rating of 10 for
this vanilla row or grouping and then we
can also look at the sum
and there are all the sums for these and
again it only does integer because we
can't add the strings here are the sum
or the total values for all of them and
for the total values since we had you
know six rows that were grouping into
this vanilla we now have a lot of a much
higher score for vanilla now that's a
really simple way to do your
aggregations but there is actually an
aggregation function and let's take a
look at this CU this is um a little bit
more complex although when I write it
out or show you hope it makes a lot of
sense we can do a so this is our
aggregate function and what we need to
pass into our aggregate function is
actually a dictionary so let's do an
open parenthesis and we're going to do a
squiggly bracket and then we need to
specify what we're going to be
aggregating on or what column so let's
do this flavor rating let's copy this
we'll do flavor rating and I need to put
that as a
string and then we'll do a colon and now
we can specify what what aggregate
functions we want so we've done sum
count mean Min and Max all of those and
we can actually put all of those into
here and perform all of those
aggregations on just one column so let's
make a list and then let's say
mean
Max count and uh what's another one sum
so let's do all four of those only on
this flavor rating
column and when we run this we have our
base flavor right here chocolate and
vanilla but now we don't have multiple
columns we have one column with multiple
Columns of our aggregations and it is
possible to pass in multiple columns
like that so we'll do texture
rating and we'll just come right here
and do a comma then we'll say uh uh
texture
rating and then a colon I don't know why
I spelled it out when I copied it but I
did and then we'll do the exact same
ones and now when we run it we're
getting the exact same columns mean Max
count and sum for flavor rating then
mean Max count and sum for our texture
rating now so far we've only grouped on
one column but we can actually group on
multiple columns let's go back up here
to our data and I should have just
copied this down here let's go back down
and just look at this so really we only
grouped it on this base flavor but you
can do multiple groupings or group by
multiple columns so let's do our base
flavor which we did already as well as
the liked column so we're going to say
DF dog Group by then we'll do an open
parenthesis and then instead of just
passing through one string we're going
to do a list and we'll say base
flavor oops comma and then we'll do
liked so now when it groups this it
should put put two groupings and let's
run this and just see oops I got to say
let's just do
mean so now we have our chocolate and a
vanilla and remember chocolate only had
yes so that's the only one that it's
going to group on but vanilla had a no
and a yes so if we look at the vanilla
we have our base flavor vanilla and then
within liked we have no and a yes which
can show us that within our vanilla when
we group on these our NOS were really
low
but our yeses were really high we
actually had a pretty similar rating or
very close to the same rating as the
ones we really liked in chocolate and
just like we did above we can take this
doag and I'm going to copy this and
it'll perform it on each of those rows
let me close that and what did I do
wrong oh I need the squiggly
bracket and it'll show us each of those
so the mean Max count and sum for all of
the chocolate and vanilla as well as the
groupings of light yes and no now after
we've looked at all that and that's how
I usually do it there is one uh shortcut
function that can give you some of these
things just really quickly and so let's
go back up here and take this it's just
called describe um and if you've ever
done it it's just going to give you some
high level overview of some of those
different aggregations so let's run this
and it's going to give us our chocolate
and vanilla and within each column it's
going to give us our count our mean our
standard deviation I believe is what
that is our minimum 25% 50 75 and 100
which is our Max then our count and our
means so a lot of those aggregate
functions but the describe is you know a
very generalized um function we can't
get as specific as we were with the
previous ones that we were looking at
but I just wanted to throw this out
there in case this is something that
you'd be interested in because it you
know technically is showing a lot of
those aggregate functions just you know
all at one time so that is our group Buy
and aggregate functions within pandas I
hope that that was helpful I hope that
you understood you know everything that
we were working on if you like this
video be sure to like And subscribe and
check out all my other videos on python
as well as pandas and I will see you in
the next
[Music]
video hello everybody today we're going
to be talking about merging joining and
concatenating data frames in p do this
whole video is basically around being
able to combine two separate data frames
together into one data frame these are
really important to understand when
we're actually using the merge and the
join right here we have what's called an
inner join and the Shaded part is what's
going to be returned it's only the
things that are in both the left and the
right data frames then we have an outer
join or a full outer join and this will
take all the data from the left data
frame and the right data frame and
everything that is similar so basically
just takes everything we also have a
left join which is going to take
everything from the left and then if
there's anything that's similar it'll
also include that and then the exact
opposite of that is the right join which
is going to give us everything from the
right data frame and it's going to give
us everything that is similar but it's
not going to give us anything that is
just unique to the left data frame so
this is just for reference because in a
little bit when we start merging these
these become very important so I just
wanted to kind of show you how that
works visually so let's get started by
pulling in our files so first we're
going to say import and is aspd we'll
run this and then we'll say data frame
one and we'll also have a data frame two
and these are the different data frames
the left and the right data frame that
we'll be using to join merge and
concatenate so we'll say data frame 1 is
equal to pd. CSV read and we'll do R and
here is our file path so we have this
lr. CSV that's our Lord of the Rings CSV
and let's call that really quickly so we
can see what's in there and I'm having a
dyslexic moment uh because it's supposed
to be reor CSV uh I apologize for that
but this is our data frame this is our
data frame one we have three columns
it's their Fellowship ID 10001 2 3 and
four their first name froto Sam wiise
gelf and Pippen and their skills hide
and gardening spells and fireworks so
this is our very first data frame that
we're going to be working with let's go
down a little bit let's pull this down
here and we're just going to say data
Frame 2 Data Frame 2 and this is the
Lord of the Rings 2 so let's pull this
one in now as you can see it's very
similar we have Fellowship ID 1 2 6 7 8
so we have three different IDs here we
don't have six seven and eight in this
upper this First Data frame we also have
the first name so froto and Sam or Sam
wise are in the very first and the
second data frame but now we have three
new people barir Eland and legalis and
now we have this age column which again
is unique to just this second data frame
really quickly I want to give a huge
shout out to the sponsor of this video
and that is zendesk I've been using
zenes for my company's customer
analytics and it has been absolutely
phenomenal they're going to be hosting a
conference called zenes relate on May
10th and they're going to talk all about
customer analytics chat Bots and AI in
this space you can attend in person in
San Francisco or you can attend
virtually but space is limited so be
sure to apply if you want to attend so
if you are a business leader and you
want to make most out of your customer
data or you want to learn customer data
analytics I will leave links in the
description again huge shout out to
zendesk for sponsoring this video now
the first one that I want to look at is
merge and I want to look at merge first
because I think this one is the most
important I use this one more than any
of ones that we're going to talk about
today the merge is just like the joins
that we were just looking at the outer
the inner the left and the right and
there's also one called cross and I'll
show you that one although if I'm being
honest I don't really use that one that
much but It's Worth showing just in case
you come into a scenario where you do
want to do that so let's go right down
here and I want to be able to see these
while we do it so we're going to say
data frame one and when we specify data
frame one as the very first data frame
we say datf frame. merge this is
automatically going to be our left data
frame then if we do our parentheses
right here and we say data Frame 2 this
is our right data frame and let's see
what happens when we do this
so what it's going to do and this we
didn't specify this it's just a default
it's going to do an inner join so it's
only going to give us an output where
specific values or the keys are the same
now you can't see this but what is
happening is is it's taking this
Fellowship ID and saying I have 101 here
a 102 here this is the exact same as up
here with this Fellowship ID and
fellowship ID of 101 and 2 but when we
look at 13 and 4 those aren't in this
right right data frame and 678 is not in
this left data frame so the only ones
that match are this 101 and two and
that's why they get pulled in down here
but because we didn't explicitly say
here's what I want to join or merge
between these two data frames it
actually is looking at the fellowship ID
and the first name so it's taking in
these unique values of froto and Sam
wise which are the same in both which is
why I pulled it over but really quickly
let's just check and make sure that we
did it on the inner join because again
we didn't specify anything that was just
the default so we're going to say how is
equal to and then we'll say iner and if
we run this it's going to be the exact
same because again the inner is the
default but now just to show you how
it's kind of joining these two uh data
frames together I'm going to say on is
equal to and then I'm only going to put
Fellowship ID so let's run this now the
first thing that you make may have
noticed is this first name undor X and
this first name uncore Y what the merge
does as kind of a default is when you
were only joining on a fellowship ID we
have this right data frame with
Fellowship ID the left data frame with
the fellowship ID if you're just joining
on these and you're not joining on the
first name and the first name then it's
going to separate those into an
underscore X and an underscore Y and
even though they have the exact same
values since we are not merging on that
column it automatically separates that
into two separate columns so we can see
the values within each of those columns
if we went into this on and we make a
list and let's do it like that and we
say comma and then we write first name
oops first name and then we run this
it's going to look exactly like it did
before again it automatically pulled in
both of these columns when it was
merging at the first time even though we
didn't write anything but if we actually
write this this it's doing exactly what
it was doing when we just had df2 we're
just now writing it out now there are
other arguments that we can pass into
this merge function let's hit shift Tab
and let's scroll down here so within
this merge function we have a lot of
different arguments that you can pass
into it first we have this right which
is the right data frame which is this
data frame two then we have the how and
the on which we've already shown how to
do there's a left on right on left Index
right index not something you'll
probably use that much but you
definitely can if you want to look into
that and there's all these doc strings
which show you exactly how to use all of
these so if you're interest in looking
at the left and the right and the left
index it's all in here the one that is
really good is the sort and you can sort
it saying either it's false or true then
we have these suffixes now if you
remember when we took these out what it
automatically did was it put in these
underscore X and underscore y you can
customize that and you can put in what
whatever you'd like instead of the
underscore X andore Y you can put in
some custom um string for that we also
have an indicator and a validates again
all things you can go in here and look
at I'm just going to show you the stuff
that I use the most so these things
right here are things that I definitely
use the most so now that we've looked at
the inner join let's copy this right
down here and let's look at the outer
join and these get a little bit more
tricky I think the inner join is
probably the easiest one to understand
well look at the outer is spelled o u t
e r i I don't know why I always want to
say o t t r but let's run this and see
what we get so now this looks quite
different the inner join only gave us
the values that are the exact same this
one is going to give us all of the
values regardless of if they are the
same so we have 1 2 3 4 six seven and
eight so let's scroll back up here so we
have 1 2 3 4 1 two and six s and 8 so we
don't have a 105 and then if you notice
in this data frame right here if the
value doesn't have so if we can't join
on the fellowship ID or the first name
like legalis wasn't one that we joined
on or that has a similar value in the
left data frame it just gives us an N
which is not a number and it's going to
do that for any value where it couldn't
find that join or it couldn't match uh
something within that either ID or first
name so in age we also have that for the
ones that weren't in the right data
frame we only had 101 and 102 so we'll
have the age for both froto and Sam but
for Gandalf and Pippen we don't have
their corresponding IDs and so it's just
going to be blank for Gandalf and Pippen
and you can see that right here so again
outer joins are kind of the opposite of
inner joins they're going to return
everything from both if there is
overlapping data it won't be duplicated
now let's go on to the left join and I'm
going to pull this down right here and
now we're just going to say how is equal
to left and let's run this so what this
is going to do is it's going to take
everything from the left table or the
left data frame right here so everything
from data frame one then if there is any
overlap it'll also pull the overlapped
or the you know whatever we're able to
merge on from data Frame 2 so let's go
back up to our data frame 1 and two so
it's going to pull everything from this
left data frame cuz we're specifying
we're doing a left join so everything
from the left data frame will be in
there we're also going to try to bring
in everything from the right but only if
it matches or or is able to merge so
just this information right here will
come over we weren't able to join on
1006 17 or 1008 so really none of that
information is going to come over so
let's go down and check on this so again
we have 1 2 3 4 all of the data with
this first name and skills everything is
in here but then we are trying to bring
over the age but we only have matches
with 1,1 and 1002 so only these two
values will come in let's look at the
right join because it's basically the
exact opposite let's look at the
right and this is basically the exact
opposite of the left in the fact that
now we're only looking at the right hand
and then if there's something that
matches in data frame one then we will
pull that in so this this is basically
just looking like data Frame 2 except
we're pulling in that skills column and
since only 101 and 102 are the same
that's why the skills values are here
now those are the main types of merges
that I will use when I'm using a data
frame or when I'm trying to merge a data
frame but there also is one called a
cross or a cross join uh and let's look
at this one and this one is quite a bit
different here we go let's run this so
this one is different in that it takes
each value from the left data frame and
Compares it to each value in the right
data frame so for froto in this left
data frame it looks at the froto in the
right data frame Sam wise in the right
data frame legalis elron and baromir all
on the right data frame then it goes to
the next value Sam wise and does the
exact same thing Roto Sam wise legalis
Elon baromir and it does that for every
single value so let's go right back up
here so it's taking this this this 101
it's comparing it to 1 2 3 4 5 then it's
taking Samwise it's comparing it to 1 2
3 4 5 Gandalf 1 2 3 4 5 Pippen and then
you kind of see that pattern and that's
what a cross joint is um there are very
few in my opinion reasons for a cross
join although you'll if you ever do like
an interview where you're being
interviewed on python you will sometimes
be asked on Cross joins but there aren't
a lot of instances in actual work where
you really use need a cross join now
let's take a look at joins and joins are
pretty similar to the merge function and
it can do a lot of the same thing except
in my opinion the join function isn't as
easily understood as the merge function
it's a little bit more complicated um
but let's take a look and see how we can
join together these data frames using
the join function so let's go right up
here we're going to say data frame one
do join and then we'll do data frame two
very similar to how we did it before and
let's try running this and it's not
going to work um when we did the merge
function it had a lot of defaults for us
let's go down and see what this error is
it says the columns overlap but no
suffix was specified so it's telling us
that it's trying to use the fellowship
ID and the first name just like the join
did except it's not able to distinguish
which is which and so we need to go in
there and kind of help it out a little
bit again a little bit more Hands-On
than the merge but let's see what we can
do to make this work let's do comma and
we'll say on and let's really quickly
let's open this up and kind of see what
we have so this one has less options
than the merge does we have other and
that's our other data frame we can do on
and we're going to specify you know what
column do we want to join on and then we
can look at how do we want it to be a
left an inner an outer the same kind of
types of joins as the merge then we have
that left suffix right suffix and that's
right here is kind of part of the issue
that we were just facing is that those
columns are the same but if we say left
suffix it'll give us an underscore
whatever we want to specify any string
four columns that are both in the left
and the right we can give it a unique
name so we'll no longer have that issue
and then we can also sort it like we did
on the other one but anyways let's go
back to our on we'll say on is equal to
and then we'll say
Fellowship ID let's try running this and
we're still getting an error it's just
not as simple as the merge so let's keep
going so now let's specify the type so
we'll say how is equal to and we'll do
an
outer and if we run this it still
doesn't work we're still getting the
exact same issue as the left suffix and
the right suffix so now let's finally
resolve it I just wanted to show you how
a little bit more frustrating it was but
now let's say uh L suffix is equal to
and now it automatically when we did the
merge did an underscore X but we can do
let's do
underscore uh
left and then we can do a comma we'll do
right
suffix and we'll says equal to and we'll
do underscore right now when we run this
it should work properly let's run this
so this is our output and obviously
looks quite a bit different over here we
have this Fellowship ID then we also
have Fellowship ID left first name left
Fellowship ID right and first name right
so it just doesn't doesn't look right
now something I didn't specify when I
first started this cuz I kind of wanted
to show you is that the join usually is
better for when you're working with
indexes before when we were using the
merge we were using the column names and
that worked really well and it was
pretty easy to do but as you can see
right here when we're trying to use
these column names it's not working
exceptionally well let's go ahead and
create our index and then I can show you
how this actually works and how it works
a little bit better when we're working
with just the index although you can get
to work just the same as the merge it's
just a lot more work so let's go right
down here and let's go and say df4 so
we'll create a new data frame we'll say
df1 do setor index and we'll do an open
parentheses and we'll say we want to do
this index on the
fellowship ID and then we're going to do
the join so now we're going to say join
so we're setting an index so we're
setting that index on the fellowship ID
now we're we're going to join it on df2
do setor index and then we're also going
to do that on the fellowship ID and I'll
just copy
this oh geez I hate it when I do that
okay now we also want to do and specify
the left and the right index so I'll
just copy this as we do need to specify
this now let's try running the data
frame 4 so really quick just to recap we
were setting the indexes we were doing
the same thing above right we have this
join we were joining data frame one with
data Frame 2 now we're joining data
frame 1 with data frame two except in
both instances we're setting the index
as Fellowship ID so we're joining now on
that index so now let's run this and
this should look a lot more similar to
the merge than the join that we did
above except now the fellowship ID right
here is actually an index so it's just a
little bit different but we can still go
in here and do how is equal to
Outer oops let's say outer so we can
still specify our different types of
joins or the different way that we can
merge or join these data frames together
we can still specify that again it's
just a little bit different and that's
why for most instances I'm using that
merge function because it's just a
little bit more seamless little bit more
intuitive the join function can still
get the job done but as you can see it
takes a little bit more work now let's
look at concatenate concatenating data
frames can be really useful and the
distinction between a merge and join
versus the concatenate is that the
concatenate is kind of like putting one
data frame on top of the other rather
than putting one data frame next to one
another which is like the merge and the
join so concatenating them is just a
little bit different in how it'll
operate but let's actually write this
out and see how this looks let's go up
here and we'll say pd. concat we'll do
an open parenthesis and then we're going
to concatenate data frame 1 comma data
Frame 2 that's all we have to write and
let's run this and so just like I said
it literally took the First Data frame 1
2 3 4 and put it on top of the right
data frame 1 2 6 7 8 so that is our left
data frame this is our right data frame
and they're literally just sitting one
on top of the other but just like when
we merg either with a left or a right
when you have these skills and there
aren't any values that populate for them
it is going to say not a number and
since we're not actually joining we're
not joining on one and two even though
this one and this one is the same rows
it's not populating that value because
again we're not joining these together
we're just concatenating and putting one
on top of the other now if we go into
this concat we say shift tab there are a
lot of different things that we can do
which if you remember the zero axis is
the leftand index and the axis of one is
the top index which is the columns so
you can specify that and we can also o
do joins and this is the one that I'm
going to take a look at but there are
other ones that you can um look into as
well let's look at join let's do comma
and we'll say join is equal to and let's
do an inner join so let's see what
happens with this as you can see it is
only taking the columns that are the
same that's what this in is doing it's
joining these columns together and the
ones that were different they didn't
take because again we weren't able to
combine them they aren't similar between
both frames Let's do an outer and now
it's going to take all of them and like
I said that's doing this on these
columns right here but we can also do it
on this axis as well so let's go ahead
and say axis is equal to one and when we
run this now it's joining us on this
Index right here of 0 1 2 3 4 so now
these ones are being joined together and
it's putting it side by side much like a
merge wood so that's how concatenate
works and I'm going to show you one more
thing and again it's not up here in this
you know title because it's not one that
I recommend but is one called append the
append function is used to append rows
from one data frame to the end of
another data frame and then we can
return that new data frame and so let's
do data frame one. aend we'll do an open
parenthesis and we'll say data Frame 2
very similar to how we've been doing
other things and let's run this and as
you can see this is almost exactly like
how the concatenate did when we first
did it but if we read kind of this
warning it's saying the frame append
method is deprecated and will be removed
from pandas in the future version use
pandas do concat instead so it's
literally warning us you know a pend is
on its way out if you want to do exactly
what you're doing right here go and try
concat or concatenate because that'll do
the exact same thing so I'm not really
going to show you any other variations
of a pend because there's no reason it's
going to be on its way out in the next
version so that is our video on merge
join and concatenate and aend as well uh
in panda does and I hope that that was
helpful I hope that you learned
something I mean this stuff is really
important because often times you're not
just working with one CSV or one Json or
one text file you're working with
multiple of them and you need to combine
them all into one data frame and so this
is a really really important concept and
thing to understand with that being said
be sure to like And subscribe check out
all my other videos on Python and pandas
and I will see you in the next
[Music]
video
hello everybody today we're going to be
building visualizations in pandas in
this video we'll look at how we can
build visualizations like line plots
Scatter Plots bar charts histograms and
more I'll also show you some of the ways
that you can customize these
visualizations to make them just a
little bit better with that being said
let's go right over here start importing
our libraries and we'll start with
importing pandas as PD and this one is
really all you need to actually create
the visualizations in pandas but we may
get a little bit crazy uh and so we're
going to do a few different ones as well
like import
numpy as NP and then we're going to do
import Matt plot lib do
pyplot as PLT now I may or may not use
this I just you know when I get into
visualizations I may want to change some
different things so we're going to at
least have them here in case we do want
to use them let's go ahead and run this
so now let's get our data set that we're
going to be using so let's say data
frame is equal to pd. read _
CSV and let's get this in right here now
we're going to be doing these ice cream
ratings let's take a look at this really
quickly now these values are completely
randomly generated they are not real in
any way um but that's what we're going
to be using cuz I just wanted something
kind of generic something that wouldn't
be too crazy confusing just something
that we could use and you guys can
understand that they're just numerical
values but let's also set that index
really quick so we'll say data frame.
setor index and then we'll say date and
then we'll say that's equal to the data
frame and we have this date column right
here as our index so we have uh January
1st 2nd 3rd 4th and then we have our
ratings right here and again these are
all just integers and they're pretty
easy or are really easy to demonstrate
how you can visualize these so that's
why we're using it today so the way that
we visualize something in pandas is we
use something called plot so let's just
take our data frame we'll do data frame.
plot and we'll do our parentheses now
let's go in here really quickly let's
hit shift Tab and this is going to come
up and this is pretty important because
this kind of is going to tell us what we
can do within this plot and
unfortunately there isn't like a quick
overview we just have this doc string
but we have our parameters right here
these are what we can pass in to kind of
customize our visualization so the data
is going to be our data frame then we
have our X and Y labels we can specify
the kind and this one's important
because you can specify what kind of
visualization do we want we can do a
line plot horizontal a vertical bar plot
histogram box plot and then a few others
including area Pi density all these
other things we can also specify if we
want it to be a subplot and a lot of
these things that I'm specifying you
know I'm going to show you how to do you
can use a different indexes you can add
titles add grids Legends Styles all
these different things I mean you can go
through here CU there are a lot but you
can specify and and you know customize
all of these things we won't be going
into all of them but I will show you
some of the ones that I probably use the
most and that I think are the most
useful to know right away so let's get
out of here and we're just going to do
DF do plot and when we run this we'll
get this right here and that was super
super easy created a line plot by
literally doing just about nothing
nothing um but by default it's going to
give us a line plot so if we come up
here we say kind and let me get that out
of the way is equal to line and we run
this so by default without us actually
having to input anything it's giving us
that line plot as a default so uh we can
specify it's a line plot as you can see
we already have all of our data right
here we didn't have to specify anything
it kind of automatically took it in it
is visualizing all three of these
columns
and it has this little um Legend right
here and we can specify where we want
that uh there is an argument to be able
to do that it also gave us these tick
marks of 2 4 6 8 10 again it read in and
said it's only going from 0.0 to 1.0
that is kind of the peak and so it kind
of automatically gave us these ticks for
us again that's another thing that you
can specify we make it go up to 2 5 10
1,000 whatever you want it to be and
then we're doing this based on off of
this date value right here really
quickly I wanted to give a huge shout
out to the sponsor of this entire Panda
series and that is udemy udy has some of
the best courses at the best prices and
it is no exception when it comes to
pandas courses if you want to master
pandas this is the course that I would
recommend it's going to teach you just
about everything you need to know about
pandas so huge shout out to you me for
sponsoring this Panda series and let's
get back to the video if we wanted to
break these out by the actual column we
could go in here and say subplot is
equal to true and it's actually subplots
whoops and now we can run that and then
we can see each of those columns being
broken out by themselves instead of them
all being in one visualization it's now
uh three separate visualizations now
let's go right over here we're going to
get rid of the subplots I want to show
you just some of the different arguments
that you can use to make this look nice
uh because I don't want to do this on
every single visualization I just want
to show you what you can do so we have
this one right here we can add a title
notice there's no title or anything
really telling us what that is so we can
say comma title and we'll say ice cream
ratings if we run this we now have this
nice title right here now we can also
customize the labels or the titles for
the X and Y AIS it automatically took
this date which is right here this is
our date index it automatically took
that for us but we can customize that if
we'd like to all we have to do is comma
and then we'll say xlabel is equal to
and so our X is this date one right here
and we can say daily
rating and then we can do the Y Lael
we'll say y label is equal to and for
this one we can say
scores hope you cannot hear my dog in
the background CU they being insane uh
but let's go ahead and run this and now
we have these daily ratings on the x-
axis and on the Y AIS we have scores now
let's go right down here and start
taking a look at our next kind of
visualization which is going to be a bar
plot so we'll do DF do plot we'll do
kind is equal to and for this one we're
going to say bar now this is what your
typical bar plot will look like and a
lot of the arguments that we just did on
the line plot you can also apply to this
bar plot something that's unique to the
bar plot is that you can also make it a
stacked bar plot all we have to do is go
in here we'll say comma and we'll say
stacked is equal to true so now this
going to make it a stacked bar chart
instead of just know your regular bar
chart let's go ahead and run this and as
you can see this is now stacked on top
of one another with each of these
columns all representing the values that
they have now we don't always have to do
every single column we can also specify
the column that we want so let's take
the flavor rating for example we could
do flavor oops flavor rating good night
flavor rating and then it's only going
to take in that flavor rating column and
if you notice we don't have a legend
that's only when you have multiple
values which we are only looking at this
one column so all the values are right
here now in this bar chart it
automatically defaults to a vertical bar
chart but you can change it to a
horizontal bar chart let's go ahead and
take a look at how to do that bring back
all of them we'll do DF do plot Dot and
then we'll say
barh and I don't know if I can keeping
that kind equals bar let me run this
yeah I need to get rid of that because
the bar. H is its own um this is its own
function so now I'm going to run this it
should just have a stacked bar chart
except now it should be horizontal so
now you can see this worked properly
it's basically the exact same thing as a
vertical bar chart just now horizontal
which may look better especially
depending on if you have values like
this or you know something else that
just looks better being horizontal now
the next one that we're going to take a
look at is the scatter plot so we're
going to say DF do plot do scatter
scatter and if we run this we're going
to get an error what we need in order to
run this properly is we need to specify
the X and the Y AIS in order for this
scatter plot to work so let's go here
and we'll say x is equal to and we can
take any of our columns that we have up
here so we'll say x is equal to texture
rating and then oops Y is equal to we'll
do overall rating
now when we run this it should work
properly let's go ahead and take a look
now if we go in here and we do shift tab
we can also see some other things that
we can specify so let's go right down
here so we have our X and we have our Y
and those are the ones that we just did
we can also pass through an S which is
going to tell us or or change the size
of the actual dots right here in our
scatter plot then we can also do a c
which is the color of each point let's
start with the S
let's say s is equal to let's just do
100 let's see what that looks like so we
have a much larger number let's do 500
and see what that looks like so we can
make these much larger on our
visualization depending on what you're
looking for we can also look at the
color let's put comma C so for color we
can say color is equal to and let's do
uh yellow let's see if this works so now
we've changed it to Yellow that looks
absolutely terrible but it does work now
let's move on to the histogram histogram
is always a good one it's very similar
to something like a bar chart but what's
great about a histogram is you can
specify the bins um so let's go ahead
and say DF
dolot doist then we'll do an open
parenthesis and let's go ahead and hit
shift tab in here take a look at this
one as well so some of our parameters
are the actual Columns of the data
frames that we want to pull in we get
you can choose the bins and they have a
default of 10 in here and so let's take
a look at how this works so we'll just
run this as it is so this is by default
what this histogram is going to look
like let's go ahead and specify our bins
we'll just say it was 10 by default
let's just do 20 see what that looks
like so there are smaller columns right
off the bat and remember histograms are
really good for showing distribution of
variables you know that's really what a
histogram is for but of course since
these are completely random numbers this
histogram isn't going to make any sense
at all but you can at least kind of see
visually how it works and if I didn't
mention it before which I should have
the bins represent how many kind of tick
marks are down here so if we just do one
only going to be one very large uh you
know histogram we could even go further
down from 10 and do five so now there's
only one 2 3 four five so the
distribution gets smaller and and things
get more compact as you spread it out
again like we did
100 it's going to spread it out a lot um
and this is what it shows you know it's
showing the distribution of those bins
across however many you want so the 10
by default you know it usually is pretty
good for a lot of different things now
let's go down here and look at the box
plot and the box plot is a pretty
interesting one let's go ahead and
visualize it really quickly and then
I'll kind of explain how this one works
let's do d boox plot let's run this and
really what we're looking at is some
different markers within our data this
line right here is the minimum value
within that column we also have the
bottom of the box which is the 25th
percentile of all the values within just
this column this is 50% then we have 75%
and then up here we have our maximum
value so I can take a glance at this and
see that we have a low minimum a high
maximum and it definitely skews towards
the lower range whereas if I look over
here we have a lower minimum and a
higher maximum and you can see that this
medium point is at0 6 versus 04 over
here so the skew is a lot higher now
let's go down here and take a look at an
area plot we'll do DF do plot. area and
let's just run this this is what we're
going to get by default now something I
wanted to show you earlier I just
haven't gotten around to I want to show
you something called Figure size or fig
size um so for this it's know it's just
looks small small looks a little bit
cramped let's say we want to increase
the size of this and we'll say fig size
oops fig size is equal to and let's just
do a parentheses and say 10 comma 5 that
should be pretty large this is going to
make it a lot larger just something I
wanted to throw in there I look at these
area charts as pretty similar to like a
line chart if we went and compared those
be pretty similar um but they're
different visually and you know you
absolutely can use these for different
types of visualizations but I don't use
this one a lot if I'm being honest
that's why it's kind of towards the end
of the video but you definitely can do
it let's go on to our very last one of
the video that's going to be the
beautiful pie chart let's say DF plot.py
do an open parenthesis and let's run it
we're going to get this error that's
because we need to specify what column
we're working with here so let's just
say the Y and that's what we need let me
open this up for
us right here we have our y and this is
our our label or a column that we're
going to plot that's really all we need
so we can just say Y is equal to flavor
rating oops flavor rating let's run this
and now we get this visualization right
here let's make this one a little bit
bigger big size is equal to 10 comma 6
now it's a little bit bigger it
definitely depends so this Legend is
going to autop populate you know you can
make this as big as you want and
obviously it's going to look a little
bit better if you do it larger and these
colors autop populate now you can
customize these colors although I found
these ones to be just when you have a
lot of them it's harder to customize
them as easily but you know definitely
look into it these are things that
everything in here is almost something
that you can customize in some way
although it does get a little bit tricky
you definitely have to do some research
and some Googling around just to kind of
figure out how to do those things now
one last thing that I wanted to show and
something you know I could have probably
done at the beginning um is you can
actually change what visual this is and
we can do that pretty easily within mpot
lib there are different styles um and so
let's go right here let's add a new row
a new cell and we'll say print and we'll
do PLT so that's that map plot lib right
here we'll do PLT do style.
available and what this is going to do
whoops what this is going to do is show
us all these different different types
of stylings that you can do to kind of
change up this visualization then once
we find the one that we like we'll just
do PLT do style. use and then in the
parenthesis we'll just specify which one
we want now there's all these Seaborn
ones and Seaborn is a really great um
really great Library let's try Seaborn
deep I haven't tried this one at all
let's go ahead and try this and just
changes some of the colors some of the
visuals we can try something like
538 let's try this that looks quite a
bit different and let's try something
like um classic I don't know what this
one looks like let's just try
it so you can try out all these
different styles find one that you like
find one that you think looks really
nice and you can run with it through all
your visualizations so this has been our
video on visualizing data in pandas I
think it's is a really good introduction
on how you can visualize data within
python and in future videos we'll look
at mpot lib and Seaborn which are some
really great libraries for visualizing
data which I use a lot so I hope that
you enjoyed this video if you did be
sure to check out all my other videos on
Python and pandas and I will see you in
the next
[Music]
video hello everybody today we're going
to be cleaning data using paint P now
there are literally hundreds of ways
that you can clean data within pandas
but I'm going to show you some of the
ones that I use a lot and ones that I
think are really good to know when you
are cleaning your data sets so we're
going to start by saying import pandas
aspd and we're going to run that and now
we're going to import our file so we're
going to say data frame is equal to PD
that's pandas do read uncore and we
actually have this in an Excel file so
we'll say read oops say read Excel do an
open parenthesis eses and we'll do R and
then we'll paste the path right here and
now we're just going to call that
variable so we'll call data frame and
we'll actually read it in and look at
the data so let's scroll down here and
let's take a look at this data frame or
this Excel file that we're reading in so
right off the bat we have this customer
ID that goes from 101 all the way down
to
1020 we have this first name and
everything looks pretty good here except
in this last name column uh looks like
we have some errors we have some forward
slashes some dots some null values um so
definitely going to have to clean that
up because we don't want that in the
data we have a phone number and it looks
like we have a lot of different formats
um as well as Nas not a number um just
lots of different stuff so we're going
to need to standardize that so clean it
up and then standardize it to where it
all looks the same um we also have
address and it looks like on some of
these we just have a street address but
on some of the other ones we have like a
street address and another location as
well as a zip code in some of them so
we'll probably want to split those out
we have a paying customer uh which is
yes and Nos and some of those are not
the same so I have to standardize that
we have a do not contact kind of the
same thing as the paying customer and we
have this not useful column which we'll
probably just want to get rid of okay so
the scenario is is that we got handed
this list of names and we need to clean
it up and hand it off to the people who
are actually going to make these calls
to this customer list so they want all
the data in here standardized and
cleaned so that the people who are
making those calls can just make those
calls as quickly as possible but they
also don't want columns and rows that
aren't useful to them so things like
this not useful column we're probably
going to get rid of and then ones that
say do not contact if it says yes we
should not contact them we probably will
want to get rid of those somehow so
that's a lot of what we're going to be
doing to clean this data set normally
the very first thing that I do when I'm
working with a data set most of the time
except very rare cases when you're
actually supposed to have duplicates is
I actually go and drop the duplicates
from the data set completely all you
have to do for that is say DF do
dropcore duplicates so they make it
super easy for you let's just run it and
up here is our original data set we have
this 19 and 20 and those are obviously
duplicates they have the exact same data
it's just a duplicate row that we need
to get rid of if we look right down here
we no longer have that 20 we now just
have one row of Anakin Skywalker and of
course we want to save that so we're
just going to say DF is equal to and DF
so now it's going to save that to the
data frame variable again and now when
we run this our data frame Now does not
have any duplicates that's definitely
one of the easier steps that we're going
to look at uh things are going to get
quite a bit more complicated as we go
but I'm starting out you know kind of
simple so that we can kind of get a feel
for it and then we'll start getting into
the really tough stuff so the next thing
that I want to do is remove any columns
that we don't need I don't want to clean
data that we're not going to use so if
we're just looking through here you know
they may need you know first name last
name phone number for sure address might
give them some information of where
they're calling to or time zone so we
want that this not useful column looks
like a pretty good candidate to delete
and it's very easy to do that we're
going to go right down here and we're
going to say DF do drop and we'll do an
open parenthesis drop just means we are
dropping that column and we can specify
that by saying columns is equal to and
then we'll paste in that column that we
want to delete so let's run this and see
what it looks like and it literally just
drops that column exactly like we were
talking about it no longer has that
column again we want to save that we can
always do in in place equals true um if
you follow this tutorial series you can
always do in place equals true and
that'll save it as well but just for our
workflow most of the time I'm going to
assign it back to that variable um just
for keeping it the same really quickly I
wanted to give a huge shout out to the
sponsor of this entire Panda series and
that is udemy udemy has some of the best
courses at the best prices and it is no
exception when it comes to pandas
courses if you want to master pandas
this is the course that I would
recommend it's going to teach you just
about everything you need to know about
pandas so huge shout out to you me for
sponsoring this Panda series and let's
get back to the video now let's kind of
go column by column and see what we need
to fix and we'll start on this left-and
side this customer ID to me looks
perfectly fine I'm not going to mess
with it at all the first name at a
glance also looks perfectly fine I don't
see anything wrong with it visually
which is a good thing um although
sometimes that can be deceiving and that
can cause errors down the line but we're
not going to uh assume that there are
errors in here now let's look at this
last name now the last name obviously
I'm I'm seeing some obvious things
things that we talked about when we were
first looking at this data set we have
this forward slash which we definitely
need to get rid of we have null values
so not a number right here we have some
periods as well as an underscore right
here so all those things I think we
should clean up and get rid of it so
that when the person is making these
calls you know it's all cleaned up for
them so how are we going to do that we
can actually do this in several
different ways but let's just copy this
last name the first one I'm going to
show you is strip and we'll write it
kind of like this we'll say data frame
and then we'll specify the column that
we're working with because we don't want
to make these changes or strip all of
these values from everywhere we only
want to do it on just this column if we
do this and we don't specify the column
name it will apply to everywhere so if
we're trying to do these yeah let's say
bum these underscores maybe that would
mess with something else in another
column and we don't want that so we just
want to specify just this last name so
let's go last name.
string. strip now what strip does and
let's see if we can open this up really
quickly no we can't um but what strip
does I was just I was hitting shift tab
in here to see if it could bring up um
you know some of the notes on it but
what strip does is it takes either the
left side or the right side well L strip
takes from the left side our strip takes
from the right side and strip takes from
both but you can strip values off the
left and the right hand side and we can
specify those values now for what we're
doing in this column we can just use
strip because as you can see this
forward slash these dots as well as this
um underscore are all on the far sides
if there was a value Like swancore Son
the strip wouldn't work at all because
it's not on the outside of the value or
the word so we can use strip I'll also
show you how to use replace and replace
is another really good option for things
like this but let's start with strip and
just see what it looks like and see if
we can get what we need done so let's
just run this for now see what happens
so it looks like nothing has changed
because again we're not specifying any
specific value just by default it's only
taking out white space so like spaces
that shouldn't be there that's what it
does by default now we can specify
within this exactly what values we want
to take out so let's go ahead and do
that let's say left strip and let's try
to take out these dots real quick so
we're just going to do a parenthesis dot
dot dot now let's run this and see what
it looks
like for this one Potter it is now gone
so those three dots were there before
let's just show it so they were there
and then when I ran it like this now
they're gone that's what the L strip
does it takes it only off the left hand
side now we can also do a forward slash
so we'll do something like this and
it'll get rid of the white but as you
can see now we aren't taking out these
three dots so they're still there now is
it possible to do something like this
where we put these values inside of a
list um let's try it so we'll say just
like this one two 3 let's run it and no
it doesn't um this L strip actually sits
within the the realm of regular
expression so if you've ever worked with
regular expression you know it gets very
complicated very complex so you want to
keep it kind of simple especially with
these values where we're just taking a
few out so what we're going to do is
we're going to do dot dot dot and we're
take it out one by one now in order to
save this because we want to save this
we want to take out that value we don't
just want to say data frame equals
because that would be uh very bad what
this would say is now this data frame is
only equal to these values that we're
seeing right here we want to only apply
it to this column so we're going to go
like this so now when we do it and then
we call the entire data frame it's only
applying this to this one column the
last name column so let's run
it and now when we go down to Potter
right here it's cleaned up so we're
going to do the same thing but for those
other
values and we'll do it just like this
we'll do a forward slash and it's a left
strip and then we'll do I'll do the left
strip on this underscore to just to show
you that it won't work and then
we will go on from there so it's not
pulling it because we're looking at the
left hand side only we need to use R
strip so now let's use R
strip and now that looks perfect has no
underscore so that's how you can use
strip for either the left side the right
side or just Strip by itself which
covers both sides now I showed you all
of that because I am going to show you a
different way to do it um and I
apologize because I somewhat lied to you
earlier um let's run this right here
actually we're just going to pull it in
like
this we're going to remove the
duplicates again bear with me we're
going to drop that column and then now
we're sitting with that data frame again
with those exact same mistakes I just
wanted to reset it for a second there is
a way uh that you can do this and I just
wanted to you know kind of show you how
you can do it you can do this right
here and we'll say so we're now again
we're just looking at this column just
this column and we're using strip and
let's get rid of R CU we want to do
apply it to everywhere you can input all
of those values in visually and it will
clean it up so let's say we want to get
rid of numbers we'll do one two three
then we can do the dot so that's going
to be for a period or for a dot dot dot
Potter we could also do the underscore
and we can do the forward slash so we
put it all in one string right here now
let's take a look at this we'll get rid
of this really quickly now let's take a
look and all of them were removed I
showed you how to do it before because
that's at least how my mind would think
about it I'd think oh I can put it in a
list and run it through this L strip or
this right strip and it would work um
but that's not how strip works you have
to kind of combine it all into one value
so uh yes I deceived you I apologize but
now when we call data frame and we
assign it to that column so the last
name column or assigning what we just
did to this last name column everything
should look perfect
and it does so our customer ID first
name last name are all cleaned up now
we're going to come to a much more
difficult one this is probably if I'm
being honest the hardest one I said we
were going to work up but this is
probably the hardest one of the whole
video working with phone numbers and
look at all these different types of of
formats I mean it is um it's not going
to be fun and imagine you you know
there's 20,000 of these you can't just
go and manually clean those up you need
something to kind of automate that
so that is what we're going to do so
let's go right down here we'll copy the
data frame and I'm going to pull it
right here so now we need to clean up
this phone number what we want is it all
to look exactly the same unless it's
blank and we'll keep it blank we don't
want to populate that data but we want
all of them to look exactly like this
one and what we're going to do is right
off the bat we're going to take all of
the non-numeric values and just complete
completely get rid of them strip it down
to just the numbers so this 1 23- 643 or
forward slash will just be the numbers
same with these bars and these slashes
and everything all of these will just be
numeric then we'll go back and reformat
it how we want to format it which will
look exactly like this one um but we
just want to do it for the entire column
so let's go right up here and we're
going to try replace for the first time
so let's do phone number
just oops that's not what I wanted so
we're going to do a bracket say phone
number do
string. replace just like we did before
now we're going to use some regular
expression in here and I'll kind of do a
really high overview although I'm not
going to dive super deep into the
regular expression then we're going to
do a parenthesis and within there we're
going to do a bracket um I can't
remember what this is called is it
called a carrot I think it's called a
carrot uh I'm just going to call it that
it may not be correct but I think it's a
an upper Arrow so it's an upper Arrow a
dash oops A- Z A- Z and then
0-9 now at a super high level what that
character that first thing is doing it's
saying we're going to return any
character except and then we specify
anything A to Z A to Z upper or
lowercase and then actually I think this
should be like this A to Z uh and then 0
to 9 so any value like a BC 1 2 3 those
are not going to be matched it's going
to match all of them except these values
and then we're going to replace them by
saying comma and we're going to replace
them with nothing so this is just an
empty string so literally we're taking
everything that is not an A B C A one
two 3 so a letter or a number we're
replacing all of that and then we're
replacing it with nothing so let's run
this and see what it looks like and it
looks like that worked properly now we
do have this na cuz we had an n- a for I
don't remember maybe that was Creed
Bratton um but it worked for basically
everything else we're going to go
through the entire process and then at
the end we'll remove any values we want
them to just be completely null we we
don't want them to even see n an and
wonder what that is we just want it to
be blank and we'll do that at the very
end so now that we know that that worked
let's assign it we'll do DF phone num is
equal to and then we'll say data frame
and this looks a lot more standardized
than it did before already but now what
we want to do is try to format this um
and I've done this many many times I
always use a Lambda you can definitely
use a for loop I just I don't do it that
way myself so I'm going to show you how
to do it using a Lambda let's get rid of
this and we're going to say thef phone
number we've already done that I'm just
going to get rid of it now we're going
to say d phone number then we're going
to say do apply we'll do an open
parentheses and then this is where we're
going to build out our Lambda so we'll
say Lambda X colon now this is where
we're going to kind of format it so what
I want to do is I want to take the first
three strings one two three then I want
to add a slash and then the next three
strings add a slash or a dash uh and
then that be the value that's returned
so it's not super difficult we're just
going to do X then a bracket let me get
rid of that an X and then a bracket and
then we want the 0 to three so goes 0 1
2 so 0 1 2 it doesn't include the three
it goes up to three so 0 one two that's
our third first three values then we'll
do plus and do a quote and do a dash so
this is our first kind of sequence and
I'm just going to copy this we'll do
plus and instead of three or we are
going to start at three because now it's
inclusive so we're going to go from
three and we're going to go all the way
up to six so it should be 3 four five
our next three values then we have a
dash and we'll copy this and we'll say
plus and now we go from six all the way
to 10 now let's try running this and as
you can see we get an error now I
already know what the error is float
object is not subscriptable which means
we're trying to um basically look at it
like a string right now it's not a
string it's actually a number so let me
get rid of this for just a second I'm G
show you what it's talking about so
right now we have values that are floats
and values that are strings or not even
a number so we have values that are
strings or not a number so if we want to
actually look through it like kind of
like indexing if we want to do that they
all have to be strings so we need to
change this entire column into Strings
before we can apply this um formatting
now when I was creating this if I'm
being honest my first thought when I was
doing this was to do it like this string
DF phone number um let's just run that
this is what the values look like um and
I don't remember why or why it was doing
this I can't I can't remember but I
looked into it quite a bit and I was
like oh I need to apply this string
converting it to a string on each value
not the entire row or not the entire
column so how we can do that is actually
fairly easy because we've already done a
lot of the heavy lifting we're just
going to copy this and we're going to
say
x so string of X and again Lambda is
like a little Anonymous function so you
could do this by saying for um X in this
uh column we could do a for Loop and
then say for every X it equals the
string of X and then it changes it to a
string but a Lambda just does it a lot
quicker um so we're going to say so
let's do that really quickly and all of
our values look exactly the same and
that's how we want it so we're just
going to copy this apply
it good and now we're going to take this
and we're going to run this again just
ignore all my commented out stuff
pretend I don't have that um so now when
we run this it should work there we go
now if we look at these numbers 1 2 3-
545 d 5
421 and it does that for every single
one where there's values even when
there's Nan or na it's still adding
those values but we expected that so
let's apply it say is equal to and then
we'll look at the data
frame and this looks almost exactly what
we're hoping for we just need to get rid
of these so this n- Das and this na Dash
we need to get rid of those and that is
super easy to do um we're just going to
say so now that we've done it and we'll
comment that out we'll say
DF and let's copy this ignore the
messiness I do apologize for that it's
very messy um but if you're following
along with me you get what we're doing
so DF phone number so only on the phone
number say string.
replace no open parenthesis now we can
specify this value so we want to take
this exact
value and replace it with nothing and
let's just see if that does work it does
now we have these
Nas and so let's actually I'll paste
that right down here we're going to do
this is equal to and then we're just
going to take this entire string put it
right here and put this value as our
what we're looking for and then
replacing and then when we call that
data frame it should work properly and
it is perfectly cleaned so we have every
single value all the exact same they
don't have different characters or
different um you know formatting and we
got rid of all the ones that we don't
have or don't need um all the ones that
were just random values so this column
is now completely cleaned up again
definitely one of the more difficult
ones um one that I've done a thousand
times I've had to work with a lot of
phone numbers and stuff like like that
this one does get very tricky especially
if you have like a plus one which is
like an area code um that can get tricky
as well but this is on a kind of a high
level this is how you can do that and
it's pretty neat how you can actually
you know clean up and standardize those
phone numbers so let's go right down
here uh let's run it the next thing that
we're going to look at is this address
now let's just pretend that the people
who are on the call center want all
these separated into three different
columns they can read it easier see what
the ZIP code is where they live
uh you know whatever they want it for
let's just say we want to do that and
this is you know again for this use case
it may not make sense but you have to do
this I do this all the time um you need
to split those columns now luckily all
of these things are separated by a comma
so we can specify that we're going to
split on this column and then we'll be
able to create three separate columns
based off of this one column which is
exactly what we want then we can name it
as well and we can do that very easily
by using this split so we're going to
say DF and we want to
specify oh jeez not again so we want to
specify that we're looking at the
address then we're going to say.
string. split we'll do an open
parenthesis now the very first value
that we need to specify is what we're
splitting on so we want to split on the
comma so we want to specify that and
then we need to specify how many values
from left to right it should look for
now we'll just start with one and then
we'll go from there let's just see what
this looks
like
so it doesn't really look like it did
anything let's do two well let's go back
to one and then let's say
expand equals true when we expand it
it's actually going to uh separate it I
believe okay so we're expanding we now
we're only doing this with one comma so
we're only looking at the very first
comma and splitting it but in some of
these well just in one there is an
additional comma so we should do it up
to two let's do this okay so now we have
three columns if we just save it like
this it's going to give us these 0 one
two these basically these indexed values
for these columns and we don't want that
we want to specify what these actually
are and we can do that by saying DF and
let me just do is equal to we'll do
bracket and then within there we're
going to specify our list so we have
three three of them that we have so I'm
going to do um the first one this is the
street address so we'll say street
address the next one is and it's sh is
not a state uh but these all are states
so I'm just going to say
State and then for the very last one
that looks like a zip code so we'll say
zip and we'll do code in fact I also
want to do streetcore address um so what
this is is now going to do is these
three columns are going to be applied to
these three names and they'll basically
be appended it doesn't replace the
address we're not saying DF address
equals the DF address we're not
replacing it we're now creating
different columns so let's run it and
then let's also call it so they're right
over here on this right hand side I
couldn't see them at first but it did
exactly what we needed it to do so now
if we wanted to at the very end if we
want to we're not going to we could just
delete this address and keep the street
address the state and the zip code
another really common thing that you can
do this happens often again with like
first name last name well you'll have
Alex freeberg but it's Alex comma
freeberg or Alex space freeberg and you
can separate those out into different
columns now the next one that we want to
look at is this paying customer and the
paying customer and do not contact are
very similar um in the fact that it's
yes no NY yes no NY
um and so let's go right on down here
and we're going to say DF Dot and we
want to just replace these values as all
yeses or all NOS but just with the same
formatting um just to keep it consistent
so let's make anything that's an N into
a no anything that's a a y into a yes I
like it spelled out so let's change
anything that's a yes into a y anything
that's uh a a no into an n that's
usually how I do it just saves on data
because it's less strings although it's
can be often very minimal um but let's
specify the P
customer we'll s say DF bracket Pay
customer then we'll do do string.
replace so now we're just going to look
for those specific values so if it's a y
oops a capital Y then we'll say
yes now let's run it and now we have no
more y's we now just have yeses although
now these are yes yeses okay we don't
want to do that let's do if we're
looking because it's taking it's
literally looking up here and saying
okay there's here's a y um let's change
the let's change that Y into a y so now
it's doing y uh we don't want that so
let's look for the yes and change it
into a y now when we run this that looks
a lot better um so we'll
do DF paying customers equal to and then
we'll copy this we'll do the exact same
thing
no and
N then let's call it and now that entire
column looks really good except for that
value right there but I'm going to leave
that because I'm just going to apply it
to the entire thing all at once to get
rid of those at the end instead of just
going column by column and then it's
it's literally going to be the exact
same thing so I'm not even going to
scroll down whoops I'm just going to put
it right up here because this is the
exact same thing I'm going save us all
some
time and when we run this this looks
exactly like what we're looking for
again some not a number values but we
can get rid of that in just a second by
doing a place over the entire data frame
and that is basically the end of
cleaning up individual columns now let's
go right down here we're going to say DF
do string.
replace and then we'll first do these
values oops so we'll do oops let me do
that there we go and replace that with
nothing and let's just see what it looks
like oops data frame object has no value
string well that's CU we were looking at
columns before yeah I think I just need
to get rid of this string we're not
looking it we're just really doing it
across the entire data frame now let's
try that
okay that worked
appropriately and we'll just say data
frame is equal to and then we'll copy
this and we'll do the NN as
well and we'll
[Music]
do and now when we do this it is not
going to replace these because these
aren't actually a value because we're
looking for that string we actually need
to use and I I completely forgot this
I'm not going to lie to you um let's get
rid of this uh to get rid those values
because it's literally not a number
there it is technically empty um I
forgot we can do um or we could not even
specify it we'll do DF do fillna so
we're going to fill these values if
there's nothing in them we're going to
fill it and we're going to
say blank and when we run that every
value that doesn't have something in it
is going to show up blank even over here
where we only had a few all of them
throughout the data frame if if it
doesn't have a value it is now blank so
let's apply
that and we'll run
this and now all of our cleaning we
actually cleaning up the individual
columns is completely done we've removed
columns we've split columns we've
formatted and cleaned up phone numbers
we've also taken values off of first
name or or this last name column and
then we formatt it in just kind of
standardized paying customer and do not
contact now they also asked us to only
give them a list of phone numbers that
they can call so if we take a look some
of these do not contacts are why which
means we cannot contact them and then
there are some that don't even have
phone numbers so we don't want to give
the people the call center numbers that
or or people who don't have numbers so
we want to remove those now there's a
few different ways that we can do this
but let's start with and we'll just go
by do this do not contact it seems like
the most obvious one now if it's blank
we want to give them a call we only want
to not call them if they've specifically
said we cannot call them so if it's y
we're not going to call them so what we
need to do it's not anything like this
we probably need to Loop through this
column and then look at each row that
has a value of this and drop that entire
row uh and we probably will'll need to
do that based off this index instead of
doing it based off just this column uh
that may not make sense but let's
actually let's actually start writing it
so we'll do 4X in and we need to look at
our index so we're just going to do
let's do nf. index and we'll do a colon
enter and then we want to look at these
indexes how do we look at these indexes
we use lock that's going to be DF
Lo and then we need to look at the value
which is this x right here so each time
it looks at the index it's looking at
the value but we want to look at the
value of this column do not contact I
don't know if I copied this before let
me copy it we only want to look at the
value in this one column if we didn't it
would look at um a different value so we
don't want that so we're looking at just
that value if it's equal to Y so if this
value is equal to Y then we want to drop
it so we actually need to say
if so if this value X in this column is
equal to Y then we want to do DF do drop
and then we'll say x and we I think we
have to say in place equals true here
otherwise it won't take a fact um
otherwise you have to say like DF is
equal to DF yeah I don't I don't want to
start messing with that let's just do in
place equals true
um and let's see if that works I I can't
remember if this is going to work or not
invalid syntax okay
neon and now let's try to run
this okay okay yeah if we look at our
index we can already tell that there are
ones missing the one the one is missing
the three is missing um let's see and
the 18 is missing so we already got rid
of those values and you can you can see
that there's no y's in here anymore
which is really good we can if we want
to and we probably should we should
probably populate that um really
quickly um let me just go up here really
quick I'll copy this we probably should
populate that and I didn't plan on doing
this so um if it's blank oops it's blank
give it an n and we want to attribute it
to do not
contact do not contact
whoops let's see if that
works and we probably need to do do
string let's just see if it
works so if it's
blank dude okay I don't know why it's
giving us a triple
n maybe there's maybe I need to strip
this or
something uh okay never mind let's not
do that but now we basically need to the
exact same thing for this phone number
um because if it's blank we don't want
them calling it um so we can copy this
entire thing go right down here and but
now we're looking at phone
number so now we're looking just at the
values within phone number and we only
want to look at if it's blank so if it
literally has no value we want to get
rid of it let's run this and see if it
works again it should good and now our
list is getting much smaller so you can
see in our index a lot of um those rows
were removed and okay good actually this
worked itself out because these all have
ends um so right now we're sitting
really good everything looks really um
standardized cleaned everything looks
great I might drop this address if you
want to you can drop this address but
besides that this is all looking really
good this Paint customer doesn't uh the
yes and NOS aren't really anything um
now we could and we probably should
before we hand this off to the client or
the customer call list we probably
should reset this index because they
might be confused as why there's numbers
missing or you know they might use this
index um to show how many people they've
called or I don't know something like
that so let's go right down here we're
going to say DF Dot and then we'll do
reset
index and let's just see what this looks
like um it does work but as you can tell
it didn't uh get rid of that index
completely it actually took the index
and saved that original one we do not
need to save that whoops let's put it
right in here now we're just going to do
drop equals true and when we do that it
just completely resets it drops the
original index and gives us a new index
and that is what we want let's do DF
equals and this is our final product now
one thing that I you definitely could
have done here um and I made this a
little probably more complicated than it
needed to be um that was just how my
brain was working at the time when I'm
you know typing this out we could have
done DF do drop an a um which is
literally going to look at these null
values um
before we couldn't do that with this one
because these aren't we're not looking
at na we're looking at y's so we
couldn't do that but because we're
looking at null values we could have
also done drop
na um and done subset is equal to and
then done it just on this phone number
and then done like this and done in
place equals true so we could have also
done this and then said DF equals um I
can't I mean I can run it it's just not
going to do anything I can run it on the
different column but that'll me mess
everything up but this is another way
you can do it and I'll just save it in
case you want to um I'll say another way
to drop null
values there you go and that'll just be
a note for us in the future um but this
is our final product it looks a lot
different than when we first started I
mean we had mistakes here completely
different formatting in the phone number
different address everything that we
just talked about um and this looks just
a lot lot better and you can tell why
it's really important to do this process
because again we're working on a very
small data set I I purposely you know
created this data set with these
mistakes because you know when you're
looking at data that has tens of
thousands 100 thousands a million rows
these are all things that are going to
be applied to much larger scale and you
won't be able to as easily see them um
you'll have to do some exploratory data
analysis to find these mistakes and then
you're going to need to clean the data
or doing it at the same time when you're
exploring the data uh so you'll clean it
up as you go but these are a lot of the
ways that I clean data a lot of the
things that you can do to make your data
just a lot more standardized is a lot
more um visually better and then it
really helps later on with
visualizations and your you know actual
data analysis so I hope that that was
helpful I know that this was a long
video I'm sure it was uh but I hope that
you got something out of this you
learned some of the techniques on how to
actually clean data in pandas if you
like this video be sure to like And
subscribe check out all my other videos
on pandas as well as Python and I will
see you in the next
[Music]
video
hello everybody today we're going to be
looking at exploratory data analysis
using pandas exploratory data analysis
or Eda for short is basically just the
first look at your data during this
process we'll look at identifying
patterns within the data understanding
the relationships between the features
and looking at outliers that may exist
within your data set during this process
you are looking for patterns and all
these things but you're also looking for
um mistakes and missing values that you
need to clean up during your cleaning
process in the future now there are
hundreds of ways to perform Eda on your
data set but we can't possibly look at
every single thing so I'm just going to
show you what I think are some of the
most popular and the best things that
you can do when you're first looking at
a data set the first thing that we're
going to do are import our libraries so
we'll do import pandas
aspd we're also going to import Seaborn
and matplot lib now dur during this
exploratory data analysis process I
often like to visualize things as I go
because sometimes you just can't fully
comprehend it unless you just visualize
it and it gives you a a larger broader
glimpse of everything so we're going to
import and let's do caborn
oops as SNS and then we'll import Matt
plot li.
pyplot as
PLT
let's run
this this should work okay perfect now
we need to bring in our data set so
we've worked with that world population
data set that is the exact one that
we're going to use now so we'll say
dataframe equals pd. read undor
CSV do R and we'll paste in our CSV and
this is what it should look like
although your path may be different be
sure to make sure that you have the
correct file path then we'll read it in
now this data set should look extremely
familiar if you've done some of my
previous pandas tutorials but I did make
some alterations to this one took out a
little bit of data put in a little bit
of data here and there um to change
things up because if it was just exactly
how I pulled it which I got this data
set from kaggle if it was exactly how we
pulled it like we've looked at in the
previous videos it's too simple you know
we wouldn't actually be able to do some
of the things that I would like to show
you so be sure to actually download this
exact data set for this video because it
is a little bit
different but what we're going to do now
is just try to get some highlevel
information from this now if yours looks
just a little bit different like your
values are in scientific notation uh I
have applied this so many times I think
it's um you know still applied to this
you can do something and we'll write it
right down here we're going do pd. setor
option and we'll do an open parenthesis
and we'll say
display. float uncore format and so
we're going to change that float format
by just saying Lambda X colon and then
we're going to change basically how many
um decimal points we're looking at so
let's just do here so we'll do a quote
percent sign 2f so we're formatting it
whoops 0 2f so we're going to format it
and we'll do percent X this is going to
format it appropriately I'm I can run it
um and actually it will change it this
is at 0 one I believe last time I did it
so let's run this and then let's run
this again it'll change it to point 2 so
that's two I like it at 0.1 we don't
really need it any well let's keep it at
point two why not we're going to keep it
at point two that's how you change that
and I like looking at it like this a lot
better than scientific notation so just
something to point out um let's go down
here and let's just pull up data frame
so we have this data one of the first
things that I like to do when I get a
data set is to just look at the info so
we're going to do doino and this gives
us just some really high level
information this is how many columns we
have here are the column names here are
how many uh values we have and if you
notice this is where it kind of gets so
we have 234 in each of these so in each
of these columns we have 234 until we
get to this 2022 population once we get
there we start losing some values and
then at the world population percentage
we have all of our values all 234 of
them the count tells us that it's non
null so it does have values in it and
then we also have the data types and
these come in handy later um and these
are really great to know and we'll be
able to kind of use those in a few
different ways later on in this tutorial
really quickly I wanted to give a huge
shout out to the sponsor of this entire
Panda series and that is udemy udemy has
some of the best courses at the best
prices and it is no exception when it
comes to Panda courses if you want to
master Master pandas this is the course
that I would recommend it's going to
teach you just about everything you need
to know about pandas so huge shout out
to you to me for sponsoring this Panda
series and let's get back to the video
the next thing that I really like to do
and this one is DF do
describe this allows you to get really a
highlevel overview of all of your
columns very quickly you can get the
count the mean the standard deviation
the minimum value and the maximum value
as well as your 25 50 and 75
percentiles of your values so just at a
super quick glance there is a row
somewhere in here and there this country
their population is 510 for 2022 and in
fact if you go back to 1970 it was
higher it was at
752 that's just interesting then if we
look at the um max population one has
1.42 billion I believe that's China and
then over here in 1970 we have 822
million again I still believe that's
China but this gives you just a really
nice high level of all of these values
or all these different calculations that
you can run on it and we can run all
these individually on even specific
columns but you know it's just a nice
highlevel overview one thing that we
just talked about was the null values
that we're seeing in here um I'd like to
see how many values we're actually
missing because that is a problem um we
don't want to have too many missing
values or could really obscure or change
the data set in irely and so we don't
want that so we'll say DF do is null and
then we'll do a parenthesis and we'll
say do sum and when we do this
whoops dot sum there we go when we do
this it's going to give us all the
columns and how many values we're
actually missing now we have
234 rows of data so we have 41 477 55424
um so we have we definitely have data
missing what we choose to do with it in
the data cleaning process maybe we want
to populate it with a median value maybe
we just want to delete those countries
entirely if the data is missing um you
know I don't think you're going to do
that but these are things that you need
to think about when you're actually
finding these missing values this is
what the Eda process is all about we
want to find different um either
outliers missing values things that are
wrong with the data or we can find
insights into it while we're doing this
as well so so this is definitely
something that I would consider um when
I'm actually going through that data
cleaning process really really important
information to know now let's go right
down here go to our next cell say DF do
unique and this is going to show us how
many unique values and it's actually n
unique uh this is going to show us how
many unique values are actually in each
of these uh columns and this one makes
the most sense um for continents because
I think there's only seven continents
right right um but we have six right
here and for all of these each of these
ranks countries capitals should all be
unique that makes perfect sense as well
as these you know these populations are
such specific numbers and such large
numbers I would be shocked if any of
these were similar and then for these
world population percentages it's much
lower and again that makes a lot of
sense because when we're looking at and
we'll pull it up right here when we're
looking at these world population
percentages um a lot of them are really
low 0.00 0.01 like this one um 0.2 there
are a lot of really low values for those
small countries and so those are all um
you know one unique value now let's say
we just have this data right here and we
want to take a look at some of the
largest countries and we can easily do
that we could even we could say Max and
take a look at the largest country but I
want to be a little bit more strategic I
want to be able to look at some of the
top range of countries and we can do
that based off this
2022 population so we'll say DF do
sortore values this is how we sort and
um not filter but um order our data so
we'll do sort values and then we'll do
buy is equal and then we'll specify that
we want uh this 2022 population and then
we're going to say comma and we'll say
actually let's just run this as is um
but we'll do head because we just want
to look at the top values so now we're
just looking at the very top values so
what we're looking at is actually these
2022 population um that's what we're
filtering on or sorting on basically and
we're looking at the very bottom values
because it's sorting ascending so from
lowest to highest so this Vatican City
in Europe is um you know 510 that's the
value that we were looking at earlier
now we can do comma ascending equal to
false because it was by default true we
can do false whoops we can do false and
then it'll give us the very largest ones
so if we just take a look at the top
five largest by population we're looking
at China India United States Indonesia
and Pakistan and we can even specify
that we want the top 10 in this head we
can bring in the top 10 we also have
Nigeria Brazil Bangladesh Russia and
Mexico and you can do this for literally
any of these columns whether you want to
look at continent capital country um you
can sort on these and look at them and
you can even look at you know things
like growth rate world percentage this
one seems really interesting let's just
look at this one really quickly before
we move on to the next thing um if we
look at this world percentage just China
alone I believe yeah just China alone is
17.88% of the world so
17.88% world population percentage again
just getting in here looking around
that's all we're really doing now I want
to look at something and I have always
liked doing this which is looking at
correlations um so correlation between
usually only numeric values we can do
that by saying DF
docr and a parenthesis and we'll run
this and what this is is it is comparing
every column to every other column and
looking at how closely correlated they
are so this 2022 population if we look
across the board it's very highly I mean
this is a one: one this is highly
correlated to each other and that almost
for all of these populations they're
very very closely tied to each other
which makes perfect sense because for
most countries they're going to be
steadily increasing and so they're
probably almost exactly correlated but
we can look at these populations and if
you look at the area it's only somewhat
correlated and that's because in some
countries you know they have a very high
population but a small area or vice
versa a small area and a very high
population so there isn't a one toone
correlation there but it's hard to
really just glance at this um and
understand everything that's there we
could just visualize it and it would be
a lot easier so let's go ahead and do
that let's go down here we're just going
to visualize this using a heat map
basically so we're going to say SNS do
heatmap and an open parenthesis and the
data that we're going to be looking at
is DF do core correlation and then we
also want to say inote equals true I'll
kind of show you what that looks like in
just a little bit um but let's do PLT
doow and this will be our first look and
I need to say show not shot um we can
get a little glimpse of what it looks
like but this looks um absolutely
terrible let's change the figure size
really quick so I want to make this much
larger than it already is we'll do
pl. RC prams RC params oops right there
do an open parenthesis and then right
here we're going to do in quotes do
figure. fig size this actually needs to
be in brackets I
believe just like this not parentheses
we'll say fig size is equal to and now
we can specify the value that we want
let's do 10 comma seven and see if this
looks any
better no no that doesn't look good do
20 okay that looks a lot better and um
you know this is just a quick way
because it gives you basically a
colorcoded system highly correlated is
this tan all the way down to basically
no correlation or negative correlation
even which is black so when we're
looking at these 2022 populations and
these are populations right down here on
this axis we can see that all of these
are extremely highly correlated very
very quickly whereas the rank really has
nothing to do it's it's negatively
correlated doesn't really have anything
to do with it then for the population
and the world population percentage it
again is quite correlated except for the
area density and growth rate so I find
that really interesting that you know
the density the growth rate in the area
aren't really all that Associated or
correlated with the population numbers
that is I kind of would assumed that on
some level they went hand inand the area
does um would you know again make sense
you know larger area larger population
that kind of thing but even density um I
guess I guess density and growth rate um
growth rate I can see because that's a
percentile thing that could be
definitely not correlated I thought the
density would be more correlated than it
is all that to say is this is one way
that you can kind of look at your data
see how correlated it is to one another
that can definitely um help you know
what to analyze and look at later when
you're actually doing your data analysis
let's go right down here um something
that I do almost all the time when I'm
doing any type of uh exploratory data
analysis like this I'm going to group
together columns start looking at the
data a little bit closer um so let's go
ahead and group on the continent so
let's look at it right here let's group
on this continent because some times
when you're doing this Eda you already
know kind of what the end goal of this
data set is you know kind of what you're
looking for what you're going to
visualize at the end that you really
comes in handy when doing this but
sometimes you don't sometimes just going
in blind and so far we've really just
been going in blind we're just throwing
things at the wind kind of seeing some
overviews um looking at correlation
that's all we've done now I kind of want
to get more specific I want to have like
a use case something that I'm kind of
looking for not doing full data analysis
not diving into the depths but something
we can kind of aim for so the use case
or the question for us is are there
certain continents that have grown
faster than others and in which ways so
we want to focus on these continents we
know that that's the most important
column for this use case this very fake
use case um so we can group on this
continent and we can look at these
populations right here because we can't
really see growth you can see a growth
rate but the density per uh kilometer we
don't have multiple values for that it's
just a static one single value same for
growth rate same for world population
percentage but we have this over a long
span many many years um you know 50
years of data here so this we can see
which countries have really done well or
which continents have really done well
so without you know talking about it
even more let's do DF Group by and then
we'll say continent oops let me just
copy this I'm I'm not could it's
spelling we're going to say DF groupy
and then we'll do
mean and we can just do it just like
this and now we have Africa Asia Europe
North America Oceana and South
America okay so if I'm being completely
honest I knew most of these all right
I'm no geography extra expert but I I
knew most of these I don't know what
this ocean is um this that I don't I
genuinely don't know what that is um
so let's just search for that value and
see we'll come back up here in just a
second but I want to I want to kind of
understand um what this is so we're
going to DF um and we'll say
continent let me sound that out for you
guys um then we'll do string. contains
oops contains good night and then I want
to look for
Oceana uh and let's let's run this oh I
need to do it like
this now let's run this so now we're
looking at our data frame we're seeing
when the values have this continent as
Oceana um okay so these look like
Islands I'm guessing so we have Fiji
Guam um New
Zealand Papa New Guinea yeah these look
like all I'm I'm guessing based off the
continent Oceana
um Oceania o Ocea Oceania guys this is
tough for me okay I'm doing my best I
you know this is part of the Eda process
I don't know what that means I don't
know what ocean ocean ocean Oceania geez
I'm just going to call it Oceana that's
so wrong but I'm just gonna it's so easy
for me to say you know I I now am seeing
this and it looks like
Islands um which would make sense
because for their average they have the
highest average rank um and I'm guessing
that's because they're just mostly small
continents so let's let's order this
really quickly we're going to do dot
sortore values do an open parenthesis
and I want to sort on the population
we're just doing the average population
um we'll do BU um equal so on the
average population and we'll do
ascending equals false so we're looking
at this average or the mean population
Asia has the highest population on
average and we have South America Africa
Europe North America and then Oceana at
the very bottom which makes perfect
sense again small Islands um world
population percentage so each of the
countries each of those countries in
Asia makes up about 1% on average really
interesting um to know and just kind of
look at this and and the density in Asia
is far higher than double almost double
every single other continent um really
really interesting actually now that I'm
looking at this but you know that's
something that I would actually look
into and I would be like what is this
Oceana or Oceania what does that mean
and you know let me look into that let
me explore that more because I want to
know this data set I'm trying to really
understand this data set well but what I
want to do now is I want to visualize
this um
because I just feel like looking at it I
don't it's hard to visualize and again
the use case that we're saying is is
which continent has grown the fastest
like it could be percentage wise it
could be um you know as just a whole on
average let's take a look so we're going
to take this and let's copy it like this
let's bring this right down here so
let's look at this so if I try to
visualize this and let's do that let's
do df2 is equal to because I'm I already
know it's not going to look good just
based off how the data is sitting um we
do df2 oops what am I doing I don't need
to do that but I will okay df2 and we'll
do df2 do
lot I'll we'll run it just like this um
as you can see Asia South America Africa
Europe North America Oceana we can kind
of understand what's happening but these
are the actual um values that are being
visualized not the continents which is
what I wanted um in order to switch it
and it's actually pretty easy and this
is something that um you know is good to
know we can actually transpose it to
where these these continents become the
columns and the columns become the index
and all we have to do is say df2 do
transpose and we'll do this parentheses
right here and let's just look at it and
then we'll save it so now all these
columns are right
here and all of the indexes are the
columns so let's say df3 is equal to and
I'm just doing that so I don't you know
write over the DF or my earlier data
frames so now we have this data frame
three so now let's do data frame 3. plot
and it should look quite a bit
different uh whoops I didn't run this
let's run this and run this
and as you can see this does not look
right at all and the reason is is
because we're not only looking at uh the
correct columns we have this density in
here word population percentage rank we
don't need any of those the only ones
that we want to keep are these ones
right here this
population now we can do that and we can
just go right up here this is where we
created that data frame two that we
transposed we can go right up here and
we can specify within this we actually
only want specific specific values now
we can go through and handr write all of
these and by all means go for it but I
am going to go down here I'm going to
say DF do columns and I'm going to run
this it's going to give us this list of
all of our columns and I'm just going to
you can just copy
this and you can put it right in here
think I need a list with I think it
needs to be like this if I'm let me try
running this okay so this worked
properly you can do it just like this or
a little shortcut if you want to do it
like that if you want to do a shortcut
like um I I would hope you would you
would just do DF doc columns just like
how we looked at down here except since
this is our an index we can search
through it so we can just say 0 one two
okay so we can do five up to 13 because
I think it's seven and we'll just let's
see if this
works uh it may not I may actually need
to go like this let's see
there we go so you can just use you know
the indexing to save you some visual
space gives you the exact same output so
now we have this this is our df2 now
let's go down and transpose it so now we
just have these populations and we have
our conents right here and then now
we're going to plot it and this looks
good although it's
backward um okay it's
backward so what I actually want to do
is not this uh that is a quick way to do
it although not the best way to do it um
so I'm actually going to copy all of
these and although I said it would save
us time it did not at all so I'm going
to put a bracket right
here I'm going to paste this in here and
I'm literally going to change these up I
might speed this up or I might just have
you sit through this because you know
this is an interesting part of the proc
process and I want you know you to get
the full experience you know what now
that I'm talking about it that is what
we're going to do you guys can hang out
with me this is a good time we have
2020 and 2022 now let's run it what did
I do oh too many brackets there we go so
now it's ordered appropriately we have
1970 all the way up to 2022 this is how
we want it let's transpose it
appropriate
let's run it and now we basically have
the inverted uh image of this now just
at a glance and we haven't done anything
to this except for literally what we are
looking at at a glance we can see that
from
1970 China here you know Asia and China
are already in the lead by quite a bit
and it continues to drastically go up
especially in the 2000s like right here
it explodes like just straight up then
kind of starts going up and just
leveling off every other continent
especially oce Oceana is just really low
it it never has done a bunch let's see
look at green green has gone up um from
you know Point let's say
0.1 up to about point2 so they've almost
doubled um in the last 50 years and
again you can just get an overview a
high level overview of each of these you
know continents over the span of this
time so this is kind of one way that we
can you know look at that use case we're
not going to harp on that too long I
just want to give you an example like
you know when you're looking at this
sometimes you'll have something in mind
of what you're looking for and you go
exploring and just kind of find what's
out there and find what you see um the
next thing I want to look at is a box
plot now I personally I love box plots
you know they're really good for finding
outliers and there's a lot of outliers I
already know this because because the
average the 25th 50 percentile are very
low and then there's some really just
big outliers but for your data set it
may not be that way and those outliers
may be something that you really need to
look into and box plots have been
something that I've used a lot where I
found those outliers that way and
started to dig into the data to find
those outliers and you know came across
some stuff that I'm like oh I have to
clean this up I have to go back to the
source really um really really powerful
and useful to be able to find these so
all you have to do is d. boox plot and
let's take a look at it and this already
looks good as is maybe I'll make it a
little bit wider um let's do fig size
oops sorry fig size is equal to let's
try
20 by
10 um okay that didn't help at all I
apologize thought I would but let's keep
going what this is showing us is that
these little boxes down here which are
actually usually much much larger
because you have a more equal
distribution of of um numbers or values
in the small value this is where our
averages lie this number right here is
the upper range and then all these
values all these Open Circles those
actually stand for
outliers so we're looking at the 2022
population there's a lot of outliers now
for our data set knowing our data set is
really important outliers are to be
expected especially when most countries
are continents are small so we're
looking at you know all of these little
dots are outlier countries um or outlier
values which each value corresponds to a
country so if this was a different data
set I would be you know searching on
these and trying to find these so that I
can see what's wrong with them if
anything or if they are real um numbers
like if this was Revenue everyone's
revenue is way down here and then
there's one company that's making like
10 trillion dollar that'd be an outlier
up here and it would definitely be
something that you want to look into to
for our data set knowing that you know
we're looking at population this is more
than acceptable you know oddly enough
but that's what box plots are really
good for showing you some of those cor
tiles the upper and the lower um as well
as denoting these points that fall
outside of those normal ranges for you
to look into so really really useful so
now let's go down here pull up our data
frame again and we've kind of just
zoomed into the whole Eda process there
was one last thing that I wanted to show
you and this is the very last thing that
we're going to look at we're ending on
really a low point if I'm being honest
because the last kind of stuff was more
much more exciting but there is
something DF DOD types oops let's do DF
DOD
types and we'll run this now just like
info it gave us these values but we're
actually able to search on these values
now so these um object float and integer
we can search on those which is really
great because we can do include equal
and we can do something like number and
none of these are numbers right or none
of them explicitly say number but when
we run it I'm getting an error series
object not oh that's because I'm doing
um D types is for a series we need to do
select underscore D types now let's run
this now it's only returning um The
Columns in this data frame where the
data types are included in this number
so you won't see any you know country or
any of those text or the strings if we
want to do that we go in here and say
object and run that and this is another
really quick way where we can just
filter those columns to look for
specific whether it's numeric um we
could even do float in here and so now
it's not including that rank which was
an integer so we can specify the type of
data type and it'll filter all of the
columns based off of that which you know
when you're doing stuff like this you it
is good to know what kind of data types
you're working with and look at just
those types of data types because there
might be some type of analysis you want
to perform on just that whether it's
numeric or just the string or integer
columns within your data set so again
ending on a low note I apologize um you
know everything else that we looked at
all those other things that we looked at
are all things that I typically do in
some way or another when I'm looking at
a data set exploratory data analysis is
really just the first look you're
looking at it you're going to be
cleaning it up doing the data cleaning
process and then you're going to be
doing your actual data analysis actually
finding those Trends and patterns and
then visualizing it um in some way to
find some kind of meaning or Insight or
value from that data and again there's a
thousand different ways you can go about
this it it does typically um you know
depend on the data set but these are a
lot of the ways that you'll clean a lot
of different data sets and so you know
that's why I went into the things that
we looked at in this video video so I
hope that you guys liked it I hope that
you enjoyed something in this tutorial
if you like this video be sure to like
And subscribe as well as check out all
my other videos on pandas and Python and
I will see you in the next
[Music]
video what's going on everybody welcome
back to another video today we are back
with another data analyst portfolio
project where we will be scraping data
from Amazon using
[Music]
python now you may be asking do I need
to know web scraping to become a data
analyst and the answer is no you
absolutely don't need to know it but it
is a very cool skill to learn and in
fact I have used it in my job in the
past and so it is useful but you really
don't need to know it something that it
is used for is kind of creating your own
data sets um and we're going to be
looking at one where you can create your
own data set today but there are a lot
of other uses for web scraping and I'm
sure I'll talk a little bit more about
that while we're actually walking
through the project one last thing I
want to say before we get started is
that this is most likely an intermediate
project so if you are just now learning
the basics of python this might be a
little bit challenging for you but I
still recommend going through it because
I will do my best to walk through
everything every single step of the way
and and kind of explain all the concepts
and so you can still learn something
even if you aren't super good at python
right now with that being said let's
jump over to my screen and get started
on the project all right so we are going
to get started and if you didn't watch
the last project I had people download
Anaconda uh we use Jupiter notebooks um
and I'll show you how to get to that in
just a second but I'll I'll leave this
link in the description if you haven't
done that already and you are just doing
this project um but you'll go you'll
download andaconda You Know download
super easy um and you're going to open
up Jupiter notebooks I'll launch it
right now I already have it open uh but
I'll open up another one just for you
know the purposes of demonstration what
we are going to do today and what we um
what people voted on I mean there's like
there was like 8,000 people that voted
um in the poll that I made of what data
you wanted me to scrape there was like
Amazon cryptocurrency weather um
something else I don't remember
overwhelmingly I mean like 70% of people
maybe even 80% I you don't don't fact
check me on that voted for Amazon um and
so I'm going to do it now there are many
things that you can scrape um off of
Amazon just a ton of stuff um and I'm
going to show you how to do it I'm going
to show you how to make it useful how to
make a data set um and it's going to be
really interesting but there are lots of
other ways to do this and so I think um
and I have already kind of created it
I'm going to show you how to do it off
of this page um when you're actually in
an item and you can scrape you know
basically anything in here um and I'll
show you how to do that another thing
that is a little bit more advanced and
that's why this first video is starting
off I think on the more easy side it's
not easy but it's easier the next thing
the next video that I'm going to make is
how to actually do um basically do
multiple items right so this item this
item this item this item and then
Traverse through the different pages so
there 20 Pages um you want all of that
data how do you get all of that that'll
be the next project um I don't know when
I plan on doing that I it like 90% of
the way done um but I had this one
completed and so I wanted to get that
out to you guys now but that will
probably be the next project I think
that is much more difficult um and so if
you can understand this one and you get
it and and you understand it then the
next project you should be able to
understand too is just a little bit more
complicated so with that being said um
we are going to actually get into the
project I'm going to delete one of these
um all we're going to do is go to new do
Python 3 it'll open up new one we'll
call this um
Amazon web
scraper um project that's what we'll
call it I spell it right perfect um the
first thing that we need to do uh or
that we should do is
upload um or or or import our
libraries so I'm going to say um import
oops what am I doing it's off to a
terrible start there we go import
libraries now I'm not going to write out
all the libraries um I have some things
that I'm going to be copying and pasting
throughout this I won't there's only a
few things that I'm copying and pasting
you can take a quick glance um some of
the things that I just don't want to
waste time on um because this could be a
long video I don't know I don't want to
waste time on stuff like this um and so
you know I'm just going to copy and
paste it you guys are going to I'm going
there will be a link below if you
haven't clicked it already that will go
to the GitHub page where you can
literally have all of this code already
written WR I do recommend writing it all
yourself because you will learn it much
better I promise CU then you'll make
mistakes and you'll figure it out and
all that all that good stuff but you
will have that code available so just go
copy and paste it um that's what I would
do but what we are we are going to be
using today is uh something called
Beautiful soup requests um then we're
going to be using time and date time and
a potential one if you want to get and
I'm going to show you this at the end
this is not really part of the project
it goes above and beyond but this
Library here is for sending emails to
yourself um and I'll show you how uh you
can use it if you want to I already have
the whole code written out um you can
just steal it and try it out yourself
and see if you can get it to work but
this one is not um as important I'll put
it down here so um let's move on now one
thing I want to say before we get too
into it is that well give me a
second is that right here in front of me
is a different laptop now it took me a
solid I would say you know 10 hours or
so to write all of this is took over the
course of like two weeks in my free time
I'd pick it up it took me a solid you
know two weeks on and off an hour here
an hour there to finish this project um
and I made a ton of mistakes and messed
a bunch of things up and I finally got
it to work um you know after a bunch of
revisions that's typically how things go
when I do projects and so uh I'm about
to give you a stream lined version of
this because I have all the code right
down here and so I'm going to be
glancing at this a lot um just so I
don't make this video 20 hours of trying
to remember all the code off the top of
my head I have it written out already I
already did the project it works it's
beautiful it's a good project so um I
don't want to waste your time and I just
want you to know that you know you you
nobody should be able to do this up top
their head in an hour most people won't
um it takes time you make mistakes um
but uh let's get started on the project
now in this uh in this what we're going
to have to do is we going to have to
tell beautiful soup and requests where
we are actually getting this data from
what website um what is our computer you
know some information from our computer
I'm going to again there's going to be a
little copying and pasting in here
because you don't ever you will never
ever ever need to know this um but right
here we're going to to basically connect
to the website so I'm just going to say
connect to
website and we going to say URL is equal
to and let's go get our
URL so we have this right here so
literally just go up here do you know uh
controll a copy that oops that's the
actual project get rid of
that uh paste it in here and that is our
URL we will use that in just a second uh
what am I doing
me just get some room here and then we
what we're going to need is something
called headers now again you will never
ever ever need to know this so I'm just
going to say headers um what I'm going
to do is I'm going to copy this I'm
going to show you how to get this really
quick um but is something called headers
so uh let me show you how to use how to
get
this and why you don't need to know any
of this so what this headers is is this
something called a user agent you need
to do this for your computer um and you
can do that by going to this link right
here so I'm going to put this link in
the description so that you can go and
get that and there's something right
here called the user agent so all you
have to do is copy this just like this
do copy I'm going to go back here and
I'll show you that it's I'm going to
copy it in um it'll be the exact same so
there you go
it's the exact same um all of this extra
stuff except encoding except um this
HTML stuff Connection close all the you
don't need to know any of it I promise
you'll never come in handy ever in
life actually there will be one person
who that becomes in handy for and then
they'll message me um but we are now
connecting um using our computer using
this
URL and then what we want to write is we
want write page we're going to say
equals and this is where we start using
uh these libraries so we're going to use
requests.get and we are going to pull in
that URL and we're just going to say
headers is equal to our headers right
here so uh we have this and this is
where we're going to actually
start getting the data bringing in the
data um and it's not going to look like
that at first but I'll try to print some
stuff out out as we go along the way so
that you can kind of see what it looks
like and how we're going to kind of make
it more useful because it comes in very
dirty uh when we first get it and some
of the things I'm going to show you will
just help clean that up um and before we
actually go any any further I don't want
my head to be here for the entire time
I'm going to get rid of myself so you
can just see the page uh I just it's
less distracting uh I hate when I feel
like people are always watching me so I
want people to just focus on the code uh
so I will see in a little bit let's get
back into it all right so what we are
going to do is we are actually going to
start using the beautiful soup Library
all right so we are going to say soup
one is equal to and this is where we
actually start bringing beautiful soup
and you guess it you're going to say
beautiful soup and then in parenthesis
we're going to do page.
content um and again these aren't really
things that you need to remember or need
to memorize we're just pulling in the
content from the page that's really all
we're doing right now and and it comes
in as HTML so we're going to do html.
parser uh and let's see if I can print
out uh actually let me just do soup one
I don't like I don't like doing upper
caps on
stuff let's see if anything prints out
real quick so we are literally pulling
in all of the
HTML um and let me go show you really
quick because we're going to get to this
in a second anyways um if you come here
this is
this is a static page basically written
in HTML um if you have never seen HTML
before um you
know actually a lot of this is you know
just stuff that most people will never
use uh it's just good to know some of
the stuff is good to know so as you see
I'm scrolling on this right side by the
way I did rightclick and inspect or
control shift I whichever one works
better for you but as I'm scrolling over
this you should see it kind of
highlighting different areas um it's
hard to kind of get what you want let's
say we want this title um what I can do
is I can click select element go right
here um and then we can select like a TI
the the the header or the title of the
the page now I just want to show you
though of what we're pulling in so we're
pulling in this doc type HTML all of
this is coming in so that's what this is
right here this doc type HTML and we're
pulling every single thing in that is
what we're doing right now uh so let's
get or let's go down a little bit let's
do soup two we're just going to do a
very uh you know an upgrade to soup one
basically we'll do beautiful soup
again and then we're going to do uh soup
one so we're pulling in that content
again so that soup one and we're going
to do do PR prettify if you don't know
what that is it is common in a lot of
different languages and a lot of
different stuff um it just makes things
look better it that's really all it
is uh I don't know why I'm using double
quotes I don't know why I can you can do
single ones if you want um and now let's
do beautiful soup to and it should just
be a it should be better formatted um
and let's see if that's true and it is
so before if you did if you could tell
it was didn't have basically any
formatting it has a little bit of
formatting now um it'll help in a second
um and you'll see that but now what we
want to do is go back and we want to
actually get the data that we want now
you can get any data you want I'm going
to show you simple things really really
easy um in my in in in my opinion it
gets more difficult the more complicated
stuff you start pulling um and and
you'll understand that as we go into it
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
select this and I'm going to select this
um the title I want that and so if you
do span ID it's equal to product uh
title so we need to remember that um
class we don't need to know class I
believe uh we're going to be using that
ID this um ID equals product title so
that's what we're going to be using um
class will come in in the next video
when we start looking at these uh but
not in this one so let's remember ID
equals product title so let's go back
over here so we have this soup 2 it's
basically all of that HTML in it right
down here that that is what we're
pulling in so we need to kind of specify
what we actually want so let's say title
that's what we're going to be getting um
and we're going to do soup 2 so using
taking all that content um we're do
find and we're going to do open
parenthesis and we're going to say we
want to find that ID where it's equal to
product
title and then we're going to do do
getor text and then we're going to do
open parentheses so now let's um let's
print the
title and see what we get all right so
that is exactly what we're looking for
it's funny got data Mis um T-shirt that
that is what we're trying to pull in so
that's perfect that's exactly what we
want we don't uh let me let me just do
this save me some time later on we don't
only want the title we are also going to
be pulling in the price so if you can
guess uh we'll be doing some uh a data
set on the actual
pricing um and so let's go back here
we're going to again use this right here
and we're going to go to this
price and it says again we're going to
look at this ID the ID equals price
blockor our price so fairly easy you can
copy this I'm just going to write it out
um we're going to say price is equal to
sup
2. find and then it's going to be again
ID is equal to and it's going to be
price block underscore our price did I
saw that right
oops excuse me there we go and the exact
same
thing.get
text
parenthesis uh and there's a g text
there's a get all or get all text um so
you know that get text is a specific
thing that we are using you we might use
a different one later on um but that
that is what we have so now
let's let's print the title and print
when I why do I have all
this too much uh too much space so let's
T print the title and print the price
let's see what we get okay so we have
our title and we have our price I mean
you know I don't know what all this
white space is over here um but it looks
like there's a lot of white space over
here we'll have to get rid of that uh in
a little bit as we clean it up a little
bit you can if you want do things like
um you can get and this is up to you I'm
not going to do this right now but I'm
just going to show you how to do it you
can get this where you're pulling in the
ratings um which is you know if you want
to look at like how the ratings over
time or or what ratings are for specific
products that could be really useful um
you can pull basically anything you can
go down the product details and look at
Dimensions uh anything you want on this
page it is static so you can go in here
and pull anything it's it you just have
to pull it from the HTML know where
you're looking pull it in um and now
when we go back here excuse me I'm going
to show you now kind of how to use this
right because we have this
but how are we going to use it um that's
kind of the important part I think first
thing we need to do is clean this up a
little bit because it just is you know
if we try to use this it wouldn't be
super useful because it'd be just a
little bit dirty it's not super
clean um so what we want to do is let's
start with the price why not uh we're
going to say price. strip um and that's
just going to take uh basically the the
junk off of either side and so let's run
that real quick so this is what we have
but what we can also do is I don't want
that dollar sign I just want the numeric
value um later on we are going to be
putting this and we're going to be um
creating a process to put this into an
Excel file again we're trying to create
a data set I don't want you to have to
copy and paste stuff it's all going to
be automated basically to input this
data into an Excel file for you or a CSV
file for you so um you know think about
making it useful in a CSV or in an Excel
later on so what we can do is do a
bracket and we're going to do one and
then everything after that so basically
it's just going to take everything from
the first position onward uh so let's
run that and there we go so let's just
say price is equal to price. strip um
and pull uh just do everything after
that first um that first not value what
am I saying what's the word for that I
can't remember the word the first space
that's not the right word but all right
let's do the title um this is basically
going to be the exact same thing um
super easy so we're just going to do
title. strip and open
parentheses um and we can you know if
you want to do this exact same thing so
now we have it it's a little bit cleaner
so this is what it originally looked
like and now this is what it looks like
so you know nothing super crazy but you
know something interesting to know now
we are about to in the very next part
what we are going to do and let me just
add a few of these because makes me feel
better um what we are about to do is
we're going to create our CSV to insert
this data into the CSV and then later on
what I'm going to do is show you kind of
how to um automate this process to pull
this data
um to create a data set right just
pulling this one time and putting into a
csb really doesn't do anything you can
just copy and paste that and save
yourself a lot of time um what I'm going
to show you is is um basically doing it
over over time and just having it
automated in the background that is what
I'm going to show you um I guess a
spoiler but what we need to do is we
need
to create uh create the CSV insert it
into the CSV and then create a process
to append more data into that CSV um I'm
doing a lot of talking let's do some
writing so what we need to do is we're
going to use um I should have done this
at the top maybe I'll go back and add
that later on we're going to do import
CSV now in a CSV what you want is you
want headers and then you want the data
right so for our headers and we're going
to call it header we're going to do um
we're going to do a bracket and let's
make the first one a title because
that's going to be uh we can call it
title you can call it product um
whatever you want I'm just going to call
it because I've been using title I'm
going to call it title um and then we'll
also
have
price now we need our data so I'm going
to say data is equal to now this is
important um right now how our data is
and I can do this right here we're going
type um title or no let's do type
price so these are strings and that's
important to know um again I don't want
to get too much into you know
dictionaries and arrays and lists and
and strings and all these things but
this is a string and you can't put that
right now it's not super usable what
we're going to do is make this a list um
and so I'm doing an Open Bracket and I'm
going to say our data is title
comma price oops price now oops if I do
type oops of data I'll just run that
it's a list now um and this is important
because you can run into a lot of issues
with the stuff it's really important to
remember what's what type
um how do I say this uh how your data is
is it a list is it an array is it a
dictionary um you know what is it these
things are important they do play a big
impact especially with this type of
stuff so just wanted to show you that
really quick but what we are now going
to do is create a CSV um you're going to
create an Excel I I call an Excel CSV
you know whatever you want to call it so
what we are going to do is we are going
to say with and we're going to say open
and now we're going to name our file you
can name this whatever you want I'm
going to call it
uh um
Amazon web
scraper data set that's real long
uh.
CSV and then we're going to do
underscore W and that means
right um oh whoops that's not right just
like I was wondering why that was uh in
Black uh so we're going to do W which
means right um and then we're going to
do new line and if you don't know what
new line is uh all that does is when we
insert the data it doesn't have a a
space in between each CSV and then we
are going to do encode
coding is equal to oops is equal to
utf8 and that is it and we'll just say
as uh let's do F so some of that stuff
you don't need to know some of it's
useful this W definitely need to know
this new line is is good to know and um
I'll take it I might take it out just to
show you what it actually does because
it's annoying if you don't have it I
promise um but you know that that new
Line's important this encoding you know
good to know I think that's by default
is is it's like that uh anyways what
we're going to do now is we're going to
uh it's something within the
CSV within the CSV um Library so we're
going to do something called CSV
writer and oops CSV do
writer and we're going to do open
parenthesis and that is that and we'll
just call that
writer and then we'll we'll do this is
where we need to actually create the
header so uh we're going to do writer is
dot sorry writer. WR row uh and this is
just for the
initial um the
initial import or or or um not import
the initial insertion of the data into
the CSV this is what's important the
next one that we're going to write is
for when we're actually appending the
data which is going to be a little bit
different but anyways we're going to do
right Row open parenthesis and this is
where that header is going to go so
we're going to that these headers are
going to be the title and the
price and then for our last one we're
going to actually write the data which
is this data right here and we're going
to say
writer. write
row and we're going to do data so this
one we are creating the
CSV and then we are inserting the header
and inserting the data so super easy um
yeah I think that's fairly
straightforward right now let's do this
and let's see what happens so I just ran
it um let's go over here in here
somewhere Amazon web scraper data set
let's open that
up and there we go oh
jeez this isn't good can't verify my uh
my subscription uh why does it say
$699 I'm going to go back and look but I
think I know the
issue um but this is exactly what we
want now of course we want more data and
maybe a little bit more useful data um
and I'll show you how to get that in
just a second but we just created that
out of thin air uh that was not I didn't
have that saved before so we have this
data set and the issue was is that I ran
this multiple times so now it's $6.99 if
I do it again it's 99 uh and if I did it
again it's it gets rid of everything so
I'm just going to run this again run
this
again now everything's back to normal
okay so now if we run this it's going to
overwrite this Amazon webscraper data
set. CSV and it will put the data in
properly so there we go oh jeez guys
this is embarrassing
I'm
embarrassed no I don't want this okay
perfect um guys I if you can't tell I'm
in need of some um I'm in need I'm in
need of some help here but I'm just
kidding I'm I'm doing fine uh I just I
don't know why that uh why I don't have
my uh subscription activated it's not
going to matter for this video I guess
but that's really random um so we got
what we need that's perfect
now what we want to do after this um I I
guess actually what is important is some
more useful
data something that I like to do a lot
when I do this type of this type of
stuff is I like to have some type of
date stamp um or some type of Tim stamp
to know when I collected this data it
usually comes in handy later on um I I
have never regretted putting it in there
I'll show you really quick how you can
do it uh you're going to do import
daytime
geez I hate having to format stuff like
that and what you can do is you can do
date let me get date time and you do
dat. today open parentheses and that is
going to give us this right here uh and
so we're just going to do um today
that's what we'll call it is equal to
this and we'll say print today and there
we go so that is today's date is the 20
of August in
2021 so today is now um is now this so
actually I'm going to get rid of that
I'm going to put it back up here I'm
going to put it right there I'm going to
run it again let's add this right here
we'll do
um we'll do we'll call it
date and then we'll add
today and we'll just run this again
and what we can do just to check the
data without having to open up the data
every single time which is super
annoying is we're going to use pandas
again I should have imported this at the
top I'm just kind of um I'm not doing
this off the top of my head but uh I
didn't have it 100% planned so import
pandas and we're just going to say pd.
read CSV and then we'll read it in um
what you can do or what I often do is I
go to properties and I go right
here and we'll say boom boom back
slash this right here this I am doing
off the top of my head I don't do this
often I think I have this memorized by
now uh I I I hope and then we'll do
print oh no we don't have to do print
we'll just do this uh what do I do R
let's actually call this um data frame
and we'll do
print let's see what happens perfect
okay so what we have now is the new our
new header our new data that we added in
there so we have our title we have our
price and we have our date now again you
can customize this whatever you want to
add go back here um you know find what
you want you know do you want it to make
sure it has a men's option or different
colors or you want to pull in this
information whatever you want it it
really does not matter um just matters
that you know you get what you need for
whatever purpose whatever you're making
this for this is more of an introductory
video to how to scrape data from Amazon
um the next video will probably be a
little bit more difficult and in-depth
but this is kind of let's get you guys
started so um we now have this and this
is
beautiful now something that you want to
do when you're scraping data and you're
getting um I guess data over time and
that's kind of what we're doing is going
to be almost like um a price tracker
over time is you want to then append
data to this so we can't only create it
and that's what this does because if I
run this 100 times it'll only give me
this first row we need to now append
data to this so um
let's let's pull this down here
uh again I'm I'm not I haven't added a
bunch of notes I'm going to say now we
are appending data to the csb I haven't
added a ton of notes I'll try to go back
maybe afterwards and add some notes for
people who like to read
notes
um so what we are now going to do is
we're going to change this W to an A+
now this is going to be how we append
the data um and we no longer need the
header so we don't aren't going to do
the header anymore and there we go so
now instead of excuse me so now instead
of creating that header again creating
that first row of data again we are
ignoring the data and we're now going to
the next nearest free row and a pending
data which means to add on data to
that um and so if I run this which I'm
not going to right now I mean why not I
can I can run it um and then we can read
this in so now there there's our data
I'll run it a few more more
times I ran it like three or four more
times I I run that in and there we go
now it's all the exact same data super
um
boring but very very uh you know good to
have now we don't want to have to come
in here and run this every day let's say
we're going to do this daily um we don't
want to have to come and write run this
every single day right we want a way
where it does it while we sleep it does
it in the background of our laptop um
and is easy to do right I don't want to
come in here every single morning with a
set an alarm on my phone every single
morning come in here I want to automate
this so uh how are we going to do that
give me one second uh if you didn't know
I have three kids and one of them is
waking up I'll be right back all right I
think he is asleep um at least let's
hope he's asleep so now what we're going
to do is we're going
to put this
all into
uh this check uncore
price now you may never have used oh
geez what are these things called oh my
gosh
super used all the time you'll know what
I what it is
uh not a function I don't even remember
what it's called maybe this's a function
um I can't think I'm having like a
writer's block or whatever that is we're
going to put it all in here and then
we're going to be able to use this price
check later um because we want to be
able to automate this so let's go back
all the way up
here we are going to use this so let's
copy all of that
in and oh jeez I hate
this all right everything just like that
um so this pulls in our
data pulls in uh or or yeah pulls in all
of our data down to the title and the
price we want
to make it look
right so we're going to put it right
here so now we have it formatted
properly um we want to add our date
time do it just like that I don't know
if there's a better I'm sure there's a
better way to do
this um then we need
need this right
here and just like that like that so now
we have our header and our data and then
we want to pull this in right
here boom boom boom
okay so everything that we just wrote
out we are now putting into this check
price now you can call it whatever you
want doesn't matter but let's run that
see if we get any errors we don't so
this is now good to go
basically um what we are going to use
this for um and what this is going to do
is we are going to put this on a timer
um you know have you ever wanted to like
check something once a day once every 10
seconds once a minute whatever you want
and you don't want to have to actually
pull up your phone and look at it this
is how we are going to do that so we had
something called uh let's see time this
this Library time right here that's what
we're going to use right now so we're
going to say while oops while
true and go like this do a
colon we're going to say check unor
price that's what we just wrote out and
we're going to do time dos sleep now
this is completely up to you how how
much time you want to put in here for
the purposes of demonstration I'm going
to put 5 Seconds which means every 5
Seconds it is going to run through this
entire process and so let's run this
really quick and I'm going to run it for
let's say 30 seconds and then I'm going
to
pull this in right
here so we just looked at it earlier we
had four um well five rows of data right
what we are going to do is in just a
second I'm going to stop this you know
maybe after 30 seconds or so we're going
to see how much data is in
there uh and let's stop it right now
it's been going far enough um and La
let's run it so now we have five six
seven eight so I guess I ran for 20
seconds we
can that was for demonstration purposes
I've never do any some anything every
every 5 Seconds um unless it was like
Black Friday on
Amazon we can put this
as long or as short as you want you can
run it every second if you want um that
doesn't make sense to me but you can
what we can do is do a little bit of
math uh and I don't know this off the
top of my head so I'm going to uh do the
math with you live pretty exciting stuff
got the calculator out so there are 60
seconds in a minute and this goes by
seconds by the way and you could do you
know you can do some um some string up
here of calculating this but I'm just
going to put in the number because it's
easier uh maybe not easier I'm just
going to do it there's 60 seconds um in
a minute there are 60 seconds or 60
minutes in an hour so that's one hour uh
and we can do 24 hours in a day so
that's
86,000 400 I believe did I read that
right oops did I read that right
right yes so this now if I ran this and
I'm going to this is going to check the
price every single day and this is the
entire point of this um of of
this project not the entire point but
this is a big part of this project is we
want to create our own data set now
something that I personally really love
is a data set that
has you know that I can do some type of
time ser series with now this is not
exciting it's probably not super
exciting for this right but you get the
idea that if this price were to change
we would then see that reflected in the
data at some
point you can do this on any item you
could ever imagine on Amazon it's the
exact same process and some items change
often this t-shirt will most likely
never change um and so you know again
this is for for demonstration purposes
the code itself will be nice to put in a
project although the data set that you
get from this probably won't be the best
I would
imagine but notice that this is running
um I can then minimize this and this can
run on my computer basically as long as
my computer uh is is
working um one thing I will say before I
go on to some more stuff one thing that
I will say is that I personally when I
did this for a when I um created this I
did something similar and I put this in
Visual Studio code um and I didn't put
it in Jupiter notebooks that's a
personal preference I would look into
that if that is something that you want
um I think visual studio code is a
little bit easier for automating these
types of tasks um but for illustrative
purposes and for demonstration purposes
you cannot beat jupyter notebooks that's
why I did it
so with all that being said that is
basically the end of the project now um
I'm not going to stop this and read it
again but you get the point um we now
have um a data
set that oh jeez all this again that now
has um data I'm getting out of here oh
geez it's hounding me let me get out of
here oh
no all this is embarrassing guys I'm
embarrassed we now have a CSV file with
data in now you run this in the
background of your computer you can do
that I have done it I've ran it for
weeks I have ran it for months um if you
restart your computer just come back in
here and restart running this process um
it's the same for any automated process
unless you start using some online um
automation service which will run it
regardless of your computer they do it
you know either in the cloud or on some
um
server so you know that this is a really
good option again if if you restart your
computer or something happens and you
lose connection just come in here run
this through this script again um except
for the one where it deletes all your
data don't run that one again only run
that one time um and then you will in
fact what I would do is then um I would
just comment this out right I'd come in
here and I would just comment this
out so that anytime I come back in here
I would never accidentally delete all my
data
but that is what this project does now
something really interesting something
that I have done in the past that I
thought was really cool really useful I
actually did it for um I actually did it
for some
watches that I was watching especially
on Black Friday it's when I used it I
was interested in a price drop or
specific price change and what I did was
is I said and I don't
know so what I basically did was is I
said if the price is lower than let's
say let's say we wanted to drop below
$14 it would then send an email um and
I'm going to show you the script that I
used it still works um and if this is
something that you are interested in
this could be a completely different
project I just think it's interesting
and I wanted to show it to you although
I wouldn't say this this is part of the
um final project let me just come in
here and we are going to create this
super simple um not super simple we're
sending a mail we're connecting to a
server we we're using Gmail we're
logging into our account that is my
email you will not get my password we're
creting the subject the body um we we
configure or or just kind of create this
message and then we send a mail so then
I have this Define uh or this send mail
I am blanking on what this is called I'm
going to call it a function but that's
probably not right so if that price
drops below a certain point it'll send
me an email um I have used this and I
used it and was able to buy a watch that
was like you know let's say 140 bucks
for like 90 bucks um on Black Friday
sale I was really really happy about
that so this can be used in that way as
well um not something you to write into
your project just something I'm going to
include down here if you want to try it
I think it's super interesting something
really
fun um really fun to mess around with I
enjoyed this so with that being said uh
this is this is the project um I in the
next one and I promise you this one is
probably going to get a lot
more difficult if you thought this one
was easy which I hope maybe I hope you
do then that means you're you know
pretty good at python you know in the
next the next um web scraping project
and I hope to do many of these I might
do um even all the ones that I put in
that poll but I started with the one
that was the most
popular um you know if you were able to
get through this I think that that is
fantastic I think this is a solid
project to create um a data set and so
use this how you will you can copy my
code exactly I don't have a problem with
that again I don't think this is
beginner there are some a little bit
more advanced things and I not even
Advanced just like intermediate level
things um that you kind of learn as you
get into it and so um I hope that this
was instructional I hope I explained it
you know well um and I hope that this is
useful again you know when you actually
use this you'll have 22 23 24 25 you
know you'll see a price change a price
change a price change a price change go
use a a product or go to something that
you were interested in or that you know
fluctuates often um and there are plenty
of those on Amazon I promise you there
some that literally change almost every
other day like down a dollar up a dollar
um and then Black Friday just goes crazy
um with these price changes so use this
as you will I hope that this was
instructional I hope that it's useful I
think I said that before is you know I'm
doing this because I think it's really
interesting it's really useful um um
this to me again was a good
introduction a really good introduction
to web scraping because in this next one
it gets quite a bit more difficult um I
would say on a scale of like difficulty
this is like maybe a four and it'll
probably jump up to like a seven on this
next one um just just much
more um technical or or coding heavy so
um you know look forward to that if
that's something that you look forward
to with that being said I'm going to go
back over here for my send off with that
being said I hope this was helpful I
hope that you learned something um don't
get mad at me if it was too easy don't
get mad if it was me if it was too hard
uh I'm doing my best over here so I
appreciate your patience thank you so
much for watching I really appreciate it
if you like this video be sure to like
And subscribe below and I will see you
in the next
[Music]
video
what's going on everybody welcome back
to another video today we're going to be
creating a script to automatically take
data from a crypto
[Music]
API now this project stems from an
earlier video that I did where I walked
through what an API was and how you can
use it and in that video I showed you
how to use coin market caps API so you
could start pulling in their crypto data
and in this video we're going to take it
one step further and automate that
process now we're going to do a little
bit of transformation with the data I'm
going to show you some cool stuff of how
you can use it and maybe we'll do a
little bit of visualization at the end
but that is not the main point of this
video it's mostly around the automation
piece and a little bit of the data
cleaning piece as well now fair warning
this is not a beginners level project
it's probably more like an intermediate
project and it's not even a complete
project per se because we're not doing
all the data cleaning we're not doing
all the visualizations but but if you
follow along we're going to cover a lot
of different things and you're really
going to set yourself up to be able to
do just about anything you want with
this data or different apis that you
pull from so with that being said let's
jump onto my screen and get started with
the project all right so this is where
we stopped in our last video so if you
haven't watched it now is the time to go
back and do that I'll have a link in the
description also all the code that we're
going to be looking at today and working
through is going to be in a GitHub repo
below so you can go and get all the code
and have it completely finished and just
follow along or you can code it from
scratch along with me I do recommend
writing it from scratch if you can
because I think you'll learn more and
you'll make mistakes and you'll learn
from that as we go through it but it is
up to you so let's get started and as
you can see uh we have the script right
here and I'm starting basically from
scratch I have a completed one up here
I'm actually going to get rid of those
um and what we're going to do is we're
going to start from exactly where we
started in our last one I'm going to run
the script um this is going to p from
our
API and we're going to look at the
dictionary set our option and do our
Json normaliz so this is where we
literally left off from the from the
last video so we have all of this
data
and what we want to do with it is we
want to kind of automate that process
right because we don't want to have to
come in here run this and you know put
into a CSV manually or something like
that we want to automate this data
collection process so that we can just
have the data ready for us to use um and
it all be ready to go so we're going to
be using this script um but you know we
we might want to add a little bit more
to it before we do that uh the first
thing that I want to do before um before
anything is something that I like to do
when I'm creating these automation
scripts as I I like to add a Tim stamp
uh and the reason for that is because I
want to know when I ran or when each of
those um Loops you can say runs through
an and does those automated runs right
so if I do it every day I want to know
what time of day I ran it making sure
each run ran
successfully and so all I'm going to do
is I'm going to add a new column at the
end and just call it timestamp so let's
go right up here and we're going to say
PD Dot and there's something called two
date time so we're going to do
2core date
time and then we're going to do now and
what this is literally going to do is
take the the date the the Tim stamp of
right now when it's running and it's
going to show that now we need to of
course add a new uh a new column for
that so all we're going to do is we're
going to say data frame whoops we're say
data frame and let me see real quick we
just have the
data
we need to add we need to create this
data frame right here so data frame
equals and then this Json normalized and
we're going to say data frame and then
we're going to do a bracket and we're
going to say timestamp and we'll do well
are all these lowercase we're going to
keep with the the lower case we're going
to say time
stamp and we do that bracket and we'll
say equals so what this going to do is g
to first off it's going to create this
dat or or assign this DF as our data
frame and then we're going to add this
time stamp and add this new column and
so let's run this really
quickly and let's go all the way to the
right and this is our timestamp and this
is the time uh that it is right now this
is the day that I'm running it this is
the time that I'm running it and so this
is working properly now if you look
really quickly there is a last updated
in here and this is very close to this
timestamp but it is not the same thing
um but if you looked through this data
and you really into it a little bit
there's this last update is coming from
coin market caps API and this is when
the actual um cryptocurrency was updated
in their system and so it is going to be
really close but it's not going to be
exact and so I don't like to rely on
built-in ones that you know are coming
from an API or something I want to make
one myself that's running on the system
where I'm creating the automated process
just like just something I do um so now
we have this original data frame created
right we H we now have what we need but
what we want to do is to keep adding
data to this um we don't want it to just
go to um you know create these 5,000
rows we want it to create 5,000 5,000
5,000 over time whether it's a day an
hour a week um whatever you want to run
it so um what I'm actually going to do
is I'm going to limit this a lot I just
want to look at the top let's say 15 so
we're going to do that that we're going
to run through all this again so now I
just have top 15 it's going to be um
easier to to see and it won't take as
much time to run our scripts again you
can keep as many as you'd like if you
want a 100 200 all 5,000 you do whatever
you'd like but what we are now going to
do is we're going to create a function
using this original script so we again
we have this data frame and we are going
to create an automated process that is
going to autom a script to automate this
that is going to append data to this
data frame right here so that's kind of
you know the big thing that we're trying
to accomplish in this project um so
let's go up here and we're going to
we'll just take from here all the way to
here we just going to copy this and
going to paste it down here now what we
need to do is we need to create a
function so we're going to say
DF and we're going to call this the a
apore Runner because this is going to
run our API um whenever we need it to
run now when you are
formatting um something for a function
it it needs to be formatted properly and
so what we need to do is need to go over
here hit tap we're going to do this all
the way down I'm just going to skip
forward when it's all the way done all
right so now we have this URL and what
we want to add because this is again
this is going to run through kind of
this this automated process we're going
to run this um this function there what
we want is to also add this right here
so we need to take this and we're gonna
need to add
this we'll just put it down
here
[Music]
okay and let's do that so what we have
so far is really close to what we want
our function to be um we have this
function that we're going to be running
through it's going to call this function
it's going to call the the API we're
going to use our key we are going to um
you know test it load it format It And
format it right here then we're going to
add this timestamp and then we will have
this now right now it's just C it's just
going to print this data frame basically
but that's not what we want right now
what we want is to actually append this
data so when it gets to here when it
gets to this data that's going to be
right um right here what we want to do
now since we already have the original
data frame set up up top is we now want
to say that this is going to be data
frame two and we're going to say it's
going to append it to data Frame 2 and
so the original data frame we're going
to say data frame
2. append and we're going to say
df2 all this does is this says this new
data that's GNA be coming in every time
let's say it's a loop and it's just
looping through pulling the data pulling
the data pulling the data we're going to
create this data frame we're going to
add add this time stamp like like we
want and then we're going to append that
to this original data frame so as of
right now this looks good I will we'll
run it in a second I'll create it so I
just created
it so now we need to actually create our
script to automatically run this so
we're going to do something called
import OS and let me tell you there's a
thousand different ways to do this and
there are better ways to do this but
they are much more complex much more
complicated and some cost money in order
to do it I'm going to show you different
options on how to do this in future
videos on how to automate your Python
scripts but this one to me is one I've
used a lot um many many times for
different projects and it works so I'm
not going to show you the most
complicated thing in the world I'm going
to show you something that I've just
used a lot and so we're going to say
from time import time from time import
sleep that one's
important and now we're going to create
our Loop so what these um what the time
and the sleep and the OS uh your
operating system what what these are
going to do is they're going to give us
the ability to track the time and we're
going to be able to run through and call
this function in certain intervals that
we want so let's create our for loop
we're going to say 4 I in now
you can create this specific part in
different ways but what I'm going to do
is I'm going to say range of one uh
let's say
333 and I say 333 and if you remember
from the first video on the API you only
have 333 runs per day and so if I ran
ran this 333 times today that would be
our Max and so that's why I'm using that
333 just for reference so now we're
going to
do
API Runner so in this loop we're going
to call this function up here and then
I'm going to say I want to prove or or
show have an output to show that this is
running through successfully so I'm just
going to and you can write anything here
we're just going to say API Runner
completed uh completed
successfully successfully how do you
spell that successfully that doesn't
look
right I'm just going to say completed
all right forget that I don't remember
how to say uh Spell successfully if
that's if it spelled it right you guys
spell it that way but I can't remember
now we're going to use this sleep right
here now this counts it in seconds you
can change it to minutes hours whatever
we're GNA have it run every minute which
is every 60 seconds and so this is going
to I'm just going to say it's going to
sleep for one
minute and then we're g to say
exit so all this is going to do and this
is again fairly simple it's just a
simple for Loop and what it says is it's
going to call this API it's going to
tell us that it ran successfully and
then it's going to wait for 60 seconds
and it's going to run again that's it so
let's run this and see what happens see
if what we did works so rant the first
time now I'm not gonna I'm not going to
bore you because I'm doing this live
exactly what we're about to get is what
we're going to use I didn't run it
overnight or or for a week so that we
have a bunch of data I'm what you were
going to work with I'm going to work
with as well so I'm going to wait a few
minutes I'm going to let this run I want
you to do the same thing I'm going to
let this run for maybe like five minutes
or so and we'll work with what we have
and we'll keep going with the project
because again we're not the point of
this project is not to create the final
product or creating all the visuals
ations that um will most likely be in
another video where we're taking all
this data and doing all these things
with it the point of this video is to
automate it clean it up to where we have
it to where we can really use it and
then I'm going to let you guys loose and
you guys can do whatever you want with
it and I think it's really setting you
up for a lot of successful projects in
the future that you can do all by
yourself without me having to walk you
through it so as you can see it's
already ran through twice I'm going to
pause for a second I'm going to let that
run through uh just a few more times and
then we will continue with the project
all right we are back and of course it's
only ran what five times um it has not
reached the limit of 333 so we are
perfectly fine what I'm going to do is
I'm just going to stop this by clicking
this uh square up here and it's going to
give us some error and then we're going
to check it and we will see what we have
I don't know why it's taking so long if
I'm being honest all right so I
interrupted it and let's run this let's
see what we got I hope we have more than
15 because if not I'm going be very
upset
okay so okay
well uh I made a mistake um I was
supposed to put data frame right here
and I had data frame too so um take
change your script do not do what I just
did we're supposed to be append it's
supposed to be data frame append and
we're supposed to be appending the
original D this data frame two to the
original data frame so so um I messed up
on that one let's rerun that let's rerun
that um let's
see local variable DF reference before
assignment okay this is perfect because
this happened to me before um we're
running into all sorts of good stuff I
like to keep this stuff in my videos I
laugh because I hate running into
mistakes but everybody says they they're
happy that I do this um so I'm going to
keep doing it I'm not going to cut this
out I promise um
but what we actually need to do is we
need to go back up to this function
because what happened was is we called
this data
frame and now it's it's because it's in
a function it's in what they would call
a local variable what we need to do is
we now need to state that this is a
global um it's just called a global
that's all it is um and so what we're
going to do is we're going do tab we're
say Global say
DF and what this should do is this
should declare it as a global variable
and it should let this run properly
let's hope it
does all right it's
running um again I run into mistakes I
let me tell you something while we're
here for just a second this project I
ran into probably a hundred mistakes or
a hundred errors issues that I had to
research for hours um and hours I'm
legitimately on stack Overflow and just
Googling and F figuring these things out
there were a lot of new things that I
had never run into before um just on
this project and so um everything that
you're seeing is from after I went
through all of those things or after I
fixed all of those things and had to
really work through them it was it was
very um it was frustrating at times I
just I couldn't figure it out and so
what you're looking at is kind of the
polished version of that now that I have
everything laid out because I I can't
spend 10 hours on a project nobody would
watch it so just know that if you are
running into some of these mistakes or
you run into mistakes later on when
you're expanding this project that's
completely normal so what we're going to
do is we're going to let this run for a
little bit and then after maybe three or
four minutes we'll come back and we'll
keep going with the project all right so
let's run this and check and see if we
have uh the data that we're looking for
uh and it looks like we do let's go
actually back up here really
quick um we want to set this to display
Max rows because I want to be able to
see all the rows and not just um a few
of them so and that just instead of it
gives us this scrolling instead of that
dot dot dot that shows us just a few so
there's our original 15 and then we have
the next um the next Loop and then we
have the next Loop and let me scroll
over to the timestamps and I'll show you
what I mean um so was ran on
52651 let's go down
526 at 150
2905 I say 1501 2905 and then the next
one you can see was ran at
36 31 these are all the ones one minute
after each other my original one was
from
earlier 32 33 yeah so you can see 32 31
3030 or um 3029 and this one was about
15 minutes ago when I first
um ran the original data frame right all
right guys this is Alex from the future
I've actually completed this entire
project uh in the video and you're about
to see all that after this but I wanted
to show you one more thing that you can
do in this function up here that I
didn't show you uh originally that I'm
coming back to show you and that's how
to actually put it into a CSV now all
we've done in this one is we we've kept
it all enclosed in a data frame and
that's it and that may be great but a
lot of you guys are going to want to
automate this and put it into a CSV and
I want to show you how to do that all
right so what I'm going to show you
really quickly is right here in this uh
in this folder right here I have all
these different API 3es and fours these
were tests that I did before but what
you can do is instead of just putting it
into a data frame you can actually
append the data to a CSV and have that
CSV sitting out there for you instead of
just keeping it all in the data frame
and there's a lot of different uses for
that you may want to have that file
separately from here just in case
something times out or something breaks
which is a legitimate concern or your
computer shuts off or or something like
that that is a legitimate concern so
what we're going to do is we're going to
say um if not and this is basically an
if statement we're going to say
os.
path dot is file so what this is going
to do is check if there's already a file
under this name and we're going to do r
dot or or R um if you have never done um
if you've never done CSV stuff before
it's really important that you put that
you you're going to get an error every
time so we're going to take this right
here and we're going to copy that and
we're going to put that right here and
then we're also going to do a slash and
then we're going to name it basically um
let's name this API because I don't
think I have that one in there I think I
deleted it yeah so I don't have API so
I'm just going to keep it api.
CSV and then I'm going to close that
parentheses and then we're going to add
a colon right here and we're going to
say if that does not exist we are going
to write this to it and create it so
we're going to say data frames that's
this data frame right
here data frame dot we going to say 2or
CSV and we're going to do that R and
then we're going to copy this so let's
just let's just replace it like
that and then we're going to say
comma
header oops header is equal
to column uncore names so what this is
going to do is if we run through this
and what we would have to do is um I'll
talk about this in a little bit we'll
have to change this up a little bit but
what this is going to do is going to
check to see if this file right here
exists if it does not it is going to
create it and create the column headers
based off the this data frame that is
what that does now what we want to do is
say else and this next part that we're
going to write is saying if there's
already the API file there we want to
append the data we don't want to
overwrite it or anything like that we
want to append the the data so we're
going to say we're basically going to
copy
this maybe not the whole thing but I
already did it um so we're going to copy
that and we're going to say mode oops
mode equals
a and a stands for append and then we're
going to say header oops keep messing up
header and we're say false oops we're
going to say false which means when it
depends the data it's not going to use
those the column headers every time
which you don't want because every time
you append it if you added the headers
every 15 rows every 15 rows you're going
to have another headers that you're
going to have to like go out into that
CSV and filter out and and get rid of
them so we're going to say header equals
false now just a second ago I said you
would need to mess with this just a
little bit and you would because every
time um you'd be putting in this data
frame which it's already appending it to
this data frame so every time you'd be
creating a lot of duplicates if if you
kept it exactly as is what you were
going to need to do is basically take it
back to its to its um bones um so you
need
to kind of keep it like this so what you
need to do is just now run this and it
would work perfectly uh let's test it
really quick um to see if it works uh
because I'm I'm promising you something
I want to make sure it actually works
let's run it this time okay so it just
ran for the first time so it should have
created this file
let's go see if that works properly so
now it just created that file and now
we're going to see if it actually
appends the data so let's wait just one
time um and then I'm going to stop it
I'm going to see if it works again I'm
just verifying to make sure that what
I'm telling you is actually working uh
because if it doesn't I would feel
terrible we don't want that and while
that's running actually I'm going to add
this because now I want to show you how
to call it um super easy we're just
going to do
pd.
reor CSV we do that we're going to call
this just like
that and then we're going to say data
frame and we're just going to do
72 something random because I've already
done this whole project I don't want to
mess anything up so we're going say data
frame 72 so now let's stop this
um and what we're going to do is once
that stops we're going to run this and
see if it actually um worked and see
make sure that this actually pulled the
data in all right so we interrupted it
the file is ready to be read in so let's
read it in there's our file um let's see
what did I mess up or did I mess
anything
up ah I didn't mess anything up this is
the index for this file and we already
had this in here we'd probably be able
to get rid of it but if you see we have
zero 1 two 3 four five six seven eight n
14 then we have zero 1 2 3 and if we
look at the time stamp it should be one
minute apart so it's 11
1945 it said 12045 so this worked
exactly as planned um again you have two
different options you can just keep it
how it was before and I'll leave both of
those options you know in the in the
script so that you can kind of choose
which one you want but um that's how you
do that so then right here you're
appending it to a CSV file and then if
you just keep this and you get rid of
all this you're just appending it to a
data frame now please continue with the
rest of the video that I already have
done um but again I'm future Alex so uh
please continue with the rest of the
video okay so we have all this data we
have we have so many columns we can do
now you know if you want to completely
just go and do your own thing you
absolutely can do that I'm going to mess
around with a few things um kind of show
you something that I did that I thought
was really interesting um in order to
visualize this data a little bit and
transform it a little bit to make it
more
usable um but we're not doing a full
data cleaning that's not what this
project is I'm not doing a full data
cleaning of this data that would be a ma
a very large undertaking because
honestly this needs a lot of work one
thing that I do want to clean up really
quick uh is is this right here I this
the math will be fine it's just the way
that it's shown on here is in state the
scientific notation and I don't like it
so what I'm going to do really
quickly I is just um get rid of that so
we're going
to we're GNA say
pd. set and we do underscore option and
this is going to be do parentheses I'm
going to say display this is just this
how this is formatting so we're going to
display
float underscore
format and we're going to say comma and
now we're going to use this
Lambda say x colon and we're going to
say
percent
0.5f and that right there and we're
going to say percent X now if you don't
know what lambdas is lambdas are um I
highly recommend looking those up um
again this is not a beginner tutorial
whoops no such Keys display floor format
that makes sense uh this is float yeah
guys this is not a beginner's level all
right uh you can't use the floor format
this is the float format all right so
now let's take a look at this uh this DF
uh this data frame that we have so we're
just GNA hit DF hit enter and now our
numbers are a little bit more easily
readable I prefer it this way you do not
have to do this I'm doing this just
because this is what I
prefer so let's jump right into it um
something that when I saw this data I
was like something that I really thought
was interesting is this percent change
of one hour percent change 24 hours 7
days 30 days 60 days 90 days if you're
not in crypto or you don't do investing
or anything like that what this is going
to show us is how I mean it's pretty
obvious how much the price of this coin
has changed over the last hour 24 hours
seven days so as you can see it's it's
barely fluctuated over the past 24 hours
a little bit over the past um seven days
a lot over the last 30 days 60 days and
90 days 20 minus 26% minus 33% we're in
may we just had a kind of a crash in
crypto a couple weeks ago so I mean this
tracks right but I want to visualize
this see this and kind of see um
you know how this is going to look and
how if I can gain any insight from that
information and just having it all
displayed for me but in its current
state um you know we really cannot do
that um now another issue not an issue
but another thing that we have to take
into consideration is we
have Bitcoin net right here we have
Bitcoin right here after different polls
now we just did it a minute after each
other but for your project may do it a a
run each day a run every hour or
something like that right
and if you did that your data could be
very different and so you may just want
to take this first one but what I'm
going to do for the sake of this project
I'm going to group them so let's go down
here and we're going to say DF dog Group
by and so if you've ever done something
like SQL uh this is how you Group by in
pandas basically we're going to group by
uh the name so so on bitcoin etherium te
so we're gonna we're gonna do that on
name and uh I'm not gonna I'm gonna say
sort is equal to false oops I'm not
going to sort it uh you could say true
there but we're not going to and I guess
you'll see why later we're going to do
an open
bracket and now we need to choose what
we're going to group by uh or what we're
going to what columns we're going to
have so I'm going to do another Open
Bracket and I'm just going to copy and
paste these so I'm going to start right
here at quote percent one hour so I'm
going to do boom and
then go over one and we're going to take
hours paste that
comma we have the 7day 30-day
and we're going to do like
that and I'm just going to do comma I'm
gonna do the same one but I'm just going
to manually change it to
30day rid of that at the end I don't
know what that is uh then we're going to
do 60
days and comma and we're going to do our
last one which is 90 days and let's see
what that gives us
uh doesn't give us
anything okay I know what's wrong here
um we forgot to add basically the what
we're we have we're grouping by
something we need to have like an
average a
mean a mode or something like that right
so all we have to do is go to the end
right here and let's just do we're going
to do an
average um and so we're taking this
number let's say this is for Bitcoin so
we're going to take this number in this
one hour for every time it's Bitcoin
it's going to group them all together um
and then it's going to average them so
in the past five minutes where it's been
running we're going to take the average
or the mean of that so let's run this
again and so now this is our output
let's take a
look Oops I meant down here let's run
this
now now what we have is all of these um
cryptos these are all 15 that we have
and this is the average um for this 1
hour 247 days 30 days 60 days and 90
days so now we have all of our
cryptocurrencies over here we have our
percent changes up top and then our
averages um here as well and so now what
we're going to do is you know if you try
to visualize this as is doesn't really
work because these percent changes are
up here as columns and we don't really
want them as columns because that it
just doesn't work for visual for
actually creating the visualizations we
really need these to be rows and so my
initial thought when I was doing this
was I of course I need to Pivot um you
know if you've ever used pivot like an
Excel or powerbi or something like that
that was my first thought and I tried
everything and I could get not could not
get it to work and I almost gave up
until I I ran across um something called
stacking or back and and so this was not
something that I I I think I have used
it before but I I couldn't remember to
be being completely Frank I couldn't
remember how to do this so I just did um
once I saw what it was I did Stack let's
make that dat four you don't have to do
this uh you can keep this all the
original data frame I'm just I like for
visual purposes you can see like the
progression that we're making um but I
like to you know create its new data
frame and I can always go back and look
at this data frame three um as we go but
you don't you don't have to do that
that's just what I'm doing so now let's
take a look at this now uh up here we
had Bitcoin and we had all these columns
and we had uh these numbers as rows but
now we have all of these as rows as well
this how we have this is much much more
usable um and if you've ever done
something like pivot or the stacking
before you'll know that you you kind of
have to do it if you really want to
visualize this
well but um you because we just stacked
it it kind of changed it so if we look
at um let's look at the type of let's do
type of data frame three this is
before um before we stacked it this was
in a data frame but now let's go and
look at data frame four so this is a
series this is no longer a data frame so
we have to remember that that's that's
really important because we can no
longer treat it as a data frame it's now
a series so we want to get it back to a
data frame we don't want it to be like
that because you can't really use it in
the series so what we're going to do and
let me just create a few of these so you
can be up here better so now what we're
going to do is we're going to say data
frame 4 Dot and something called 2core
frame so we're going to make this into a
frame and now we're going to specify the
name and it doesn't mean um the name
like right here we have actually mean
the name of these values right here this
is part of the stacking process in these
columns or these two columns so let's go
right here and we're going to call it
let's just say
values and let's make this data frame
five and let's see the output whoops for
data frame five and now so there's that
values and now this already looks a lot
better right so it's in this it's in
this more um this is already a data so
this is a data frame so let's look at
type data frame five so now it's in a
data frame
but the issue is is that this name is
kind of acting like a an index which we
don't want because we want to be able to
use this so it doesn't really have an
index at the moment so we need to give
it an index but typically when you give
an index you'll do something like um
we'll say dataframe do5 we'll do
setor index and then you'll do something
like um name so let's just do dat frame
six is equal to we'll see we'll see what
happens here it's going to give us an
error oops what I meant is we're going
to do data frame five
bracket uh name and that's a column
right we're going to do that and it's
basically going to say that that's not
going to work and and what we need to do
is what or at least what I want to do
and what we're going to do in this video
is I'm going to create numbers I really
would just want it to be numbered one
two three four five that's what I want
um but we don't have that right now I
can't just will it into existence so now
what we're going to do is kind of create
uh an index basically out of thin air so
we're going to do pd.
index and we're going to say uh you know
we basically want how many um rows are
in here that's where we want our our um
index to be we want it to count how many
are in here now you can make this
Dynamic and I it probably wouldn't be
that hard but I'm gonna take this super
lazy route um and I'm just GNA
say let's do DF
do5 or oops df5 doc
count and there's 90 values in here so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to do
a
range of 90 uh and this is not uh I
would definitely make this Dynamic but
I'm again I'm just
being being a little bit lazy we call
this index is equal to and I'm going to
put this Index right here so now this is
a number so now it's going
to literally Index this for us now I've
ran into this issue many times um so
what I need to actually do is to reset
this index and then do it properly the
first time uh so let's do re let's get
rid of this let's reset this index um
and it actually fixed itself um so what
was happening was is we were indexing
something that was already indexed we
were causing
issues in a nutshell so we reset the
index and now this is what it looks like
and this is exactly what we want this is
really how we wanted it formatted in
order to for our visualizations we have
multiple rows for the Bitcoin um each of
these columns are is now a row with the
value attached to it exactly what we
wanted so um really quick I for whatever
reason it it makes that uh level one I
don't know why but we're just going to
rename that column really quickly so
we're going to do data frame
6.
rename and then we're going to do and
open parentheses say columns equal to
we're going to do one of these these bad
boys oops one of these bad boys this
this type of bracket and we're going to
say
levelor one and we do a colon and then
oops and then a colon and then we want
to change it to and I'm just going to
call this the percent underscore change
so let's call this dat frame
[Music]
seven again you don't have to do that
I'm just doing it so now this looks much
much better now let's try to visualize
this one um because we haven't done any
visualizations yet we've just been
messing with the data a little bit I I
you know I kind of want to see how we
can use this it's something that I
personally am interested in so I kind of
wanted to see visualize how these
changed over these these time periods um
but we need to um import some stuff in
order to be able to visualize this so
we're going to import cbor as SNS and if
we need to um we're going to import map
plot lib as well I don't know if we'll
use it right now or at all but um we're
going to we're going to add it in here
either
way so now those are added and so what
we're going to do is come right here
we're going to do
SNS doat plot and we're going to oops
we're going to say the x axis is equal
to and we want to do this as the percent
change percent
change and then we have the Y AIS now we
want the y- axis to be these values
right here say comma Y is equal to and
we're going to say
values oops and then we're going to say
comma and we'll say we want to basically
create a Legend um I guess you could
call it we're going to say Hue is equal
to name um I'll show you what it looks
like without it and then you know you
can
see that we need that we're going to say
the data is equal to this data frame
seven data frame
seven and then we are going to say the
kind is equal
to now let's run this and see what we
get and super quickly with just you know
limited um inputs here's what we have
now this looks really good we can narrow
this down if we wanted to to a few less
because there's a lot here and there's a
lot of colors but again that's just
because we have a lot of different stuff
but there's a few that are doing really
well I think this is
Tron um and then we have a few that are
not doing so well but it's really hard
to see if you look down here it's really
hard to see this um and that's just
because of the the column name
and so I actually want to change these
column names or these values so that
when we visualize it right down here it
it doesn't look like that I kind of want
this to be you know at least one good
visualization you can take out of here
this is definitely not perfect or
complete by any means but you know you
can take take that away from here um so
let's um I did Alt Enter which adds
another row I could have just pushed
plus that's was kind of the lazy way um
what I'm going to do
is I'm going to change these um these
values in here so how I'm going to do
that is I'm going to do data frame seven
and we only want to look at this one
column so we'll do that right
there and we want to say dot
replace and we're going to an
open parenthesis and then a bracket now
what we need to do is I'm just to show
you um one of them is I'm going to say
this one
hour do that oops and then what I need
to do is a comma another bracket and
this is what it's going to change to I'm
just going to say one hour oops one hour
um and we'll do this one really quick
and then I'm gonna I don't want you to
have to watch me type all this out but
I'm going to go through and basically do
all of this uh for those but let's let's
see this really quick and so now as you
can see that um the originally it said
quote. USD percent change 1 hour is now
only 1 hour now
this didn't actually do anything we need
to apply it to this right here so I'm
going to say data frame 7 is equal
to and then we'll run data frame 7 again
so now that has actually changed that
value now I'm going to go through and
I'm going to update that for every
single one all right so I basically just
put the other ones um in here that we
wanted to change with commas afterneath
so I have 24 hours comma with the seven
days 30 days 60 days 90 days and then
this bracket over here which tells uh it
what to change it do 24 7 days 30 days
60 days 90 days so let's run this I
haven't even tried it yet uh and it
looks like it obviously worked properly
so now let's go back down here and let's
run this
again and look at that it looks so much
cleaner so much nicer um and as you I
mean all of them with that 1 hour change
has very little change and then you can
look back so we can see back within 90
days it's gone a lot of these have gone
down which again if you're following
crypto you know there's a big crash
recently um especially with with you
know all these altcoins um that you're
seeing right here went down a ton so I
think this is um Avalanche or die or
whatever these ones are you know went
down dramatically whereas there's one up
here this Lone Wolf um that's just
that's just did do really well for
whatever reason so it's really
interesting um to see now this is a
pretty specific um visualization that I
personally wanted to see and I thought
was interesting you can do absolutely
whatever you want to do with this data I
mean there's so much here you can do a
lot I mean a lot with this data
especially depending on how long you
track it right I only did this over the
course of like five minutes but if you
set this up um and you can track it over
a longer time
now um let's say you wanted to do
something much simpler uh you just
wanted to look at like Bitcoin over that
time that you you know uh uh took the
data in that's going to be a lot simpler
than what we just did and I'll show you
how to do that really quickly so we're
going to look at the data frame and we
are going to say uh or we're going to
take specific columns we just want um a
few columns that we want to keep or or
pull from so we're going to take uh oops
we're going to take the name
column we're going to do
uh might be easier if I copy them but
I'm just going to write them out quote.
USD do price this is the price of the
actual
cryptocurrency then we're going to
do Tim
stamp and let's make this data frame and
we're just going to do 10 for absolutely
no
reason uh maybe made at n it would have
been easier so now we just have these um
these columns and you know we have all
these separate columns so what we can do
and the re kind of the reason I want to
show you this is you can just query this
really quickly and just take the columns
that you want so let's say we just
wanted to look at Bitcoin so we're going
to say data frame
10. query do open parenthesis and we're
going to say name is equal and equal is
not like that uh when you're doing it
like this you need to say equal equal
equal
to oops ignore that uh is equal to
bitcoin and we're going do it just like
that and we're going to say data frame
10 is equal to let's try running that I
think something's wrong with it try it
like
this oops all right let's try that there
we go it was just the I needed a double
quotation instead of a single quotation
that was the issue so now we have
Bitcoin we have the price and we have
these time stamps so this is the actual
time when we ran it so this is the
original data frame and then in the you
know this this project it took me 15
more minutes to get this one and then we
had it running properly for the next
five minutes so that's you know that's
actually what we have now if we want to
just visualize this really simply what
we can do is we're going to
say uh we're going to do SNS doline plot
and that's going to be like a little
line chart or line graph what whatever
you want to call it and then we're going
to say x is equal to and we'll say
quote no actually we wanted the time
stamp to be on the x-axis um and then
we'll do y is equal to quote. USD do
price and let's see if that
works good not interpret time stamp for
the
parameter uh that's because it's not
understanding that the
data equals data frame 10 now let's try
this all right so this is uh looks
terrible let
me me just say SNS doet underscore
theme and open parentheses we'll do
style is equal to dark
grid this looks a little better now
again we are looking just at a very very
short time series but we can look at
just Bitcoin or we could look at
multiple and we're showing this you know
this line that's showing us this
trajectory over time so you can get
really creative with this you can run
this for a long time you can show
Bitcoin over days weeks or month months
however long you run this and so that's
really all I've got um honestly like I
said this is not a I wouldn't say this
is a complete full project but I'm
showing you how to do something to
enable you to kind of run with it and
run with the ball and do basically
whatever you want with this you can pull
it from you know data from a different
API you can use this exact API in data
but I wanted to show you just a few
things that I initially saw that I might
do with the data and you you have so
much let me go back to this original
data
frame uh right we'll use this one right
here this one right here look at all
this data I mean you have so so so much
data actually let's go to this one this
one's better you have so much data so
many numbers here um so many columns
that we didn't even look at that you can
use um and so you know there's a lot
that you can use here and I'm really
trying to just set you up so that you
can run with it and do whatever you want
I could have done a thousand different
things here but you know I tried to just
show you two things that you can do with
the data that I thought were pretty
interesting or or simple to do and you
know I want you guys to go out and do
something way way better than what I did
so I hope that this was helpful I hope
that this showed you how to automate
that process so you don't have to sit
there and click it and append it and do
all these different things that it can
show you how to kind of automate this
process and hopefully that will be
helpful in your future projects so with
that being said thank you so much for
watching if you made it all day to the
end you guys are fantastic if you like
this video be sure to like And subscribe
below I'll see you in the next
[Music]
video what's going on everybody welcome
back to another video today I'm going to
be walking you through how to create
your very own portfolio
website
[Music]
now we just completed our data analyst
portfolio project Series where we walk
through four projects in SQL Tableau and
Python and so if you have completed
those projects you now want to share
them with potential employers and I
think the best way to do that is to
create your own website in just a little
bit I'm going to show you two options on
how you can actually create your own
website the first one is a website
builder like wix.com and the second one
is hosting your own website through
something called GitHub Pages now if you
have never created your own website
before it can sound a little bit
daunting but don't worry I'm going to
walk you through every single step of
the way from the very start to the very
end and once you reach the end you'll
have a complete data analyst portfolio
website so without further Ado let's
jump on my screen and let's get started
all right so the website that you're
looking at right now is the actual
website that we are going to build in
this video um it is hosted on GitHub
Pages or github.io so this is actually
being hosted right now by GitHub pages
so if you type this in I'll leave a link
in the description if you type Tye this
in um you will get this page and you can
check it out for yourself if you don't
want to just watch me look at it um so
you know it has this little header and
you can write a little bit about
yourself and then these are our actual
projects so this is our data cleaning in
SQL project um and then there's the
covid uh data exploration Tableau
dashboards movie correlation with python
um this is a future video I plan on
doing a few more of these projects
because I just really enjoy them so uh
you know and then there's this contact
information at the bottom so it's a
really
simple website and it gets the point
across and uh I have something similar
to this for my own personal one I I use
a different variation but um this all
comes from this website HTML 5 up there
are lots of templates lots of options
that you can use um again the one we're
going to be working with is this one but
I use a different one for mine and they
are really good
I me super easy to build and customize
yourself and I will say again I have no
experience doing this I just watched a
YouTube video that showed me how to do
this and now I am creating my own
YouTube video to show you how to do this
so it's coming um pretty much full
circle so like I said there's no no real
narrative to it it just clicks to your
project um if you click on this and
let's just open a new tab it'll take you
right to our to the GitHub project um
and then you the the whoever is checking
this out like a an employer or a
recruiter can see your code so super
simple another way that you can do this
is kind of creating your own website
through like a template or something
like that um almost like a Blog style so
I imagine it being very something very
similar to this where there's this
introduction and you can talk about you
know where you got the data set how you
got the data um and then you can kind of
have a more narrative uh approach with
screenshots and with some code as well
so you know this person included
screenshots um and then there's the code
right here that I can actually copy um
and paste that and it just walks through
the logic of how the project was done um
there's a story to it really and so that
might be something that you're
interested in now I have done something
like this in the past and I used Wix and
there's a you can do this completely for
free um the one we're doing today is
completely free as well but you know if
you want the customize
um the customized URL you do have to pay
for it on Wix but you can get a free Wix
website with the Wix um in the URL so
you know try this out these are super
easy you can find thousands of templates
and a million tutorials of how to do
them um so that's not the one we're
going to be working on today so with
that being said uh the very very first
thing that we need to do before we do
anything is actually download visual
studio code this is where we're going to
download that HTML and we're going to be
working with it in there um again I
don't know if I said this before but it
seems a little bit intimidating at first
but once we actually start looking at it
it's a lot easier than it looks I
promise you so if you are me and you
have a Windows computer you'll just go
right here you'll install it um super
easy to install I'm not going to walk
you through how to do that um of course
I already have it up and running down
here so once you have that installed
what you're going to do going to come to
this website a link should be in the
description we are going to download
this all you have to click is the free
download it's going to pop up I'm going
to put it in my downloads I'm GNA click
save
fantastic uh so let's go to the
downloads and it should be right here
now if we open this up it has a few
different things in it okay so um I'm
using the brave browser so that's going
to be right here so that's this the
symbol but for you if you're using
Google Chrome that should be the symbol
there as well but this is everything
that you should be seeing and what we
want to do is we want to take it out of
this um zip folder because it's there
are things that can read into it with
Visual Studio code but I want to make
this as user friendly as I possibly can
so what we're going to do is we're going
to make create a new folder and I'm just
going to call it massively or you can
call it um Port website whatever you
want to call it I'm just going to do
Port website
um and we are just going to I'm going to
copy this in I'm not going to cut it in
just in case I make a mistake so going
to put all of those um all of those
things in
here and now what we're going to do is
we're going to go to visual studio code
right here and you should be greeted
with this um this right here and we're
just going to click open folder and
we're going to go to Port website and
we're going to go select
folder and you're going to say say yes I
trust this one and right over here is
all of the documents that we were just
looking at now the one that the only one
really that we're going to be working in
um we'll work a little bit in the images
um because I'll show you how to add your
own images the really the only one we're
going to be working in is this index so
again it looks complicated um if you've
never looked at HTML before um it does
look a little bit complicated but HTML
to me
is one of the more easily understood
languages um once you start kind of
getting into it which we're about to
we're going to walk through the entire
process it actually makes a lot of sense
and it is pretty simple um something
that you're going to want is you're
going to want something called a live so
like if I click right here and I click
open with live server you don't have it
yet I'm guessing unless you've done this
before um it's going to open up this
website and this is what we're looking
at right now so it has a bunch of um
gibberish or some language that I do not
know and so we can view this live um in
just a second I'm going to take myself
off screen but before I do that um let's
download or let's um search for that
that
live um I think it's called live share
live server um let me see what this is
called yeah live server so come right
here it's called this live server there
it is yeah that's the one so this is our
live server you just need to click
install it takes like 5 seconds and it
should be completely installed um what
this does is it just hosts a local
website it's not something that anybody
can access um but it connects to your
code and when we make updates it'll make
a lot you can see it live you can see
those updates live so I'll show you all
that in a second just be sure to um be
sure to download that or install that uh
with that being said let's get out of
this let's go all let's go back right
here uh with that being said I am going
to take myself off screen so that you
can see everything that I am seeing as
well um it's been really great seeing
you have lots of different videos coming
up lots of new projects um I just I
really enjoyed this project series I
think I'm just going to do more of them
so uh all right I'm G to get myself off
screen so let's look at what we actually
need to do so I'm going to um
so let me see okay so we're already
connected to the
live um actually I got rid of it
whoops let's pull this over and let's
pull
that and we're going
to open in live server so if we look
right over here and I know this going to
be a little bit Squish and I'm sorry
about that um but if we look right over
here this says this is massively so you
you can change that that's that's this
right here and you can say we're going
to say Alex the analyst portfolio and
we'll get rid of this massively I'm
gonna hit control save you can also go
up here and hit save but I'm I'm going
hit controls so I hit contrl s and just
like that it updates on the website now
again this is just a local so it's
nothing that anybody can see so don't
worry but what we're going to do is I'm
going to walk you through the entire
process of creating this and then at the
end I will show you how to host it on
GitHub um and it's honestly it's it's a
fairly easy process it's just takes a
little bit of time to customize it all
so let's get into it so we have this um
you may not be able to see it let me
actually pull this up so it says
massively by HTTP we're going to
customiz that customize that as well
whoops I don't want to do that every
single time I'm I'm going to try not to
go full and go back and everything like
that so we're just going to say Alex the
analyst
portfolio um contrl s and right up here
that changed it you may not be able to
see yeah don't ask me that again thank
you uh right up here you probably can't
see at the moment we'll see that later
um but it it customizes this um tab
which is really
cool so let's go right down here now
this is where it says a free fully
responsive HTML uh five template we can
customize that and I highly encourage
you do so what you can do and they
actually included their Twitter handle
right here and you can do the same if
you look at this one right here I
included my Alex the analyst handle that
that goes to my YouTube channel and you
can do the exact same thing includes
your LinkedIn or your GitHub profile or
whatever you want to include in there um
and so you know be aware that you can do
that so let's say um oops I need to
click back in here
so we're going to
say
um data analyst skilled in and then
again don't write what I'm writing um
you can it's I'm just going to make it
really simple but you know this part is
meant to be a little bit about you um as
who you are so I'm going to say data
analyst skilled in
SQL Tableau and
Python and then I'm just going to get
rid of all of this
yep yep yep everything from here
over and contrl
S and so super simple um actually let me
where was that
four four here it is we don't need that
actually we don't need any anything from
here
over probably here honestly see what
that looks like um and yeah and I can
again you can use any website right here
that you want
and you can customize what it looks like
so I'm going to say Alex the analyst um
and then whatever URL you want to
include in there that's what you need to
put so now if I save oops if I hit
contrl s so now it says Alex the
analyst um so pretty
easy now we're going to go down and you
can use this however you want to use it
I would you can even make this um you
can make this like one of your one of
your readmes like a you and put the link
for that I decided to include um again
on this one I decided to include the
project that I thought that we've done
that was like the most impressive or the
I don't know the coolest one I don't
know if you consider data cleaning and
SQ cool but um I do I think it's cool so
I included that one as my very first one
so that's what we're going to do um
right here so we're going to go down and
it's going to
say
let's say it says this is massively
that's not
it uh cool so let's see what oh okay I
know what that is we'll come back to
this up here um in just a little bit I'm
going to go full screen I'll show you
what this is and then we'll come back to
it but if we go right down here this is
our what they're calling a featured post
and then the ones below this are posts
so in our featured post um I'm going to
get rid of the date I don't want them to
know that I just created it like um I
don't know oops I keep doing uh control
a selecting everything whoops so we're
going to say um data cleaning in
SQL and we'll get rid of
this and contrl S again I'm just
updating it a lot so that you see what
I'm doing and where it's going and we're
going to get rid of basically all of
this and go back and we're just going to
say in this project we C clean data in
we clean let's do we clean housing data
in SQL
server and contr S so super easy again
uh give a little bit more description I
did in my other one um and you have the
you have you can see that website so go
check it out and then we'll have an
image and I'm going to show you um at
the end we're going to go back and redo
all the images but I'm not going to do
that at this very
moment um
so what
now you can have this full story I chose
to do view
project and i h contrl s it says view
project I think that just looks better
especially if you're displaying a
project I think it is nice uh now we go
into all the indiv individual posts um
actually no wait what I want I want to
show you really quick is how you
actually link it to this so let's go
right over here this is our co uh that's
our Co one here's a data cleaning
project so all you have to do is take um
take this website so that's the URL and
you're going to put it right here now
there's three different places this href
is places are places where you can put a
link to a website um and on here it
references this right here so you can
they can click on this data cleaning and
SQL they can click on the image um as
because you know this href is right next
to this image they can also click on the
view project button so you can put it in
all three um and you'll just go like
this you'll you'll stick the URL right
where that um hashtag or pound sign
is and then we're going to save that
oops oh I I this is embarrassing I am
not a website I am not a web developer
as you can see um but then if I go in
here and I right click and I say open
link it is going to take me to that
project so super super simple and we're
going to do basically that for all of
these um I'm only going to show you
three and then you can do the rest but I
want to show you how to also do the um
put the Tableau it's the exact same
thing but you know it's different so
wanted to show it to you so the next one
that we're going to do is go down to
posts
and again I'm going to get rid of this
date you can keep that in there if you
want excuse me and that's totally fine
just
update the date um this is that said mag
again I think this might be like some
language that I just don't know about um
the next one is data
exploration in
SQL and I'm going to get rid of
this and we'll save that
perfect and we'll do view
project
cool and yeah so now we need to um
customize this summary and so I'm just
going to say something really simple um
data exploration of
covid-19 data set in SQL
Server there we go let's save that we
have view project now let's go get our
project so this is the data exploration
we're going to take this we're going to
copy it and we're going to put it right
in
here and right in here as well and if
you want to you can also include it
right up here so we have it in all three
places uh again once you click on these
they will come up let's go to the next
one we're going to get rid of
this this one is going to be our Tableau
projects so actually let me just copy
that while we're here this is going to
be our Tableau projects so if you have
one specific project that you want to
include what you need to do is actually
go in here click view grab that URL what
I am doing is I am just sharing my
Tableau public page so if you have tons
of projects in here and um you want to
display all of them then or you want
them to be able to see all of them and
go and pick and see and choose what they
want to look at then just choose this
URL that we're choosing right here so um
in here on in the um HTML we're going to
put I'm going to put tab
projects
and let's go like
this and then we will get rid of uh that
hashtag pound sign whatever you want to
call
it and we'll hit contrl s and oh we got
to do the
um this as
well this is my this is going to be a
terrible don't use this this is my
Tableau this holds I'm just this is bad
this holds all of my
Tableau
dashboards don't please don't do this um
I am doing this because I don't want to
take forever in a video to make it
perfect um and then you know you're
going to do the exact same thing so in
this one right here I included four so
I'm going to keep
four
um let me do the
no I'm just going to do these three I'm
not gonna take up more of our time um so
we did those I'm just going to keep
these three in for visual purposes but
once you get down here um you know what
we're going to do is delete some of this
right so we this is our data
exploration and where's our
Tableau this is our Tableau right here
so Tableau projects they're separated by
these articles so what we're going to do
is go around right here and we're going
to go down down down down to right here
this is going to get rid of all these
other articles or all these other what
they're calling um posts so we're going
to get rid of those and we're going to
hit
save and now as you can see we have our
header we have our first project and we
have our second and our third I would
include those other projects that we've
done in here so that it looks good this
is this footer right here we don't need
that because we don't have any
um anything else in there so we're going
to get rid of that as well and now we
just have this information
now I don't have anything where they can
do the name email message or you can
keep that in there if you'd like um but
I am going to get rid of this so we're
going to go right here that's the
section so don't delete the section we
want that I'm going to delete this
footer section as what they're calling
it and now we have this address phone
email social um and I'm G to get to the
Social in just a second it's again super
easy but for the address I just put
location I don't want to give somebody
my address or put it on a website
anywhere um it's not something I want to
do so what we're going to do is just put
I'm going to put
Dallas and Texas and we can keep it like
that and we'll hit oops we'll hit save
and it'll have Dallas Texas um hate the
look of the zeros 6 seven8 n z so we're
going we're going to do that phone
number
two3
7890 and then email and we'll
put Alex the analyst 95@gmail.com
if you have issues with this um you can
email me
but I'll try I will try to respond to
all your emails I get a lot um so I will
do my best but that is my actual email
if you are curious
now um now that we have this we also
have these the social media now I want
to display my LinkedIn and I also want
to display my GitHub so what I'm going
to do right here is I'm going to go over
here and do
LinkedIn perfect let's go to this so I'm
going to take my LinkedIn
URL and I am going to get rid of these
first two because I'm only going to
include two and for this one I'm going
to do uh
LinkedIn oops linked in and then for
right here I'm going to replace that
with linked
in and what you're going to do is put
this link right here and then we're
going to go get get the
GitHub so let's do GitHub oh who is this
sign up what is going on
um I don't there let's just go back here
I that was some I was like viewing a
while back or something um so we're
going to take the GitHub and we're going
to put that right here so it already has
it as um the GitHub is this supposed to
be
lowercase I think it is let me see if
this is lowercased as well yeah um so do
it like that do it lowercased um I
forgot that that was how they did it
um and oh that's the label that doesn't
matter as much but this right here is
the class is actually the important part
because then when we go back here there
is no LinkedIn image but when we save it
oops when we save it it has the LinkedIn
image because it's already a class that
was created in this HTML um
template so we have that um and let me
bring this full screen really quick
because there are a few things that we
couldn't see in that that screen these
right here are things that we could not
see before um and these as well so what
we can do is we're going to go down here
we're just going to copy these social
we're going to replace them right here
so they can have those and then we're
going to get rid of these two right here
and this says this is massively um and
we're going to change that as well let's
make this full screen for the first time
feels good um I hate doing split screen
but I do it for you guys um so this is
massively and we're just going to put
we're just going to get rid of these two
this is um it's called The Navigator the
the different tabs we're going to get
rid of those two tabs and then for this
I'm just going to call it
projects and I'll once I once we go back
and update all this then you will um
you'll see those
changes so let's see so we made those
changes here's our social or the social
medias uh Social Media stuff we're going
to go and copy copy these
two and we're going to replace all of
these with
this
um and let's save that and let's go back
so now as you can see those two are gone
this says projects there's only two
right here and if you click on it it's
going to go to my LinkedIn or your
LinkedIn when you do it um and this will
take you to the GitHub so it is all
working as intended this is great um
when you scroll down and it says
massively we can change that as well and
we should let's do that really quick um
we'll just
say Alex the
analyst and we'll update
that and there we go so in a nutshell
this is the a lot of it um we need
images and I don't think I set this up
for this video so I'm going to I'm going
to like cut myself off for like 2
seconds go pull those images in um
because it could take like a few minutes
I don't want to waste your time and then
I'll come back so I'll see you in two
seconds all right so I just pulled over
the images that we are going to use
let's go to the downloads um they're
right here they're the housing Tableau
and Co um if I open up this Co one this
is what the image looks like this is
what we're going to use for that covid
project so I'm going to copy these I'm
going to go into the port website um
that we just have I'm going to go to
images and I'm going to insert these in
here so now that we have those images in
here let's go
back and let's see what we got so we
just put these images in this um you'll
have this folder right here and you can
open it up and you can see all of these
that we have so all we're going to do is
go and replace the images these these
you know temporary images that they had
for us and we should be gold and then
we're going to actually upload it to to
GitHub and then create our website for
free so let's go right down here this is
our very first uh one this is our data
cleaning in SQL this is with the housing
data so this image right over here it
says images p1. jpeg so jpeg I don't
know why I said it like that so this is
the housing so what we're going to do
right here is do housing and it'll
autocomplete for us um so that housing
should be in there now next one is the
data exploration in SQL that was with
the co so we're going to get rid of this
we're going to say Co um because that is
the image that I have right over here
and then the last one is excuse me
Tableau so let's go right over here
let's do TBL
low let's get rid oh I got to save that
uh contrl s perfect and now let's look
at
it there you go there you go go oh this
one still says full story go change that
um I'm going to go change it just
doesn't feel
right uh view project oh that's not how
you spell
it okay contrl s perfect okay so now
this looks a lot better um and when we
host it um through GitHub Pages or
github.io this is going to be what it
looks like I mean it is and you can add
a lot more to it you can take away from
it you can add as many projects as you
want you can keep adding you can copy
those articles or those posts and you
can just keep adding them um so this is
kind of what it's going to look
like
and it was not that hard I don't think I
hope this was not too difficult I really
don't think it is um it's really just
using a template and kind of
understanding a little basics of HTML so
um we are going to take this and we we
have this saved already we have this all
saved what we are going to do now is
upload this to GitHub so let's go right
over here let's go to here and let's go
to
repositories and how do where where's
the new one oh I need to sign in okay
I'm going to get rid of this part so you
can't see it so we are going to say a
new
repository we're going to call it Alex
the analyst
2 .
github.io so we're going to write it
just like that you know if your name's
um
Alex Jimmy I don't know why I said Jimmy
Alex Jimmy Alex jimmy. github.io you can
always go back after the fact and change
this so it's not a big deal whether you
change it or not and we're going to
create this
repository we're going to say upload an
existing
file and instead of choosing them what
we're going to do is just go right over
here go to this and we're just going to
copy this in or not copy it in but drag
it in okay so we're going to take this
drag it in right here and it can take a
it'll take a little bit has a 75 but it
shouldn't take that
long and let's just wait for it I taking
a sip of water I
apologize but it is literally uploading
just everything that we had in there so
all the updates and all the changes and
all the stuff that we um had
and it looks like it's done so let's
just
write initial
commit commit
changes it is processing
it all right and it should be done very
very soon as long as I have a good
internet
connection we shall
see stick with me it's taking its
time um while while it's loading let's
go over to oh oh there it is so perfect
so here's everything that we have has
this read me that it generated let's
over to
settings and we have this U
github.io and if we go right down here
to GitHub Pages pages settings now has
its own dedicated tab let's check it out
here so it is
um it's currently disabled but we're
going to say want it to do pull from the
main um I think it's the doc we'll see
I'm going to save this your site is
ready to be published let's open this up
okay site not found maybe it's from the
root
save um your site is having a build a
problem let me see if I can actually
change the name I already have an Alex
analyist but I'm GNA see it's already
taken um I'm just going to try this one
one more time oh and now it's working uh
I have no idea why it uh didn't work
before but this is fantastic it was
giving me all this I was maybe I was
just reading too much into that I had I
had never tried to create another
umio or or GitHub pages on this so
anyways thanks for sticking with me
through all that um stuff so now we have
our actual website um it doesn't look
the same up here because of that thing
that we were just looking at it should
just be this part right here but um this
is an actual website now it's being
hosted through GitHub and it's
completely free if you want to pay you
can hide this from your GitHub um your
repository has to be public uh something
I didn't mention when you're doing this
your repository has to be public um if I
change the visibility to private um you
will not be able to see it anymore
you'll have to then pay if you want to
make this repository private you have to
then pay I think it's like $4 a month or
something like that so worth looking
into um if you don't want to display
that on your GitHub worth looking into
but this is our final product I mean it
looks pretty fantastic and you can use
any of these templates right there are
lots of different templates that are
fantastic I mean they look amazing they
look professional um it's really up to
your style like this one looks kind of
cool a little bit um edgy for for my
taste but uh this one looks really good
too might might be able to add some more
narrative to that one so again go
through it make your make a good choice
in it and then update it how we updated
it uh I will include the um let's see I
will include everything that's in here
and I'll keep this on my on this GitHub
that you can go in there and if you want
to download these images you can
download the images that I I used um or
you can go find your own just um you
know look for try to get like HD images
on Google just type in Google Images and
search for whatever image you want to
search try to get an HD image with that
being said that is the entire project I
I I I hope this didn't go too long um
this may have gone you know this may
have gone like 30 45 minutes but in the
end of it at the at the end which is
where we are now we have an entire
website it was completely free and I
hope that you can host the projects and
you can create create more projects I
will be coming out with more projects
myself that hopefully will be
interesting to you in the future so with
that being said thank you guys for
joining me for you who stuck it out to
the very end you are fantastic you know
send me a post your website on LinkedIn
and tag me in it because I love seeing
um you guys do these projects and this
stuff so I'm super excited to see all of
these um that you guys tag me on on
LinkedIn and whatnot so with that being
said this is it I hope you learned
something I hope that it worked for you
and I appreciate you watching be sure to
like And subscribe below and I will see
you in the next video
[Music]
goodbye what's going on everybody
welcome back to another video today I'm
going to help you create a data analyst
resume
[Music]
now when I say data analyst rume it's
not that much different than a regular
rume except that it's going to be
catered for a data analyst job in just a
second we're going to take a look on my
screen at a sample resume I'll have the
template in the description so you can
just go and download it and fill in your
information but it's a fantastic
starting place to actually creating your
resume when we're looking at this resume
we'll take a look at each section kind
of dissect each part of it and then at
the very end I'll give some extra tips
on what you should include and how to
actually write your rume as well so
without further Ado let's jump onto my
screen take a look at the rume and see
how you can create your own data analyst
resume so here's our sample resume I'm
just going to walk through the entire
thing super quick and then we'll break
down each section individually I'll give
my thoughts and some tips on each
section and remember you can download
this exact thing in the description
below I'll have a link I'll probably put
it on my GitHub or somewhere else but
it'll be free to download uh so you can
go ahead and do that but let's zoom in
just a little bit so at the very top we
have our header we have some just basic
uh contact information then we have
skills then we have projects and notice
the projects are up here at the top and
we'll get to that later about the order
of where you should be putting your
things then we have work experience and
then we have education so really quickly
I'm going to zoom out and I hope you can
still see it the order is actually quite
important now there is one piece that is
not in here right now and that is a
summary section I don't have a summary
section on my real resume I just I don't
think it's useful or helpful I don't
have one you can include one and it
would be right up here at the very top
now why do we have the skills and
projects at the top well it's because
that most people who are trying to break
into a data analytics don't have any
experience in data analytics if I am
reading this resume as a hiring manager
and the first thing that I look up here
and I see is experience and it's not
analyst it's a teacher or a nurse or
something I'm going to be like
this person doesn't have any experience
I don't want to hire them the first
thing that you want to have in your
resume is something that is good for the
hiring manager to see the first several
things you should put all your best
stuff at the top that's my uh what I
believe so I think that these skills are
really strong a lot of great skills and
then these projects are all really good
projects now this is just a sample these
aren't all real projects um or they are
real real projects they're just not you
know ones that I built myself it's just
a sample so uh then right here we have
our work experience now if you're like I
said a nurse or a teacher or a lawyer or
something that's not relevant to data
analytics you want that at the bottom um
and then you're going to want to tie in
uh some things in these descriptions and
then the education at the bottom my
education was terrible okay I had a
bachelor's in recreational therapy which
had nothing to do with data analytics so
for a tech job has was not good I always
had mine at the bottom so let's start at
the very top and walk through each
section so
at the very top you want to have maybe a
title but for sure your full name you
definitely want to include your phone
number if you're okay with them calling
you but definitely an email for sure
include things like a LinkedIn profile
or a GitHub profile you can also put
your portfolio in fact I highly
recommend putting your portfolio because
it just looks good or if they check it
out that's a really good thing and then
your location cuz sometimes your job is
going to be location based whether
you're in Dallas or another Metropolitan
City it's just nice ni to have that on
there this should be the simplest one to
fill out unless you haven't built out
something like a portfolio you just
don't include it um but this one should
be the simplest one right you're just
putting contact information maybe a link
to a website next we have the skill
section and this one on my own personal
resume I have at the very top I
typically recommend anyone who does not
have experience who is trying to break
in to data analytics to put this at the
top as well and have these skills and
know these skills that's important um
but when the hiring manager first
initially sees this there's just going
to be a mental check okay they have the
skills that we're looking for let's move
on to the rest of the resume um but you
want as many mental checks for what
they're looking for at the beginning
just going to I'm going to keep
repeating that um this is how I
personally write my skills so I write
something like SQL and then I'll say SQL
Server my SQL postrace SQL now I have
used all these different types of SQL in
my actual job if you don't you haven't
done done that and you're just starting
out maybe you put something like um you
know
subqueries store procedures joins
whatever the actual things within SQL I
don't really think I don't recommend
that as much because typically people
know what SQL is like if they use SQL
they know what SQL is so they're just
going to expect that you know those
things now for something like python
it's different because there are
packages something are there are
packages and libraries within them so
you can specify I have worked with
pandas in my actual job and I look for
people who know pandas as well because
you know we use it so actually
specifying these packages or libraries
is really helpful so this is how I would
put these things on a resume now this is
another resume this is our sample two
I'm going to maybe include this one down
below although I don't like this format
as much but if you like it you can but
here's another way that you can um show
these skills just a different way to do
it I want to show you both ways um we
have like Python and the libraries
underneath it I've even seen it to where
people will write out almost like um let
me go down here they'll write out like a
narrative um they'll do
Python and then they'll have like a
colon and then they'll say use to um
manipulate data and I'm not spelling
that right in pandas dot dot dot and
they've write it out you can do that as
well again I'd like bullet points
because it's to the point it's exactly
what you need let's get rid of this one
real quick so this is the one
uh that I like so that's the skill
section let's move down to the projects
now the project section is almost
primarily for people who are just
starting out once you get experience
typically you maybe have one project on
there or no projects at all but the
project section is used as kind of um
inl of actual experience right I've
always said that you need to build
projects not just for your resume but
also for the interviews so so then when
you get into an interview you can point
to these projects and say yes I've used
SQL I did it in this project and they
may have seen it and you can walk them
through how you actually used it it
gives you more credibility than just
saying you know how to use SQL So within
the project section we're going to have
a project like this one says data
science job market exploratory data
analysis so this is a personal project
and then within it they did some really
great stuff here's usually what I
recommend and this is in here which is
you specify what you did you say I used
Python and what did you do to analyze
this and gain insights in the job market
then you walk through some of the things
that you actually did things like regex
techniques you used pandas matplot lib
you built a wordcloud these are keywords
that somebody will look for and they
even highlighted them which I personally
like and do as myself they highlighted
these things so that the viewer or the
um hiring manager is actually seeing
them making sure that they're bold so
that they are catching their eye so I
personally do this and I recommend this
that's all it needs to be it just needs
to be I built a Tablo dashboard doing
this from this data set I cleaned it in
SQL and you show those skills something
that's important in both the skill
section and the project section is using
and highlighting your skills as much as
possible especially if you don't have
any experience if you've never had a job
before once you have a job and you come
down to like the work experience then it
kind of speaks for you but if you don't
you want the projects and the skills to
speak towards your skills and
credibility so we have this right here
now one thing that's not in here that I
actually do recommend is a hyperlink
maybe right here or actually this being
a hyperlink to the project because they
might read this and be like I we work
with you know data science job market
data I don't know and then they'll click
on this link and they can see your work
that is the one thing that I would
change change in this other than that
this is exactly how I would have it very
very very similar to my own um and a lot
of this that I did I actually took from
other resumés and formatted how I prefer
and like it um so again some of this is
personal preference and you can change
it however you want that's just how I
like it so that is the project section
now we're going to go down to the work
experience section now this person does
have a little bit of analyst uh
experience so you know if you don't
that's okay
but you put your previous experience now
here's what I recommend if you've been a
teacher for 15 years you've been a nurse
for 10 years you've had 10 different
jobs don't put all your experience on
here um maybe put your last two jobs
going back maybe three years I don't
recommend you filling it up because it's
not going to be super relevant unless
you're applying for a healthc care data
analyst position and you have a Nursing
degree then it's relevant and that
experience is super helpful because it's
domain experience right then you may go
back five years just you know use your
discretion but what you need to include
of course your title where you worked
your location and the times that's
standard for almost any resume but
within here uh what you really want to
do is highlight again the skills if you
can if you can't that'll change but in
here he says implemented a new reporting
using Excel pivot and VBA which reduced
processing time by 50% these types of um
quantitative information I reduced time
I I I saved the company money I I did
something quantitative putting that in
here is always helpful always highly
recommended although it can be tough to
measure these things right typically
what I recommend especially if you're
first starting out is to highlight
skills if you're a teacher you've
probably used Excel and you've probably
used Excel for closer to data analytics
than you think just in a teacher way and
not a data analytics way but you can
reward these things and make them sound
good if you are a a nurse like I was
saying youve used used Excel you've used
a health information system you've used
uh some type of database talk to that
include that in here um and it can be
hard to write these out and I'm going to
show you away in just a little bit about
how you can write these out and think
about these things or have a way to help
you write them or give you ideas we'll
get to that in a second lastly we have
the education piece this is again really
simple at the very bottom education what
your degree was where you went um and if
you have you know some help ful things
to include you can do that and then when
you actually went now you can include
other things in here as well like boot
camps if you went to a boot camp or you
could also include things like a GPA
although I don't personally recommend it
GPA has never been anything that I've
ever cared about or I've seen anyone
care about ever um so you don't normally
have to include it one other thing that
you can include at the very bottom is
something like
certifications uh I personally don't put
a lot of stock in certifications unless
it is one that I have recommended in
previous video like the Tableau
certification or Tableau desktop
certification if you're applying to a
job that uses taow that actually could
be really good so definitely include
that but ones on udem me ones on corsera
or like my Alex the analyst boot camp
that I have on my channel I wouldn't
really include that in your resume it's
mostly for learning if you get something
like the Tableau one or the AWS uh Cloud
one or the um Azure Cloud one those are
all actual certifications that can help
you and give you credibility towards a
certain skill now really quickly let's
just take a glance at the other resume
this is resume 2 so we have the
education at the top doesn't have to be
at the top unless it's relevant which
you could put at the top we have a skill
section they again this is the projects
same projects and then work experience
this is just a little bit different um
order so you can do it like this as well
in different way you can write the
skills and you can also include a
summary section as well so that's the
meat and potatoes of how I would create
create a data analyst resume now writing
it is actually a different Beast right
you have to actually write it out get
something on the resume and then apply
using that resume but it can be hard to
come up with these ideas so uh I just
want to show you something that a lot of
people have been using I personally
haven't written a resume in a little
while so I don't use it for my own
resume or haven't used it but I will um
and that's using chat gbt or some
variation whether it's on Bing or you
know you get some different version or
some new product that's out there at the
moment I'm just going to show you how to
do it in chat GPT some of the things
that you can prompt it to do and that'll
be it I'm just going to show you kind of
some ideas that it can generate for you
to help you write these things all right
so here in my screen we're on chat gbt
if you haven't used it I'll leave a link
in the description I also have a whole
video on how to use chat GPT for a data
analysis um so I like chat GPT now I've
already written out these questions
because I don't want to wait for the
responses but here's what I asked it to
do and you can do some variation of this
whether you're a nurse or a lawyer or a
teach teacher or whatever I said I'm a
math High School teacher trying to
become a data analyst how can I use my
experience on my resume to help me get a
job this is just to help provoke some
ideas and it says you know you most
likely have some skills emphasize your
quantitative skills so those are some of
the things you can focus on showcase
your ability to commute complex Concepts
which is really important in data
analytics being able to present
information which teachers have
highlight your experience with
technology hopefully you're using some
type of uh you know database for
students or you know Excel or something
like that you can highlight that and
showcase your ability to solve problems
now the next thing that I asked it was I
built a covid tableau dashboard using
Tableau how can I add this to my resume
and then it's going to tell you exactly
how you can do that it's going to say
include the link to your dashboard which
I also recommend provide a brief
description highlight your data
visualization skills include screenshots
or images which that's what I would be
putting in the project itself not on
your resume then provide context for the
data all really good stuff really great
now the last thing is kind of what I'm
trying to get at as a whole it can help
you write things so I'm going to say
write a two sent I said write a two
write two sentences highlighting my
covid Tableau dashboard to add to my
resume and it's going to say developed a
covid tablet dashboard to visualize
pandemic Trends using real-time data
sources demonstrating strong data
visualization and Analysis skills so
this can help you generate those
descriptions in your work experience it
can help you generate the descriptions
in your projects and this can be really
helpful to just generate some ideas cuz
I personally really struggle with like
highlighting my skills and descriptions
within those things this can be a way to
kind of help you do that so don't you
know just copy and paste but let it
prompt you let it give you ideas now the
last thing that I want to mention is
just your overall resume as a whole the
template that I use the template that I
recommend is very very friend friendly
to these automated systems that check
your resume if you did not know most
companies especially big companies use
these automated systems that scan your
resum see if it has what they're looking
for and then that rume if it gets
through that system gets passed on to a
recruiter or hiring manager typically
most companies don't go straight to the
hiring manager so you need a resume that
can pass through those initial systems
and pass those tests the RS that I've
shown you today will do that they have
bullet points they have the keywords
they have everything you need that's why
I recommend or partially why I recommend
this type of resume other ones that have
images and different fonts and different
stylings can cause issues with these
automated systems where it just doesn't
read it properly or you know it doesn't
read the right words that you want it to
read so just know that these types of
résumés have different uses right you're
not just handing it off to somebody to
where they can read it and it's needs to
be visually stimulating really what you
need is you needed to get through those
initial systems which these resumés uh
if you write them well you have good you
know skills and the right things on your
resume they will pass through that first
layer to get to those hiring managers so
again be sure to download those those
are completely free I just I highly
recommend using them I think they're
really good so be sure to download those
use those just put in your own
information be sure to build out your
own projects don't just keep the ones
that are on there because you'll need to
be able to speak to them sometimes
recruiters or hiring managers are going
to ask you about them how you build it
what you did and you can also point to
those projects in your actual interview
so I hope that this was helpful I hope
that your resume is ready to go I hope
that you ready to start applying for
those data analyst jobs thank you guys
so much for watching I really appreciate
it if you like this video be sure to
like And subscribe below and I'll see
you in the next
[Music]
video what's going on everybody my name
is Alex freeberg and today we're going
to be walking through my top three tips
on how to use LinkedIn to land a job
LinkedIn is a fantastic place to look
for a job it's its own little ecosystem
where career-driven people can connect
and talk with one another and help each
other find jobs I personally have landed
jobs through Linkedin and so I know how
effective it can be let's jump over to
my screen and I'm going to show you my
top three strategies that I have found
to be the most successful to actually
finding a job so I'm logged into my
completely Anonymous account here and
I'm going to show you the very first tip
which is you shouldn't be just applying
to a position you should be actually
reaching out to the recruiter and I'm
going to show you exactly how to do that
so the first thing that we have to do is
actually find a job that we want to
apply to so let's go to the job section
right over here and let's search for
data
analyst and let's do that
in let's do
Chicago because why not uh so it's going
to search for data analy positions in
Chicago we have one right here let's see
what it looks like cuz you know I don't
want to apply to jobs that I'm not
extremely qualified for so this is a job
that I want to apply for and before I
actually go and applies to the job I
want to see if I can reach out to a
recruiter and talk to them beforehand so
let me show you how to do that so what
we're going to do is actually click on
the company right here it's going to
take us to basically their LinkedIn
profile page for their entire company
and we're going to scroll down we're
going to go over to
people and then we're going to search
for
recruiter
so if we scroll down all the way to the
bottom we can see that there are
recruiters that actually work inh house
for this company and so now would be a
time where I actually reach out to some
of these recruiters and I say hey I see
a job that I really like I think I'm
really qualified for and I would love to
talk more about it with you you can ask
them things about the job to make sure
that it is a good fit for you and then I
highly recommend you asking them what
they think is the best way to apply for
this job to make sure that your resume
gets noticed and you get an interview
since they are a recruiter who works at
this company they may be the the one
who's actually going to be looking at
these resumés and so they may give you a
tip on the best way to actually apply
they may also just ask you to send them
your ré directly that they can look at
it or maybe later on down the line this
actually is a person who is reviewing
resumés and so if they come across your
resume they may be able to put a face to
the name and that may give you bonus
points I'm going to leave a template
script in the description in case you
don't know exactly what you want to say
to this recruiter and it'll give you
just a baseline of some of the things
that you might want to say number two is
to actually ask for a referral now if
you don't know what a referral is it is
is where somebody who already works at
the company can refer you to a specific
job and then might get you a little bit
higher on the list for interviews so I
highly recommend reaching out to
somebody who already works at that
company and ask if they're willing to be
a referral for you I get people reaching
out to me all the time asking to be a
referral for them for my company and
nine times out of 10 I say yes I always
ask to see their resume first just to
make sure that their resume aligns with
the position at least a little bit but
there's basically no harm in me being a
referral for somebody in fact I may
actually get a bonus if that person ends
up getting hired and so for the most
part there's almost no risk for the
employee to actually being a referral
and so a lot of times they will say yes
now let me show you how to do that and
it is very similar to finding a
recruiter so we're going to stay on this
people section but instead of searching
for a recruiter we're going to search
for a job title that is similar to yours
so let's actually see if they do already
have any data analysts and if they do
that is the person that we're going to
reach out to because that is the person
we'll probably have the best connection
with so it looks like we have six
employees and let's SC SC down and so it
looks like all these people have data
related jobs and so I would reach out to
these people and say I saw an open data
analyst position at your company I would
love to know more about your company as
a whole and then you can talk to them a
little bit and then in the end your goal
is to ask them for a referral and if
that happens that is fantastic and then
you can go ahead and apply for the job
and mark them as a referral for you now
my third tip on how to get a job through
Linkedin is to actually have recruiters
reach out to you so let me show you how
to do that the first thing we're going
to do is actually go over to my profile
here and we'll click view
profile now there's a few things that we
want to make sure that we have on here
so that recruiters can reach out to us
the first thing that I want to do is to
actually come to this section right here
which is show recruiters you're open to
work and when I click on this I can
actually choose some job titles and some
locations where I actually want to apply
and have recruiters reach out to me and
so right now I have data analyst I have
in the DFW area which is where I live I
can also add titles like business
analyst um and then maybe Junior data
analyst entry-level data analyst or
things like that that could potentially
have recruiters reach out to me for
positions that I'm interested in and
then you can say that you're immediately
and actively applying and you can also
say that you're only looking for
full-time positions or contract
positions and then you can actually add
this to your profile and I only want
recruiters to see that because I do
currently have a job at McDonald's and
so I don't want McDonald's firing me
because I'm looking for employment
elsewhere so let's save that and it
looks like it was updated and so now
when recruiters are searching for
candidates for a specific position you
will be on that list so that they can
find you and reach out to you something
else I should mention is on your profile
page I would try to have some type of
professional photo so that you look
really good I would also try to include
data analyst somewhere in your title if
you already have a data analyst job and
you're looking for another one you can
just have your previous company but if
you're looking for a data analyst job
you can always put seeking data analyst
position or something like that another
thing I think is really important is
having really good descriptions for your
previous work I don't currently have
this but I would go a little bit into
the work that I actually do make sure
that the experience matches kind of what
you're looking for if you do have
previous experience if not that's
totally fine the next section on your
profile page that I would recommend
looking at and updating is your skill
section and so you want to go in there
and make sure you have all of your
relevant really data analyst heavy
skills on there specifically hard skills
because soft skills aren't going to
translate too much into this section I
would definitely stick to things like
SQL python Tableau Excel things that
data analysts are going to use because
this is where they're going to actually
look and see if you have the skills that
they are looking for for that position
when I was applying to jobs in only
applying to job postings and not using
any of these strategies my success rate
was 0.04 which means out of 1,000
applications that I filled out and sent
my resume to I only heard back from four
of them to actually get an interview but
with these strategies I was able to get
that up to 10% and at my best I was able
to get that up to 15% but that's because
I was applying to a lot less positions
and I was targeting jobs that I really
wanted to work for and so I put in more
effort in order to contact people and
work with Recruiters in order to get
that job I genuinely hope that these
strategies can be helpful for you
especially if you're trying to apply for
jobs right now thank you guys so much
for watching I really appreciate it if
you liked this video and got anything
out of it at all be sure to like And
subscribe below and I'll see you in the
next video hello everybody
congratulations if you are watching this
that means that you completed the data
analyst boot camp if you haven't don't
keep watching this is only for people
who have completed the data analyst boot
camp playlist on my YouTube channel woo
all right now that we filtered those
people out I'm going to show you how you
can download your certificate and your
certification now that you've completed
the data analyst boot camp I will leave
a link in the description but let's go
on to my screen I'm going to show you
how to actually access this and download
your certification all right guys don't
go around telling people this or sharing
this uh but this is our data analytics
boot camp on the Alex the analyst GitHub
right up here I will have this link in
the description what you can go ahead
and do is you can come right here you
can download this you'll just right
click or click download and you just do
something like save image as um or you
can come to this one this is the one
that I think is the the real money maker
here uh this is the certificate of
completion for the data analytics boot
camp I have my not signature but my name
as well as U my position with a blank
space right here to fill in your name
feel free to put this on LinkedIn or
Twitter or Instagram and tag me in that
because I would love to just say
congratulations because honestly it's a
lot lot of work to go through all those
videos and learn all of those skills so
congratulations I hope that you learned
something along this journey a new skill
a new thought a new idea and I'm proud
of you I'm proud of you for putting in
the work it's not easy but you did it
and I hope that you came out on the
other side better for it so congrats
I'll see you in the next
[Music]
video